SURE WILL COME TO ORDER WILL
COME TO ORDER AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
A GOOD MORNING AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN WRIST
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC TO OUR HEARINGS IS
PROVIDE ACCESS. BOTH IN PERSON
AND TELECONFERENCE DISSIPATION
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPEND TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR
ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEBSITES-
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING IS THIS CUSTOMER IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING SOMETIMES
THOSE THE SWING SPACE I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE COME TO
THE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN BEGIN.
THE HEARING. WELL NOW WE STAND
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE HERE MOMENTARILY-
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILLS- LET'S SEE BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. SO- CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD JUST CALL THOSE WHO ARE-
JUST LET LET LET'S LET'S BEGIN
THE PROCESS OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM SO IT'S CALLED THE WRONG.
NUMBER HERE AMBEG HERE ORDERS
FOR JUST PRESENT ZERO YOUR
CAREER HERE IT ALSO GONZALEZ
HERZBERG JONES LAYERED STERN
WHITE COW SKI WINNER I HAVE
THREE COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESENT
. ALL RIGHT SIR WAITING OTHERS-
WE WILL NOT VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THIS POINT BUT LET
ME ANNOUNCE THE ITEMS THAT ARE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND ALSO
AS I MENTIONED A LITTLE EARLIER
THAT- THE- THE- ITEM NUMBER ONE
FILE OR S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY PRESIDENT PRO TEM. AT
KINS WILL BE HEARD AS SPECIAL
BUSINESS AT ONE THIRTY THIS
AFTERNOON. WE HAVE NINE ITEMS OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ARE AS FOLLOWS. PHYLUM NUMBER
FIVE SP ONE THREE NINE SIX
PERCENT- BRADFORD WITH
AMENDMENTS PHYLUM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. ONE ZERO FIVE
FOUR BYE SENT A CHILL BOOK. FILE
NUMBER FOURTEEN SP ONE ZERO FOUR
ZERO BY SENATOR RUBIO FOUNDER
SIXTEEN NINE FORCE SP NINE FOUR
SEVEN BY SENATOR WILK WITH
AMENDMENTS. FILE NUMBER TWENTY
S. B. ONE FOUR ZERO SIX BY
SINNERS ROSSELL FILE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO S. B. 1216% OF
CATHOLICISM. FILE I'M NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR ONE ONE TWO ZERO BY
SENATOR JONES FARM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE. SP ONE TWO FIVE NINE BY
CENTER LAYERED FILE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT S. B. ONE ZERO
SEVEN SEVEN ONE BY. SENATOR OR
MEMBER. ALL RIGHT. LET US NOW
TAKE UP FIVE ITEMS NUMBER TWO.
CENTER OR TO LET IT IS PRESENT.
SO- WELCOME CENTER ARCH ALETTA.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BIL. ELEVEN
ELEVEN. BEGIN BY ACCEPING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME TO IMPROVE THE IMPORTANT
BILL- THE RICK BEST SAFETY ACT
IS NAMED AFTER LONGTIME
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND LOBBYISTS
RICK. BASS WHO SADLY PASSED AWAY
AFTER A TRAFFIC ACCIDENT WITH AN
UNMARKED DUMPSTER. THE
COMMONSENSE MEASURE WILL REQUIRE
LARGE TRASH RECEPTACLES PLACED
ON ROADS AND CURBS SIDES THEY
HAVE LEFT FOR RED TO HAVE
REFLECTIVE MARKETING ON EACH
SIDE TO PREVENT ANY FURTHER
ACCIDENTS WITHOUT REFLECTIVE
MARKETING LARGE TRASH
RECEPTACLES PLACED ON ROADS AND
CURBS ARE VIRTUALLY INVISIBLE ON
A DARK STREET. AT PRESENT A
HAZARD TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
2019404% OF THE BICYCLE
ACCIDENTS IN OUR STATE TOOK
PLACE. AT NIGHT AND IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK
AT THIS BILL SERIOUSLY AND
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND- TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO. TOTAL
CYCLISTS HAVE DIED ON CALIFORNIA
STREET WHICH IS AN AVERAGE ABOUT
A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE- PEOPLE
PER YEAR SENATE BILL ELEVEN
ELEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT STEP.
CALIFORNIA COULD TAKE TO IMPROVE
OUR ROADWAYS FOR MOTORISTS AND
BICYCLISTS ALIKE. HEAVILY LOADED
YARD WASTE CANS ARE ESSENTIALLY
IMMOVABLE AND THEIR IMMOVABLE
OBJECTS THAT OFTEN ARE DARK AND
NOT COLOR DIDN'T NOT VISIBLE AT
NIGHT. THERE ARE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE YOU CAN SEE
A DUMPSTER BLOCK IN A BICYCLE
LANE CAUSING BY CLUELESS TO VEER
OFF THE ROAD OFF THE PATTERN IN
THE PATH RATHER IN INTO TRAFFIC
LANES AND A POTENTIAL ACCIDENT.
AS WE KNOW RICK'S SCENARIO A
DRIVER BICYCLIST RIDING ALONG AT
NIGHT CAN POTENTIALLY RUN INTO
ONE OF THE- ONE OF THESE
DUMPSTERS AT FULL SPEED AND
BECOME SERIOUSLY INJURED.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF RETRO. MARKINGS
TO ENHANCE VISIBILITY
FURTHERMORE CALIFORNIA ALREADY
USES LIES REFLECTIVE MARKETING
OR MARKINGS ON ROADS AND TRAFFIC
SIGN SLICE A PLACE JUST TO NAME
A FEW. S. P. ELEVEN ELEVEN SIX
TO IMPROVE NIGHTTIME VISIBILITY
ENABLE ENABLING MORE REACTION
TIME. AND IT WILL BE SAFER IT
WILL MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER
DRIVERS THAT CYCLISTS SAFER AT
NIGHT IF WE TAKE ACTION. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS COREY CELL ZERO. ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE AM
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY DIVISION.
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU SEARCH
LETTER OF MR SOCIO. THERE YOU GO
GOOD MORNING MR CHARMERS
COURCELLES ALONE BEHALF OF THREE
M. TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
DIVISION WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AGAIN STUDIES SHOWING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF REFLECTIVE
MARKINGS IN ENHANCING VISIBILITY
I AM PROVIDING THOSE WHO USE OUR
ROADS- THE ABILITY T AVOID
HAZARDOUS SITUATIONS. WE ALREADY
REQUIRES THE AUTHOR NOTED REAL
CARS LICENSE PLATES TRAFFIC
SIGNS TRUCK TRAILERS ET CETERA
TO HAVE REFLECTIVE PROPERTIES-
AND THIS BILL CONTINUES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
ROADWAY SAFETY IN THAT REGARD SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CECIL. ALL
RIGHT OTHERS WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SAYING NO ON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE- MODERATE IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP THOSE. ON THE
PHONE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE ONE ONE
ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB ONE ONE ONE
ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. ONE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THIS CALL AT.
HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS NICK
WASTE HAULING IN AND SUPPORT.
RIGHT BACK WITH THE A LONG TIME
ADVOCATE CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON THE FISHING
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIR. BUT
IT WAS A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY. ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH A LOTUS
FLOWER LINES AT THE TIME. ALL
RIGHT- THOSE IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SAYING NO WHEN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE ON
THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
ELEVEN ELEVEN. HE WOULD QUEUE
THEM UP. THAT IS INTERRUPTED AT
THAT POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. HELLO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE PROVIDE
LINE NUMBER WE CURRENTLY HAVE
FOUR IN Q. ALL RIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL  NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M I'M CALLING WITH F. B.
ONE ONE ZERO ZERO THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTY- THAT'S A DIFFERENT BILL
QUICKLY READ NEXT. MEXICO IN ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- HI I'M CALLING FROM
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA AND I AM
CALLING TO OPPOSE. SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED- THIS WOULD VIOLATE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT OUR FREEDOM OF
ALL RIGHT I THINK. MA'AM I THINK
THAT'S A DIFFERENT BILL THIS IS
ON S. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN BY
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA- I APOLOGIZE
ALL RIGHT MODERATOR DOES ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP ELEVEN
ELEVEN BY CENTER ARCH ALETTA.
THROWING ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
ELECTED UP PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS FOR THE REMINDER TO
THIRTEEN BILLION IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVERAL HUNDRED
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEXICO
IN ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE OR LATER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE HAVE A NUMBER FOR THEIR
LIKING CUTE. ALL RIGHT- LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS COMMENTS- SO
I MOVED THE BILL SET A CAREER
MOVES THE BILL CENTER BARGES.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE- JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY
THOUGH- HOW MANY DO YOU HAVE ANY
DATA OR METRICS ON. THE AMOUNT
OF INCIDENTS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
- THAT COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
HAD THERE BEEN REFLECTIVE TAPE.
ON THESE BINS THE STATISTICS ARE
ARE- NOT TOTALLY- AVAILABLE
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T REPORT
EVERY ACCIDENT YOU WILL AROUND
THAT ALLEY YOU RUN INTO THAT THE
TRASH BIN YOU GET UP DUST
YOURSELF OFF FOR NOW AND OFF YOU
GO AND IF IT CALLS FOR A NINE
ONE ONE CALL THEN IT BECOMES
DISTRICT AND AS I HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO TOTAL CYCLISTS HAVE
ACTUALLY DIED- IN VARIOUS
ACCIDENTS. WHICH DOES INCLUDE
RUNNING INTO TRASH BINS AS AS
THE BILL REPORT RECALLS- AS A
MATTER OF FACT WITH THE ALL THE
HIGHWAY PATROL THAT WE HAVE
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING I'D MAGIC A
FEW OF THEM AND THEY WERE SO
GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE TAKING A
STEP FORWARD TO STOP ACCIDENTS
PREVENT ACCIDENTS- THAT WOULD
SAVE LIVES SO THAT THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE BUILDING WE CAN
TAKE THIS STEP FORWARD- I THINK
IT'S WAY WAY OVERDUE. THANK YOU.
RT THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- NOTE THE PRESENCE OF
CENTERS ARE THERE ALSO THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- SURGERY CARE
CLOSE. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
RESPECT LESS RELIABLE THANK YOU-
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS UNTIL
WE HAVE A QUORUM SAID ARCHULETA.
SO WE'LL LET YOU KNOW- WHAT WHAT
POINT TIME WE ACTUALLY VOTE ON
THE BILL SO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
. RIGHT NEXT- LEAVE CENTER
BECKER HERE. AND- BETTER WE'RE
PROCEEDING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE-
YOU'RE FILING NUMBER THREE SP
ONE ZERO FIVE NINE. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THINK UP TO THE
PRESENT S. B. ONE ZERO FIVE NINE
THE BILLABLE CALIFORNIA STRONGER
PRIVACY RIGHTS AND BETTER
VISIBILITY INTO AN OPAQUE WORLD
THAT OF DATA BROKERS. DATA
BROKERS ARE BUSINESSES THAT
COLLECT SELL AND SHARE OUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION EVEN THOUGH
THEY DO NOT HAVE A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH US IS A
CONSUMER. WHEN THE PRIVACY GROUP
EPIC THERE THOUSANDS OF DATA
BROKERS UNITED STATES WHO BY I
AGREE SELL TRADE BILLIONS OF
DATA POINTS ON AMERICANS. SOME
DATA BROKERS ADVERTISE THEY
COLLECTED ANGRY OVER TEN
THOUSAND DATA POINTS PER
CONSUMER. I WANNA THANK JOHN
OLIVER FOR KINDLY RANGING A
TWENTY MINUTE SEGMENT ON DATA
BROKERS OUT LAST WEEK TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC. ON THIS TOPIC.
BECAUSE CONSUMERS DON'T HAVE A
DIRECT RELATION WITH DATA
BROKERS OFTEN OBLIVIOUS TO WHO
IS SELLING ENTRY IN THE PERSONAL
DATA. AND WHAT THOSE THIRD
PARTIES ARE DEALING WITH THAT
DATA. CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED TO BROKERS TO REGISTER
WITH THE PARTNER JUSTICE AND
SHARE INFORMATION REGARDING WHAT
KINDS OF PERSONAL DATA THEY
COLLECT AND HOW CONSUMERS CAN
OPT OUT TO THAT DATA. THE
PROJECT AT LEAST ONE THOUSAND OF
THIS TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DATA
BROKERS WORLDWIDE WOULD
REGISTER. IN FACT ONLY FOUR
HUNDRED HAVE REGISTERED. TO THE
ONE THING THIS BILL DOES SET
STRICTER ANNUAL REGISTRATION
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR DATA
BROKERS AND TOUGH IT'S A PENALTY
FOR DATA TRAFFICKERS WHO DO NOT
COMPLY WITH THE LAW. CONSUMER
ADVOCATE ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
BECAUSE REPORTS HAVE FOUND THAT
MANY DID BROKERS ARE PUTTING UP
ROADBLOCKS. THAT IMPEDE
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO EXERCISE
THEIR PRIVACY RIGHTS. SO THE
OTHER THING THIS BILL DOES IS
REQUESTED BROKERS TRIED CLEAR
INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW CONSUMERS
CAN EXERCISE OUR PRIVACY RIGHTS
TO DELETE CORRECT. OPT OUT. AND
HOW TO IDENTIFY WHO'S PURCHASED
A PERSONAL DATA AND LIMIT THE
USE OF SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES DATA BROKERS TO
ANNUALLY DISCLOSE IF THEY BREACH
AND- IF THEY COLLECT SELL OR
SHARE INFORMATION REGARDING
CHILDREN. AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS BILL. THE TENSION MAKE IT
VERY SIMPLE FOR CONSUMER TO SEE
ALL THIS INFORMATION AT ONCE
MAKING THE RATIO A ONE STOP SHOP
DOESN'T EXIST TODAY RATHER THAN
HAVING TO GO DIG THROUGH
HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY
DISCLOSURES AND FIND OPT OUT
LINKS. IN THE SAME VEIN THE BILL
ALSO CONSOLIDATES THE
REGISTRATION AND REGULATION OF
DATA BROKERS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY SIMPLIFYING PRIVACY
OVERSIGHT FOR CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES. ARE LESS
IMPORTANTLY- THE POINT OF
CONTENTION HARMONIZES THE
DATABROKER LOG WITH THE CPR RAY
TO CLUE THE CONCEPT OF SHARING.
THIS WAS THE SAME LOOPHOLE
CLOSED BY THE CPR A. TO LINK AT
THE BOTTOM WEB PAGE NOW SAYS DO
NOT SELL OR SHARE MY INFORMATION
. THE DIFFERENT CELL DOES
ENCOMPASS A LOT OF SHARING FOR
VALUABLE CONSIDERATION. FOR
QUOTE VALUABLE CONSIDERATION. OF
EXTRAS THAT CONSUMER REPORTS I
FOUND THE TICKET BROKERS CLAIM
THEY DON'T TECHNICALLY SELL OUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION. BUT SHARE
IT. TO OPERATE THE SHADOWS AND
NOT REGISTER. WITH THE PORT
DISTINCTION IS BILL MAKES IT
INCLUDES A DEFINITION OF SHARE.
A CROSS KICK IN WHEN YOU SHARE
INFO FOR CROSS CONTEXTUAL
BEHAVIORAL ADVERTISING PURPOSES.
WE'VE HAD A FEW PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CHAMBER
AND OTHERS WE'RE IN THIS ISSUE.
I PLAN TO CONTINUE TO SEE IF
THERE'S SOMETHING WE CAN
RESOLVE. HERE BUT WHEN I THINK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING US
TO ADDRESS A FEW ISSUES RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION. MAYBE THE
LACK OF A CROSS REFERENCE THE
CURRENT DATA BREACH LAW. AND
STRIKING THE DEADLINE FOR THE
PPA TO ISSUE UPDATE REGULATIONS
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THOSE AS
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. CALLING IN
TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS JUSTIN
BROOKMAN. DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY. POLICY AT CONSUMER REPORTS.
THANK YOU- MISS BROOKMAN YOUR
AVAILABLE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME I CAN YOU
KNOW BEFORE YOU BEGIN LET LET ME
JUST- GO OVER THE GROUND RULES
HERE THAT APPLY TO THIS BILL ON
EVERY OTHER BILL. SO- IF IN
ORDER TO- IN ORDER TO MOVE
THINGS ALONG AND DO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS OBVIOUS TO TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED TO WITNESSES WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH ALL OF THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE- JUST TO. REITERATE TWO
MINUTES FOR TWO WITNESSES ON
EACH SIDE AND THOSE WISHING TO
ALSO LEND THEIR VOICES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
SIMPLY GIVE THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ALL RIGHT HAVING
SAID THAT MR BROOKMAN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FROM US. TODAY MANY THOUSAND
BROKEN UNDER THE DIRECTOR
ACKNOWLEDGED THE POLICY AFTER
CONSUMER COURT FIVE FIGURES WHO
WORKED ON PRIVACY AT THE FEDERAL
TRADE COMMISSION AND THE NEW
YORK. OFFICE ON THE LINE TODAY
IN ORDER THAT YOU TEND TO BE
NINE TO STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA'S
SEPARATE REGISTRY TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY WITH THE PPP EIGHT
AMENDED BY PROPERTY FOR. AND TO
BETTER ENSURE THAT THE REGISTRY
WORK FOR CONSUMERS- OUR DATA
BROKERS BUYING HERE CONSUMER
INFORMATION ALMOST ALWAYS
WITHOUT THE CONSUMER'S KNOWLEDGE
FROM READING IN THE SET OF
RECORDS ONE OF THE KEY GOAL OF
THE FIFTH YEAR IN A PPR RIGHT.
ON IN TWENTY NINETEEN CONSUMER
REPORT SUPPORTED THE CREATION OF
A OF A PUBLIC CHECK OUT A BOOK
REGISTRY TO HELP BRING THESE
DIFFERENCES OUT OF THE SHADOWS.
AND TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS TO EXERCISE THEIR
PRIVACY. RIGHTS WITH RESPECT THE
COMPANY. I IN PRACTICE SO HE A
CALIFORNIA. DIRECTORY GIVE
WORKING AS AN- IT IN TWENTY FOUR
WE WERE. CROWDS THAT ON USING
THE DATA FOR REGISTER TO TRY TO.
BUY POPPED OUT RIGHT. MANY FOUND
IT TO. THINKING DO YOU HE OP OUT
OF ONE THING THAT I OUR PROGRAM
TO FIGHT. HUNGER SO. WE
APPRECIATE THE SP TEN FIFTY NINE
REQUIRE THAT A- CLEARANCE. ON
HOW. EXERCISE THE RIGHT DELETE.
CORRECT OPT OUT NO GROUP. DATA.
A WE APPRECIATE IT THAT YOU CAN
PICK NINE STATES THAT THE- OF
THE RIGHT LAW BECAUSE TYPICALLY
IF WE ADOPTED PROPERTY. WE HAVE
FOUND THE- MANY COMPANY THAT. TO
THE CPA IN. LIKELY UP MY ON DATA
SHARING HE WITH IT AND- MEDICAL
YES. THEY ARE A THREAT BY. THE
SCOPE OF THE OP. ALL DATA
SHARING THE WITH THE SAME FOR
THE REST. WE ALSO COURT FACT
IMPORTANT- HIGHER FOR FINE. AND
THE TRANS. FORTY THE NEW TELE
FIVE PROTECT AGENCY. PLEASE
REFER WE ARE HERE I- THING YOU
VERY MUCH AND HAVE A TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU BROWN ALL
RIGHT- OTHERS WERE TO. IN SOME.
OTHER WITNESSES IN TWELVE OR THE
PHONE WISHING TO TEST IN SO.
MODERATOR IF YOU WENT TO UP
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE WE
SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. ONE ZERO FIVE NINE. CLICK HERE
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR THE WEAPONS-
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
YEAH ROBERT PLEASE WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF TIMES AND KEEP THE
PEACE SO FAR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
- HE. ALL IN LOWER. THIS. THE
FIRST THING YEAH I THINK SOMEONE
ON THE PHONE- NEEDS TO MUTE
THEIR PHONE LINE I THINK I HAVE
. SHOULD YOU GUYS WILL GO.
REPORTER PROTECTED BY YEAH- COME
FROM ONE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TERRY BRADY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT HER PRIVACY
I'M IN A MORE PARK I DON'T HAVE
AN AFFILIATION THANK YOU. THE
COLONEL IN FIFTY YEARS LATER THE
PURPOSE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KELLY CRANDALL FRIEND YEAH AND
ON BEHALF OF THE AFFECTED ACLU'S
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY FIRING FOR
THE SOUTH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR MORE
LIGHTNING KILLS. SEVERAL AND ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT. ARE YOU
MY NAME IS CHRIS TUCKER I AM IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. MARIA DESTROYED THANK YOU AT
THE TIME ALREADY LET'S NOT TURN
THE OPPOSITION- RUNNING. ALLOW
ME IS HERE. IN OPPOSITION. MR
LAMMY FORGERS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN CHRIS ROCK DAYLAMI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FIFTY NINE
LIKE TO START BY THINKING THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR THE
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
HAD THUS FAR AND FOR THE MOMENTS
TAKEN TODAY PARTICULARLY IN
PROVIDING FURTHER CLARITY AROUND
WHAT ARE CONSIDERED. DISPOSABLE
DATA BREACHES UNFORTUNATELY WE
BELIEVE SB TEN FIFTY NINE IS
UNNECESSARY DUPLICATIVE AN
OVERLY BROAD MOST CONCERNING IS
THE BUILD- SIXTY EXPAND THE TERM
DATA BROKER TO INCLUDE COMPANIES
THAT ARE TO BE BLIND NOT DATA
BROKERS. FUNDAMENTALLY DATA
BROKERING IS AN ACTIVITY THAT
DESCRIBES SELLING DATA AND
BECAUSE THE LAW RELIES ON THE
CCPA DEFINITION OF SALE WHICH
INCLUDES ANY DISCLOSURE THE
CONSUMER'S PI. FOR ANY MONETARY
OR OTHER VALUABLE CONSIDERATION
WE BELIEVE EXISTING DATABROKER
DEFINITION ALREADY CAPTURE SUCH
ACTIVITIES COMPREHENSIVELY.
STATED PLAINLY THERE IS NO GAP
HERE THAT NEEDS TO BE CLOSED.
ADDING IN BUSINESSES THAT SHARE
CONSUMER DATA FOR CROSS CONTEXT
BEHAVIORAL ADVERTISING WITHOUT
ANY MONETARY VALUABLE
CONSIDERATIONS PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL WOULD MERELY CONFUSE THE
SITUATION AND FLOOD THE
DATABROKER REGISTRY WOULD NOT
DETER BROKERS. FOR EXAMPLE WERE
CONCERNED THIS MIGHT REQUIRE
REGISTRATION OF A COMPANY THAT
DELIVERS AN ADVERTISEMENT TO THE
IP ADDRESS OF THE CONSUMER THAT
INTENTIONALLY INTERACTED WITH
THEIR WEBSITE. WE'VE ALSO HEARD
CONCERNS I COULD CAPTURE LOYALTY
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW
PARTICIPANTS- CONSUMER TAXES
DIFFERENT BRANDS USING THEIR
POINTS GATHERED THROUGH
INTERACTIONS WITH ONE RETAILER
WITH ANOTHER RETAILER AND SUCH
EXAMPLES THE CONSUMER KNOWS
WHICH BUSINESSES TO CONTACT
EXERCISE OR CCP WRITES WITHOUT
FURTHER ASSISTANCE. SO IF
ANYTHING WE BELIEVE THIS OVERLY
BROAD DEFINITION UNDERMINES THE
UTILITY OF THE REGISTRY FOR THE
CONSUMER. LASTLY GIVEN OUR
LIMITED TIME ALL SIMPLY REFERRED
HER LETTER REGARDING CONCERNS
OVER ADDING RESPONSIBILITIES TO
THE NEW PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY. AND OVER THE POSSIBILITY
AT THAT DUPLICATE DISCLOSURES ON
THE REGISTER REGISTRY COULD
INADVERTENTLY CAUSE UNNECESSARY
CONFUSION IF THEY ARE NOT
UPDATED IN A TIMELY FASHION.
EXCUSE ME. SOMETHING THAT
BUSINESSES CANNOT NECESSARILY
CONTROL WHAT THE GOVERNMENT RUN
REGISTRY FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS THE ALARMING.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. I DON'T OFTEN ON
BEHALF OF TECH THAT WE ARE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MARGARET LATCHING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU. OSCAR SORIANO POSES BILL THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SAYING NO WHEN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE NO
ONE ELSE PROTEIN MICROPHONE
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE PHONE LINE
OF FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. ONE ZERO FIVE
NINE YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN DISRUPTED THE TRANSFER
OF THE ONE ZERO FIVE NINE. ONE
POINT ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THIS. YEAH BUT THIS TIME
WE HAVE A ROLLING SUITCASE ALL
RIGHT- QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
RAISED NO QUESTIONS NO COMMENTS-
COUPLE EURO. SO THERE WERE SOME
ISSUES RAISED BY BY THE CHAMBER
AND SOME OF THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS CAN YOU ADDRESS-
HOW ARE YOU YOU KNOW YOUR
FRAMEWORK FROM WHICH YOU'RE
YOU'RE WORKING ON- IT'S READ AND
PART OF THAT I THINK PART OF THE
CHALLENGE FOR ME IS YOU KNOW WE
PASS THE CCPA SO THAT THEY COULD
WORK ON REGULATIONS IN SETTING
UP THE FRAMEWORK. AND THEN. YOU
KNOW THERE'S THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH. THAT ARE CHANGING IT
BEFORE IT'S EVEN FINISHED I
GUESS IS THE BEST WAY TO PUT IT
IN SO IF YOU COULD IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED. YOU THINK SEVEN WE
BELIEVE THIS IS REALLY IN SYNC
WITH IT. THIS THE S. C. P. R. A.
TECH THIS IS THE SHARING
LOOPHOLE WAS TO BE SACKED WHEN
THAT WAS CLOSED WHEN CCPA. WAS
UPGRADED WITH PROP TWENTY FOUR.
TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THIS
EFFECTIVE T. C. IN ITS
DEFINITION OF DATABROKER
INCLUDES. SHARING BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- A LOT OF DATA
BROKERS ARE SURE USING. THIS
LOOPHOLE AND SAYING THAT THEY
DON'T GET VALUABLE
CONSIDERATION- AND SO THERE FOR
USE AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO NOT
REGISTER SO. THE CAR WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO CLARIFY IS THAT. THAT
NEAR USE CASE WHEN YOU AND I ARE
BEING TRACKED AND TARGETED FOR
ADS ON THE WEB. BASED SOLELY ON
OUR PERSONAL INFORMATION- THAT'S
WHAT I MEAN WHEN I CALLED. CROSS
CONTEXTUAL BEHAVIORAL
ADVERTISING SAID THAT'S THE ONLY
CASE. THAT IRAQIS WERE JUST
CLARIFYING THAT THAT- IS. EQUAL
TO SHARING. AND AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE CONSUMER AT THAT'S FINE. YOU
CAN STILL DO ALL THIS AND I
THINK MANY OF THE- CONCERNS I
THINK ARE MARCHING IN THAT
RESPECT. IF YOU WOULD DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S FINE WHICH
SHOULD MAKE IT CLEAR THAT.
PERSON THAT YOU DON'T KNOW THAT
YOU'VE DONE INTERACT WITH AS A
CONSUMER. IF THEY ARE THEN
SHARING THAT THEY SHOULD BE
COVERED. SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT STATION HERE. RIGHT
SIR MICHAEL SKI DO WE HAVE WE
USED A FOR PURPOSES OF MOVIE THE
BILL BECAUSE I LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL AT APPROPRIATE TIME ALL
RIGHT LET'S LET'S DO THAT-
SENATOR BOOKER IF YOU'LL INDULGE
IS FOR ONE MOMENT- MEANT TO
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
RULE FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM UMBERG HERE A BREAK HERE
PORGES. THANK BOARDS HAS FROZEN
CURRY AT ALL YOUR CAREER HERE
DID US ALL THE REST SO HERE
GONZALEZ HERZBERG JONES I'M ALSO
HERE JONES HERE LAYARD STERN
WACO SKEETER WHITE CASKEY HERE
WINNER. YOU HAVE SIX RMB OF
CORN- THE BILL SO IT HELPS YOU
MOVE THE BILL OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NONE OF SERVER
OF YOUR CLOTHES RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE PART THANK YOU- CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLE OF BEFORE YOU CALL THE ROLE
JUST ONE ISSUE. TERMS OF THE
TERM SHARE- IT MAY BE A BIT
OVERBROAD THE CHALLENGES IS
FURTHER DEFINING AT NINE OH
SEVEN A BACKER THAT YOU ARE- OF-
HAVE AN OPEN MIND AS TO HOW WE
COULD FURTHER DEFINE IT I'VE NOT
HEARD A DEFINITION THAT.
ENCOMPASSES THOSE THAT ACTUALLY
ARE SHARING FOR VALUE VERSUS
THOSE WHO ARE INADVERTENTLY
SHARING AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU AND
THOSE WHO OPPOSE THE BILL ON
FURTHER REFINING IT I KNOW
YOU'RE OPEN TO THAT SO THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER. SAID ALL RIGHT-
THIS IS A SPEED TEN OF PSYCHO
HEAD THIS IS S. B. TEN FIFTY
NINE BY. SENATOR BACKER- THE
MOTION DEPOT AS A BY FIRST AMEND
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MODE MOTION BY
SENATOR CASKEY- BERG HI AM BERG
I PURCHASE. ZERO ZERO I DID I
SAW THAT I SAW I GONZALEZ
HERZBERG. JONES JONES NO LAYERED
STERN WHITE COW SKI. MY CASKEY I
WINNER. SEPTORIA FORTY ONE
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER. YES WE
CAN DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR NEXT
. OKAY YOU HAVE ONE MORE LET'S
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST
THOUGH ALL RIGHT- I I'VE ALREADY
ANNOUNCED THE BILLS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT SO MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AMBERG HI
AMBERG BY BURGESS. BURGESS HI
COVEY IT'LL FIVE SORRY AT ALL I
DID ALSO. STRESS SO I GONZALEZ
FOR ITS BERG JONES. JONES I
LAYERED STERN WORKOUTS SKI. HI
FOR CASKEY I MEANER. I HAVE SIX
ZERO MEMBERS NOT PRESENT ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL-
SELF CENTER BECKER PHYLUM NUMBER
FOUR SP ONE FOUR ONE NINE. THANK
YOU F. SECURE MEMBERS WHEN MOST
SACROSANCT RELATIONSHIPS IN OUR
SOCIETIES WITHIN A PATIENT AND
THEIR POSITION IN SUCH A
RELATIONSHIP PATIENTS CAN
CONSULT THEIR PHYSICIAN ON
PRIVATE MATTERS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH RECEIVE A FREE FLOW OF
INFORMATION AND HIGH QUALITY
CARE TAILORED TO THEIR NEEDS.
HOWEVER THE SHARING OF PATIENT
HEALTH INFORMATION WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT PHYSICIAN
CONSULTATION THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS CAN HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT THIS CAN
HAPPEN BECAUSE FEDERAL
INFORMATION BLOCKING RULES
REQUIRE PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS REALLY SHOULD PATIENT
DATA RELEASE PATIENT AS SOON AS
IT'S AVAILABLE. THANKFULLY THE
FEDERAL RULE THE FIRST A STATE
LAW ALLOWING CALIFORNIA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BOUNCE THE GOAL
PROVIDING PATIENTS ACCESS
INFORMATION ABOUT PROTECTING THE
PRIVACY AND HEARING TO THE
WISHES. TO THIS BILL DOES IS
SETS NEW PATIENT PROTECTIONS IN
A CALIFORNIA LAW THAT WAS SURE
PATIENTS RECEIVE CHALLENGING
HEALTH INFORMATION IN. A TIMELY
MANNER THAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM.
IT ALSO ADDS NEW PER. FOR THE MO
SENSITIVE AS THE PATIENT PRIVACY
IS MAINTAINED AT ALL TIMES. IT
ALSO REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO
MEET PATIENTS DATE AVAILABLE
THROUGH API'S TO PATIENTS CAN
HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER THEIR
DATA. THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AND
RECEIVED AS RECEIVE NO RICHARD
OPPOSITION. ARE STRICTLY URGENT
I FELT SPEAKING SUPPORT THIS
BILL I'LL BE A DOCTOR SHANNON
UNIVAC CONSTANT AND- DR UNIT
COMES TO. I WROTE. I GUESS I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN AND I AM
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
IN SAN FRANCISCO AS A
PEDIATRICIAN FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETEEN AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR BACKER.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NINETEENWAS INTRODUCED IN RESPONSE TO
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT I'VE
GIVEN PATIENTS I'M PRESIDENT
ACCESS TO THEIR OWN HEALTH
INFORMATION. THE INTENT OF THIS
REGULATION IS A VERY GOOD ONE
AND THAT IT ALLOWS PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO BE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN COORDINATING
THEIR OWN CARE. BUT THE RULE IS
ALSO SERIOUS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ESPECIALLY IN MY
FIELD OF PEDIATRICS. CLINICAL
NOTES WHICH PATIENTS NOW HAVE A
RIGHT TO SEE OFTEN CONTAIN
SENSITIVE INFORMATION. THE
PATIENT MIGHT NOT WANT SHARED.
SUCH AS TEEN MENTAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HISTORY THIS
PUTS ME AS A PHYSICIAN IN THE
UNTENABLE POSITION OF HONORING
MY PATIENT'S WISHES TO PROTECT
THEIR INFORMATION OR COMPLYING
WITH THE LETTER OF THE FEDERAL
REGULATION. THANKFULLY THE
FEDERAL REGULATION DIFFERS TO
STATE LAW ALLOWING US TO RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
NINETEEN CLARIFIES THAT I AND MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PROTECT MY PATIENTS INFORMATION
WHEN THEY SO CHOOSE. AND SO I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR AND MR
DAVID FORD IF YOU PRESENT. BUT
HE'S AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT MISTER FORD
IS AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT LET'S NOW TURN
WELL LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE FOUR ONE NINE BUT- IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FOUR ONE NINE
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR F. B. ONE FOUR. ONE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
REPORTER FIRST LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU HIM THROWN DOWN ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. HELLO TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S. TWO TWO
FIVE IF YOU LIKE THE PROPERTY IF
I HAD. REGULATORS IN TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI ANOTHER QUESTION.
PARTY THANK YOU. SERVER LIVE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE
FOREST. RT THANK YOU EXCEPT FOR
LIKE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
AHEAD. HELLO THEY'VE BEEN A
STRONG EMPHASIS ON. PARTY THANK%
YOU NEXT ROTATIONAL AND AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THE SPRINGBOKS
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS SING NO
QUESTIONS NO COMMENTS IS THERE A
MOTION SO MOVED THANK YOU
SENATOR CASKEY- JUST ONE QUICK
COMMENT IN TERMS OF- THERE MAY
BE SOME CONFUSION BECAUSE OF-CROSS REFERENCING IN THIS BILL
TWO OTHER PROVISIONS- SO I WOULD
ASK YOU SENATOR BOOKER TO TAKE A
LOOK WORK WITH OUR STAFF TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THERE ARE NO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS
OF. ALREADY EXISTING LAW AND HOW
THAT MAY IMPACT ALREADY EXISTING
LAW SO THE LAST FOR SUPPORTING
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY- IN THE
ROOM OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. YES
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE TWO MINUTES
TEST MINIATURE THERE WAS NO
OPPOSITION SENATOR BAKER- WE DID
NOT PUT A SECOND LET ME START MY
NAME'S KRISTINA HILDEBRAND FROM
VOICE BETRAYS ABBASI WE DID NOT
PUT IN A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE WERE ONLY RECENTLY
MADE AWARE OF THIS BILL I THINK
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS IS THAT WE
SUPPORT PRIVACY WE IN SUPPORT
INFORMED CONSENT AND
TRANSPARENCY BUT WHAT ISN'T MADE
CLEAR BY SENATOR BACKER IS THAT
MANY OF THESE- SECTIONS OF THE
CODE THAT IS DRESSING IS WHEN H.
TWELVE PLUS YEAR OLD MINER. IS
GIVING CONSENT TO A BROAD RANGE
OF- OF TREATMENTS AND IN THIS
CASE THE PARENTS WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO ANY OF THOSE RECORDS-
WE WANT CHILDREN TO BE EMPOWERED
WE WANT TO ENSURE HOWEVER THAT
CHILDREN HAVE A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP AND A STRONG
SUPPORT SYSTEM WITH THEIR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER AND THERAPISTS BUT
ALSO WITH THEIR PARENTS AND
THEIR GUARDIANS THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ON MANY OF THESE
ISSUES SUCH AS- COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES THE PREVENTION OF STDS-
DRUG AND ALCOHOL PROBLEMS AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT ALL OF
THOSE WITH THIS BILL WOULD NOT
ALLOW. THE PARENTS TO SEE ANY
MEDICAL RECORDS IF THE MINOR
CONSENTED TO THOSE- TREATMENTS
WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MET WITH HER WITH
SENATOR BACKER WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HIM- TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE OF AN
OFTEN THAT ALLOWS CHILDREN WHO
DO CONSENT TO THOSE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR
PEDIATRICIAN WITH THAT PROVIDER
WITH THAT THERAPIST THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO CHOOSE WHETHER
THEIR RECORDS ARE ARE- SHARED
WITH THEIR PARENTS OR- BUT NOT
HAVE THE SORT OF BLANKET UP. BY
REMOVAL OF MEDICAL RECORD.
SHARING WITH THAT PARENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION HERE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. YOUR POST MICROPHONE.
MY NAME IS DENISE ADLER CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS AND
PRESIDENT OF SELL A KING COUNTY
LIBERTY COALITION A
REPRESENTATIVE OF LEXINGTON WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MUSK SORRY UNKNOWN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND HE WAS
TRYING TO LASH I AM HERE
REPRESENTING JAMES TO BRADLEY
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. TARBOLTON CO FOUNDER
FREEDOM ANGELS OPPOSE A BILL
THANK YOU. WE TOOK A TAN FOUNDER
AVENUE TEMAS USD FOR FREEDOM
THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. WHEN THE RICH PLASTER COUNTY I
OPPOSE AB FORTY AS B. FOURTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. HELLO I
OPPOSE THANK YOU. I OPPOSED TO
AND WHAT PEOPLE OUTSIDE TO BE
BLOCKED FROM COMING IN BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIDICULOUS SOCIAL
DISTANCING RULES WE WILL OPPOSE
I THANK YOU. V. LU AGGIE LAR
PLASTER COUNTY FOUNDER OF. HOPE
DEALERS IN ACTION AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
ONE FOUR ONE NINE. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE-
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WISH TO.
PROVIDE THEIR NAME AND THEIR
AFFILIATION- IN THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL FEW QUEUE THEM UP.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
A POSITION TO PRESS THE ONE FOUR
ONE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY SEVEN
IN Q. OR FIRST LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS ALLISON THE RADIO AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
BREXIT EIGHTY FOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD WITH OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LAURA
HOBSON ASSISTANT TO DISNEY
AGUILAR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
GOING ALL IN ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARINO
NAIL AND I OPPOSE THE BILL SB
ONE FOURTEEN NINETEEN THANK YOU
. BY ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
YEAR OLD IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. H. MENU AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE YEARS LATER PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND IN A FORUM FOUNDER OF
HELP YOU'RE LOOKING FOR FREEDOM
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANKS SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
YOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SHERRY I REPRESENT THE
TRUTH TELLERS AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANKS SIXTY
TWO YEARS LATER PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO THIS IS DAN MARTIN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS NICOLE
PEARSON FOUNDER OF FACT WATCHES
JEFF IS THE ATTORNEYS WHO WILL
BE DOING ON THIS BILL IF IT
PASSES WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT TWO FORTY
SEVEN ELEVENS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY SACRAMENTAL OPPOSE
THANK YOU. BY TWO HUNDRED W.
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JENNIFER CO FOUNDER OF
CATHOLIC FAMILIES FOR FREEDOM
CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. BY LOOKING
UNDER NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THIS IS LISA LINDE FROM YOLO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL I AM READY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ALABAMA GOING NOW AND
I FIRMLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. BY WATER FOR ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN TWENTY SIX. I OPPOSE FOURTEEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS KIM FROM SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. FOURTEEN NINETEEN AS A PARENT
IT IS. VERY VITAL YOU THAT THANK
YOU TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRENDA I OPPOSE SB
FOURTEEN NINETY THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BECAUSE THE FIA AND I
OPPOSE THANK YOU. SEVERAL
HUNDRED NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ERIC HALL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ONE FOUR ONE
NINE THANK YOU. LATER UNDER
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE
NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX SHILLINGS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MELISSA
FERRARA OF THE LOS ANGELES
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS UNITED AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. H. M. ALL
BURGER ORANGE COUNTY DESTROYED
POSING AS THE FOURTEEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE A FOLLOW UP HERE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARGARET CALLAHAN I
OPPOSE ITSELF THANK YOU. IN
ORDER TO FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MONICA RODRIGUEZ FIELD
ACCOUNTING I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY TWO I
WAS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLAYED ONE
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
AMANDA MAY I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. BY TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SETTLED THANK YOU. FIVE SEVENTY
TWO YOU'RE GOING TO PUT THEM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ANDREA TYPES OF ASSEMBLY IN
ACCOUNTING I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO YEARS LATER SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS VERONICA FIGHT WITHIN THE
FAMILY DINO COUNTY  REPRESENT
MYSELF MY CHILDREN MY FAMILY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT THE- THANK
YOU. BUT IN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
GILBERT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ITSELF. THANK YOU. ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE GALLONS OF
CONFLICTS THAT HAD. GABRIELLE
INGRAM FOUNDER OF FAN AT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE THE PEOPLE
STILL. THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED
AND TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT THAT THOSE
THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MANDY HOLTON HIM FROM SOMEONE
YOU KNOW COUNTY MOTHER OF TWO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT EIGHT
ONE FOUR ONE NINE. THANK YOU.
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M DAVID
KERN COUNTY RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ONE FOUR ONE
NINE. THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX YOU LIKE
THE LOOK OF PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
HAVE NO ADDITIONAL EXECUTE THIS
TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR LET ME
ASK ONE MORE TIME IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WHO'S IN OPPOSITION TO SP ONE
FOUR ONE NINE PLEASE PRODUCE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE MATER
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
ONE FOUR ONE NINE. AS A REMINDER
TO SHOW UP IN SOCIAL PRESS THE
ONE FOUR ONE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON HERE. ALL RIGHT ONE
I'M SORRY MODERATOR SUMMONING Q.
CURRENTLY HAVE NINE ADDITIONAL
LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ALL RIGHT. TOTALING ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AMANDA AND I
OPPOSE THE FILM. THANK YOU.
GROWING ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MARGARET AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO I. NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
THE FORMER SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THE- THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY MY NAME IS KAREN
RALPH KERN COUNTY I PULLED
ITSELF. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
CALLING MODERN THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JASMINE- I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AS A
MOTHER I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
LANES OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT FROM
ENGLAND STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME'S
SALLY MITCHELL FROM NEVADA
COUNTY WITH THE SEVEN HUNDRED
NUMBER OF LIFE THAT SHE HAS BEEN%
ON A FORTY YEAR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND A PARENT I'M
TRANS FINALLY. THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TRANSACTION WELCOME I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ONE FOUR ONE
NINE THANK YOU. I THINK I MEAN
YOU KNOW TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT TO
GROUND OR SOMETHING. ILLEGAL BY
TWO FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO PROVIDE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK YOU HELLO NO ADDITIONAL
LINE TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
JUST CENTER BURGESS. THE
CATCHER- MAYBE JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION- SO WE MAKE A
MINOR. HAS A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PROVIDER- DOES THE PRIVITY
WITH THE INSURANCE POLICY RESTS
WITH THE PARENTS. OR IS IT
SEPARATE BETWEEN THE PATIENT AND
THE PHYSICIAN. MAYBE IT'S A ADAM
THIS WE NEED TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT IF MAYBE IF ANYBODY CAN
ANSWER THAT. YES YOU ACTUALLY
PASSED MY WITNESS TO COMMENT
BECAUSE ALSO ON THE OTHER PIECE
I THINK THAT THE CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED IS MOSTLY REALLY
EXIST ARE ALREADY EXISTING LAW
WHICH ADDING CLINICAL NOTES BUT
IF I COULD ASK- DETERGENT THANK
YOU IT'S A GREAT QUESTION- SO.
JUST T CLARIFY THIS THIS IS
POINTING TO STATE LAW THAT'S
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE AROUND
SENSITIVE SERVICES FOR MINORS.
AND IT'S VERY NARROW IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S PROTECTED AND THAT AND
THE INTENT OF THIS IS NOT- I'LL
GET YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
INSURANCE. AND THE INTENT AROUND
THIS IS NOT TO- IT TO EXCLUDE
PARENTS FROM THE CARE OF THEIR
CHILDREN- PARENTS ARE INCREDIBLY
TRUSTED- AND SO IMPORTANT AND
THE HEALTH OF THEIR OF THEIR
CHILDREN. AND YET THERE'S SOME
SENSITIVE SERVICES THAT IF
THEY'RE A IF THE YOUTH IS NOT
GUARANTEED THAT THEY'LL BE SOME
PRIVACY. THEY WON'T DISCLOSE AND
DISCUSS WITH ME OR ANYONE
POSSIBLY- AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THE INTENT OF THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW. SEPARATE FROM THIS-
WAS WAS PUT INTO PLACE FOR WAS
JUST TO MAKE SURE. THAT THERE IS
A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN ASK A
TRUSTED ADULT WHO HAS A
RELATIONSHIP IN THAT FAMILY-
ABOUT SOME THINGS THAT THEY MAY
NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE DISCUSSING.
AND I ALWAYS- ENCOURAGED THAT WE
BRING THAT CONVERSATION BACK TO
THE PARENTS. AND OFTEN OFFER TO
HELP AND MOST OF THE TIME THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO THEN. RETURN
BACK INTO THAT THAT ME THE CHILD
AND THE PARENTS. IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE INSURANCE WHAT IT
HAPPENED WHEN THE SENSE OF
SERVICES WORK I. PUT IN IS THAT
IT GOT CARVED OUT FROM
TRADITIONAL INSURANCE AND SO
MEDIKAL HAS PROTECTION AROUND
SENSITIVE SERVICES. SO THAT
THERE WOULDN'T BE BILLING ON THE
BACKEND WHERE YOU'VE ALLOWED
SOME CONFIDENTIALITY AND THEN
UNINTENDED LEE- DISCLOSED
THROUGH BILLING. AND SO THAT'S
THE WAY THE INSURANCE PIECE HAS
BEEN- HANDLED WITH THE EXISTING
LAW. ANY OTHER THING THAT I
WANTED TO JUST CLARIFY IS THAT-
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS THE ABILITY.
TO DOCUMENT THE- ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT'S NOT. UNDER
THE SENSITIVE SERVICES AND
RELEASE AN OPEN NOTES AND HAVE
THIS OTHER SENSITIVE-
INFORMATION KEPT IN A SEPARATE
AREA SO ONLY THAT WOULD BE WOULD
BE BLOCKED. IF THE TEEN WANTED
IT- SO THAT OPT OUT ACTUALLY IS
AND OUR SIDE THE OPT IN TO THE
CONFIDENTIALITY FROM FROM
NINETEEN. IS AVAILABLE IN
CURRENT TECHNOLOGY OF MEDICAL
DOCUMENTATION. THANK YOU I'M
THANK YOU I THINK. THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES WHERE YOU. CAN
YOU SCRATCH YOUR HEAD A LITTLE
BIT ON. YES YOU WANT
INDIVIDUALS- TO SEEK AND OBTAIN
MEDICAL TREATMENT YOU KNOW. AS
AS IT'S NEEDED- AND SOMETIMES
THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
YOU KNOW MAYBE A PARENT- WOULD
DISAPPROVE. BUT I KIND OF
HARKENS TO. OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
DEALT WITH WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO
BE AN ADULT. IN CALIFORNIA WE
JUST RUN THE GAMUT MAN. I MEAN
YOU GOT TO BE TWELVE TO GET
CERTAIN SERVICES YOU GOT TO BE.
SEVENTEEN OR EIGHTEEN TO JOIN
THE MILITARY. PERHAPS YOUNGER
WITH PARENTAL SO- CONSENT. YOU
HAVE TO BE. YOU KNOW SIXTEEN NOW
TO VOTE HE USED TO BE EIGHTEEN
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT TWENTY
ONE TO. TO DRINK ALCOHOLIC
WORKERS ALL OVER THE PLACE. SO I
GUESS THE IDEA IS. AND I HAVE
TWO LITTLE BOYS A PERSON OUT
THERE TO GET AND I WANT AND I
WANT. I WANT TO KNOW THAT. WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING SERVICES I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY THE SPECIAL
SERVICES IN THE CAR ABOUT. I
THINK IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY TO
KNOW. JUST TO A FATHER'S
PERSPECTIVE I SUPPOSE. YEAH I
APPRECIATE YOUR- THOUGHTFUL
REMARKS IN A PORSCHE YOU KNOW
JUST IN THIS PART OF THE BILL
IS- WITNESS MENTIONED- ACTUALLY
EXISTING LAW ARE WE REALLY ARE
ADDING THE THIS IS CAN ONE PIECE
THIS BILLS THAT THAT'S CLINICAL
NOTES TO- THAT PART THAT'S
THAT'S PROTECTED SO THAT PART IS
REALLY ALREADY PART OF. OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT A CLARIFICATION BUT WE
DO THINK THOSE CLINICAL NOTES I
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT WE
DO THINK THAT CONNOTES ARE
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT AS PART OF
THIS. RT THANK YOU KNOW THE
QUESTIONS IS A MOVE BY SEN
WHITEHOUSE SKI. IT'S I'M OF THE
BILL NO IT'S A COUPLE EURO JUST
TO BE SURE THAT IT'S BEEN
PROPERLY MOST CYNICAL YOU'RE
ALSO MOVES THE BILL- YES- SIR
BECKER YOU COULD CLOSE. IT OUT
OR USE THAT SICKNESS. A VOICE IS
REMOVED AND WE DO BELIEVE THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THAT AND
WILL ACTUALLY INCREASE THAT THE
PATIENT- PHYSICIAN RELATIONSHIP
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NINETEEN BY
SENATOR BACKER WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR COPY AT ALL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. AMBERG BY
BARGES. FOR JUSTIN- COPY AT ALL.
SORRY AT ALL I DID A SELF.
ADDRESSED SO HI GONZALEZ PARTS
BERG. JONES. JONES NO LAYERED.
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI. WINNER
SUMMARY OF THREE TWO TWO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT PUT
THAT ON CALL I SEE CENTRE
CORTESE IS HERE- NEXT TO BE SP
ELEVEN HUNDRED. FOR PURPOSES OF
HOUSEKEEPING- AT NOON. WE'LL
TAKE A NINETY MINUTE BREAK AND
THEN WE'LL RECONVENE AT ONE
THIRTY THIS AFTERNOON. SO
SENATOR CORTESE AND- FOLLOWED BY
A SENATOR HEY MAN ALL RIGHT
SELLER CORTESE THE FLOOR'S YOURS
. GOOD MORNING SURE IN CENTERS
EMPLOYEES PERCENT SP ELEVEN
HUNDRED TO ENSURE ACCESSIBLE IN
CITY PUBLIC MEETINGS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. IT'S BECOME
INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT
MECHANISMS PROVIDED BY THE BROWN
ACT WE JUST ASK IF YOU ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED YES ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THIS. HAS BEEN
INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT
MECHANISMS PROVIDED BY THE BROWN
ACT TO DEAL WITH DISRUPTIONS
DURING BROWN ACTED PUBLIC
MEETINGS ARE INSUFFICIENT.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND PUBLIC ATTENDEES
CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH DISORDERLY
CONDUCT DURING MEETINGS AT SUCH
A HIGH MAGNITUDE THAT CRITICAL
BUSINESS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AS A WHOLE HAVE BECOME
IMPAIRED REPEATED. DOUBLE SURE
ONLY A FEW EXAMPLES THAT SPEAK
TO THE NEED FOR S. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD OF
SIMILAR INSTANCES IN MANY OF
YOUR OWN SENATE DISTRICTS. WELL
IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PLUS GET US MAYOR
RICO SALE IN OUR FAMILY AS WELL
AS OTHER MEMBERS OF THE CITY
COUNCIL FACE DISRUPTIVE ACTIONS
TARGET BULLYING AND HARASSMENT
EFFORTS AT PUBLIC MEETINGS.
INCLUDING AN ANTI LGBTQ AND
ANTI. API RHETORIC THIS YEAR AND
LAST THE POTENTIAL YORBA LINDA
UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD HAD IN
MULTIPLE MEETINGS EARLY DUE TO
MEETING DISRUPTIONS RECENT SAN
DIEGO BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
MEETINGS HAVE ALSO MADE NATIONAL
HEADLINES IN PART DUE TO RACIST
COMMENTS AS WELL AS THREATS OF
VIOLENCE. IN PERSONAL ATTACKS
WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS
AS WELL AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND THE NEED FOR CLARITY OF WHAT
THE FORTY- LET'S SEE THE BODY
CAN EXERCISE IN REGARD TO
REMOVING AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
DISRUPTING A PUBLIC MEETING DUE
IN PART TO THE WIDE RANGE OF
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONS OF.
LEGAL COUNSELS THAT TOURNEY'S
ACROSS THE STATE AS WE HAVE
UNDOUBTEDLY SEEN MANY TROUBLING
INCIDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING
HARASSMENT AND THREATS OF
VIOLENCE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THE
NEED TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC MEETING ACCESS BY
MODERNIZING THE PRODUCTS. THAT
IT PROVIDES CLEAR STANDARD
AROUND ONE. FOR MEETING PART IS
WARRANTED AND WHAT AUTHORITY OF
OUR- BODY CONNECTIONS. THE STATE
MUST SET A BARE MINIMUM. BY
ESTABLISHING COMMON SENSE
MECHANISMS TO DE ESCALATE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS. HELLO
MEMBERS OF LEGISLATIVE BODY TO
RETURN TO THEIR IMPORTANT
GOVERNMENTAL BUSINESS IN A SWIFT
MANNER. THIS BILL WOULD ENHANCE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO MEETINGS. I
WILL NOTE THAT WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE ACLU AND OTHERS.
INCLUDING LEGAL COUNSELS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICES WHO ARE
HIGHLY ESTEEMED. ACROSS
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
CONSISTENT WITH FIRST AMENDMENT
PRINCIPLES AND EXPRESSLY STATED
OUR INTENT TO PROTECT CIVIL
LIBERTIES. AND NOT TO PROHIBIT
PUBLIC CRITICISM. I'VE BEEN I'VE
ACCEPTED- AS I JUST NOTED ALL OF
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
ON PAGE NINE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS- NOTE- THAT THE
WARRANTY PROVISIONS WERE IN THE
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL
WHEN IT WAS LAST HEARD. THE WIND
WITH ME TODAY. IS MAYOR ROB
RENNIE REPRESENTING THE TOTAL
BOSKALIS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS
WELL AS GENE HEARST REPRESENTING
URBAN COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THE
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN THE URBAN COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU- MAYOR RENNIE
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. I AM HERE ALL
RIGHT THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND ESTEEM
SENATORS BLOCKED OUT OF MAYOR
ROB RENNIE TOWN OF WALKED OUT OF
THE ATHLETES OR F. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED- AS SENATOR CORTEZ HE
SAID DURING TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MOSCOW'S MAYOR. RICO SCI FI THE
PARTED BOWLING AND HARASSMENTS
MULTIPLE TOWN COUNCIL MEETING IN
ADDITION TO THE INAPPROPRIATE
COMMENTS THE SPEAKER SHALL
INTERRUPT THE MEETING TO THE
POINT WHERE RECESS WAS NEEDED TO
CLEAR THE COUNCIL CHAMBERS. THE
DESTRUCTION SERIOUSLY IMPEDE THE
CRITICAL BUSINESS OF THE TOWN
SUBSEQUENTLY THE COUNTY COUNCIL
ADDED A COUPLE OF CIVILITY.
BILITY TO AT THE GENDER WHICH IS
SET AT EVERY MEETING TO INFORM
THE PUBLIC THAT HATEFUL
SLANDEROUS AND BIGOTRY AND
LANGUAGE WILL NOT BE TOLERATED
PARTICULARLY AGAINST NON PUBLIC
OFFICIAL DISABILITY EXPECTATION
TO READ AT ALL NOW ON BOARD
COMMISSION AND COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. SADLY LOST OUT NOT
ALONE SCHOOL BOARDS AND OTHER
BODIES HAVE FACED DISRUPTIONS
AND THE INABILITY TO COMPLETE
THE WORK FOR WHICH THE BODY WAS
ELECTED DUE FOR ITS CONSTITUENTS
S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO PROVIDING
STATE WIDE SUPPORT WITHIN THE
BROWN ACT DEFINE WILLFUL
INTERRUPTIONS SET A MINIMUM
STANDARD FOR WHEN THE REMOVAL OF
A MEETING PARTICIPANT IS MARKET.
AND ARTICULATE THE AUTHORITY
MEMBERS OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY
AND EXERCISE WHEN FACED. WITH
BULLYING HARASSMENT OR VIOLENCE.
REALLY QUICK RESTORE ORDER
PRESERVE STATE OPEN ACTS FOR THE
TO. IN GOVERNMENT PERCEIVE. THIS
LOOKS IS FOR. TO THE BUSINESS
BEFORE TOWN. CITY GOVERNMENT
THANK YOU FOR AND SUPER BOWL-
AND SPECIAL. TO PROCEED AND AN
ORDERLY AND WORST FOR. THE
PROPOSED TOPIC TO THE BROWN ACT
BEST FEEL LEVIN HUNDRED STRIKE A
BALANCE. TO MAINTAIN INDIVIDUAL
CIVIL LIBERTIES AND.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS PUBLIC.
CHECK PUBLIC SAY AND PROVIDE
NEEDED PROTECTION FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THEIR WORK ON
BEHALF OF THEIR COMMUNITIES THE
SMELL LOCAL APPROACHES WILL BE
DISAPPOINTED I'M NOT HAPPY. THE
STATE LAW BEHIND THEM WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED TO ENSURE THE PROTECTION
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AS WELL
AS OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS SO THEY
CAN COMPLETE THE IMPORTANT WORK
WHICH THEY WERE ELECTED TO DO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I
BELIEVE GENE HEARST GENE YOU'RE
HERE. THIS FIRST GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- GENE
HEARST HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN HUNDRED-
I WANT TO START. BY EXPRESSING
OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
CONSIDERABLE WORK THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF AS WELL AS COMMITTEE
STAFF- HAVE DONE WITH NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO STRIKE A CAREFUL
BALANCE. ATTENTION THAT THIS
MEASURE IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
BROWN OUT AND ITS ASSOCIATED-
CASE LAW. S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED
WILL ASSIST LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC MEETINGS ARE
SAFE AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN TO
HELP US ADDRESS AND UNFORTUNATE
BUT NOTABLE INCREASE IN
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR THAT IS
PRESENTED FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF INTERRUPTING THE NORMAL
CONDUCT OF THE PUBLIC'S
BUSINESS. A REGRETTABLY EVEN
HERE IN THE CAPITAL INCIDENTS OF
THIS TYPE HAVE BECOME MORE
COMMON DURING THE PAST FEW
YEARS. THEY'RE STRESSFUL THEY'RE
DEMORALIZING AND OFTEN
FRIGHTENING FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS STAFF AND THOSE IN
ATTENDANCE- THESE BEHAVIORS NOT
ONLY DISRUPT THE PROCEEDINGS OF
THE DAY BUT FUNDAMENTALLY BREAK
THE PROMISE OF THE BROWN ACT.
UNDERMINING THE ABILITY OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CONDUCT OF
THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS SAFELY AND
PRODUCTIVELY. S. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED PROVIDES HELPFUL
GUIDANCE FOR LOCAL AGENCIES AS
TO HOW TO MANAGE DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR IN A MANNER CONSISTENT
WITH CASE LAW. IT ASSIST LOCAL
AGENCIES IN DEALING WITH THE
RAISING HOSTILITY AND
INTIMIDATION OCCURRING DURING
PUBLIC MEETINGS AND ENSURES THE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE CONDUCT
OF THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS. AT THE
SAME TIME THE BILL SAFEGUARDS
THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO ADDRESS
ITS ELECTED LEADERS IN PUBLIC
MEETINGS UNDER REASONABLE
CONDUCT REQUIREMENTS. WE
RESPECTFULLYURGE YOUR VOTE ON
SB ELEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU
MISS FIRST- OTHERS WISH TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED IF YOU WOULD APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. MORNING CATHY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SIGNAL ON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE- ONE MORE PERSON
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE. IF
YOU WOULD ALSO QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN HUNDRED. OSCARS ARE ABLE
TO SHOW SOME FIGHT LIST MR-
FIRST MR SEARLE. OSCARS SORROW
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL DOES
BILL DOES NOT REPRESENT OUR
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN HUNDRED. REGULAR
TREATMENT OR SUPPORT FOR SB
ELEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE PROBLEM
THAN ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIRST A
LITTLE AT ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JENNIFER
TANNER ON BEHALF OF ALL EIGHTY
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME MY FAMILY
CHANGE BEGINS WITH A MATE WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTED SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIVE ONE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN RIGHT LET'S OPEN.
EXPLORE LIKE EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEDIA
ALL TOGETHER WE WILL GIVE YOU
THE FULL OF CANDLES IN STRONG
FAVOR OKAY IF YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED. THANK YOU. BUT A LOTUS
WILLING TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
RT THANK YOU- OTHERS A SUPPORT
SAYING NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
NO ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
LET'S NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION TO
S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED I SEE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE SP ELEVEN HUNDRED. I
ASKED THE CHAIR FOR MY
ORGANIZATION TO SPEAK AS AN
EXPERT IN OPPOSITION WILL
PERMIT- TWO FOR TWO OF US FOR
TWO MINUTES TWO MINUTES THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
JENNIFER YOURSELF YES TARA
NORTON CO FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS
AND UNITED COUNTIES OF AMERICA-
AT THIS POINT. WE ALL KNOW
THERE'S PROBLEMS WITH THE BROWN
ACT BUT IT'S NOT JUST ONE SIDED
THERE IS PROBLEMS WITH ENFORCING
THE BROWN ACT AND ALLOWING THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE ACCESS. TO
MEETINGS OF ALL TYPES FROM
SCHOOL BOARDS TO STATE MEETINGS
AT EERY LEVEL WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS
TO THE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
IF WE DO NOT WE DO NOT HAVE DUE
PROCESS OF LAW WE DO NOT HAVE
DEMOCRACY. AND THE LAST TWO
YEARS EVERYONE OF US ACROSS THIS
NATION HAS LIVED WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO BE LOCKED OUT OF THE PROCESS-
AROUND RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT WORKS THAT AFFECTED EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US FROM OUR
CHILDREN TO OUR ELDERS TO OUR
BUSINESSES EVERY PART OF
SOCIETY. AND THERE WAS A
COMPLETE BREAKDOWN. IN THE BROWN
ACT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE TO
KEEP AN OPEN CHANNEL FOR
ELECTIVES AND THE KINGS AND THE
CITIZENS AND THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
I THINK WHAT THIS BILL NEEDS TO
BE. COMPLETELY STOPPED PUT ASIDE
AND LET'S LOOK AT HOW FROM ONE
SIDE OF THE TABLE TOGETHER LOOK
AT HOW TO SOLVE THE BREAK DOWN.
IN THE LEASES OF THE CHILDREN
THE BUSINESS'S THE CHURCHES THE
ELDERS EVERYONE ONE THING YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR ABOUT THE LAST TWO
YEARS NOBODY'S VOICE WAS HEARD.
AND IF YOU LOCK PEOPLE OUT
FURTHER BY THIS YOU ARE ONLY
ADDING INSULT TO INJURY THE TIME
WHERE EVERYONE DESERVES A VOICE
AT THE TABLE AND ALL ANYONE WAS
CRYING FOR WAS TO BE HEARD. AND
BE PART OF A SOLUTION TOGETHER
AND THIS DOES THE EXACT OPPOSITE
IT'S REALLY REALLY ACTUALLY
SHAMEFUL AND PAINFUL FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN HURTING
FOR TWO YEARS. AND I WASN'T
PREPARED. TO SPEAK IN THIS I
WANT TO TELL YOU THAT. THIS THIS
BILL. AMONG MANY OTHERS ARE
SENSUALLY FUNCTIONING A SECRET
BILLS THE COMMUNITY DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT THEM. AND IF YOU WERE TO
GO OUT AND PULL YOUR COMMUNITY
IF YOU WERE TO GO OUT AND HOLD A
TOWN HALL YOU WOULD FIND THEY
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS AND THEY
DO CARE. THEY WANT A VOICE THEY
WANT TO BE HEARD AND THAT'S ALL
ANYONE'S ASKING NO MATTER WHAT
POSITION THEY'RE IN. SO PLEASE
PULL THIS BILL LIKE DON'T
SUPPORT IT AND SENATOR CORTESE
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PEOPLE WANT TO BE HEARD. BUT IF
THERE'S A WAY TO DO IT OTHER
THAN THIS THANK YOU MA'AM-
ANOTHER WITNESS IN. TWO MINUTES
GO AHEAD MY NAME IS DANNY
SECULAR I'M CO FOUNDER FREEDOM
ANGELS AND I REPRESENT THOUSANDS
OF PARENTS WHO WERE GOING TO
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS. AND
ASKING REPRESENTATIVES FOR
DIALOGUE ON WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH OUR CHILDREN'S HEALTH A
LOT OF THESE BILLS ARE ATTACKING
OUR KIDS. AND WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT- PARENTS WHO ARE
FED UP WITH. REPRESENTATIVES
HIDING BEHIND ZOOM CALLS NUMBERS
NOT WORKING QUEUES BEING SHUT
DOWN. WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AN AD
IN A TIME WHERE WE CAN HAVE
HONEST DIALOGUE WITH OUR
REPRESENTATIVES AS WE VOTE YOU
IN. THE DESTRUCTION THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS FOR PARENTS
BEING IGNORED. AND AGENDAS BEING
PUT IN PLACE WITHOUT THAT THE
DIALOGUE WITH PARENTS THAT IS
VERY MUCH NEEDED. WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSE WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING
IS THAT PARENTS TO JUST BE QUIET
THAT TAX PAYERS SHOULD JUST BE
QUIET AND RIGHT NOW WE JUST LEFT
A MEETING. WHERE WE WERE TOLD TO
FOLLOW THE F. ING RULES. WHY IS
IT THAT REPRESENTATIVES ARE
ALLOWED TO TALK TO US THIS WAY.
BUT WHEN WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON IN SCHOOLS WHEN
WE HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
REPRESENTATIVES WHY CERTAIN
POLICIES ARE BEING PLACED IN
SECRET BECAUSE WE HAVE DONE
COMMUNITY CANVASSING AND PEOPLE
DO. NOT KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHY IS THIS BUILD PUT INTO. OF
ACTUAL COMMUNICATION AND
DIALOGUE AND OPENING UP THOSE
LINES TO PEOPLE WHO DO YOU WANT
TO BE ENGAGED IN CIVICS. WHO DO
YOU WANT TO BE ENGAGED IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION AND DO YOU
WANT TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR HEALTH
CARE. WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION I SEE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT
ARE LINED UP HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED- IF YOU WOULD GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS LINDA RICHARD. SORRY
I RESIDE IN PLASTER COUNTY. AND
I BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE HELD AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL I THINK IT'S
REDUNDANT RT THANK YOU MA'AM. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE OPPOSE NO THING
SORRY THANK YOU. FOR AS LONG AS
SCHOOL BOARDS CONTINUE TO PAUSE
IN OUR OWNER YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITIONS ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD'S CONTAINERS
ACROSS YOUR NAME MANDATES IN
YOUR AFFILIATE WILL INTERRUPT
IT'LL MEETINGS ALREADY THANK YOU
BYE AND OF COURSE I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. SONY VARGAS I AM A
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
GATE FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THERE. I'M MIKE FROM
THE FUNKY FATHERS ALSO- THE WHO
OWNS YOUR BODY TO THE WHO ON
YOUR BODY- THAT YOU OWN YOUR
BODY IN YOUR SLAVE ALL RIGHT
FOUNDATION AND- ANY OF THESE
BILLS ARE A SITUATION AND YOUR
POSITION YOU PUT YOUR HEAD DOWN
A FILIATION. ALL RIGHT YOU'RE MY
HERO YOU MIGHT REPRESENT THANK
YOU SIR ON. THIS CRAP YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY HEART TO THE PEOPLE AND
YOU TRY TO STOP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU CAN R. AS OUTRAGEOUS
MAN WE'RE SUPPOSED TO REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
TURN OFF THE MICROPHONE. YOU'RE
FIRED. THANK YOU FIRE ALL RIGHT
NEXT YEAR YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
MISSILE DANA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM. RENEE
BREEDLOVE PLASTER COUNTY YOU
WORK FOR US THANK YOU MA'AM. WE
SHOULDN'T BE SILENCED THE DEAL
POSSIBLE ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD BE
HER. THIS EXCERPT. BOTH OF THESE
ALONG. THIS IS MY NAME IS STEVEN
BREEDLOVE I'M FROM PLASTIC
COUNTY AND I ALSO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR. VEAL AGGIE
LEARN A PRODUCT OF PREGNANCY
HERE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TIMOTHY DANA SAMBAR
DINO COUNTY RESIDENT I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MARGIE
LOVES TERM RESIDENT OF EL DORADO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. DEBBIE HARDY FROM
AMADOR COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AFTERNOON
CHARTER MEMBERS THE MISSION
LAUNCHED IN A REPRESENTING JAMES
P. BRAWLEY IS RUNNING FOR U. S.
SENATE THANK YOU AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL YOU DO NOT LET ME
FINISH WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT IN THE SPEECH
THERE'S APPARENTLY NO ONE ELSE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE. WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION. TO THE SP
ELEVEN HUNDRED. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THERE'S THE CORRECT
VERSION OF. THE ELEVEN HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. CURRENTLY
HAVE FORTY LINES IN Q. FIRST
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS PAM PORTER WREAKING AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN WE WILL ALWAYS
DEFEND OUR RIGHTS AND WE KNOW
YOU'RE AFRAID I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS VERONICA FIVE
WHICH STANDS AT PEMBERLEY DINO
PALMIERI PRESENT MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY MY FOUR CHILDREN AND I
PULLED YOURSELF THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LIFE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JUST
BECAUSE I AM THE FOUNDER OF. I
AM CALLING TO CLOSE. FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE YEARLINGS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT. ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT I. TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SERRA WILL HELP HIM WORKING FOR
FREEDOM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SELF. THANK YOU. OR TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL SB ELEVEN HUNDRED
FANTASY THE COUNTY. THANK YOU.
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE. I BUY TWO
FOR EIGHT DOLLARS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MANDY GOLDMAN. SAID OF
SEVERINO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB ELEVEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY FIVE
REAL LIFE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GABRIELLE IN GRAHAM
FOUNDER OF SCANNED IT BACK TO
MADISON COUNTY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID DAVIS AND
I'M CURRENT COUNTY RESIDENT AND
I SPEAK FOR MYSELF AND MY FAMILY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO SEVENTEEN YEAR I
WOULD LOOK AT IT BECAUSE- ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LEGS UP
AND PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS NICOLE MEL B. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AND I'M FROM LA COUNTY.
THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY YEAR
LEVELS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JENNIFER OFFENDER
CATHOLIC FAMILIES FOR FREEDOM
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AT ONE ONE ZERO ZERO.
THANK YOU. ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO EUROPE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN
DOWN AND- IT CREATED A
SACRAMENTO AND I. THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY A YEAR AND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MONICA
RODRIGUEZ. YOLO COUNTY RESIDENT
AND TAXPAYER I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. RIGHT AT FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LAURA
HOFFMAN ASSISTANT YOU NEED
CELLULAR I EXTREMELY OPPOSED ALL
. THANK YOU A SEVENTY TWO YEAR
OLD IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NINETY TWO EUROPE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T. WELL I CAN COUNT AND I
POSE ITSELF. IF. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE YEAR OLD IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE INDIANA
COUNTYI OPPOSE ORDERED FROM
TYRANNICAL HOT SPOT THANK YOU.
GOD THE R. E. THANK YOU TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY THIS IS WHAT HE
BOUGHT SHIRTS AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB A LEVIN ZERO ZERO.
ELEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS CAM FROM
CINEMA COUNTY REPRESENTING MY
FAMILY INCLUDING MY VACCINE
INJURED DAUGHTER THANK YOU ONLY
IF I WAS ACTUALLY A LEVIN
HUNDREDS THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED
AND. THIRTY TO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL. TWO THIRTY SEVEN ELEVEN.
NOTHING SPECTACULAR TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE MILLION IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND BY TWO TO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN ALONG WITH A COMPLETE. HE
WROTE YOUR CALIFORNIA MOTHER
BORN IN THE FILM THANK YOU. FOR
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ALYSSA FOR NORA LOS ANGELES
EDUCATORS AND THE PEOPLES UNITED
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ALAN MITCHELL
FROM THE BAD ACCOUNTING I
REPRESENT SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
IN THAT SITUATION. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE IS THE PREDICAMENT ON OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND ALSO
ON CONSTITUTIONAL OVERREACH.
AIMS TO CENSOR FREE THANK YOU
HAD ENOUGH FOR THE NEXT. TWO
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT TURNED
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ALLISON FOR
RAIL AND THE PRESIDENCY IN
HICKORY REPRESENTING OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND AMERICANS THANK YOU
ONLY A THIRD OF. THE COUNTRY
THANK YOU. TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN
MILLION IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS AMBER VON PM
ANOTHER THREE AND LESS STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN HUNDRED. THANK
YOU. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS GAIL BAIRD
OF FAMILY KING COUNTY
RESIGNATION FIVE HUNDRED- WHAT
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU. SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
GINA MARTIN THAT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. FIVE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINE
AREA AND IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWENTY ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PRESS SECRETARY
IN COUNTY AND THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HOPE YOU'RE DOING
STANDARD WATCHES JUSTICE AGAIN
TOURNEY THAT WILL BE SUING FOR
STILL HAPPENS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AND REPRESENT. ALMOST ALL RIGHT
NOW THE NUMBERS THANK YOU. ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN ORDER TO THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE. TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BLANKA ELEVENTH ECONOMIC
COUNTY AND AS PART OF STANDARD
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN HUNDRED. THANK
YOU. HER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX SHOWINGS UP AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX TO ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SHERRY AND I REPRESENT THE
TRUTH TELLERS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
HUNDRED AND THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE COVER
MODEL MOTHER OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE STUFF THANK
YOU. ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LISA LINDE IN
YELLOW COUNTY ON BEHALF OF MY
FAMILY WE OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU. TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT YEAR OLD IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS JESSICA FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I HAVE A CELL. THANK
YOU. THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
MCKINNEY I AM A NURSE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL WITH MY ENTIRE HEART.
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH OR- ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIFTY MILLION
CAPPUCCINO CANYON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VANESSA
SANTOS I LIVE IN SENECA COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT. THANK
YOU FOUR TIMES WITH NO
ADDITIONAL IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT- LOOK LET ME JUST
DISCUSS THE ORDER OF BUSINESS
HERE SO- THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
LAST BILL WE'RE GETTING HERE
BEFORE- OUR NOON OF WHERE WE ARE
IN OUR NOON RECESS WHERE WE HAVE
TO ATTEND OTHER ACTIVITIES- WILL
BE BACK AT ONE THIRTY- BUT
BEFORE WE LEAVE AT NOON I'M
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE ON ALL THE
OUTSTANDING MEASURES. SO GO BACK
TO SLEEP. BUT IF YOU'RE LOOKING
TO GET A MOVE- YES AND WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO- I BELIEVE HIS
FILE AND NUMBER TWO CONSIDERING
CENTER ACTUALLY IT IS BUILT. ALL
RIGHT. SO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SIR BARGES. THANK YOU
SURE. I TELL YOU I HAVE NEVER
SEEN. FOLKS RESPOND WITH SUCH A
LACK OF CIVILITY DECORUM HI IN-
LOCAL AFFAIRS OR EVEN STATE
AFFAIRS FRANKLY FEDERAL AS WELL-
SO THIS THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
RESONATES WITH ME- THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
YOU HAVE COME TO EXPECT. IN OUR
REPRESENTATIVE FORM OF
GOVERNMENT IS THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THE RIGHT TO APPEAL IN MAKE
THEIR OPINIONS KNOWN TO THEIR
RESPECTIVE LEGISLATIVE BODIES.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
INTIMIDATION THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE HARASSMENT THAT IS NOT
INCLUDING CIRCLING INDIVIDUALS
IN KEEPING THEM FROM ACCESSING
OR LEAVING A BUILDING OR GETTING
INTO THEIR CAR OR PROTESTING IN
FRONT OF THEIR HOMES. I'VE
SERVED ON THE CITY COUNCIL LEVEL
INVOLVES YOU'RE ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT PUSH THE ENVELOPE. IN THEIR
ORDER IN THOSE INDIVIDUALS
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. BUT
THERE'S A BALANCE HERE. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THE STATE IS
UNDERTAKING THIS WHEN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO USE THEIR BEST DISCRETION TO
REMOVE INDIVIDUALS HERE TODAY
ARE ELEVATING THEIR CONDUCT IN
SUCH A WAY. SO MAYBE I CAN THROW
THAT OUT THERE IS A QUESTION TO
THAT I FEEL THAT THERE IS
IMPORTANCE TO THIS MESSAGE. BUT
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK THAT
THIS IS A STATE RULE THAT NEEDS
TO BE PROMULGATED WHEN
JURISDICTION EXISTS ELSEWHERE.
US SECRETARY Z. FOR PROCEDURE
COMMON CENTER INTO. THE ISSUE IS
THAT THE BROWN ACT IS. HAS BEEN
IN IT IS CALLED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TAKES
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO CLARIFY OR
MODIFY IT AT ALL DESPITE THE
FACT THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ESTABLISH CERTAIN AREAS OF
DECORUM IN IN BASIC RULES OF
CONDUCT AND SO FORTH SO- THIS
THIS BILL IS GOING TO YOUR
COMMENTS OF JOST. IT MAY BE EVEN
MORE NARROWLY DEFINED IN YOUR
COMMENTS ACTUALLY BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY JUST TALKING ABOUT- YEAH
DISALLOWING MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR
AS TO WHEN YOU CAN DISALLOW THE
WILLFUL DESTRUCTION OF THE
MEETING- RENDERING A MEETING IN
FEASIBLE AS THIS. IS OBVIOUSLY
NOT GONNA WORK. CHRIS BUT- TO
PUT THOSE CLARIFICATIONS INTO
LAW- WE HAVE TO START WITH THE
BROWN ACT. THANK YOU SENATOR I'M
SORRY I FULLY APPRECIATED AND
I'VE SPENT A GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME
DEALING WITH THE BROWN ACT AT.
MUNICIPAL INC AND COUNTY LEVELS.
THIS IS A MATTER OF THIS IS A
TRUE MATTER OF LOCAL CONTROL.
CLARIFYING WHAT IS ALLOWABLE
THROUGH THE BROWN ACT THE BROWN
ACT IS OPEN DISCLOSURE OPEN
MEETING REQUIREMENTS. DECORUM
SETTING. IT LOOSE LARGELY
DECIDED BY THE CHAIR FOR THAT
RESPECTIVE BODY. AND SO I GUESS
WHAT I'M SAYING IS I UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU'RE DOING THIS I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS INAPPROPRIATE
USE OF STATE POWER- TO- TO GIVE
LOCALS WHAT THEY HAVE INHERENTLY
THAT GUYS RESPECTFULLY PUT THAT
OUT THERE. FOR YOU. JANUARY
THANK YOU- YES SERVERS FOR NIXON
CENTER LAYER. I WANT TO- ECHO-
COMMENT MADE IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE WAS THAT GOVERN
FINANCE I BELIEVE IT WAS WITH
SENATOR WIENER I THINK CUT TO
THE CHASE AND REALLY ELEGANTLY-
I MADE THE POINT ABOUT THIS
BILL. WHICH IS THE ESSENCE OF IT
. WE IN GOVERNMENT ENGAGING THE
HEARING PROCESS TO- DISCUSS
DEMOCRACY TO HAVE EVERYBODY'S
POINTS
SHOULD BE TO PROMOTE DEMOCRACY
AND TO AVOID FOLKS INTERRUPTING
THAT DEMOCRATIC DELIBERATIVE
pPROCESS EVERYBODY HAS THE RIGHT
TO PROTEST DISCUSSION ANYWAY
THEN THEY THEY WANT TO MAKE IT
HOME FOR A- CENTER WHERE TO
FURTHER MAKE THIS POINT BREAK
JUST **** PERMISSION BECAUSE I
WANT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR IT
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT MAKES THE
POINT ELEGANTLY. IN THE SENSE
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY PRO
DEMOCRACY AT ITS GREATEST
BECAUSE FOLKS COME INTO A ROOM
AND THEY IN FACT WANT TO SHUT
DOWN THE DILUTES THE
DELIBERATION- AND NOT. MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS ENGAGE IN THE
DISCUSSION SO. SHORT AT THAT
THOUGHT. GLAZER HERTZBERG SAID
EARLIER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO RESPOND
TO A PREVIOUS COMMENT BECAUSE-
IT WAS STATED THAT IT SHOULD BE
UP TO THE PERSON PRESIDING AT
THE MEETING IT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. I WAS EXACTLY THAT
PERSON. I WAS THE MAYOR. AT A
TIME. THAT A FULL ROOM LIKE THIS
SHOUTED US DOWN FOR AN HOUR AND
A HALF IN A BUDGET HEARING. AND
OUR CITY ATTORNEY ADVISED US WE
HAD NO RECOURSE BUT TO ALLOW IT
TO HAPPEN AND WE HAD TO SIT
THERE. WE COULDN'T HEAR BETWEEN
US WHAT WE ACTUALLY HAD SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC STANDING
AT THE PODIUM THAT COULD BARELY
AND GENERALLY NOT BE HEARD. BY
US AND OUR ATTORNEY ADVISED US
WE HAD NO RECOURSE. AND SO. WHEN
IT IS SAID THAT THAT A CHAIR OF
A OF A MEETING COULD COULD DO
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT RIGHT
AND I THINK WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE. THE END IN THE KEY ISSUE
WILL BE AS THIS BILL MOVES IS
HOW YOU DRAW THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN FREEDOM OF SPEECH. AND
DISRUPTION AND ENDED AT THE
AUTHOR OR AUTHORS HAVE GONE
ADDED IN A GOOD WAY AND MAYBE
THEY'LL BE QUESTIONS. BUT THERE
WAS NOT THAT ABILITY TO DO THAT
AND I CAN'T DESCRIBE. I'VE HAD
THAT MANY WEIRD MOMENTS IT IS
FOUR OR ELECTED THING OVER THE
SPAN OF FORTY YEARS BUT THAT WAS
ONE OF THE WORST BECAUSE- YOU
JUST POWERLESS YOU JUST BEING
COMPLETELY SHUT IT DOWN YOU HAD
NO CONTROL. THERE WAS NO RESPECT
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND
THAT WAS NOT EXPRESSING AN
OPINION THAT WAS NOT A COMMENT
THAT WAS AT A PODIUM IT WAS JUST
LITERALLY SHOUTED THE ENTIRE
TIME AND SO. I THINK THAT IS
WHAT THIS BILL. IS ADDRESSING.
THANK YOU SIR- JONES CENTER WHAT
CAL SKI. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE FOR.
YOUR TIME. VERY STRONG DIALOGUE-
THERE ARE SOME THINGS IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS ACT I DO AGREE
WITH- YOU MENTIONED THAT THESE
CASES ARE LIMITED AND RARE AND I
WOULD I THINK THAT THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S TRUE ESPECIALLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- I THINK
WHAT'S HAPPENED BECAUSE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA TWENTY FOUR HOUR
NEWS CYCLE AS THOSE LIMITED A
RARE OCCASIONS HAVE BEEN
SENSATIONALIZED BY THE MEDIA BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND HAS
DEVOLVED TO THOSE SITUATIONS ARE
ELEVATED MAYBE MIGHT BE A BETTER
TERM TWO ELSEWHERE. PEOPLE ARE
ASSUMING THAT THAT'S THE GENERAL
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THESE
MEETINGS I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE CASE- I THINK THAT WE DO
HAVE ALL THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED-
WITH THE BROWN ACT AND WITH THE
FIRST AMENDMENT OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. I DO WANT TO BE IN
A RECOGNIZE THE TWO SPEAKERS
THAT SPOKE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I THOUGHT THAT THE VERY
ELOQUENTLY AND GRACIOUSLY
PRESENTED THEIR POSITION TODAY.
BUT I DO WANT TO GO BACK TO YOU
KNOW WHAT I THINK IS. THE NUMBER
ONE TOOL WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE SITUATION IN THESE PUBLIC
MEETINGS. AND IN CENTER LEARNED
NOT TO BE SNARKY WIT. IF I GET A
NEW CITY ATTORNEY YOU KNOW IF
THAT WAS MY SITUATION- AND I'VE
BEEN ON THE CITY YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN A CITY COUNCIL- WE'VE HAD
YOU KNOW MY THE CITY THAT HAS ON
THE CITY COUNCIL WE HAD A SPLIT
IN THE CITY BETWEEN. FOLKS THAT
WANTED THE CITY TO DEVELOP AND
FOLKS THAT DIDN'T WANT THE CITY
TO DEVELOP AND- WHEN THERE WAS
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS COMING UP.
YOU KNOW WE GOT A VERY HEATED
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT. BUT I'M
OFTEN AMAZED BY THE FORESIGHT
AND THE INTELLECT OF OUR
FOUNDING FATHERS WHEN THEY WROTE
THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE
CONSTITUTION THEY WROTE THE
RIGHT OF THE PEOPLE PEACEABLY TO
ASSEMBLE AND TO PETITION THE
GOVERNMENT FOR A REDRESS OF
GOVERNMENT GRIEVANCES. I JUST
IMAGINE IF WHEN THEY WROTE THAT
. FIRST AMENDMENT IF THEY JUST
LEFT OUT THE WORD PEACEABLE. AND
I THINK ALL OF OUR MEETINGS AND
ALL OF OUR INTERACTION BETWEEN
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE PUBLIC
HINGED ON THAT ONE WORD
PEACEABLE. AND AS SOON AS I
THINK THAT'S THE GOVERNING
CONCEPT. IN THESE MEETINGS AS
LONG AS THE INTERACTION WITH THE
PUBLIC AT THESE MEETINGS IS
PEACEABLE. AS ELECTED OFFICIALS
WE HAVE A DUTY. TO STAY THERE
AND LISTEN AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT AS
SOON AS THE THAT TURNOUT BECOMES
UNFEASIBLE. THE PRESIDING
OFFICER OF THAT MEETING HAS THE
AUTHORITY AND THE DUTY. TO
REMOVE THOSE ON PEACEABLE
MEMBERS FROM THAT ASSEMBLY AND I
THINK IT'S IS CLEAR IN AS CLEAN
AS THAT- AND I'LL WRAP UP WITH
THIS I KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
FRUSTRATION FROM THE PUBLIC IN
DEALING WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
BODY AT THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN
THIS TIME OF KOBE HAD WITH. YOU
KNOW BEING ABLE TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
AND ONLY STATE YOUR POSITION.
BUT THERE'S FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALL FORTY MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
THAT RIGHT TO COME AND SPEAK TO
US ON THIS DYESS. BUT IT IS IT'S
NOT TENABLE FOR US TO GIVE
EVERYBODY. THREE MINUTES OR TWO
MINUTES OR WHATEVER. SO I'M
GOING WITH THIS IS FOR THE
PUBLIC YOU'RE NOT LIMITED TO TWO
YEARS SPEECH HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM. AND EXCHANGING
WITH THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE OR ANY COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE. ALL THE WAY UP UNTIL THE
TIME THE BILL COMES TO THE
COMMITTEE TO ENGAGE WITH YOUR
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS THERE
THROUGH THEIR EMAIL THROUGH
THEIR DISTRICT OFFICE TO THEIR
PHONE. DON'T LIMIT DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE JUST LIMITED TO YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION HERE- USE
THE RESOURCES THAT THE SENATE
PROVIDES YOU THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
YOU KNOW TO WRAP IT UP TO SOME
RISE I THINK THE FIRST AMENDMENT
TAKES CARE OF THIS. PROBLEM
WHERE THERE MIGHT BE HE IS IN
OUR CHALLENGE THE FIRST MEMBER
DOESN'T TAKE CARE OF IT
TIGHTENED CERTAINLY BELIEVE THE
BROWN ACT AS- AND- I ALSO WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TAKES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
JONES OTHERS TELLICO SKI. MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO MOVE FEE-
MATTER BUT AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BALANCING THE RIGHT TO DO
OUR BUSINESS AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PEOPLE
HAVE. WE CAN'T FORGET THE OTHER
PART OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
WHICH GIVES MEMBERS THE FIRST
MEMBER RIGHT TO. PETITION THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S SORT OF
WHAT'S NOT BEING LEFT OUT HERE
SO I. WISH YOU GOOD LUCK GOING
FORWARD AND WILL. THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS- CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I ALSO
JUST I HOPE IT DOESN'T GET LOST
THAT THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THAT
IT'S ABOUT TWO THINGS IT'S ABOUT
THE ABILITY OF. DECISION MAKERS
TO BE ABLE TO CONSIDERING THE
ISSUE AND CAST THEIR VOTE. BASED
ON THE MERITS AND FEEDBACK
THEY'RE GETTING AND NOT BASED ON
A FEAR. THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE- BASICALLY ON RASTATT HEARING
AND ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR AND FRANKLY
BULLYING. BEHAVIOR WE DON'T WANT
ELECTED OFFICIALS DEMOCRAT
REPUBLICAN CONSERVATIVE LIBERAL
WE WANT WE DON'T WANT THEM
MAKING DECISIONS. BECAUSE OF
FEAR. OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
PHYSICALLY- IN A CITY HALL OR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT YOU
CAN BE SUPER RIGHT WINGER SUPER
LEFT WING OR ANYWHERE IN BETWEEN
THAT'S GOOD THAT'S DEMOCRACY. AT
A TERMS OF REPRESENTATION BUT I
DON'T WANT ANYONE EVER TO HAVE
IN THEIR HEAD WILL IF I CAST
THIS VOTE. IS THAT GONNA MAKE
EVERYONE. SO UNSETTLED THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A
POTENTIALLY VIOLENT SITUATION
THAT'S NOT DEMOCRACY. THAT'S MOB
RULE. AND THAT IS NOT HOW WE
SHOULD BE RUNNING A DEMOCRACY
ANYWHERE IN THE REDDEST COUNTY
OR THE PLUMAS COUNTY. THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. I HAVE SPOKEN TO PEOPLE
WHO DON'T WANT TO GO AND MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT OR THEY WANT TO
GO MADE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT. BECAUSE
THEY ARE. THEIR FEAR ABOUT HOW
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE
GOING TO REACT TO THEM. AND
THERE FOR AND THIS IS YOU KNOW
EVEN THAT AND VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE STATE. AND I SHOULD NEVER BE
THAT WAY NO ONE SHOULD EVER BE
SCARED TO GO AND MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. NO ONE SHOULD EVER BE
FEARFUL TO THIS ASSEMBLY
CLARIFYING- IN THE BROWN ACT
BECAUSE THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE BOUND BY THE BROWN ACT. AND
IF THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY
EVEN THEN THEY COULD GET SUED.
AND THEY COULD LOSE AND WE WANT
TO JUST BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO SO THIS
IS A VERY IS A PRO DEMOCRACY
MEASURE. BECAUSE LET'S ALSO BE
CLEAR WHERE YOU ARE DECISION
MAKER WHETHER YOU'RE A STATE
SENATOR REPRESENTING A MILLION
PEOPLE OR CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
REPRESENTING TWENTY THOUSAND OR
A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE. YOU
REPRESENT AND ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO
EVERY SINGLE PERSON. IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT A LOT TO DO. NOT
ONLY THE PEOPLE WHO CAME IN AT
THE TIME. TO CALM AND MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT NOT ONLY PEOPLE
WHO AT THE TIME TO COME. AS WE
START YELLING OR GAZING UP INTO
THE INTERESTING BEHAVIOR YOU
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
EVEN KNOW THAT HEARING IS
HAPPENING. THEY'RE WORKING THREE
JOBS AND TRYING TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE AND SO THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S WHY I
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT A- THANK YOU
SIR WIENER OTHER COMMENTS-
CENTER STERN. YEAH JUST VERY
BRIEFLY WANTED I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS BRAVERY IN
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- AND WE
KNOW WHEN. WHEN YOU COME FOR THE
MEASURE LIKE THIS. WE'RE GOING
TO GET ANGRY AND- AND IT TAKES
COURAGE ESPECIALLY SOMEONE
SERVED AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL
TO BRING THIS DISCUSSION FORWARD
I WOULD NOTE THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS WELL THE TEXT OF THE
BILL ON THIS IS NOT AN OPEN
ENDED- REQUIREMENT THE DIFF THE
DEFINITION OF DISRUPTION ITSELF
BRINGS IN THE NOTION OF THE USE
OF FORCE OR TRUE THREATS OF
FORCE SO. TERMS THE COMMENT
ABOUT PEACE ABILITY OF THESE OF
THESE AND- OF THIS OF THIS
SPEECH I THINK THE BILL TAILORS
ITSELF NARROWLY TO THAT- AND
THEREFORE IN MY VIEW. SHOULD
MEET THE CONSTITUTIONAL
THRESHOLD AS WELL AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID THE NINTH
CIRCUIT. ON THE ONE THING I WANT
TO SAY THE WITH THE WITH WITH
VOTING ON THIS BILL I DO THINK
WE SHOULD OBLIGATE OURSELVES. TO
LOOKING FOR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC.
I THINK THAT THE FACT THAT A LOT
OF THE REMOTE HEARING
PARTICIPATION IS GOING TO SEIZE-
AFTER THIS PANDEMIC. AND THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY
ATTEND MEETINGS CAN BE LIMITED
BASED ON INCOME OR WHEN THEY ARE
WORKING PEOPLE FOR INSTANCE AND
CAN'T GO TO A MEETING. WE HAD
LEGISLATION PENDING FOR THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR AB THREE
THIRTY. OUR HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
ANOTHER BILL COMING BACK- THIS
YEAR AGAIN AB NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR FROM THE ASSEMBLY BUT-
LOOKING AT EXPANDING THAT ACCESS
SO. AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
TRYING TO ENSURE PEACE
STABILITY. AND HAVING SOME KIND
OF MODICUM OF SAFETY WHEN PEOPLE
ARE. TRYING TO GOVERNOR TRYING
TO TESTIFY WE ALSO PARTNER AN
OBLIGATION TO EXPAND ACCESS FOR
FOLKS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND I
THINK THERE ARE OPPRTUNITIES TO
DO THAT BOTH ON DIGITAL
PLATFORMS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
PARTICIPATE THOSE WHO COULDN'T
GET ALL THE WAY TO SACRAMENTO
TODAY BUT MAYBE ON THESE
FACEBOOK FEEDS OR WHATEVER
MAYBE. YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY TO. IT'S VERY HARD TO
MAKE THAT SOUTHWEST LATER EVEN
GET DOWNTOWN MAY DAY- SO I'D
LIKE TO SEE THIS LEGISLATURE
OBLIGATE ITSELF WITH. IF WE DO
END UP MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD-
WITH A COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING
ACCESS WHILE WE ENSURE- SECURITY
IN CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS BEING
PROTECTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER STERN ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO BE HEARD SINGING UP NO ONE
ELSE- ALL RIGHT- THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION BY SENATE WHITE HOUSE YOU
ONE FINAL POINT- I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR ELECTED OFFICIALS AT ALL
LEVELS BUT BUT- COUNTRY
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM- SEVERAL. OF
US CAN READ AND SO. IF THOSE WHO
WISH TO EXPRESS THEIR POINT OF
VIEW WHICH TO DO SO IN WRITING-
THEY CAN SUBMIT THOSE TO THE
SENATE WEBSITE- AS WELL AS THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND WE DO- TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION. THOSE
WRITTEN COMMENTS AS WELL SO.
HAVING SAID THAT. THE CENTRE
CORTESE NUCLEAR CLOSE. HERE SO
I'M SURE IT'LL BE A BRIEF
CLOSING FIRST FULL TO ME THANK
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE FOR-
REALLY PRODUCTIVE ASSISTANCE-
GETTING TO THIS POINT APPRECIATE
THAT- AND- APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION. AND I APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION OF THE PRIOR-
COMMITTEE HEARING- LOTS OF GOOD
AND IMPORTANT STUFF TO STE.
SAYING THAT WOULD REALLY BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT WE ARE AT SOME
POINT DEALING WITH
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES HERE- THE
BILL'S BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY WELL
THAT IT- I JUST WANT TO SAY IN
AND NOT TO BE ARGUMENTATIVE BUT
TO RESPOND IN MY CLOTHES- THE
BROWN ACT IS NOT CLEAR IF THAT
THE PRESIDING OFFICER. CAN TAKE
THOSE ACTIONS WHICH WERE. WHICH
WERE SPOKEN TO EARLIER- BUT ONE
OF THE SENATORS WERE CLEARING
THAT UP HERE- WE'RE SEEING THE
PRIVATE PRESIDING OFFICER.
KEENAN TAKE THOSE ACTIONS- IT
IT'S IT NOT ONLY A BIG USE THE
PRODUCT CURRENTLY BUT IF
ANYTHING IT SAYS THAT THE ENTIRE
BODY WOULD HAVE TO VOTE- TO TAKE
AN ACTION. YOU KNOW IN A
THREATENING SITUATION ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF IMPORTANT
CLEAN UP IN. REALLY EFFICIENCY
AND CLARITY THAT'S GOING ON HERE
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL-
THAT ENCROACHES ON. THE CONTENT
OF WHAT PEOPLE WOULD SAY NOTHING
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING I APPRECIATED
THE OPPOSITION I APPRECIATE
HEARING IT TODAY. IT CAUSES ME
TO THINK IT CAUSES ME TO REFLECT
THAT THINK IT CAUSES ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO REFLECT ON WHETHER
OR NOT WE ARE. THE NEARLY
TAILORING THIS APPROACH WELL
ENOUGH IN IN IN AND I BELIEVE WE
ARE- BUT I LISTENED CAREFULLY
I'VE LISTENED CAREFULLY FOR.
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MEETINGS TO THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
HOURS OF TESTIMONY. NEVER GOT UP
AND LEFT OR ABANDONED MY
POSITION REGARDLESS OF WHAT
PEOPLE WERE SAYING. THE BILL
REFLECTS THAT WHEN WE STARTED. I
MADE IT VERY VERY CLEAR TO MY
OWN STUFF. THAT THEY WERE TO BE
THERE IS TO BE ABSOLUTELY NO
CONTENT BASED REGULATION IN THIS
BILL WHATSOEVER PEOPLE ARE
ENTITLED TO SAY WHAT THEY WANT
TO SAY. PEOPLE ARE NOT TELL TO
COME OVER THAT REAL. IT'LL
GOVERNMENT MEETING PEOPLE AND
I'VE HAD THAT HAPPEN TO BE. A
PEOPLE ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
OCCUPY THE MICROPHONE BEYOND
REASONABLE TIME PLACE AND
MANNER. REGULATIONS AS TO HOW
LONG WE ALL KNOW THAT BUT PEOPLE
DO THAT. AND THEREFORE DENY
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THE RIGHT TO CONTINUE WITH
THE HEARING AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE WHO SPOKE TO THAT. SALUCES
EGGS. OF WHAT. BEING DEALT WITH
HERE AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE YEAH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE.
COUNTY COUNCIL TO CALL THE ROLL
. THIS IS SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
HUNDRED WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KEEP THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. UMBERG I AM
BURKE HI BORGIAS BARGES SNOW
COVER YEAH IT'LL- BE IT'LL I
DRESSEL. DRESS SO I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JONES.
JONES KNOWS LAYERED LAYERED ICE
STERN HI STERN I WAKE CAL
SKENEIDAE WHITE HOUSE HE AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE. I IT'S EIGHT
TWO TWO WITH A MEMBER MISSING
ARE I'M GONNA PUT THAT ON CALL
BEFORE EVERYONE LEAVES- WE'VE
HEARD SB ONE ONE ONE ONE BY SEN
ARCH ALETTA IS A SUB COMMITTEE
IS THERE A MOTION ON- ITEM
NUMBER TWO. S. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN
. SOME OF. CENTER CAREER MOVES
THE BILL. A MINUTE CHIEF COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL S. B.
ELEVEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR ARE TO
LET THAT. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR COVER YET ALL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
NUMBER I. AM BURKE AYE BURGESS.
ZERO CAREER I DID ASAL. THE
DRESS SO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. JOHNSON
VOTING LAYERED LAYERED I STERN.
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI Y. CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING TITLE PUT IT
BACK ON CALL MENTERI CONSERVE
YOU WOULD JUST OPEN THE ROLE IN
THE BILLS THAT WE'VE HEARD THUS
FAR AND THEN WE WILL BREAK FOR-
OF THE BREAK UNTIL ONE THIRTY ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE
CHECK VOTING AYE GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE THAT'S TENDS
ZERO WITH A MEMBER MISSING FILE
PUT BACK ON CALL- NEXT ITEM S.
B. TEN FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
BACKER THAT'S SB TEN FIFTY NINE
BY SENATOR BACKER. WITH THE
MOTION BASE. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING AYE BURGESS.
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY
LAYERED ON LAYERED I STERN STERN
HI WIENER. WE AYE THAT'S EIGHT
ONE WITH MEMBERS MISSING RIGHT
BACK ON CALL THE NEXT BILL IS
ALSO BY SENATOR BACKER IT'S S.
B. FOURTEEN NINETEEN WITH MOSHE
MY SENATOR KABBADI AT ALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING II
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI.
CLEARED CLEARED AYE STERN AYE
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI. Y. CASKEY. AYE WIENER WIENER AYE. THAT'S
EIGHT TO FAR WITH THE MEMBER
MISSING. ALL RIGHT PUT IT BACK
ON CALL WE'LL BREAK NOW TILL ONE
THIRTY THANK YOU WHERE
JOURNALISTS WERE RECESSED
RATHER. WORSE SO.
AS I ANNOUNCED EARLIER WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER- AT ONE THIRTY IS
NOW ONE FORTY THREE SO INVITE
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO JOIN US-
MAN PRO TEM. S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE SPORTFISHING.
WELL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. WITH
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. IF YOU
WOULD ASK ME THIRTY YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS MANAGING A CLINIC
FIVE AND SERVICES AT A WOMEN'S
HEALTH CLINIC. IF I WOULD STILL
BE TALKING ABOUT DEFENDING ROE
VERSUS WADE AND FIGHTING FOR
ABORTION ACCESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO UNFORTUNATELY I WOULD HAVE
SAID MOST LIKELY. AND THAT IS
TRUE STILL TODAY. IN STATE
HOUSES IN COURTHOUSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
SUPREME COURT OUR REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS ARE BEING STOLEN FROM US.
ONCE AGAIN WOMEN ARE BEING
PUSHED TO EXTREME MEASURES TO
ACCESS ABORTION CARE ONCE AGAIN
THERE THEY HAVE ARE THEY FACE
HAVING TO PUT THEIR BODIES IN
DANGER. THE SUPREME COURT'S
IMPENDING DECISION ON A CASE
THAT WILL DESTROY ROE VERSUS
WADE AND THE REAL REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM IN AMERICA IS BIGGER
THAN THIS ONE BUILT. AND IT HAS
A VERY REAL IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF MANY OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES.
THAT DECISION WILL CARRY THE
WEIGHT OF MILLIONS OF WOMEN WHO
WILL NOT HAVE THE AUTONOMY OVER
THEIR OWN BODIES. IT'S A
DECISION THAT WILL IMPACT WOMEN
FAMILIES AND OUR COUNTRY FOR
DECADES TO COME. IT'S ONE WE
NEED TO PREPARE FOR IN EVERY WAY
THAT WE CAN AND SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AS PART OF THAT
PREPARATION. BY GIVING MORE
TRAINED AND QUALIFIED NURSE
PRACTITIONERS THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE ABORTIONS WITHOUT THE
SUPERVISION OF A DOCTOR. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE IS A
PROACTIVE STEP TO FURTHER
INCREASE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
QUALITY REPRODUCTIVE CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR STATE IS FACING
A SERIOUS SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY
CARE CLINICIANS ESPECIALLY. IN
SOME OF OUR LATINO BLACK AND
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES A
PROBLEM THAT'S EXPECTED TO GET
EVEN MORE DIRE OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. CURRENTLY OVER 40% OF
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
EVEN HAVE CLINICS THAT PROVIDE
ABORTIONS. THOSE TWO FACTORS
COMBINED MEAN THAT FAR TOO MANY
PREGNANT PEOPLE WHO MAY NEED TO
CONSIDER ABORTION AS AN OPTION
CANNOT DO SO. CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG BEEN A LEADER IN
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS. BUT THE
PRACTICAL NEED TO ENSURE REAL
ACCESS IS FAR FROM COMPLETE. ONE
EARLY STEP I TOOK WAS OFFERING
AB ONE FIFTY FOUR IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO EXPAND THE TYPES OF
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO CAN
PERFORM FIRST TERM ABORTIONS
WITH SUPERVISION OF A DOCTOR TO
INCLUDE NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
THEN SEVEN YEARS LATER THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB EIGHT
NINETY AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AND IT
CREATED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
QUALIFYING NURSE PRACTITIONERS
TO CARE FOR PATIENTS WITHOUT THE
SUPERVISION OF A DOCTOR. AND NOW
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THOSE LAWS
CAN WORK TOGETHER IN UNISON. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WOULD MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WHO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY CAN ALSO PROVIDE
FIRST TERM ABORTIONS WITHOUT
FISH PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO CLARIFY THAT
AMONG OTHER CRITERIA NURSE
PRACTITIONERS NEED THREE YEARS
OF EXPIRY AND- UNDER A PHYSICIAN
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY. ACTIVE SHOOTERS
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE CARE
ALLOWING EXPERIENCED NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO UTILIZE THEIR
FULL TRAINING AND EDUCATION.
WILL EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED REPRODUCTIVE CARE
PRACTITIONERS PARTICULARLY IN
AREAS LACKING ACCESS TO CARE. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BILLS OFF
OF THE SUCCESS OF THESE TWO
PRIOR LEGISLATION TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE WHILE ALSO
LIFTING UP WORKFORCE OF SKILLED
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND GIVING
THEM MORE OPPORTUNITIES CARE FOR
THEIR OWN PATIENTS. WHAT TIME
SEEMS TO BE MOVING BACKWARD IN
MANY PLACES ACROSS THE NATION
THIS BILL WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WITH YOUR PERMISSION I
HAVE THOUGHT TO INDIVIDUALS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CHRISTY WE
SAW BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. AND DEBBIE
BAMBERGER WHO IS A WOMEN'S
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN EAST
OAKLAND THANK YOU MA'AM PUT THEM
JUST OF BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH-
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION LET ME
JUST. A REFRESH EVERYONE'S
MEMORY AS TO THE- PROTOCOL HERE
SO EACH SIDE ON THIS BILL AND
ALL THE OTHER BILLS THAT ARE-BEING HEARD THIS AFTERNOON. WILL
HAVE- TWO WITNESSES WILL BE
PERMITTED TO TESTIFY FOR TWO
MINUTES TWO WITNESSES FOR TWO
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE. AFTER
THAT. WILL TAKE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF THOSE WHICH SAYS
FIND SUPPORT WILL GIVE US THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND THE
POSITION THE BILL THE SAME GOES
FOR THOSE. IN OPPOSITION SO.
LET'S BEGIN- WITH- THE PROMISE
WE SUBMITS WIESE'S HERE IF YOU
TO PRODUCE MICROPHONE THANK YOU
THE SWISS THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRISTIE WEEKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE FIRST TIME
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND- AS THE PERSON MENTIONED WE
HAVE ONE OF OUR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS HERE DEBBIE
BAMBERGER AND I'D LIKE TO. HAVE
HER COME UP IN HER A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE IN THE
SPACE AND- CREATE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANKS THANK YOU
DECEMBER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO HEAR AND DISCUSS
THIS IMPORTANT BILL IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ISSUE TODAY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
PROTON FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING ACCESS
TO ABORTION SERVICES. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE BAMBERGER I'M A WOMEN'S
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN EAST
OAKLAND AND A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS MEMBER I'M ALSO ON
THE ADVISORY BOARD FOR TEACH
WHICH IS TRAINING IN EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. I'VE BEEN A
PRACTICING NURSE PRACTITIONER
FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AND
RECENTLY COMPLETED MY DOCTORATE
IN NURSING PRACTICE AT UCSF. IN
MY WORK AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD I
PROVIDE FAMILY PLANNING
GYNECOLOGY AND ABORTION SERVICES
BOTH MEDICATION AND ASPIRATION.
I WAS THE FIRST NURSE
PRACTITIONER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE LEGALLY TRAINED
TO DO ASPIRATION ABORTION WHEN
SENATOR ATKINS PREVIOUS BILL AB
ONE FIFTY FOUR WAS MADE LAW.
ALLOWING SUPERVISED AND PEAS
PDAS AND NURSE MIDWIVES TO
PROVIDE ABORTION SERVICES TO OUR
PATIENTS. AT MY CLINIC WE SERVE
A DIVERSE URBAN POPULATION WITH
PATIENTS COMING FROM ALL
SURROUNDING AREAS TO RECEIVE
CRITICALLY NEEDED REPRODUCTIVE
CARE. CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A
SHORTAGE OF ABORTION PROVIDERS
OVER 40% OF COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T EVEN HAVE A-
CLINIC THAT PROVIDES ABORTION.
AND BECAUSE OF THE ATTACKS ON
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND IN OTHER
STATES I'M ALREADY SEEING
PATIENTS FROM TEXAS TRAVELING
HALFWAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
GET AN ABORTION. PROCEDURE THAT
TAKES ABOUT FIVE MINUTES. SB
THIRTEEN SEVEN FIVE INCREASE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY ABORTION AND
REPRODUCTIVE CARE BY CONTINUING
THE INTENT OF TWO PREVIOUS BILLS
AB ONE FIFTY FOUR AND AB EIGHT
NINETY. BECAUSE AB EIGHT NINETY
GIVE CALIFORNIA AND P. IS THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE WITHOUT
PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
BRING THE STATUTE ALLOWING AND
PEACE TO PROVIDE FIRST TRIMESTER
ABORTIONS. IN LINE WITH ALL OF
THE OTHER HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE. SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF SENATOR ATKINS
PREVIOUS BILL AB ONE FIFTY FOUR
. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND PEAS
ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND PROVIDERS
WHO WILL TRAIN THEM AS MANY OF
THE TRAINING PROCEDURES ARE
GIVEN TO PHYSICIAN RESIDENTS
RATHER THAN OTHER PROVIDERS.
THERE'S A PARTICULAR DEARTH OF
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES IN AREAS
LIKE FRESNO BAKERSFIELD AND
RIVERSIDE SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WOULD NOT ONLY INCREASE
ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES BUT
WOULD EXPONENTIALLY GROW THE
PROVIDER POOL SINCE EXPERIENCED
AND PEAS COULD TRAIN OTHER MPS
IN ABORTION SERVICES. THERE IS
NO REASON THAT ABORTION SHOULD
BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY FROM
OTHER PROCEDURES AND PEAS
PROVIDE EVEN BEFORE AB EIGHT
NINETY I WAS PROVIDING ABORTION
CARE AND SERVING PATIENTS WITH
MY SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN WAS NOT
PHYSICALLY PRESENT OFTEN HOURS
AWAY I KNOW MY LIMITATIONS. I
KNOW WHEN TO CONSULT OTHER
PROVIDERS AND I KNOW WHEN TO
CALL FOR HELP SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD ALLOW ME TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ABORTION
SERVICES WITHOUT THE UNNECESSARY
STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES THAT
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF MPS WHO CAN.
PRACTICE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW AS TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IF
YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE-
THOSE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU TO UP
THE REPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA MATSUBARA
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SIGNAL ON
APPROACH TO THE MICROPHONE
MATAMATA- ONE MORE. APOLOGIES
FRIEND SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
CULTURE OBG WEIGH INS WE
ACTUALLY OF THE SPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION AND LOOK FOR TO
CONTAINERS QUESTIONS WITH THE
PRO TEM'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS SOME
ISSUES THAT REMAIN IN THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
SEE NO ONE ELSE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED LIST UNDER THE PHONE
LINE MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD TO UP THOSE IN SUPPORT. OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THE
COMMENTS SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. OF COURSE WE GO TO LINE
THREE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINES OPEN. WANT TO LINE FOR
TEN. NINETY FOUR TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON ISABEL ARE
QUITE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN THE RALPH RETORT
CALIFORNIA IS THE FOR EACH YEAR.
YOU THANKS TO THE TIMELINE FOR
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON TOMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANKS TO THE TO LINE
FOR FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI KATHY THEN OFTEN ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE FOR FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROCKSTAND
GOLD REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE PROBLEM
WITH THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IS SOMETHING QUITE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT IN LINE FOR
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE L. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS ONLY A PORTION FIND
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
WE'RE IN FULL COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FOR TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF
PEOPLE AT WITH GOVERN FOR
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THE TIME
FOUR THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON BUT BOND ALKI
WITH SEIU STATE COUNCIL NURSERY
THOUSAND MEMBERS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NICHOLAS LINE FOR
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MULTICHANNEL THE
CENTRAL OFFICE HEALTH INSURANCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY THE TIME
THERE'S NO THERE'S IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT LET'S
NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION THERESA
BRENNAN AND J. GAIL MITCHELL- IF
YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. OUR
OFFICE. ONE GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MY NAME IS THERESA
BRENNAN I'M A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY AND PRESIDENT OF THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE AMERICA'S
FIRST PRO LIFE ORGANIZATION
FOUNDED RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
. THIS LEGISLATURE IS OBVIOUSLY
HELL BENT ON INCREASING ACCESS
TO ABORTION IN OUR STATE BUT
PLEASE ASK YOURSELF IF WE SHOULD
DO THAT AT ANY COST. THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW NURSES TO PERFORM
ABORTIONS IN HOME HEALTH
SETTINGS AND RURAL POP UP
CLINICS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE
IS A MISTAKE OR AN EMERGENCY
DOCTOR WON'T BE THERE. A
HOSPITAL WILL BE TOO FAR AWAY.
AS MEMBERS OF THIS JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE EACH OF YOU
UNDERSTANDS THE SOMETIMES
DEPLORABLE HISTORY OF OUR
NATION. WHEN LOOKING BACK IT HAS
ALWAYS TURNED OUT TO BE A
SHAMEFUL TRAVESTY WITH SOCIETY
IS WILLING TO INTENTIONALLY DE
HUMANIZE AND MISTREAT A GROUP OF
HUMAN PEOPLE FOR REASONS OF
CONVENIENCE OR FINANCIAL BENEFIT
OF ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE. THIS
ISSUE IS AT ITS CORE A HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUE AND PRO LIFE
CITIZENS ARE STANDING ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY. WE FEEL
FOR MOTHERS WHO WILL BE BURDENED
BY CARRYING THEIR HUMAN CHILD
UNTIL IT CAN BE ADOPTED OR
OTHERWISE CARED FOR AND WE AGREE
THAT WE MUST PROVIDE EVERY
POSSIBLE SERVICE AND SUPPORT TO
BOTH MOTHER AND CHILD. BUT WE
CANNOT PRETEND THESE ARE NOT
PEOPLE WHOSE BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS
ARE BEING TRAMPLED IN THIS
CAPITOL BUILDING EVERY
LEGISLATIVE SEASON. CONSIDER
SENATORS WHETHER YOU CAN FIND
ONE INSTANCE IN HISTORY WHERE
ACTIVIST STANDING AGAINST THE DE
HUMANIZATION OF A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WERE ALTERNATELY FOUNDED
TO BE WRONG. CONSIDER SENATORS
WHETHER YOU ARE ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF HISTORY VOTE NO ON S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU- IS J. GAIL MITCHELL.
MY NAME IS MAJOR GAIL MITCHELL
AND I AM A RETIRED REGISTERED
NURSE HAVING PROVIDED CARE FOR
MANY PATIENTS DURING MY FORTY
EIGHT YEAR CAREER IN CIVILIAN
NURSING AS WELL AS TWENTY YEARS
IN THE MILITARY WITH THE UNITED
STATES ARMY RESERVE AND I
ADVANCED TO THE RANK OF MAJOR
FIVE SERVED IN BOTH CIVILIAN
HOSPITAL SETTINGS AS WELL AS ON
THE BATTLEFIELD AND I HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH PHYSICIANS
SURGEONS MEDICAL RESIDENTS
PHYSICIANS ASSISTANTS NURSE.
PRACTITIONERS NURSE ANESTHETISTS
AND NURSES AT ALL LEVELS
THROUGHOUT MY MILITARY AND MY
CIVILIAN CAREER POSITION
OVERSIGHT AND STANDARDIZED
PROCEDURES ARE THE FOUNDATION
FOR PROVIDING QUALITY PATIENT
CARE AND Y EXPANDING SECTION
ONE TWO THREE FOUR SIX EIGHT OF
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILSHIRE
ROAD BOTH OVERSIGHT IN
STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES THAT
REDUCING HEALTH CARE SUPERVISION
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION ESPECIALLY MINORITY
WILL YOUNG WOMEN WHO ACCESS
ABORTION SERVICES. THE BILL WILL
PERMIT LESSER SKILLED
INDIVIDUALS TO PERFORM A LIFE
THREATENING PROCEDURE UNDER
ANESTHESIA IN RURAL POP UP
CLINICS THE RISK FROM ABORTION
INCLUDE PERMANENT DAMAGE TO THE
UTERUS WHICH CAN RESULT IN
STERILITY PERFORATION OF THE
UTERUS AND RISK OF INFECTION
SEPSIS AND DEATH COMPLICATIONS
FROM ANESTHESIA INCLUDING DEATH
AND LASTING DAMAGE TO THE CERVIX
WHICH CAN COMPROMISE FUTURE
PREGNANCIES ALL OF THESE RISK
NEGATIVELY IMPACT. FUTURE
CHILDBEARING. AS STATED GOAL OF
THE IS THAT OF EQUITY ESPECIALLY
FOR BLACK INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND OHER UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS POSITIONS ARE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE. SO WHO
CHOOSES THAT WHICH WOMAN OF
COLOUR RECEIVES THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF CARE BY PHYSICIANS. BY
EXPANDING THE AUTHORITY TO
PERFORM ABORTIONS TO INCLUDE
LESSER TRAINED INDIVIDUALS THE
BILL NECESSARILY LOWERS THE
LEVEL OF CARE AVAILABLE FOR
THESE POPULATIONS THAT IS NOT
EQUITY THANK YOU MAJOR MITCHELL
GO HEAD WRAP IT UP. OKAY THAT'S
NOT THAT'S EXPANDED ACCESS TO
THE SUB STANDARD CARE WITH
HEIGHTENED RISK AND IF THERE IS
A PROBLEM THEN THE DOCTOR IS NOT
THERE ALL RIGHT- I AM THE PAY
VOTE NO THANK YOU. NEXT OF THOSE
OPPOSITION YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
REPROACH THE MICROPHONE. HI MY
NAME IS TASHA WHAT'S ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO ABORTION
SERVICES ALL RIGHT ALL THE
DRESSING SHOES IN THE BILL
RELATED AGENCIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NAME IS GABRIELLE
ENGRAM STANDUP SECOMBE COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
TODAY MY NAME IS LISA DISTRO I'M
WITH CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS
AND INFORM PARENTS OF CONTRA
COSTA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
OSCAR SORIANO FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
NOT IN THE- FROM WEST COVINA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS NATASHA SERRANO FROM HACIENDA
HEIGHTS AND I STRONG AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE
CHECK THE BABY IN THE WHEN YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JERRY SANTIAGO AND
I'M FROM PITTSBURGH CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
. HI MALINA MEMBER OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY LIBERTY COALITION
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
. MALAYSIAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINDA RICH PLASTER COUNTY
RESIDENT I OPPOSE S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. MISTER
MEMBERS TO MATT AND REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY PLASTIC
SURGEONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE TRANSITION OF
PRACTICE PROVISIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
TERRA TENCENT AND I REPRESENT
ALTADENA CALIFORNIA- OPPOSING
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS OF JANA MONCADA FROM MENIFEE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. JESSICA GARCIA
FROM L. A. COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR.
HI THERE MY NAME IS ARNOLD FROM
REALTOR CALIFORNIA NEXT FROM THE
POLLS THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS DAISY CONTRAST FROM
ONTARIO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
WELL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME'S
DANIEL OF ALASKA'S AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL FROM
HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TERRA GONZALEZ I'M
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SAYING NO ONE ELSE
TWELVE HUNDRED- WISHED TO
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE. WHO WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON. SB. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THURMOND ABOUT
PRESS THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WHICH PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. TOTALING
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE
FIVE AND MY NAME IS KATRINA
CANTRELL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
WOMEN'S HEALTH SPECIALISTS-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. SEVERAL NINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MEDICARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDED MARCHING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN THE PARKING LOT
COMMENDED PHYSICIAN APPRECIATE-
THE PROGRAM'S WORKING BUT FOR TO
CONTINUE IN ARTIST THANK YOU.
TWO BILLION FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
ANY HEARING FROM CANYON COUNTY.
THANK YOU OUR- FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN LET'S GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JEREMY NURSING IN THE
FOUNDER OF HEALTHCARE FOR
FREEDOM OF BROADLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. FOUR HUNDRED NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN IT'S
DIFFICULT OPEN COLUSA COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE ITSELF THANK
YOU. TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KENNETH PHELPS FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTYAND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS FAIRLY
HOLDEN PRESIDENT OF SUMMER YOU
KNOW COUNTY- I WANT TO CONCERT
OUTLETS FROM THE- CLOSE FIELD
ONE THREE NINE FIVE THANK YOU.
FOR AND EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIZES TELL ME BALLOTS
WITH CAP RESEARCH INSTITUTE AND
AUTHOR TO SB. FIVE THANK YOU.
THREE HUNDRED AND. NINETY FISCAL
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SPECIAL WILLIAMS- LAST PRESIDENT
OF THE COMPUTER ALSO A
RESTAURANT THEN THINKING BE
GRABBING FOR YOUR THANK AND WE
ARE STRONG OPPOSITION OF THE
FIELD THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
FOR NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR HUNDRED NINETY NINE
SOMETHING PUT GO AHEAD. HEY-
MANY AT THE END OF THE AND I AM
AND NUMBER OF LUGGAGE CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
THANK YOU. FOR EIGHTY ONE IS
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
WHAT ONTO FROM VENTURA AND A
STRONG OPPOSE BILL THANK. FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OF. YES MY NAME IS ONE
ANOTHER THING FULL. AND I AM
ALSO A MEMBER OF IN THE BACK
MENTAL COUNT. STRONGLY S. B. ONE
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN CRITICAL.
RAMOS JOB- I'M FROM START COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIRTEEN FIVE THANK
YOU. FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YUP OF KERRY
ARNOLD FROM IN YOUR COUNTY GOOD
AFTERNOON AND AYE. SB. ONE THREE
SEVEN FIVE STRONGLY THANK YOU
FOR. FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM I AM THE BILL
HOME AND I'M MY NAME IS GERRY
BAILEY AND HER CAN ALREADY THANK
YOU WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS NICOLE AND I'M
PAYING FOR TO COUNTY IN I STRONG
OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN FIVE THANK
YOU. THE ROAD INTO THE TIME ALL
RIGHT- C. NO FURTHER. WITNESSES
WHICH TO SIGN UP TO HUNDRED NO
ONE IS ON THE PHONE LINE- LET'S
BRING IT BACK HERE TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF SIR WIENER. YES- ONE OF THE
GOD PRO TEMP BRINGING THIS
EXTREMELY- IMPORTANT BILL- WE
KNOW THAT IN GENERAL- WE HAVE- A
SHORTAGE OF PHYSICIANS A
SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS AND WE'RE
GOING TO- TRAGICALLY SEE MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE IN NEED OF A
PORTION SERVICES HERE. AS OTHER
STATES- EFFECTIVELY BAN
ABORTION- AND AS THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT- I HOPE NOT BUT
POTENTIALLY- CUTS ARE OVERRULES
ROBY WADE- AND SO WE NEED TO
EXPAND- IT WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE.
THESE LIFESAVING SERVICES IN
THIS IS A MATTER. OF LIFE AND
DEATH- I DON'T THINK I'M BEING
DRAMATIC AND SAYING THAT- AND
SO- I'M VERY SUPPORT OF THIS
HAPPY TO MOVE IT. THANK YOU SIR
WIENER. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS ARE COMMON. OF
THE RECORDS YOU COULD CLOSE
THANK YOU. MISTER I WILL WITH
JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS.
THERE IS ONE ASPECT OF THE ISSUE
RELATED TO PATIENT PROTECTIONS
THAT HOT NO ONE RAISED TODAY NOT
DIRECTLY. AND ONE UNFORTUNATELY
THAT I'M INTIMATELY FAMILIAR
WITH IF THERE ARE NO AVAILABLE
QUALIFIED CLINICIANS WILLING OR
ABLE TO PROVIDE ABORTION CARE
WOMEN WHO NEED ABORTIONS WILL
SEEK THEM OUT REGARDLESS. AND
THE RESULTS WILL NOT BE IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF PATIENT SAFETY
CONSUMER PROTECTION OR THE
INDIVIDUALS OR THEIR FAMILIES.
WE DO NEED TO EXPLICITLY. AGAIN
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL
ENABLE EXPERIENCED QUALIFIED
TRAINED CERTIFIED PRACTITIONERS
TO BOOST OUR REPRODUCTIVE AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE. I BROADEN
ACCESS TO QUALITY OF CARE. AND
ADDRESS THE WORK FORCE SHORTAGE
OF PRIMARY CARE CLINICIANS USING
QUALIFIED TRAINED PRACTITIONERS
IN NINE OTHER STATES QUALIFIED
AND TRAINED NURSE PRACTITIONERS
PROVIDE FIRST TRIMESTER ABORTION
WITHOUT THE SUPERVISION OF
PHYSICIANS. CALIFORNIA ALREADY
REQUIRES MORE HOURS OF TRAINING
FORTY SIX HUNDRED. AND YEARS
THREE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE THAT HAS A
TRANSITION TO PRACTICE FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER IN OUR RESPECT OUR OF THE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY BUT CALIFORNIA
IS NOT A LEADER YET. NOR AHEAD
OF NINE OTHER STATES WHO ALLOW
CALTRAIN PROVIDERS TO ASSIST
THEIR PATIENTS WHO NEED ACCESS.
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES
AN ABORTION WE CAN CHANGE THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I CAUGHT.
BETTER OF. WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL SMOOTH VOICE WIENER. YES
THIS IS THE S. THIRTEEN FIVE BY
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE EIGHT
OF THE STATE SENATE TONI ATKINS-
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER AT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. I'M BURKE AYE FORTUS.
CABALLERO DOCILE RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. LAYERED
STERN RIGHT STERN I WHITE HOUSE
CHIARI WHAT KASKY AYE WIENER
WIENER I HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO SO
FAR ALL RIGHT- MEMBER TIMOTHY
PUT ON CALL THANK YOU YOU. ALL
RIGHT- I DO NOT SEE CENTER
EGGMAN HERE BUT I DO SEE CENTER
LEYVA. SOL ONE OF WE DO THIS.
LET'S SAW. LET'S GO TO ITEM FILE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S. B. NINE
THIRTY ONE BY CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND TO
BE CLEAR I DID SPEAK WITH CENTER
EGGMAN AND SHE SAID HE JUST FINE
IF I WENT IN FRONT OF HER ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND THEIR STAFF
ON THIS BILL I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON
PAGE FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. MEMBERS SENATE BILL
NINE THIRTY ONE IMPLODE IMPOSES
PENALTIES ON PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
FOR UNLAWFULLY ATTEMPTING TO
DETER OR ENCOURAGE DISCOURAGE
EMPLOYEES FROM JOINING OR
PARTICIPATING IN A UNION AT THE
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
DETERRING UNION MEMBERSHIP BY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND APPLICANTS
FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALSO
ALREADY AUTHORIZED TO BRING
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES
YOU L. P.'S AT THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD PER PER
PERSON PRECISELY THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR HOWEVER IN VIOLATION OF
THE LAW SOME PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
HAVE SET OUT ANTI UNION
COMMUNICATIONS REPEATEDLY TO
EXISTING BARGAINING UNITS FOR
WORKERS ATTEMPTING TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN AN EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATION SIX. THE SHOOTING
PER TO GRANTED UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGE PER CAN ONLY
ISSUE A CEASE AND DESIST ORDER
REQUIRING THE EMPLOYER TO POST
NOTICE OF A VIOLATION. SADLY BY
THIS POINT THE DAMAGE IS ALREADY
DONE. IT IS CLEAR THAT SOME
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ARE STILL
WILLING TO BREAK THE LAW AND
WILL CONTINUE TO VIOLATE THEIR
EMPLOYEES RIGHT TO ORGANIZE. THE
LEGISLATURE ACTS TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES SB NINE
THIRTY ONE WOULD IMPOSE A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY PER
VIOLATION PER AFFECTED EMPLOYEE
NOT TO EXCEED ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. BY CREATING
THIS FINANCIAL PENALTY EMPLOYEES
WILL HOPEFULLY THINK TWICE
BEFORE PURPOSELY DISCOURAGING
UNION ACTIVITY IN THE SECTOR.
WHY THIS BILLS IMPORT AND NEEDED
HIS MAP BROUGHT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND BY PHONE
MICHELLE CASTRO WITH SEIU
MEMBERS AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR LEYVA ARMS
WROTE GO AHEAD MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS- AS
CENTER LEYVA SAID WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE- YOU
KNOW WE JUST HAD THAT THE
PRIVILEGE AND FORTUNE OF HEARING
FROM. YOU LEAD THE WAY NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO IN ENACTING SECTION
THIRTY FIVE FIFTY WHICH SPOKE
BROADLY AND CLEARLY THAT
EMPLOYER SHOULD NOT BE DETERRING
OR DISCOURAGING. FIVE PUBLIC
SECTOR UNION ORGANIZING ACTIVITY
THAT'S THE POLICY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES HE SPEAKS CLEARLY ABOUT
EMPLOYER NEUTRALITY BY PUTTING
IN PLACE A MEANINGFUL AND
ROBUST. HI PENALTY AND SMITH- ON
VIOLATIONS OF THIRTY FIVE FIFTY-
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT ASKING THE
WORLD EMPLOYERS WE'RE ASKING
THEM TO BE NEUTRAL OBVIOUSLY CAN
. THIS STATE NOT GOING TO. THE
PANEL. AND FIND SAY WITH THE
BABIES I SEE. THAT MEN WERE. I
TAKING A GOOD IN HARD. MAKE SURE
THAT PRIVILEGED FLY. AND TO BE
SORT OF. TESTER OF THOSE CAN
FROM OPPOSITE. SO WITH THAT I
URGE YOUR AT THE YOU THANK YOU
MISS ROSS- ALSO. MR CASTRO ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. READ THANK YOU
FOR ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. MISS
CASTRO- ALL RIGHT FIFTY S.
CASTROAPPEARS ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD LET US
KNOW- OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF PROVIDE US
YOUR NAME FILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION IF YOU APPROACH THEM
UP. FROM. HELLO CARE AND MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION UP HOW CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SOUTH BRAMBLE ON BEHALF
OF MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EDUCATORS THE MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OTHERS A ROOM OF
HUNDRED SAYING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MIKE FROM LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONE LINE MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD. TWO OF THOSE WHO
ARE IN. OF S. B. NINE THIRTY ONE
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A FIFTY NINE THREE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE COMPUTER ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MAC ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE A DANCE
FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
. FIVE HUNDRED TEAM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. J. MEMBERS HAVE MARIN
WITH THEIR OWN READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SITE IS IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIVE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SENATORS THAT SUPERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NAY YES OF COURSE.
OKAY I SUPPORT THIS BILL MY NAME
IS TERRY RADIO THAT INVENTOR
COUNTY. THANK YOU NEXT. FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
UMBERG DISS KAI THEY'RE WALKING
IN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL BECAUSE YOU STAYED AT-THE STATE OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS
AND WESTERN STATE. WORKERS INTO
THE NATIONAL UNION OF ELEVATOR
COULD. IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALONG BEHALF OF SMART
KEY LEGISLATIVE BOARDS FOR LOCAL
ZERO ZERO TWENTY THREE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- NO FURTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. COMMENTS SINGLE
QUESTIONS FOR OPPOSITION. THE
GOOD POINTS THERE LEYVA IS MUCH%
IS THAT IT WOULD BE LIKE TO BE
UNOPPOSED. LIKE I. DO NOT THE IN
PRINCIPLE WITH THIS IS ABOUT BUT
I DO SEE FOLKS THEY BY SO OF
THOSE WISHES TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. HE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. THANK AND MEMBERS
AND SENATOR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
DOROTHY JOHNSON WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ALSO BEHALF OF A
BROAD COALITION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EDUCATION AGENCIES WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND WE DO APPRECIATE IT
. TURN BUT THEY ARE PRESENCE
FOUGHT. AND I SHE THE ANALYSIS
INCLUDING WHAT AMERICAN. AND
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF THE
GONNA START SAYING WE UNDERSTAND
THE INTENT AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL WE ARE NOT. TO REMOVE
THE PENALTY AS I UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW ONCE THE DEED IS DONE IT'S
DONE BUT WE ARE ASKING. ABSOLUTE
IS A LOT WHICH IS THE- ARE
ASSESSED AND WE'VE PROVIDED
SUGGESTED LANGUAGE THAT WE HOPE
TO KEEP WORKING ON THAT WOULD
ALIGN THIS BILL MORE CLOTHES.
ONE THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR
AND TAKE THE FACT. THIS YEAR-
THAT WOULD PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS FOR WHICH
THE PENALTY IS BEAT INCLUDING
THE SIZE THE NATION'S THE. ASIAN
ALSO THE TEACHER OR THE- WITHOUT
THE HARSHNESS OF THE VILE. AND-
BECAUSE HONESTLY THAT ONE
THOUSAND PENALTY. IS SUCH AN
EXTREME PENALTY FOR OUR SMALLEST
LOCAL AGENCIES AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- AND JUST THIRTEEN
MONTHS AGO PER DECIDED THEIR
TEST CLEAN PARAMETERS- ON THIS
FOR WHAT WOULD CONSTITUTE THE-
ODD DETERRING OR DISCOURAGING
AND BECAUSE OF THIS. THIS NEW
RELATIVE AREA OF LAW- WE DO ASK
FOR SOME. CONSIDERATION GIVEN
THE LARGE EXPOSURE OF LIABILITY
THAT WOULD BE CREATED SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOD JUST
ONE ONE MENTION IS THAT- WE HAVE
RECEIVED OPPOSITION AND SO
PROPOSALS HOWEVER THEY CAME IN
SO LATE THAT WE DID NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY VET THEM
DISCUSS THEM WITH THE AUTHOR. I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR IS COGNOS
FACT THAT THERE ARE NO ONE SIZE
DOES NOT NECESSARILY FIT ALL IT
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THEIR FAIR AND EQUITABLE-
F. UP ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. IS
A- WITHIN. THEY SHOULD
ESSENTIALLY IF THAT'S TRUE THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT MICHELLE CASTRO IS
ONLINE NOW IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO HER MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
LET'S DO THAT LET'S LET'S LET'S
GO TO- MISCAST TRUE THEN WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE OPPOSITION'S
CASTRO. CLOSURES. YEAH ON THE
PHONE OF TIME. ALL RIGHT I'M
SORRY MISS CASTRO. NOT THERE ALL
RIGHT SO SORRY- LET LET'S LET'S
COME BACK TO THE OPPOSITION- IF
THERE'S ANOTHER WITNESS PRIMARY
WITNESS OPPOSITION. MISTER BUT
DART DISPOSABLE DART ON THE
PHONE. YES MA'AM ALL RIGHT GO
AHEAD. ALLRIGHT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AGAIN AFTERNOON MEMBERS
MICHAEL BUT ARE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
YOU SEE AS OPPOSED TO TEN UNTIL
NINE THIRTY. COMMENDED WHAT
MINISTER. THAT THE COUNTY IS-
OUGHT TO APPLY TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS MASS COMMUNICATIONS
THAT'S FINING GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY THREE.
PASSED MEDICATIONS- INCLUDING.
WRITTEN VERBAL RECORDED OR OTHER
MESSAGE INTENDED FOR EMPLOYEES.
AND THE CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS THANK YOU SEE OR
OTHERS TO MEET AND CONFER PRIOR
TO SENDING THOSE MESSAGES OUT.
IF THE PARTY CAN'T AGREE ON THE
MESSAGE CONTENT THE EMPLOYER IS
REQUIRED TO INCLUDE A MESSAGE
FROM THE UNION AT THE SAME TIME
IN THE SAME MANNER OF DELIVERY.
WITHOUT PLAYER K. CLARIFYING
WHAT CONSTITUTES A VIOLATION OF
THE DETERRENT DISCOURAGE
LANGUAGE IT'S NOT UNREASONABLE.
IMAGINE EVERY CONTRACT DISPUTE A
BARGAINING IMPASSE IN. SUBJECT
TO MASSIVE PENALTIES. THERE IS
NOT TENS BETWEEN AND NOW BUT
EVERY DAY. SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO
PANEL THAT PUNISHMENT IS TEN
TAKE PUBLIC AND TO STUDENT FACT
AND STAFF. IN RECENT YEARS
HERE'S REQUEST YOUR VOTE ON
FINANCIAL MY THIRTY ONE. UNLESS
IT IS A TO FAIRLY WHAT
CONSTITUTES DURING OR
DISCOURAGING THANK YOU ALREADY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- NOW BACK
TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IF YOU
WOULD. LINE UP GO AHEAD SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ERIN AVERY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE TO RESPECTFULLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION I ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER JOHNSON THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LISA DISTRO RETIRED TEACHER
END. OF PRESIDENT OF TEACHERS
OPPOSING UNION INTIMIDATION I
OPPOSE THANK YOU OTHERS IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SAYING NO ONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
APPROACHING THE MIKE FROM LET'S
TURN THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO S. B. NINE
THIRTY. ONE THIRTY FOUR
DEMOGRAPHIC REPETITION THE NINE
THREE ONE SIX PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
FIRST ALLIED FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY HAD ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY WITH THE OF A POST
ON MONDAY I WANT MY COMMENTS BUT
MY COLLEAGUES THAT'S WHAT THE
JOHNSON THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE ELAINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANY WOMAN INTO THE
OPPOSITION HERE BUT LEGAL THING
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND FROM SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FIVE THIRTEEN REGULATORS OPENED
IT SO AT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN JEAN HARD CALLING IN
TODAY AND OF YOUR BRAIN COUNTY
TO CALIFORNIA IN THE EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE. ALSO AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO VICTORY CAN AND
I'M ON THE COMPUTER OPPOSITION
LEFT HIM AND THE- THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
GARCIA WITH RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS WITH
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND
ALIGNING OUR COMMON ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUES DOROTHY JOHNSON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NOT FOR THE FAINT THINKING
BECAME AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT
THE SPRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SINGLE QUESTIONS AND NO
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. I HAVE- I'M
SORRY SENATE EARLIER RESEARCHER
I HAVE A NOTE HERE AND I
APOLOGIZE I MISSED A GOOD
PORTION OF THE PRESENTATION THAT
INDICATES THAT THERE WERE
COMMITTEE AND IT'S- AND ARE YOU
IT MAY YEAH I'D BE AND FRANKLY
LOOKED BACK TO SEE IF I COULD
FIND BUT ARE YOU TAKING
COMMITTEE MEN. I THAT. THAT'S S.
THANK YOU THAT'S ALL A THANK YOU
SO MUCH RT THANK YOU. THE CLOSER
BY CAL SKI MOST OF. ALL RIGHT-
THE LADY CARE CLOSE YES I DO
THINK YOU VERY MUCH- BILL WILL.
WORKERS WITH THE RIGHT TO ORDER.
I WANTED TO JUST TO CALL THINGS
MAKE BEEN IN THE- STATED THAT
ARE NOT. THE OPPOSITION TALKED
ABOUT IT BEING A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE THAT IS UP
TO IF IT'S ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER EMPLOYEE SO IF YOU HAD FIVE
EMPLOYEES THAT HAD THEIR RIGHTS
VIOLATED IT WOULD BE A FIVE.
DOLLAR FINE NOT A ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. AND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT DETERRING OR
DISCOURAGING- I JUST JOTTED DOWN
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I'VE
SEEN- AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN
THE LABOR MOVEMENT FOR MANY
YEARS. IT COULD BE SUCH AS
ATTACHING FLYERS TO PAYCHECKS
HAVING VIDEOS ANTI UNION VIDEOS
PLAY ON A LOOP BREAK ROOMS
CAPTIVE AUDIENCE MEETINGS ONE ON
ONE MEETINGS WITH MANAGEMENT'S.
OFF HANDED REMARKS AS A
MANAGEMENT WALKS BY EMPLOYEES.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
WILL TO TURN COURAGE MEMBER FROM
TRAINING A YOU CAN'T SO THIS
<c.green>ILL JUST ASKING. THAT</c>
EMPLOYERS. LET EMPLOYEES DECIDE
ON THEIR OWN WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU BUT-
YES THIS IS SENATE BILL NINE
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR LEYVA WITH
THAT MOTION BY SENATOR WAY
CASKEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. BURKE AYE
BURGESS. BURGESS NO KILEY IT'LL-
GO YET- I. WRESTLE WITH US SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
JONES LAYERED HI LAYERED ICE.
AYE STERN AYE A WHITE CAL SKI.
FOR CASKEY AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
THAT'S EIGHTY ONE WITH SOME
MEMBERS MISSING. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL ALL RIGHT NEXT
WE HAVE CENTER EGGMAN THANK YOU
SAID EARLIER- WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS IN A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BORDER- IT IT CENTER IT WAS
REQUEST WE CAN TAKE UP. FILE
NUMBER TEN S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE FIRST. AN ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB NINE EIGHTY THREE ALSO BY
SENATOR EGGMAN THE SP TEN
SEVENTEEN ALSO BY CENTER EGGMAN
THEN NUMBER NINE S. B. THIRTEEN
ELEVEN ALSO MY CENTER EGGMAN. SO
THE SURVEY EGGMAN. I'M SO GLAD
TO GET TO SPEND SOME TIME
TOGETHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
AT THIS POINT SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD PUT SOME POWER
BACK INTO THE HANDS. OF A
PROTEST PROTESTS PERSPECTIVE
TENET RECEIVING RENT SUBSIDIES
BY ALLOWING THEM TO DEMONSTRATE
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY THE RENT ON
THE BASIS OF DOCUMENTATION THEY
CHOOSE INSTEAD OF JUST RELYING
ON THEIR CREDIT SCORE AND AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US ON AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS- SO
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS NOT REAL
LIFE I HEARD FROM. SOME BUT
SOCIAL WORKERS AT YOU KNOW THEY
GET THEY WORK REALLY HARD AND WE
ALL KNOW HOMELESSNESS IS A HUGE
ISSUE WORK REALLY HARD TO GET
SOMEBODY A VOUCHER AND THEN THEY
CAN'T FIND THEM IRAN WE ALL KNOW
THERE'S A- HUGE SCARCITY UP BUT
IN ADDITIONALLY THEY LOOK AT
THEIR CREDIT SCORE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE GOOD CREDIT. WELL IT
I THOUGHT THAT CAN'T BE RIGHT WE
DON'T SEVENTIES HOMELESS THEY'VE
BEEN THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE GOOD
CREDIT OR ANY CREDIT BUT INDEED
THAT IS WE REACHED OUT TO SOME
HOUSING ADVOCATES AND THAT IS IN
FACT TRUE- WHICH WOULD MAKE ANY
SENSE TO ME AND I HOPE IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU-
SO. AND WE WILL KNOW WE SELL A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO TO GET
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES SO THIS IS
A ANOTHER WAY TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY PROVIDE A PATH FOR PEOPLE
WHO MAY HAVE BAD CREDIT BUT NOW
HAVE ABOUT YOUR AND NEED A PLACE
TO LIVE- RESEARCH AYE MAJOR
UNIVERSITY SUPPORT THESE CLAIMS
STUDIES FROM THE BAD CREDIT IS A
NUMBER ONE REASON WHY. THE
TONIGHT SHOW. WHICH IS AMAZING
TO ME- SO. RIGHT NOW PROPERTY
OWNERS FEEL LIKE IT'S THE BEST
TOOL TO EVALUATE RISK HOWEVER
POUCH HOUSING VOUCHERS PAY UP
270% OF THAT RENT. BUT LEAVING
THE SENATE ONLY TO PAY 30% AND
THAT GOES DIRECTLY TO THE TENANT
DOESN'T GO THE TENET THEN TO
GIVE THE LAN OR- DIRECTLY TO THE
MAN. TENET SO THAT MEANS WERE
ALREADY REALLY REDUCING THE RISK
OF NON PAYMENTS- SO A PERSON'S
CREDIT SCORE WOULD NOT BE
REFLECTED IN THEIR ABILITY TO IT
NOW THEY HAVE A VOUCHER THEY
HAVE INCOME COMING IN- TO BE
ABLE TO BE. DEPENDABLE SO THIS
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO AN
ADDITIONAL TO THAT TO THE CREDIT
SCORE BUT ALSO BE ABLE TO USE
DOCUMENTATION THAT SAYS THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO PAY THE
RENT. AND THEN HAVE ONE MORE
TOOL FOR THE LANDLORD TO BE ABLE
TO USE AS THEIR- BEGINNING TO
EVALUATE IT FOR WHO WHO IS GOING
TO- TO BE RENTING THERE THEIR-
THEIR- THEIR ROOM HER THEIR
APARTMENT- WE FEEL LIKE SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES MORE
ACCURATE TO FOR PROPERTY OWNERS
TO VALUATE ATTENDANCE ABILITY TO
PAY BY ALLOWING TENANTS TO
SUBMIT DOCUMENTATION. PROVING
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
PORTION OF THE RENT. AND TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME P. BAGS DALE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY OF SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE. FIVE
STRIKE STILL. IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE. THERE YOU GO GO AHEAD. I
AM. ON GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN
RACK IN THE SECTOR FOR THE HOW
AND OF THE COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FIVE AND LIKE I THINK YOU
OUGHT TO FOR CONSIDERING THE
NEEDS OF LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES IN THE MIDST OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS. A REAL SUBSIDY
PROGRAM THE HOUSING. HOW CHOICE
VOUCHER PROGRAM. TO HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT. GRAMINIS FOR
MISTER BUT PUBLIC HOUSING
AUTHORITIES PROVIDING RENTAL
ASSISTANCE THE VERY LOW INCOME
AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES.
ACCESS TO SUSTAINABLE AND
HEALTHY HOUSING INTRUDING COUNTY
WE SUPPORT APPROXIMATELY FORTY
FIVE ON HOUSEHOLD. FAMILY ISSUE
HAPPENING VOUCHERS RESPONSIBLE
FOR LOCATING SUITABLE HOUSING
UNITS OF THE FAMILY'S CHOICE BUT
YOUR OWNER AGREES TO RENT-
EXCEPT SUBSIDY AS PART OF THAT
SHIP BUT HOUSING SUBSIDIES PAID
DIRECTLY TO LANDLORDS ON BEHALF
OF THE VISITING FAMILY AND 30%
OF THE FAMILIES JUST INCOME IF
THEIR PORTION. ALSO PAID. TO THE
LANDLORD. INDIVIDUALS INTERESTED
THE HOUSING FACTOR MUST. WHEN
WAITING WITH ARE OPEN WAIT TIMES
ARE TO FIVE YOU BUT CAN OFTEN BE
. TIME PERIOD. CAN IF THE BILL
LOAN RENTERS. THREE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY ESCALATING RENTS AND
THE CONSEQUENT CONSEQUENTIAL
CREDIT RISKS OF HAVING ON
AFFORDABLE RENTS- THE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY BASED ON
INCOME FAMILY COMPOSITION
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND. ANY AND ANY
SELECTION PREFERENCES. BUT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE VOUCHER ONCE
IF YOU TO THE FAMILY- REALLY
INTERNET. BEGINS TO BRING
MEANINGFUL AFFORDABILITY.
FINDING AFFORDABLE UNITS
LANDLORDS WILLING TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
PROGRAM HAVE BEEN AMONG THE
CHALLENGES AUTHORITIES FACE AND
DR HOLD PROTESTS AGAINST STRONG
. LEYVA DRAW FOR RELUCTANT TO
ACCEPT ABOUT HER THINKING ABOUT
HER HOLDERS ARE ADMINISTRATIVELY
BURDENSOME. WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
BERMAN HELPING ACTIVELY IS
AMENDMENT. PROVIDES PROTECTION
FOR INCOME YOU CAN
DISCRIMINATION SUITABILITY HAS
BECOME ANOTHER DISQUALIFIER AS
CREDIT SCORES AND RENTAL HISTORY
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
DIRECTLY REFLECT THEIR LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. INCREASING
RENTS HAVE ONLY MADE THE PROBLEM
WORKING SB AMONG SPECIALLY
POPULATION HAS SENATE RIGHT
INDICATED FOR SPECIALTY
POPULATION AND HOMELESS FAMILIES
ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO RECEIVE A
VOUCHER. EIGHT POOR CREDIT AND
CREDIT IS ABILITY OR APPS
CHALLENGES TO GET THOSE VOUCHERS
WE STOPPED. AHA REQUIRES OR FOR
DISTRICT BILL WITH FAMILIES
CURRENT PRIOR ADDRESSES- IT
PROVIDES- IN. ON REGISTRY YOU
DIS AND PRINT ACTIVITY. BUT THE
REGULAR USE OF CREDIT CHECKS
MAKES DETERMINES FOR POTENTIAL
TENANTS CHALLENGING A LOW CREDIT
SCORE CAN LET ME HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES AND CREDIT
AGENCIES PROVIDED FROM WITH THE
TEN PAY THE RENT TIMELY. AS WELL
INDEPENDENT OF THE INTERVENING
EVENT A RENTAL SUBSIDY. TO
MITIGATE THE EFFECT THE PREVIOUS
RENTAL HISTORY HOW DOES EXAMINE
HOW REPORTING RENT PAYMENTS MADE
BY. THOUSANDS OF HUNDRED
ASSISTED HOUSEHOLDS. THE NATION
LIKE IT'S AGENCIES. WHAT IMPACT
CREDIT RATINGS OF THESE FAMILIES
THE STUDY ALSO SHOWS WHETHER
REPORTING RENT PAYMENTS TO
CONSUMER CREDIT. COME THE
PROBLEM OF CREDITS INVISIBILITY
WELL THE STUDY SHOWED RENT
PAYMENT WHICH CAN IMPROVE CREDIT
VISIBILITY ONLY A FRACTION OF
TENANTS WITH CREDIT SCORES. CAN
GET ABOVE SIX TWENTY AS LONG
STANDING- CHALLENGES. WELL
RENTAL SUBSIDY REMAIN ON CREDIT
REPORTS- ONE OF WHAT'S AVAILABLE
WITH A PROPORTIONAL SHARE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES PREVIOUS RENTAL
HISTORY AND CREDIT SHOULD DILUTE
DILUTE THE VALUE OF SUBSIDIES AS
- PARENTS ARE STILL STRUGGLING
TO LEASE UP LEADING FUNDING I
DON'T. SKYROCKETING RENTS IN
CALIFORIA ONE THING HAS
REMAINED THE SAME RANCHERA
GRACIOUSLY HIGH WHEN INDEXED BY
INCOMES THE AVERAGE WRITTEN
STOCKTON YEAR OVER YEAR HAS
INCREASED 13% EVEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SIMPLY PUT THEIR
INTEGRATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES TO RECEIVE
RENTAL SUPPORT AND NEEDS
OUTSTRIP SUPPLY FOR FAMILY
LOOKING UP TO RECEIVE SUPPORT
EVERY POSSIBLE CONSIDERATION
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE. PICTURE
THAT FEDERAL DOLLARS FROM
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER PROGRAMS
ARE TURNED ON AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS THAT WILLING
LANDLORDS FEDERAL SUBSIDIES ARE
STOCK INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD
OF HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU MISTER
ICE WILL CALL YOU GO AHEAD AND
WRAP IT UP. OKAY JUST FINAL
EXAMPLE TO THESE ARGUMENTS RIGHT
WILL BE RESTRICTED SO YOU. THANK
YOU DAHLE GONE FOR MINUTES- I
ASSUME ARE NO OTHER. WITNESSES
AND SO- LET'S NOW TURN TO OTHERS
WHO ARE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WAS TESTIFYING. IN SUPPORT YOUR
NAME THE AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. SAYING NO ONE
APPROACHES THE MICROPHONE LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATE
IF YOU QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ONE THREE THREE FIVE.
PLEASE REMEMBER SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A FIFTY ONE THREE THREE FIVE
PLEASE RESPOND ZERO AT THIS TIME
. FIRST PROVIDER FOR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MEMBERS HE
KNOWS ALL OF THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IF FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT- OF THE POLITICAL.
SURE MEMBERS RANDOM NOT BE OF
THE HEALTH FOUNDATION AND ITS
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
DIVISION IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL THANK
YOU. YEAH. FIVE HUNDRED AND
THREE YEARS LATER THE POLITICAL
HEAD. ONE FIVE ZERO THREE LANES
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH CAN THAT
THE CARE ON BEHALF OF THE NOT
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
HEALTH TRUCK. FOUR THANK YOU.
BERNARDUS LEVINE THANK YOU AT
THE TIME ALREADY NOW LET'S TURN
TO THE OPPOSITION OPPOSITION IN
ROOM- TWELVE HUNDRED OR STATE
DEBRA CARLTON- WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION THAT DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE MISS CARLTON APPROACHING
MICROPHONE. SO IT IS OUR
COLLEAGUE AMBER MEDICINE FROM
ARMINA THE CALIFORNIA
PROPOSITION GO AHEAD SIR AND
WHILE AMBER MADISON WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
RATIONALE FOR THIS BILL WE MUST.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
TODAY. PLEASE KNOW THAT OWNERS
WILL SEE NO CREDIT REPORT THE
SAME AS BAD CREDIT. AND WHILE
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS GIVE THE
APPLICANT THE OPTION TO PRESENT
AT THEIR CHOOSING ALTERNATIVE
EVIDENCE OF THEIR FINANCIAL
STABILITY. IT BAIT IT MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH FOR THE LANDLORD TO MAKE
A DECISION ABOUT THAT APPLICANTS
ABILITY TO PAY THEIR PORTION OF
THE RENT. AS A REMINDER WE
ALREADY HAVE A LAW THAT LIMITS
ACCESS TO EVICTION COURT
RECORDS. AND AS WE ALL KNOW A
BIGGER PROBLEM IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. IN ALL CASES THERE
ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF APPLICANTS
FOR ANYONE BREAKING UNIT.
UNFORTUNATELY SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WILL NOT SOLVE THE
CHALLENGE THAT SOME APPLICANTS
HAVE IN FINDING HOUSING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS WHO WISH
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
TE- IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED- YES
SIR. OKAY GO AHEAD PRO TO MY
FULL. HELLO MUSKER SORIANO POSES
BILL THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OTHERS
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH OF ONE MORE ONE MORE IF
YOU EVERYONE WHO WISHES
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION IF YOU'D
PLEASE LINE UP. LINDA RICH
PLASTER COUNTY OPPOSES BILL ALL
YOU THINK YOU. ARE SAYING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED LET'S TURN
TO THE PHONE LINES. THOSE WHO
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE
THREE THREE FIVE- ABOUT A
MODERATOR OR MODERATOR RATHER
PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GOING
TOMORROW. THAT'S THE ONE THREE
THREE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO SAN. FIRST REALIZED
FIVE HUNDRED AND THREE I THOUGHT
THAT THE THOUGHT THAT. WHAT
NUMBER DID YOU TAKE A CUT OUT.
FIVE ZERO THREE THAT'S ME OKAY
AND I'MNOT ENOUGH POSITION I'M
IN AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TELL ME MY NUMBER ALREADY
THANK YOU OKAY ELEVEN NAMING
COUNTY SURE BURGLING THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN BUT- A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR. MEMBERS GREASY ON
BEHALF THE CAL ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN ABOUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LOTUS
FLOWER LINES AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SEEING SNOW
PUT. SENATOR STERN SENATE WHITE
HOUSE SKI SIR STERN FIRST
USUALLY JUST I WOULD JUST THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF THERE ARE BE
AMENDMENTS BEING ADDED TO THE
BILL WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S SOMETHING PRESENTED TO
COMMITTEE BEAT LOVE TO BE ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOLLOWING TO CENTER
MITCHELL'S LEGISLATION. AND HOW
TO ACTUALLY. YOURSELF IN THIS
ENDLESS LOOP WITH CREDIT HISTORY
WHERE YOU'RE- YOU'RE- YOU'RE
LIVING ON THE STREETS A WITH NO
HISTORY AT ALL PAYING THINGS
BACK AND THEN IF THAT'S BEING.
PART IS A- PRECONDITION OF YOUR
ABILITY TO. HAVE INCOME TO
SUPPORT YOUR HOUSING VOUCHER-
YOUR INDIFFERENCE CIRCULAR LOGIC
IN BACK ON THE STREET AGAIN SO I
THINK IT'S A TIMELY MEASURE
DOESN'T SOLVE THE UNDERLYING
ISSUE OF THE LACK OF VOUCHERS
AND SOME OF THE BIGGER THINGS
BUT- CRITICAL MEASURE SELF.
THANKS FOR PAYING FOR. THANK YOU
SIR WHAT KELSEY. I NOTED THAT.
THE AUTHOR. DIDN'T ASK FOR
ANYBODY'S INPUT ON HOW TO REPAIR
ONES CREDIT REPORT AND THAT
NOBODY WOULD KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
CREDIT REPORT. BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU MIGHT LOOK IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT AMENDMENTS HE SAID.
GENERALLY LANDLORDS NEVER REPORT
THE PEOPLE DO A GOOD JOB PAYING
THE RENT IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS- ABSENT. IF THEY IF THEY
MISTER RENT ARE. YOU COMPLETED
YOUR ONE YOUR FRIEND
AFFIRMATIVELY DID IT AND THAT
MIGHT BE SOMETHING YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT. ON THE PORTION THAT
THEY PAID WITH IF THEY GO INTO
THIS PROGRAM. AND THE PITTACUS
IS JUST GENERALLY AVOIDED GOES
IN WITH THESE. PRIVATE RECORD
WITH CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES.
AND THAT COULD ALSO BE PER THE
DOCUMENTATION IS SOMEBODY
PROVIDES. INTERACTIVE IN LIEU
OF. OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE- CENTER EGGMAN THANK
YOU AREYOU I SPENT SOME QUALITY
TIME ON THIS BILL SO APPRECIATE
YOUR- FLEXIBILITY- IS THE MOTION
I THINK SINISTER AND MOVED BILL
CENTER STERN MOVE THE BILL
CERTAINLY CARE CLOSE I WOULD
JUST ASK FOR YOUR I. ABOUT OUR
MANAGER HOPE IS JUST BE CLEAR
YOU ACCEPT THE ENTITIES
AMENDMENTS YEAH RIGHT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- THANK YOU COUNSEL.
THANK YOU THIS IS ANNA BILL
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
EGGMAN WITH EMOTION BY SENATOR
STERN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. BUT FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG. NUMBER
GUY BURGESS. PORGES SNOW
CABALLERO. GUERRIERO I ENDED
ASAL. DRESS SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES
LAYERED- LAYERED ICE STERN STERN
I WAKE CAL SKENEIDAE CASKEY I
WINNER WINNER HI YOU HAVE FOUR
TWO I'M SORRY EIGHT TO ONE WITH
SOME NUMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT SB
NINE EIGHT THREE CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU NOW WE'LL GET TO THE
REPAIR- I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND CHEER FOR
THE CONTINUE TO IMPORT WHICH IS
REFLECTED IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE WORKED OUT IN THE
ANALYSIS AND ED AND THE CENTRE A
BUG AND I ALSO SPENT A LOT OF
TIME. TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL
TOGETHER. AND WHAT WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT THE RIGHT TO REPAIR EVEN
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT FOR MAYBE
THE LAST FIVE YEARS I'VE HAD
RIGHT TO REPAIR BILLS- I DON'T
WANT TO I WANT IT FOR GRANTED
THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY FOR ME WHAT
WILL TALKING ABOUT- AND SOME
WOULD ARGUE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
A RIGHT TO REPAIR I DON'T TALK
ABOUT. THESE TALK ABOUT MY PAD
I'M TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
CONTROLS OUR LIFE NOW WITH THE
YOUR DISHWASHER YOUR WASHER
MACHINE WE ARE BOUND TO BUY
ELECTRONIC DEVICES- AND PEOPLE
SAY WELL YOU ALREADY CAN FIX ALL
YOUR DEVICES REYES GOING YOU TOO
CAN YOU WATCH IT THERE WELL.
THERE ARE THINGS AND YOU TO AN
AMAZON THAT JUST DON'T HELP US
FIX OUR DEVICES AND THOSE ARE
FOUR COMPONENTS THAT ARE PART OF
THIS BILL ONE AN AUTHENTIC PART
PROVIDED BY THE MANUFACTURER. TO
THE APPROPRIATE TOOLS NEEDED TO
MAKE THAT REPAIR TO MAKE IT MORE
SAFE. THREE I'M- TALKING. NOT
WALK THROUGH THE- STEPS. IN FOR
THE SOFTWARE NEEDED TO RESET.
AND KEPT RECALIBRATE THE
PRODUCT. AFTER IT IS REPAIRED.
AND AGAIN THIS BE ABLE TO SYNC
AND THINGS LIKE THAT WE'RE NOT.
NOT CAN I GET INTO THE PRIVACY
ISSUES. LIMITING ACCESS TO THESE
THINGS MAKES DANGEROUS MAKES
REPAIR LESS ACCESSIBLE. MORE
COSTLY. AND POTENTIALLY EVEN
MORE DANGEROUS. THIS BILL WILL
MAKE THE PARTS TOOLS
DOCUMENTATION AND SOFTWARE
NEEDED FOR CONSUMER ELECTRONICS
AND APPLIANCE REPAIR. ACCESSIBLE
TO INDEPENDENT REPAIR SHOPS. AND
TO CONSUMERS. I'M SURE A LOT OF
YOU AT THE BACKBONE OF A LOT OF
OUR ECONOMIES THE SMALL
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES THAT SET
UP SHOP TO BE ABLE TO FIX OUR
THINGS BUT A LARGE LOT OF OUR
LARGER- MANUFACTURERS HAVE MADE
A BUSINESS MODEL ON KEEPING THE
FIXING TO THEM AND OR- SELLING
YOU A NEW ONE- THE CALIFORNIA WE
ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF THIS IS
BASED ON THE VALUE OF THE
PRODUCT MOST CONSUMER
ELECTRONICS AND APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS MUST MAKE.
REPLACEMENT PARTS AND TOOLS
AVAILABLE FOR EITHER THREE OR
SEVEN YEARS- AND A LOT OF OUR
PEOPLE ARE AGAIN LARGER
MANUFACTURERS ACCOMPLISH THIS
THROUGH AUTHORIZING THEIR OWN.
FIRST PARTY AN AUTHORIZED REPAIR
NETWORKS TO MAKE SAID- REPAIRS
LIKE LIKE IF YOU GO DOWN TO- IF
YOU GO TO THE BIG TICKET COUNTER
RIGHT THOSE ARE THE APPLE FOLKS
WERE THEN. MOSTLY GOING TO SEND
IT. BACK WHERE WHERE WHERE IT'S
COME FROM- WE BECOME MORE
DEPENDENT UPON OUR TECHNOLOGY IN
OUR EVERYDAY LIVES AND EVEN
SIMPLE APPLIANCES HAVE BECOME.
INTERNET CONNECTED INCREASINGLY
COMPLEX AND W'VE CONCEDED A LOT
OF OUR OWNERSHIP RIGHTS- THAT I
THINK WE USED TO CHERISH RIGHT
THAT I BUY IT IS IT MINE OR DID
I RENTED AND IT'S SOMEBODY
ELSE'S AND I HAVE TO CONTINUE.
TO ASK THEM PERMISSION TO FIX IT
AND- GET ANOTHER ONE FROM THEM
IT BECOMES THIS LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP THAT YOU MAY NOT
NECESSARILY WANT- WE KNOW WHO
THIS IS. GOOD POLICY. BECAUSE IT
WILL EIGHT IT WILL SAVE
CONSUMERS MONEY AS THEY REPAIR
RATHER THAN REPLACE EXPENSIVE
PROJECTS AS MUCH AS A FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS IF THIS WERE
IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT WILL HELP ADDRESS THE GROWING
ELECTRONIC WASTE CRISIS WERE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WASTE. YOU KNOW
HOW MANY PHONES CALIFORNIA SIR
AWAY EVERY SINGLE DAY. FORTY SIX
THOUSAND PHONES GO EVERY SINGLE
DAY THINK ABOUT THAT IN OUR
WASTE STREAM- AND HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE YOU GOT A NEW PHONE WHEN
YOU DIDN'T NECESSARILY NEED ONE
BUT- HE DIDN'T. DO IT THERE WAS
NO PLACE TO GET IT FIXED. IT
WILL INCREASE THE VIABILITY OF
LOCAL REPAIR SHOPS IN OUR
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN OVERSEAS
FACTORIES THAT MAKE NEW PRODUCTS
AND OR OUT OF STATE AUTHORIZED.
REPAIRS WHO WHO WILL OPPOSE THIS
BELT. AND IT WILL ALSO DISRUPT
THE BUSINESS MODEL THAT HAS COME
TO RELY MORE ON MORE ON SHORTER
CYCLES. BEFORE PRODUCTS MUST BE
REPLACED I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
REST OF YOU BUT I AM CONCERNED
THAT WE ARE BECOMING A
DISPOSABLE SOCIETY- WE WANT TO
REDUCE REUSE RECYCLE. THIS IS
ANOTHER WAY TO DO IT. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE MOMENT
HAS SWUNG ON THIS JUST ISSUE
WITH MANY MANUFACTURERS
BEGINNING TO WORK ON SELF REPAIR
PROGRAMS. THE FTC PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL AND THE
BIDEN MINISTRATION. INCLUDED
LOOSENING OF REPAIR RESTRICTIONS
IN AN ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS.
EXECUTIVE ORDER THIS THIS RECENT
YEAR. WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS KEVIN O. RILEY. FROM U. S.
RIG AND BRIAN FOX FROM HOMEBOY
ELECTRONICS RECYCLING. ALL RIGHT
MISTER RILEY ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
I THANK YOU IN ADVANCE GET
ARTICLE HETERO BURGLARS USE YEAH
THANK YOU AND TAKING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BUT IF YOU CAN
ARRIVE EARLY ON THAT RIGHT TO
REPAIR CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR WITH US
PARDON CAL PURDUE COSPONSOR THE
BILL. HAS BEEN MENTIONED WHAT
TWENTY FOUR EIGHT THE FASTEST
GROWING PART OF OUR MUNICIPAL
WASTE STREAM CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS ALONE PRODUCE SOME
ONE POINT ONE MILLION TONS OF E.
WASTE EACH YEAR WHICH WHICH-
TOXIC CHEMICALS INTO OUR
ENVIRONMENT. THIS NUMBER IS SO
HIGH IN PART BECAUSE MANY
FACTORS OF DEVICES RANGING FROM
SMARTPHONES REFRIGERATORS
RESTRICT ACCESS TO NECESSARY
REPAIR MATERIALS AS A RESULT
CONSUMERS ARE FORCED TO GO TO
THE MANUFACTURER WHO CAN
SECRETARY REPAIR PRICES SO HIGH
THAT. MAKES SENSE TO JUST GET A
NEW DEVICE. SB NINE EIGHTY THREE
PER FIRST CONSUMER REPAIRED. IT
WOULD HELP TO. OUR YOU A QUITE
IN REDUCE THE NEED FOR OUR-
MINING OCCURRED. CHAIN- IT WILL
SAY HELP HOUSEHOLD IMPORT THREE.
TO PRE. AND IT IS BROADLY
POPULAR ACROSS THE POLITICAL.
OUR SERVICE THAT 75% OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT RIGHT TO
REPAIR INCLUDING MAJORITY THE
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS. OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL RIGHT OUT SORTS ARGUMENT TO
GET IT INCLUDING INTER REGARDING
SAFETY CYBERSECURITY AND- I'VE
RECOMMENDATIONS DEVOTED TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION. BERGEN
FELLOW CO SPONSOR ACT IN TWO
REPORTS WOULD BE WILLING TO HEAR
OUT THROUGH SHOWING THAT THE
NINETY THREE WOULD COST HARD.
ATTACKS WHAT YOU HAVE A SHOWS.
THAT INVEST BEEFS INVESTING
THESE AND OTHER- CONCERN IN TOWN
. AT THIS MANUFACTURERS
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR. RESTRICTIONS
ON QUOTE. THEY ALSO STATED THAT
THIS CHANGES WE SEE POPE
SUPPORTED BY COMMENTS MEDICAL
RECORD. AND HAVE TWENTY PROVIDED
. FREE TO REPAIR IS AN IDEA
WHOSE TIME HAS COME. FOR CROSSES
POLITICAL SPECTRUM AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY INCLUDING IN THE
OVAL OFFICE I PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS REITERATED SUPPORT FOR THESE
REFORMS. ARE THE NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
PROUD TO COME FROM A STATE AND
ON SOME CRITICAL ISSUES. YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY O TAKE A
HUGE STEP FORWARD. FOR CONSUMER
. I DRAFTING THIS SO HIGH YOUR
AYE VOTE WOULD BE HOW TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTION THANK. THANK YOU
MISTER RILEY FIVE ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. GO AHEAD. YOUR GOAL
THANK YOU COULD HAVE CHAIRMAN OF
BERGAMOT LEADING THE BRIAN FOX
DIRECTOR BUT SOME HERE AT WILL
TRY RECYCLING- ONE OF THE MAIN
DIVISIONS OF L. A. B. HOME
INDUSTRIES THE LARGE BEING BILL
TAKE FROM ON CLASS WE PUBLISHING
ABOUT- ORDER. IN THE TO
REPURPOSE AND FIX LOOK TRY CELL
DONATE THE PUBLIC BACK IN
BETWEEN. IF YOU INCLUDED ALL
OVER. CAL BASED FOR SHOP. SORRY-
ON IN SUPPORT OF THE S. B. NINE
EIGHTY THREE. LEGISLATION WILL
HELP WHAT AND BUSINESS LIKE OURS
. PARKING TOOL AND SERVICES FROM
WE NEED TO COME CONSUMER COSTS.
DO SUPPORT TRYING WAITED CAN
BETTER SERVE. WHAT A BIG BIGGEST
CHALLENGE TO DO OR HERE THAT.
THE APPROACH PART TOOL AND
SERVICES NEEDED. ALL BECAUSE OF
- PERSONAL NAY FAQ PARTS I'M
SURE AT TO THE PARK AND THAT IS
NOT WHAT IT IS THEY'RE- BUT
PERHAPS OVER. THE REASON SHE THE
COST POT. IT CAN BE PICKING UP
LEAD TIME CONSUMING FIND PARTS
SUCH AS- BAD FOR SELF THE LAST
ORGANS THEMSELVES IT'S REALLY WE
HAVE TO TELECOM THAT WE CAN'T
PART OF OUR WE CAN TO REPAIR
BECAUSE- MAYBE. BECAUSE PART.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF CALL. AND
AFTER. GOOD POP.
STRAP HERE I SEE IT EVERY DAY-
I. SB EIGHTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
REPAIR BUSINESSES LIKE OURS TO
SPEND LESS TIME LOOKING FOR PART
OF THE MORE TIME GO AHEAD
BUSINESS. TRAINING AND HIRING
TECHNICIANS IN SERVING OUR
COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
ACCESS TO CHEAPER IMPORTED.
SERVICES THANK YOU EVERYONE
HERE. EGGMAN LEADERSHIP. URGED
THANKFUL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER FOX ALL RIGHT. OF THOSE
WHO WAS TESTIFYING SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE H. THREE IN THE- ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED PLEASE THE MIKE.
SING NO ONE APPROACH IT MIGHT
FROM LET'S Q. A THOSE ON THE
PHONE WHO SUPPORT S. B. NINE
EIGHT THREE. INDETERMINACY
SUPPORT SB NINE EIGHT THREE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. HELLO TO OUR
FIRST LINE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TRANSACTION THAT THE
THINK OFFICE WITH ENVIRONMENT
ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE FOR PRACTICE
MONSTER IN SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU
. THANK FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BEEN GOING BE ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON
CATHOLICATE OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP SAMPLES NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL CALLING YOURSELF
WITH ALL THE SOPHISTICATION OF
NORTH AMERICA LEGISLATIVE TASK
FORCE ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHEN NUMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND SINCERE
REPORTS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF IT
IN NINETY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FIVE FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION-
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AN
EXAM ON BEHALF OF CALPERS AND
CLEAN WATER ACTION BOTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THERE I'M LOOKING
CHAMBERLAIN FROM THE REPAIR
MANUAL SITE A FIX IT ISN'T ABLE
TO THE PHONE BROKE COSPONSORING
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF FIFTY
NINE. THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO THE HEAD. YES THIS IS
MAGGIE WILLIAMS OWNER OF FIX MY
PC UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
TIME IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. FOUR HUNDRED AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE THIS
IS A STANDARD QUESTION ON THE-
OR ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
GROUP THINGS SHORES FIVE FIFTY
CAN COALITION CENTER FOR OCEANIC
AWARENESS EDUCATION FIVE HIRED
YOU SEVENTH GENERATION YEARS
HE'LL THE BAY WHICH BECAUSE YOU
MY ON THE AND YOUR WAY. THANK
YOU. THANK. FIVE HUNDRED THREE
PLEASE AHEAD. ME YEAH YES THIS
YEAR FIVE HUNDRED THREE. OKAY
I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT IN MY IS-
JERRY GRADY INVENTOR CAN THANK
YOU. FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY AHEAD. A
LOT FOR ANDREAS. I MEAN FOR AT
THE NINETY THREE. A YOU ARE. BUT
UNDER FORTY FOUR THE STORE AT.
HI MY NAME IS PORTAL FROM CAN BE
I AM THE I DIRECT MEDIUM SIZED
COME AND ALSO THE WORK IN BOCA
AND I THINK A FEW THINGS SUPPORT
SB. NINETY THREE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD. THAT HAPPENED
THE THIRD AND MEMBERS ALIKE OR
KEY ON BEHALF OF READING WAIT
THE PORT THANK YOU THANK. OR
UNDER CONTROL FIVE BECAUSE- HI
THIS IS CAROLINE EVAN THE FUTURE
WATCH CALL IN SICK OF ASKING
EIGHTY THREE TO PROVIDE CAL
THREE THIRTY THINGY TO FIX WHAT
KIND AND APPLY AND WE'RE COLLECT
WASTE THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR THE GO AHEAD.
SHE LED IS STEPHANIE BROWN
REPAIRER CALLING TO ASK YOU THIS
SB EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR. BECAUSE YOU
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY PLEASE GO.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF IF SHE
ACCIDENT TAX OF COURSE AFFAIRS
LOSS AND COUNTY AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THAT HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX BUT- FIGURING OF
BERKELEY FOUNDER BECAUSE CLINICS
.ORG BUT WE HELP WORKING
CALIFORNIANS IF THEY'RE GOING TO
LOWER TWENTY CAN APPOINTED
WORKING EVEN LOOK THINGS UP
THANK YOU SIR PLEASE. OR SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE LET. MACULAR
WITH MY NAME ATTACHED CALLING ON
BEHALF OF EVERYBODY IN MAMMOTH
LAKES CALIFORNIA CLEARANCE WORK
SYSTEM THANK YOU MAY WITH LAKES
. THANK YOU. WELCOME FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M NOT
FROM YEAH WELL WITH THE HELP
BUSINESS NUMBER CAN ACTS AND
SUPPORT AS NINETY THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTIAGO WHICH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL LEARNERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JOHN .ORG PLEASE
REFER KIT ORGAN WE STRONG
SUPPORT THE RIGHT TO REPAIR
THANK YOU. FIVE AND SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JENNIFER
CAN'T IN CALIFORNIA GREEN TEAM
AND FOR SO CAL THREE FIFTEEN
SUPPORT. OF SB NINETY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI IT'S LIKELY PURCELL
CALLING FROM VENTURA RECENTLY
HAD TO GET A NEW PHONE BECAUSE
MY THANK YOU MA'AM THE PHONE HAD
A YEAR TO FOURTEEN THANK YOU.
FOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR
ADDITIONAL AND KEEP.
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CYNTHIA
SHELLING WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
FULL SCREEN PAYMENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO
ADDITIONAL LINES AT THE TIME ALL
RIGHTY- LET'S TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. SEVERAL
BOARD POSITIONS YES OPPOSITION
SORRY ABOUT THAT. I JUST ASSUME
THAT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
CENTER EGGMAN BILLS SO. ALL
RIGHT YES- I BELIEVE WE HAVE
STUFF MISTER KAUFMAN HERE AS
WELL IS- DUSTIN BRIGHT STRAW
OFTEN PLEASURES. THANK YOUMISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS- DYLAN
HOFFMAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA- AND SOUTHWEST OF
TECHNET- WHERE THE NATIONAL
BIPARTISAN NETWORK OF TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES THAT PROMOTES THE
GROWTH OF THE INNOVATION ECONOMY
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- SB
NINE EIGHTY THREE- THIS. PROVIDE
ALL REPAIR MANUALS THE VICE
SCHEMATICS PARTS TOOLS AND KEYS
TO DIGITAL LOCKS WILL JEOPARDIZE
VALUABLE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
AND OUR CUSTOMERS PERSONAL
INFORMATION CONSUMERS HAVE MANY
OPTIONS TO GET THEIR DEVICES
REPAIRED IT'S INDUSTRY STANDARD
TO PROVIDE DIRECT REPAIR OPTIONS
AS WELL AS AN AUTHORIZED REPAIR
NETWORK. OF PROVIDERS SO
CONSUMERS CAN FIND REPAIR
OPTIONS NEAR THEM. THE REASONS
THESE NETWORKS. THE SHOPS CARE
ACT. IT'S REPAIR INFORMATION THE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE A CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM- THIS
ENSURES THEY HAVE THE TRAINING
TO PROPERLY REPAIR THE DEVICE-
BUT ALSO PROVIDES REDRESS IF
USERS PERSONAL INFORMATION OR
COMPANIES I. P. S IMPROPERLY
ACCESSED MANY CONSUMER DEVICES
PHONES LAPTOPS CAN PULL
INFORMATION WITH MORE COULD THE
CONNECTED DEVICES IN HOMES THAN
EVER THESE PREVENTIVE ACTOR FOR
ACTOR HACKERS TO ACCESS
CONSUMERS NETWORKS AND
INFORMATION. THE PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE IS TO TURN OVER TO
ANYONE WHO ASKS FOR IT GIVE HACK
HACKERS A SIGNIFICANT LIKE UP IN
ACCESSING OUR DEVICES AND
EXPLAIN OUR CUSTOMERS.
SIGNIFICANTLY THE COMPANIES AND
DEVICES ARE PROFITABLE AND HAVE
VALUE IS BECAUSE OF THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THAT MAKES
THEM POSSIBLE. WOULD BE
COUNTERFEITERS ACROSS THE WORLD
WHAT. IN THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
US TO GIVE AWAY. IT WILL GIVE
THEM A SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE AND
UNDERCUT OUR COMPANIES COMPLY
THOUSANDS IN THE STATE AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. CALIFORNIA'S
STATUS AS THE LEADER OF THE TECH
INDUSTRY WOULD BE IN JEOPARDY.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR TO
DEVELOP AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS OR
IP CONCERNS BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THESE AMENDMENTS NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH- FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANKS OFTEN
AND I BELIEVE- MISTER- BRIGHTENS
ON THE PHONES. THE CORRECT. THE
PHONE. OUR GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF
THE CAN MY NAME IS STEFAN BURKE
. AT PRESENT THE REPAIR DONE
RIGHT AWAY. YEAH TO MONIQUE AND
PROPOSITION AND BILL MONEY. ON
ARRIVAL IF YOU COMPANIES
ORGANISING PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT
THAT INTERNET PRODUCTS OUR
REPAIR TO MAINTAIN AND ALL MAN
THE THAT THAT THAT CONNECT
CONSUME SAYS AND TO DESIGN TO
IMPROVE ONLINE OF THE WHO USE
THEM DURING THAT AND AT. PRODUCT
THE FACTORED BY THESE COMPANIES
IN ORDER. MINISTRY SOMEONE AND
COMMERCE AND PLACES REMAIN
INTACT. BOB RIGHT COALITION IS A
TO THE BILL IT MANDATE A RIGID
EQUIPPED MAY. FOR AT NIGHT- THAT
THIS EQUIPMENT FOR OF THE SO
LOOK OUT TO PROVIDE UP REPAIR.
WITH DIAGNOSTIC IN REPAIR
INFORMATION SOFTWARE IN TOP.
INCREASE DECREASING SAFETY AND
FIVE OR SIX RESTRICTIONS AND
BUSINESSES THANK GOD YOU THE
SOUTH. INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AS
MR OFTEN JUST READ IS ABSOLUTE-
PREMIUM- VALUE. AT WHAT THE
FINAL ACTUAL PROPERTY IS. AND
ADD TO KEEP YOU THAT TWO OF THIS
. WITH THE WAY- A LOT OF THE AND
THE AND I SPENT IN BRINGING
PRODUCTS CONSUMERS THAT THEY
KEEP THE CONNECT. SMALL CONSUMER
PRODUCTS ARE. THANK YOU THAT
TIME- BATTERIES WILL SOMEBODY DE
KNOW TO PREPARE THOSE ARE FOR
DISPOSED OF THEM. AND THIS IS
KUALA. FIVE PAPERS THAT WAS
WRITTEN BY RAY BERNARD OF THE
PRODUCT THANK YOU FIVE. MANY
FACTORS JUST WANT INSURE THAT
THERE IS BY PERFECT WHO ARE THE
SECRECY ENTER THINGS IN THEIR
PROPER. ALL ALWAYS. THERE JUST.
BY. MORE THAN TWENTY LEGISLATOR
. FOR LEGISLATIVE BILLS HAVE
PASSED THE STATE COME TO THE
NATION'S LET WITH FOR MANY OF.
CREATED MORE ISSUES CAN YOU CAN
AND ANSWERS THERE ARE A LOT OF
COMP LEAGUE ISSUES AROUND
DEFINITIONS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
TOMORROW. SERVICE OKAY OF OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD LOCK
UP HERE AND RE TWELVE. C. KNOWN
A PRO THE MY- ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
THE PHONE LINES IN OP. TO S. B.
NINE EIGHT THREE. MONISTIC.
EIGHT THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. WE'RE
STRUGGLING NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I REMEMBER
STRUGGLING W. ADMIT NOT POSITION
. YOUR. PHOTO ID FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS THE DALLAS CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION REALLY GLAD AND
GRATITUDE TO WORKING WITH YOU
SHARE THE AUTHOR AND MANY STAFF
MEMBERS WE ARE IN A CLOSE
POSITION AT THIS TIME RESPECTFUL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PLEASE GO
OUT. HI CAROL RYAN WITH THE
ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT VIDEO
GAME CONSOLE MAKERS PUBLISHERS.
THE LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE HEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- JOHN
CANCEL PATIENT HOLD PARTS
MANUFACTURERS AND WE ARE CLOSED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE
HUNDRED OR LOWER PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BEEN GONE BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SEVERAL ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT
THE TIME ALL RIGHT- BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE
BEGIN LET LET ME JUST SAY FIRST
OF ALL CENTER EGGMAN THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE CALL THE TIME IF
YOU AND I HAVE SPENT ON THAT- I
THINK THAT THE PARTIES HAVE SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS- THE-
PUNCHES. PROTECTING IT'LL
PROPERTY WITHOUT COMPLETELY-
ABROGATING THE RIGHT OF A
CONSUMER TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
RELATIVELY SIMPLE REPAIRS AND
THE AMENDMENTS ARE THIS
COMMITTEES EFFORT TO TRY TO
THREAD THAT NEEDLE WHETHER WE
RENTED. PROPERLY OR NOT- I
SUPPOSE IS IT PROGRESSES WE WILL
SEE- BUT- IT DOES SEEM TO ME
THAT THERE IS A RIGHT TO REPAIR
AND THAT WE- APPS NEED TO SPEND
A LITTLE MORE TIME FOR THE
DEFINING THAT RIGHT TO REPAIR SO
WE DON'T INTENTION FRINGE UPON
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY- HAVING
SAID THAT LET'S TURN IT OVER TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS THAT ARE
COMING. AS A QUICK. I HAVE A
QUESTION. SAVE I AGREE 1100%
WITH MY CARE- THERE BUT WHAT
FRUSTRATES ME THE MOST IS. HOW
YOU BECOME A DISPOSABLE SOCIETY-
AND I REMEMBER. THE DATE RIGHT
WE GET TO AN AGING YOU START
TALKING ABOUT WHEN I'M READING-
THE- WHERE WHERE THE IMPLANTS IS
WOULD LAST FOR TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY YEARS AND- AND THEN YOU'D
GET A REPAIR PERSON AND FIX IT
AND HE WOULD ASK FOR THAT. SO
I'M- THEY'VE TO RAMP TO THE TO
THAT GIVEN AND I'M I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT- THAT THERE ARE SOME
BASIC- REPAIRS IT OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO BE DONE I HAD MY SISTER
IN LAW JUST HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH ME ABOUT HER PHONE TAG THE-
THE GLASS ON HER PHONE BREAKING
SHE REPAIRED AND- THE RIGHT-
AND- THE- SINCE IT'S A PUSH.
PHONE IT DIDN'T WORKING LIKE
SHOULD WHEN YOU PUSHED IT
TOTALLY AND TO HER THAT THAT
WOULDN'T YOU COULDN'T GET IT.
BOB GET BASEMENT WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE COMPANY THAT SHE
BOUGHT IT FROM SO I AM I AGREE I
THINK I THINK THAT YOU'RE MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION THE KEY
IS THE WHOLE ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED HERE TODAY WHICH IS-
GETTING INTO THE THAT WHOLE AREA
OF- OF THE DATA THAT IS-
PARTICULAR TO THAT PARTICULAR
COMPANY AND KEEPING IT-
PROTECTED. DISAPPEAR BRO DAY
HOPEFULLY I KNOW YOU QUIT THE
OPPOSITION IF THEY FITS. ALL THE
NEEDLE WE WILL SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRING THE STORE THANK YOU
SENATE OTHER QUITE IS AROUND.
THANK YOU WELL I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH TRY TO DO I THINK IT'S
REALLY GREAT. QUIT. SHE OF WITH
. AGAIN BACK DAY O. ONE OF THE
THAT I GAVE. WHEN I NEEDED FOR
TO A AUTHOR. REPAIR SHOP AND
THEY ALWAYS ENDED UP BEING SMALL
SMALL REPAIR SHOPS WITH THEIR
AUTHORIZES I FELT MORE CONFIDENT
THAT THEY WERE GONNA HAVE THE
TOOLS AND THEY WERE GOING TO USE
THE RIGHT CARD SINCE THAT. A
LESS OF A CHANCE ON IT- I STILL
THINK WHAT YOU DOING I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU BUT IS THERE SUCH
THING TO THAT END IN TERMS OF-
HOW. YOU GIVE. IF THEY WILL
HAVE- WE WILL NOT THEY WILL HAVE
PRIORITY IF THEY'RE A SHOP THAT
HAS THE CONNECTION OR THE
AUTHORIZATION FROM FROM THE
ORIGINAL COMPANY I DON'T KNOW IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A PLACE
FOR ANY SHOP TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE REPAIRS BUT THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT GIVES AN
ADVANTAGE TO THOSE THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED HAD JUST. TO THROWING
THAT OUT. AND NOTHING IN THIS
BILL SAYS YOU CAN'T GO TO
WHOMEVER YOU WANT YOU CAN STILL
GO TO THE TO THE AUTHORIZED
DEALER YOU CAN STILL GO TO. THE
BACK TO THE COMPANY YOU CAN
STILL DO ALL THOSE THINGS THIS
IS JUST SAYING THAT FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO GO TO A DIFFERENT
MOM AND POP SHOP IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THEIR COMMUNITY
IN THE HOME BOYS. THAT THEY
WOULD ALL. MOST TWO PURCHASE A
THE MANUALS DYSKINETIC TO BE
ABLE TO FIX IT I MEAN IT'S- BUT
YOU CAN STILL GO TO THE OTHERS.
IS IT BECAUSE THAT WAS AT THE
QUESTION. NOT REALLY WELL JUST
TO BE CLEAR SAID I CAN ASSUME
YOU'RE ACCEPTING A COMMITTEE YES
I ANSWER SUGGESTED AND TO
RESPOND TO THE SENATE ALSO
QUESTION. IS IT IF YOU ARE NOT
AN AUTHORIZED DEALER YOU'VE GOT
TO DISCLOSE THAT SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT AN AUTHORIZED DEALER
MAY HAVE SOME ADVANTAGE IN THE
MARKETPLACE OF BY VIRTUE OF THE
FACT THAT THAT THE IN AN
AUTHORIZED DEALER MUST DISCLOSE
THAT TO THE CONSUMER. SO THEY'RE
AWARE THAT THAT THAT DEVICE OR
PRODUCT IS BEING REPAIRED BY
SOMEONE AUTHORIZED THAT THAT
THAT MAY PROVIDE SOME BENEFIT IN
THE MARKET SO. OTHER QUESTIONS
SIMILAR BORDERS. I CAN WRESTLE
WITH THIS WITH THIS ONE- MY WIFE
BOUGHT ME A WATCH- IT WAS IT WAS
A NICE WATCH- AND I JUST WANTED-TO GET A REPAIR THAT WAS A
MISTAKE- AND- I GOT IT REPAIRED.
AND THEN I WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE MANUFACTURER AND THEY'RE
LIKE OOPS SORRY WARRANTY VOIDED
BECAUSE YOU WENT TO. BUT THIS
JURY PAYER WHATEVER IT WAS- I
WAS LIKE WOW. THAT IS A PROBLEM-
SO WE- HEY YOU GUYS HAVEN'T BEEN
A PUBLIC JONES TO REPAIR SHOP
YOU SHOULD. ANYWAY MY POINT IS
ALL THIS IS- I THINK THERE'S A
BIG DISCONNECT- WE HAVE COTTAGE
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
BASED ON EXCLUSIVE ARRANGEMENTS
WITH MANUFACTURERS AND THERE'S
BENEFITS TO THAT BUT THERE'S
ALSO SUBSTANTIAL CONSUMER DRAW.
AIR THE COMMENTS THAT- I THINK
ONE OF YOUR TEST FIRES- ALLUDED
TO IS THAT THERE'S NOT A LOT
THERE'S NOT A DEARTH OF
INFORMATION ABOUT DATA THEFT
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT AND
I CAN JUST SCRATCH MY HEAD ON ON
ON THAT- PERHAPS SOME OF OUR
<c.green>IGGEST COMPETITORS- JUST SIMPLY</c>
REPLICATE- THROUGH PUBLIC DOMAIN
SOURCES IN MANUFACTURE COMPETING
YOU KNOW- PRODUCTS OVERSEAS SO.
AT ANY CALL FOR THAT. FURTHER
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT RIVERS
ENGINEER HAPPENS EVERYWHERE IN
THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES IT TAKES
TO PINPOINT WHERE THAT OCCURRED
MIGHT PARTIALLY EXPLAIN WHY
THERE MAY NOT BE A DEARTH BUT WE
KNOW FOR A FACT THAT THESE
COUNTERFEIT PRODUCTS OR ALL OVER
THE PLACE ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ORIGINATE FROM OR FROM OVERSEAS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PUT FORWARD
. MAYBE IT ALREADY EXIST IN
PRACTICE BUT IN TERMS OF AN NDA
. AS IN INDIA EXPECTED- THAT IF
YOU BRING UP A SHIP IF YOU BRING
A WATCH TO A SHOP OR SOME OTHER
FORM OF TECHNOLOGY AND THEY'RE
WORKING ON A PRODUCT THEY'RE NOT
LICENSED DEALER BUT HAVE ACCESS
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION TO
THOSE MANUALS IN THOSE MODELS SO
ON AND SO FORTH. BUT THAT IS
PROPRIETARY- IN PROTECTED
INFORMATION- IS THAT PART OF.
HOW THIS IS PLAYING PLAYING OUT
THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
REDUCTION AN NDA FOR- FOR THE
MANUALS. IN THE MODELING FOR
THEM TO WORK ON AN IPHONE OR
WATCH YES AND I WILL I WILL ASK
MISTER- RALLIED TO ANSWER THAT
MORE DETAIL. THAT IS THE ONE
WHEN THE WHEN THE COMPANIES ARE
AUTHORIZED SOMEBODY THEY ARE ARE
THEY ALREADY HAVE EVERYTHING TO
BE ABLE TO SAY WHAT YOU CAN
DISCLOSE WHICH YOU CAN NOT WE
WOULDN'T EXPECT THAT TO BE ANY
DIFFERENT. MISTER RIGHT CARD.
DROPPED TIMES. YOU KNOW FIRST OF
ALL SAY THAT YOU KNOW THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL IS IN NO WAY TO.
ENFORCE THAT MANUFACTURES TO
TURN OVER INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY-
MORE TO TURN- YOU KNOW TREAT
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT'S WHY
WE'VE INCLUDED LANGUAGE IN AND
ACCESSIBLE TO COMMITTEE AMENDED
MAKING SURE THAT- SOURCE CODE IS
IT'S NOT. REQUIRED FOR
MANUFACTURERS NINE TRADE
SECRETS- ARE NOT PROVIDED MUCH
NEEDED TO REPAIR- THE THING IS
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW ACTUAL PROPERTY GET THE WAY
OF PREPARE BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE HAPPEN
VERY OFTEN- BUT- JUST TO ADDRESS
THAT THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
TO REACH. AND THAT. PERSON YOU
CAN. WHEN YEAH YOU CAN. BUY AN
IPHONE- BY. THE PRODUCT WASHU
WHATEVER MIGHT BE AND REVERSE
ENGINEERING THAT WAY. THERE'S
NOTHING ABOUT THE REPAIRS. THAT-
INHERENTLY IS PROVIDING KIND OF
NEW INFORMATION OR- I THINK THAT
PEOPLE CAN'T DO IT THEY WANTED
TO GO AND TAKE A COMPUTER APART
AND PUT IT BACK TOGETHER AND
MAKE A COMPETING- PRODUCTS I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE
ASPECT OF IT AND THEN. THE OTHER
THING I WOULD ADD IS JUST THAT-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ALSO CONFIRMED
THE NUMBER OF. YEAH HI T. LAWTON
. PROFESSORS FROM YOU SEE AND
STANFORD AND OF OTHER VERY
PRESTIGIOUS INSTITUTE WILL THE
COUNTRY- WHO'S LETTER EXPLAINING
WHY HOW CONGRESS AND THE COURTS
AND BAD SUPPORTED REPAIR ADS YOU
KNOW MORE LET'S NOT THE MATTER
OF ELECTION PROPERTY NOT A
MATTER OF CALL PEOPLE. YOU KNOW
WE JUST- SHOULD PRINCIPLES IF
YOU BE SURE ABLE TO GET WHAT YOU
NEED ORDER TO IT SO YOU KNOW THE
THIRD THOSE ARE REASONS- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT DON'T WORK. RIGHT. TO REPORT BY WHAT THAT. I'M
SORRY NIGHT CAPRI THE COMMENTARY
AND WE'VE HEARD FOLKS THAT. IN
THE INDUSTRY IN THE MODEL M.
DIESEL CODE AND THE INTELLECTUAL
. OF THAT GOES INTO THESE
DEVICES- GET A COMBINED IPHONE
IN AND TEAR APART. BUT IT'S THE
SYSTEM AND THE MANNER IN WHICH
IT CONNECTS AND COMMUNICATES
INFORMATION WITHIN IT THE PARTS
. HE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY VETS
PO SO I DON'T KNOW WITH WHAT
AMENDMENTS CHAIR HAS HAS HAS PUT
FORWARD- MAYBE MAYBE NOT THE
CLOSE TO THAT COULD BE
IDENTIFIED IN SOME. REAL DETAIL
SO YOU YOU MAY WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MEMBERS ARE
EXTENSIVE SEVEN. PAGE SEVEN BUT
BUT TO RESPOND WITH SCOTT. BUT
GET IN THE WAY PREPARE. OF BEING
CLEAR. I AM CA A- INTELLECTUAL.
I CAN ABOUT NOT OF PERHAPS THE
PUTTING. OUR MANUFACTURES
HEARING NICE IS A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE BY REQUIRING THEM
IN ANY WAY TO REVEAL ELECTORAL
PROPERTY. UP BOB YES THIS IS FAR
ABILITY TO REPAIR DEVICES BUT
NOT TO CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY IS
COMPROMISED IN THAT MANUFACTURES
AND RESORT TO GOING TO OTHER
PLACES SO JUST TO BE CLEAR- THAT
IS A CONCERN ALL RIGHT. SO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IS THERE
MOST. US SENATOR ROSS MOST OF
ALL RIGHT- YOU COULD CLOSE THANK
YOU MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
THIS AN ISSUE THE NOT GOING TO
GO AWAY AS LONG THE MORE TO
COMING OR LIKE NEXT. ZACKS TO
THEM. THE END AGAIN TO ADD TO
RESPOND THE REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY KEY TO OWNER
AND REPAIR ON THIS BILL WILL NOT
HAVE AND IT WOULD NOT HAVE TO
AFFECT MANY COPYRIGHT IS MAN TO
PROVIDE THE KEY SO THE MIDDLE
AND OR OTHER. COOPER IN THE SAME
AT. WITH OTHER. SO IT'S NOT
ANYBODY INTENTION GIVEAWAY-
INTELLECT PROPERTY AND IF YOU.
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT DRAW BUT
WITH THE CHAIR RIGHT THE WOMAN
OPENS ABOUT DIFFERENT KINDS OF
LUCK GO ON THE IN RIGHT NOW LOOK
YOU TOO BUT NOT YOU HOW TO TAKE
ONE APART IT WITH PARTS THAT ARE
BASED TO ME THAT FOURTEENTH.
CONVERSATION I'M HOPING WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE ALONG WE CAN
ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN THREAD THAT NEEDLE
MORE EFFECTIVELY. TO PART WITH
THE I. JUST TRIED TO KILL
THINGS- SO CLOSE IT I WOULD JUST
SAY I'M THE ONLY THING STILL
WORKING IN MY HOUSE BESIDES MY
NINETEEN FIFTIES. WHERE WOULD.
RESPECT CASF YOUR IPOD THANK
YOU. FIVE MINUTES YOU CAN OF YOU
CALL THE ROLL. A YES SENATE BILL
NINE EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR
EGGMAN WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR I SO THE MOTION IS
PASSED AS IT BUT FOR AMENDED
ROUTE. THE HONOR REACH. NUMBER
BURGESS. CARREIRO I CAREER I IN
THE RUSSELL RUSSELL EIGEN
GONZALEZ I HURTS. JOE LET-
LAYERED ICE. STERN I WAKE
HOUSEKI WHY CASKEY WIENER. YES
SEVEN TWO ZERO EIGHT MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL BACK ON CALL I'M GONNA HAVE
TO PART 2% BILL ANOTHER
COMMITMENT TO REPORT TO THE VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU SIR EVEN FIRST
- I'LL HAVE SO MUCH WOULD APPEAR
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE TAKE THAT
ALL THE GREAT COMPLIMENTS SELF
SIR I'M NOT ON THIS COMMITTEE IS
ONE OF THE ONLY ONES I'M NOT ON
SO I JUST THOUGHT IT'S- WE EIGHT
. CURRENT CHAIR ALL RIGHT MOVING
ON TO- I GUESS THIS WOULD BE FOR
FILE ITEM EIGHT. S. B. TEN
SEVENTEEN IS THAT CORRECT THAT
IS CORRECT ALL RIGHT- SO BEFORE
YOU PRESENT YOUR YOUR- WELL AT
THIS POINT THIRD BILL I S. AND
SEVENTEEN YOU AT THE MOMENT
PROPOSED IN THE IN. I OUR- FOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
EXTENSIVE WORK WITH MY STAFF ON
THE SOME BILLS AS A PRIORITY FOR
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S A THE
COMMITTED AGAIN TEMPTING THE
THIS BILL IS. BY USE IN STABLE
HOUSE INCREASED TAX PROVIDING
SAFETY AND STABILITY AS THEY
HEAL FROM TRAUMA WE KNOW THAT
WITHOUT HOUSING VICTIMS PRESSURE
JUST EAST OF RELATION TO AVOID
CAUSING INSTABILITY FOR HOME FOR
THEM OFTEN THERE. 97% OF THOSE
WOMEN REPORT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WITH IMMEDIATE BECAUSE OF THEIR
HOMELESS. WITHOUT FOR THE
PROTECTIONS ARE HOUSING LAWS
EFFECTIVELY PUSH PEOPLE INTO
MAKING IT POSSIBLE TO SHIP IN OF
CHOOSING BETWEEN STAYING IN AN
ABUSIVE. EARLY AT HOME. THIS
PROTECTIONS FOR. MANY OBJECTION
LAW TO EXPAND THE DOCKING A
SURVIVOR CAN SUBMIT TO PROVE
THEIR VICTIM OF DOMESTIC%
VIOLENCE. CURRENT LAW UNJUSTLY
REVOKED HOUSING PROTECTIONS IF A
PERPETRATOR COMES ON TO THE
PROPERTY WITHOUT THE TENANTS
KNOWLEDGE OR IS ON THE PROPERTY
TO TAKE CARE FAMILY AND
RELATIONSHIP PUBLIC CONCERT AS
TRIAL TO TASTE IN JUST. BILL WAS
OUT FROM HAPPENING IT PROTECT
EVERS OF A BROADER OF. DRIVER
JUSTIN OTHER. HOUSE OR SURVIVE.
THE BILL GIVE SURVIVE RECALL IF
THE PROPERTY OWNER JUST FOLLOW
EARLY TERM LAW BY TO WRITE OR
DISK THEIR CONFIDENTIAL. AND IT
PROVIDES FOR A PARTIAL VISION
THAT REMOVES THE PERPETRATOR FOR
ABUSE OR VIOLENCE BUT GIVES A
SURVIVOR AND THEIR FAMILY RIGHT
TO REMAIN IN THE HOME. LET ME BE
VERY CLEAR BUT WAS BILLED AS TO.
THE BILL DOES NOT MEAN
PERPETRATORS CAN COME INTO A
PROPERTY IN THREATEN HER PEOPLE
WITHOUT FACING LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES. THIS BILL DOES NOT
MAKE IT HARDER FOR LANDLORDS TO
EVICT PERPETRATORS AND IT DOES
NOT MEAN PERPETRATORS CAN CAUSE
PROBLEMS ON A PROPERTY WITHOUT
FACING LEGAL CONSEQUENCES.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT. THAT
MAKES LIFE EASIER FOR
PERPETRATORS. IT DOES MEAN THAT
A PERPETRATOR COMES ONTO THE
PROPERTY WITHOUT THE PERMISSION
OF THE SURVIVOR OR COMES ON TO
THE PROPERTY TO TAKE CARE OF A
RELATIONSHIP ARE FAMILIAR
OBLIGATION. THAT THIS EVER
EXPRESSED THE DO NOT HAVE TO
LOSE HOUSING. THIS IS. A TEST.
FOR THIS BILL OKAY. IN YOUR-
TOURNEY OF HOUSING A- JUSTICE
PRO AT THE FAMILY VITAL. THAT
PROJECT AND NINE GOMEZ FROM
BILLABLE SURVIVORS. ALL RIGHT.
MISTER CAMPEON. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M INSIDE TWO MINUTES OF YOUR
WONDERFUL GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON VICE CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TAYLOR CAMPION I AM THE SENIOR
MANAGING ATTORNEY A FAMILY LINES
OF HEALTH PROJECTS HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT JUSTICE. FAMILIES IS
A CO SPONSOR OF THE SPELL. AND A
LEGAL SERVICE PARTS CENTER THE
ADVOCATES FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
I REPRESENT TENANTS BASED I HAVE
REPRESENTED TENANTS FACING
EVICTION AND I'M ALSO A
LANDLORD. CALIFORNIA LAW IS
SUPPOSED TO PREVENT TENANTS FROM
BEING AFFECTED BECAUSE THEIR
ABUSE BUT THE LAW IS INEFFECTIVE
LAST YEAR'S GAS AND PROTECTION.
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS A NEW
HOUSING. A SENIOR ATTORNEY AT MY
ORGANIZATION INTRODUCED ME TO
THE EVICTION DEFENSE OF SURVIVOR
BY CHARACTERIZING IT AS USELESS
DEFENSE I WOULD LIKELY NEVER
USE. HE EXPLAINED IT WAS USELESS
BECAUSE IT DID NOT CAPTURE THE
REALITIES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
MAKING IT UNAVAILABLE TO MOST
SURVIVORS. HE WAS RIGHT. TO
PRACTICE AND ASKING HOUSING
THIRTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES I'VE
ONLY HEARD OF ONE CASE WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S LOSS PREVENTED A
SURVIVOR FROM BEING AFFECTED
BECAUSE OF ABUSE. GIVEN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A LEADING
CAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LOSS IN
EFFECTIVENESS IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. SB
TEN SEVENTEEN MAKE MUCH NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS TO CURRENT LAW. IT
PROTECTS SURVIVORS FROM BEING
EVICTED BECAUSE AN ABUSER CAME
ON THE PROPERTY AGAINST THEIR
WILL. COMMONLY AND USER A SHOW
UP AT A SURVIVOR'S HOME AGAINST
THEIR WISHES TO THE SURVIVORS
FEAR OF LOSING THEIR HOME TO
EXERT POWER AND CONTROL OVER THE
SURVIVOR. ANOTHER IMPROVEMENT
PLANS LANDLORDS TO REMOVE AN
ABUSIVE TENANT WITHOUT REMOVING
THE TENANT WHO'S BEING ABUSED.
WHICH FOR THE FIRST TIME GIVES
TENANTS SURVIVORS INCLUDE
FURTHER BRUISERS- PROTECTION
FROM EVICTION. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECT PRIVATE THANK YOU NOW
MOVING ON TO- NOT A GOMEZ I
BELIEVE- MODERATE CAN CHECK IF
SHE'S ON THE LINE. HI KAREN
MEMBERS. YOU'RE WRONG THANK YOU
. BY SHARING MEMBERS HELLO MY
NAME IS NINA GOMEZ I AM FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA BUT I STEP OUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN MY
LIFETIME NOT ONLY HAVE I LIVE
SEVERAL PLACES BUT I HAVE
SEVERAL PEOPLE I AM THE VOICE OF
VICTIMS. BUT YOUR LOCAL SHELTERS
THAT THAT STUFF CARS TO THE WAS
ALTERED. SLIGHTLY AND HOPE THAT
SOMEHOW WHEN I GO TO COURT WHEN
THEY GO TO CORPORATE BECAUSE YOU
THE JUDGE WILL KNOW THAT I AM
PROTECTING MY CHILDREN. I
GRANTED WHEN I SEE HOUSING
PROGRAMS THAT OFFER HELP FINDING
AN APARTMENT. MY HEART LOVE TO
GET EXCITED. BUT I CAN'T. NOT
THE CASE AND THEY EVERYTHING IS
I DID NOT USE MY. I HAD NOWHERE
TO GO. I WAS FORCED OUT I LOST
MY- IN MY TO. I LOVE ALL UNDER
NEW THAT I NOT. I DON'T CARE
THAT HE CHECKED THE MAN. FOR THE
RENT BY THE BILL. LET ME. OUT OF
FEAR THAT THEY WOULD GET IT BACK
TO YOU KNOW. BOB ONE BE
ENCOURAGE TO GET IN THIS WORLD
WHERE PEOPLE ARE. TO SUPPORT YOU
. THE RENT AND FOR HAS THE
HIGHEST IN EVER IN THIS YEAR. I
MIGHT NOT EVER A OF MY OWN BUT I
WILL- ALWAYS HAVE MY VOICE.
TODAY I AM USING. FOR OTHER
DISCOUNTS. THE ONE NO ONE LOOK
FOR TECH. FROM BEING A VICTIM
HEALTHY THEY HUMAN RIGHTS. THANK
YOU. FOR ARE YOU UP I HEAR WHAT
DIDN'T SHE LEAVE.
THE NEW YORK BURKE THEY ALL
THERE SHE IS SHE IS NO MORE THAN
50% OF HOMELESS WOMAN THAT ARE.
BY THAT INDUSTRY NO PROGRAM NINE
THAT IS GIVEN TO EXPAND HOUSING
IS GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IF
YOU DO NOT DO MORE TO PROTECT
VICTIMS FROM BEING A VICTIM I AM
ASKING FOR A HOUND I AM ASKING
FOR HIM I AM HAPPY. TO HELP WITH
THE HOUSING I. THOUGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FROM ONE PRESIDENT TO
ANOTHER- TO WHAT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. INTENSE PLEASE TAKE NAME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND SENATORS WAS IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A OF AB RECEIVED
JUSTICE PRAKASH MONSTERS OF THE
BILL THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE
RESPECTFULLY. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER OF FOLKS IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT MODERATOR
MOVING ON TO THE PHONE LINES TO
HAVE ANY FOLKS IN THE QUEUE. IN
SUPPORT. WAITED A MEMBERSHIP
CARD FOR SB TEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. BUT OUR
FIRST LINE IS FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH WE
HAVE A VEHICLE RIGHT ADVOCATE TO
CHARM CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S
NOT WORKING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BUT FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE COUNTY DOWN ON
AND REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON CARE NUMBER
CAME ABOLISHED ON BEHALF OF THE
CO SPONSORS WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AS WELL AS HAVE
BEEN NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KATIE WATER SPENT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU. FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LAKE
FOREST SIX TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD I. THANK YOU
THINK BACK TO AND CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP. EXAMINED AND PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE FOR INFORMATION
OF CALIFORNIA. CONFRONTED THE-
SUPPORT. BUT FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARTIN MARIETTA-
BURGER TO MARRY OF LEGAL AID OF
SONOMA COUNTY STRONG SUPPORT.
MOTOR HOW MANY UP MORE OF FOLKS
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. MORE THANK
YOU. FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT THE HEAD. LET'S HOPE THAT
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BILLION DOLLARS ARE- I'M
FROM COMMUNITY UNITED AGAINST
VIOLENCE AND WE ARE CLOSED ON
FAIR AND IN SUPPORT OF AT SEVEN
THANK. ALL RIGHT MODERATOR
MAKING LAST CALL. DAVID
LETTERMAN SHOW SUPPORT PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL LINES ONE MOMENT ONLY
PROVIDE THEIR LIKE MEMBERS.
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THAT THE CHANGE IN
THEIR WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM IN A RODRIGUEZ STATEWIDE
MANAGER WITH CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD THAT LEADS US TO SURVIVORS
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTRE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SG ONE ZERO ONE SEVEN
. THANK YOU LOTUS WELL INTO THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MOVING
ON IS USING THE SAME PROCEDURE
TO OUR OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A DEBRA CALLED- CARLTON.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN. DECISION I'M
STANDING IN FOR DOUBLE NOT LOOK
LIKE DEBORAH NOW MUCH FASTER
THAN DEBORAH. NUMBER MEDICINE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION-
WE JUST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR-
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE AUTHOR
FOR THE AMENDMENTS PROVIDED
TODAY- WE JUST WANTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAD ON THE BILL MOST OF
THOSE ALREADY. DRESSED SHE'S THE
ONE THREE WE KNOW THAT- WE WILL
HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH YOUR
OFFICE TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I ANY OTHER WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. SEEING
NONE OF MODERATE OR DO WE HAVE
ANY FOLKS IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION- FIFTY S. B. TEN
SEVENTEEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SPEAK ABOUT POSITION SB TEN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THING
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT FIRST
CAROLINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW
MANY FOLKS DO WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. IF TO IT THIS TIME.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
XTRATIME THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CLEAN GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU KNOW
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATE CAN MAKE ONE LAST CALL
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TWO SHOWS
THE OPPOSITION'S OPPOSITION
PLEASE. OPPOSITION FOR AT THE
TEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THANKS FOR THE LINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN YEAR
LIKE IT'S OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BACKGROUND
WITH THEIR INGREDIENTS SINCE
HE'S REPEATING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSED TO THE BILL HOWEVER WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND
ARE REVIEWING THEM. UP TO SEE
HOW THAT AFFECTS OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
LINES AT THIS TIME ALL IGHT
BRING IT BACK TO THE DATA SAID
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION BY
MEMBERS. GOING ONCE GOING TWICE.
HOPE CENTER CAREER ON. SO I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS THIS FORWARD ACT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE'S- REAL NEED
TO KEEP PEOPLE- TO HELP. VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- WHAT I DO
THINK WE NEED TO AT LEAST THAT
AT SOME POINT- CONSIDER AND I
DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION FOR IT
BUT- AT. THE ABBOTT DOING WORK
IN THIS AREA- ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT- THAT I'M SENSITIVE TO IS
THAT WHEN THERE IS A DOMESTIC
SITUATION IN AN APARTMENT- IT
DOESN'T AFFECT JUST THE FAMILY
THAT'S EXPERIENCING THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IT'S THE NEIGHBORS AND-
AND FRANKLY WHEN YOU. YOU CALL
TO HAVE SOMEONE ARRESTED IT'S
THE WHOLE NEIGHBORHOOD BECAUSE
IT'S USUALLY AT NIGHT. AND THERE
ARE FLASHING LIGHTS AND THERE'S
POLICE OFFICERS AND BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO VOLATILE THERE IT'S
DANGEROUS MANY OF THE SITUATION
. DEALING IN SCREAMING AND
USUALLY- THE BEST. SIX DEAD- I'M
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO WE
WANT TO SURE THEM AS WELL SO
SOMEONE IS REALLY CREATING A
NUISANCE FOR THEMSELVES BECAUSE
THEY'RE SHOWING UP WITHOUT THE-
THERE AUTHOR IS A- AT. THE OR
WITH AUTHORIZATION OF THE
VICTIMS- IT KIND OF ENDED
FINANCES OF- PROTECTIVE ORDERS
THERE'S GOTTA BE SOME SOME WAY
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SO I SAY THAT
BECAUSE THAT THE SAME THING
OCCURS WHEN YOU'RE SKATING
VIOLENCE- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FAMILY DOESN'T GET
EVICTED BECAUSE THEY HAVE A- K.
WHO'S OUT OF CONTROL RIGHT. BUT
BY THE SAME TOKEN IT AFFECTS THE
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I'M GONNA
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY I THINK
IT'S A GOOD BET. BUT I DO THINK
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT- IF
THERE'S SOME KIND OF AVOID IT.
TO ALLOW THE LANDLORD TO DO
SOMETHING THAT THEN PROTECTS THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THE NEIGHBORS
THE CHAIR AND I HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THAT AS WELL THAT'S I MEAN
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK AND
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE REALLY
TRIED TO ADDRESS THAT WHICH IS
WHAT THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
HAS. ON MORE TROLL WHO. AND
WE'RE TO SPACE UNDERSTAND KIND
OF HARD TO THE PROCESS SOMETIME
IT. SO I AGREE AND WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THAT AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT HOW WE-
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. SEE THAT.
SIR DRAWS OF- NO I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS WELL A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO I. HAD A BILL. THAT
HAD TO DO WITH. THEM NOT JUST
DOMESTIC FLIGHTS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAT BROADER SCOPE
OF VIOLENCE. AND HOW WHETHER YOU
YOU LIVED IN ONE PLACE BUT THEN.
THE VICTIM LIVED IN ANOTHER
PLACE AND HOW THAT IMPACTED YOU
HAVING TO LEAVE IF YOU'RE A
WITNESS. AND SO THERE'S ALL
THESE THINGS GOING ON ON THE
GROUND THAT. I THINK WE JUST. IT
MAKE SIMPLIFY HIS. VERY
COMPLICATED YEAH SO THAT BILL
HAD TO DO WITH BEING ABLE TO
BREAK ON THE LEASE. OR NOT HAVE
THAT THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE
USED AGAINST YOU IN TERMS OF THE
LEASE SO. I JUST APPRECIATE
THANKS. THANK YOU SIR STERN.
REMOVE THE BILL ALL RIGHT-
CENTER EGGMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST. IT IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE AS YOU ALL
SAID I BY I THINK THE PEOPLE
CAME TO TESTIFY- I THINK
DEPARTMENT SITUATION FOR
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN US AND
GETTING TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATED AND GET TO I
THINK OF A GOOD SUBSTANCE BILL
SO. I ASKED. RIGHT THE BILL IS
TO MOVE BY SENATOR STERN MOTION
TO PASS AMENDED. BUT FIRST MEN
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PROBES- CHIEF COUNSEL TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AMBERG. FORTIETH.
THREE ZERO THREE ZERO I DID US
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG JONES LAYERED.
CLEARED I STERN STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER
. YOU HAVE AS SIX TO ZERO SO FAR
WITH MEMBERS MISSING SO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL FOR. ALL RIGHT-
LAST BUT NOT LEAST OF YOUR BILLS
MOVING ON TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B. THIRTEEN ELEVEN
VETERANS PROTECTIONS. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU SENATOR MAYBE
WE'LL EVEN GET YOU'RE AYE VOTE
ON THIS ONE. I WANT TO THINK
THAT YOU'RE FOR THE CONVERSATION
ON ASPECTS OF THIS BILL I WANT
TO COMMIT AT THIS TIME TO REMOVE
IN SECTION FOUR. OF THE BILL IN
ITS ENTIRETY IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL BUILDS OFF
THE SUCCESS OF AB THIRTY TO
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
AND SEEKS TO EXPAND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS. AND VETERANS STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL CAME TOGETHER TO
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE MILITARY
PERSONNEL JAG LEGAL ASSISTANCE
ATTORNEYS COMMAND FINANCIAL
COUNSELORS. AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE MILITARY AND VETERANS
COMMUNITIES- COMING FROM A
FAMILY WITH A LONG HISTORY OF
SERVICE I AM FAMILIAR WITH HOW
THE VERY NATURE OF SERVING IN
THE MILITARY CAN OFTENTIMES. IT
CREATE VULNERABILITY TO CONSUMER
SCAMS AND UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES- THIS BILL STRENGTHENS
PROTECTIONS RELATED TO MILITARY
DISCOUNTS PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
RETURN OF SECURITY DEPOSIT
TOMORROW PROTECTIONS AND
DEFERRAL OF INTEREST AMONG OTHER
THINGS THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
OFTENTIMES IF YOU'RE A VETERAN
PEOPLE YOU HAVE A TARGET BECAUSE
PEOPLE WANT TO OFFER YOU ALL
KINDS OF MAGICAL THINGS. AND
YOUR TEMPORARILY SOMEWHERE AND
THEN GO TO MOVE SO WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE- ADD A LOT OF AGENCIES
COMPANIES THAT HAVE SPECIAL
RECRUITMENTS JUST FOR MILITARIES
TO GO OUT AND FIND AS MANY. THEY
CAN'T OFFER SPECIAL DEALS THIS
BILL WILL IMPOSE ENHANCED CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS OF THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
PERPETRATED AGAINST SILVER
SERVICE MEMBERS AND VETERANS. OF
THIS BILL COMES FROM
CONVERSATION MILITARY MEMBERS.
IN AND. THE MAJOR. WHAT'S WITH
LIFE HURDLES AND BAD ACT THAT
SEE TO OUR SIR MEMBERS WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF OPPOSITE TO THE
MARVEL REMOVAL OF FOUR AND
BELIEVE THAT THEY INTEND TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION TODAY
WITH THAT RICK I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
ANTHONY GLUE ON BEHALF TWENTY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. FORESEE NICK
WASN'T FUNNY TO MAKE IT THE
HEARING TO. GOT IT. THANK YOU
AND YOU DID MENTION AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR YOUR
COMMENTARY AND THAT- THAT. FOUR
YEAH I IS THE POST BY C. N. C.
D. A- IN THAT IS STRICKEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER LIU.
THANK YOU- WOOD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IF YOU CAN KEEP IT-
LIMITED THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL
ABSOLUTELY- GOOD AFTERNOON
THANKS CHAIR AND TO THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S ANTHONY
LEAVE THEM WITH THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS. FOR GENERAL
. WE JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IS SOMETHING I MEAN
EGGMAN HAVE I'M SORRY SENATOR
EGGMAN WITHIN THE SENATE PRO TEM
ATKINS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
AUTHORING THIS BILL- IT BUILDS
UPON EXISTING LAW AND PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL LEGAL AND FINANCIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR DUTY OF COMPOUND
THE SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND WE WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE CHAIR
FOR THE TIME THE NEXT ON THIS-
THE SENATE POLICE THE BILL. SENT
ME IT IS NOT A WHOLE LOT MORE
AND I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW
THESE LEGAL PROTECTIONS AREN'T.
SECOND AND ALLOW THERE ISN'T
MEMBERS TO FOCUS ON A MISSION
ARE PROTECTING THEIR FELLOW
SERVICE MEMBERS ON COMING HOME
SAFELY TO THEIR FAMILIES SO- THE
BILL SUPPORTED BY A BROAD RANGE
OF MILITARY AND VETERANS GROUPS
AND CONSUMER ADVOCATES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU ARE YOU MENTION THAT
MR OCCURS IS NOT ON THE LINE
LET'S MOVE ON TO ME WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. THIRTY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SENATOR DANIEL KENDO KAISER ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
AND NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY OTHER-
FOLKS IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WISHING TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT.
MATERS LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
PHONE LINES DO WE HAVE ANY FOLKS
IN SUPPORT OF- S. B. THIRTEEN
ELEVEN IN THE QUEUE IF SO HOW
MANY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTEEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE LIGHTNING Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE HOLY CRAP
THEIR LAND NUMBER.
HELLO I AM TO SIX HUNDRED AND
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANY OF THE CARE THE ONLY
HALF OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA RESPECTIVELY
BEFORE. THANK YOU ONE LAST CALL
MISTER MODERATOR. WHAT BEGAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
THEY HAVE NO ADDITIONAL AIMED AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
MOVING ALONG THIS SAME PROCESS
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE AN ANTHONY J. SAMPSON. HERE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ANTHONY SAMPSON
THE SAMPSON VISORS ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I CAME HERE TODAY TO LET
INTENDS TO REMOVE ITS OPPOSITION
IN LIGHT OF THE SENATOR'S.
WILLINGNESS TO ELIMINATE SECTION
FOR FROM THE BILL AND JUST AGAIN
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR- STAFF
JAKE UP HAS BEEN GREAT AS WELL
AS ANTHONY LIU AND HIS TEAM AT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
IN A CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH
US ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER FOLKS- IN ROOM TWO
HUNDRED IT WISHING TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU GO. TO Q. LET
US KNOW PH<c.cyan>RE THERE IN A MANY</c>
. GERMAN PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LINES
OF OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT BRING BCK TO THE DAIS-
COLLEAGUES EARLIER. ALMOST THE
BILL ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER-
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL BY
CENTER LAYERED WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER EGGMAN RESPECTIVE
TIME I WILL RESPECT YESTERDAY
BUT ALL RIGHT SO- WE'VE GOT THE
BUILD BY FOR THE MOVED WE HAVE
THE BILL MOVED BY CENTER LATER
ON SB THIRTEEN ELEVEN. AND IT IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERAN AFFAIRS CHIEF COUNSEL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. UMBERG FOR JUST FIVE
WERE JUSTIFIED CABALLERO. CARRY
IT OUTSIDE THE RUSSELL. THE SO I
A CONSULT. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
. JONES LAYERED LAYERED ICE
STERN STERN AYE A WAKE CAL SKI
BY CASKEY AYE WINNER WINNER I-
QUEBEC GOING BACK THROUGH UMBERG
AMBERG I HERTZBERG JONES YOU
HAVE NINE TWO ZERO SO FAR WITH
SOME MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON FALL OUR
FEARLESS LEADER HAS RETURNED AND
I'LL BE PASSING THE GAVEL ON TO. ALL RIGHT. NEXT CENTER MORE
INDUSTRY THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SELDOM HERE. SAN RAMON IS
OUTSIDE ON. HER WAY THIS. AFTER
SERVING THE MON WE WILL. TAKE UP
S. B. TWELVE HUNDRED BY SENATOR
SKINNER. HE SAYS CABALLERO ON A
ONE. OKAY OUR LIST LET'S LET'S
DO UP NUMBERS S. B. FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR COVER EURO. YEAH FOR
THOSE OF YOU LISTENING WILL NOW
TAKE UP S. B. ELEVEN FORTY TWO
BUT THAT ONE TWO ELEVEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAID
EARLIER. WE OF A CERTAIN AGE
NEED TO STICK TOGETHER CENTER
EARLIER. THESE YEAH RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AT ELEVEN
FORTY TWO. A BILL THAT WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS TO SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE SEEKING AN
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL AND SAY I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. HERE'S
TO ABORTIONS STILL OCCUR. EVEN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE WHO SEEK ABORTION RELATED
REPRODUCTIVE CARE ARE IN ABOUT
VULNERABLE PLACE. BECAUSE OF THE
OBSTACLES THAT SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION LODGING WAIT
SUPPORT SICK LEAVE AND SOMETIMES
CHILD CARE FOR WOMEN OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SEEKING AN ABORTION
THESE BARRIERS INCREASE
EXPONENTIALLY THIS YEAR THE U.
S. SUPREME COURT WILL REVIEW A
DIRECT CHALLENGE TO THE LANDMARK
CASE OF ROE V. WADE SHOULD THE
COURT OVERTURNED A LONGSTANDING
LEGAL PROTECTIONS OF ABORTION
SERVICES UNDER THIS MONUMENTAL
DECISION. TWENTY SIX STATES ARE
CERTAIN OR LIKELY TO BAN
ABORTIONS IMPACTING AS MANY AS
THIRTY SIX MILLION WOMEN AND
PEOPLE WHO MAY BECOME PREGNANT.
THIRTEEN RESEND GUTTMACHER
INSTITUTE REPORT CALIFORNIA MAY
SEE AND NEARLY 3000% INCREASE IN
PEOPLE DRIVING TO CALIFORNIA FOR
ABORTION CARE IF A TOTAL BAN
WERE TO TAKE PLACE IN THE UNITED
STATES. IF THIS IS THE CASE.
IT'S WILL NEED ORDERED AS A
TRAVEL AS A TRAVEL AND FOR ALL
OF THEIR NEEDS THEY MAY NEED TO
ACCESS TRANSPORTATION LODGING IN
CHILD CARE AND ABORTION
PROVIDERS CAN EXPECT TO SEE A
RISE IN DEMAND AND IN OVER
OVERALL WORKLOAD. S. ELEVEN
FORTY TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
DIRECT AND PRACTICAL SUPPORT FOR
ABORTION PATIENTS BY PROVIDING
GRANTS THE CAP. STE REALIZATIONS
WHO PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO
PATIENTS DIRECT SUPPORT SUCH AS
RIGHTS TO THE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES SOMETIMES THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TAKING CARE
AND NOT. FOR DECADES ABORTION
FUNDS LIKE ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE INDEPENDENTLY FUNDRAISE
TO BECKLEY AND INDIRECTLY
SUPPORT CALLERS. PATIENTS WITH
VARIOUS NEEDS SOME CLINICS ALSO
IT IS THE NATION'S WITH
PRACTICALS. EIGHT SUCH AS
NEEDING TO GET APPOINTMENTS AND
THE- UNMET NEEDS ARE HOWEVER
GREATER THAN THE RESOURCES
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO A CRICKET WEBSITE WITH
CENTRALIZED IN. PEOPLE TAKING
CARE IN CALIFORNIA THIS WILL
BOTH COMBAT MISINFORMATION AND
PROVIDE PATIENTS ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO ACCESS
ABORTION CARE THE SITE WILL
INCLUDE COMPREHENSIVE AND
MEDICALLY AT. MAISCH ABOUT
PROVIDE PROCEDURAL SUPPORT
OPTIONS INFORMATION ON THE TYPES
OF SERVICES AVAILABLE INSURANCE
INFORMATION ALONG WITH LANGUAGE
SUPPORT SERVICES. THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON AND NEW YORK ARE
ALREADY HAVE CREATED LANDING
PAGES TO DIRECT INDIVIDUALS TO
LINKS FOR THIS KIND OF CARE. THE
GOAL IS TO STRIP AND PRACTICAL
SUPPORT IMPRESSED BY PROVIDING
ONE POINT OF ENTRY TEND TO
CONNECT THE PATIENT WITH THE
ARREST OR MOST EXCESS- OBTAIN
HEALTH COVERAGE OR FINANCE
SUPPORT. IN THIS STICKLE NEEDS
AS A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE
CALIFORNIA MUST BE PREPARED TO
TREAT PATIENTS WHO ARE SEEKING
CARE IN THE STATE AND NAVIGATE
THEM TO THE BEST CARE POSSIBLE
SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO IS JUST ONE
OF MANY STEPS THE STATE CAN TAKE
TO HELP ACHIEVE THIS GOAL BEFORE
WHAT BEFORE WE MOVED HER EXPERT
WITNESSES- SENATOR SKINNER IS
ALSO A CO AUTHOR ON THIS- IF SHE
SHOULD SHOW UP HE WANTED TO SAY
A FEW WORDS- BUT AS WE CAN DO WE
TOOK IT OUT OF ORDER SHE MAY NOT
KNOW. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY%
REMOTELY IN SUPPORT IT SUCH
SOCHI LOPEZ I AYALA WHO IS THE
POLICY ADVOCATE COORDINATOR WITH
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
AND LISA MATSUBARA GENERAL
COUNSEL AND VP OF POLICY WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA OR HERE IN THE-
COMMITTEE ROOM FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SHOULD THEY NEED TO
GREEN. MISS LOPEZ I. ON THE LINE
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE PLEASE-
ANNOUNCE YOURSELF. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIR ON BOARD MEMBERS. BUT
YOU LOOK AT THE L. AND IN THE
POLICY ADVOCATES THE CARD READER
FOR CALIFORNIA ONLY A PORTION
FIND ACCESS TO PRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE OP INTERNET ACCESS R. J.
ACT ARGUING COMPASS THE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE MOVEMENT
WHICH TEACHES THAT. THE FIGHTING
WHEN AND IF THE PARENTS AND
RAISE CHILDREN CAN STAY
COMPETITIVE WILL COMMUNITIES. IS
A HUMAN RIGHT. OUR J. OFTEN AS
AN ADDITIONAL OF. THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR PATIENTS
NAVIGATING. AND OF COURSE ACCESS
. IN TWENTY NINETY MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED OUT PEOPLE THE POOR FUND
ACROSS UNITED STATES. LOOKING
FOR HELP TO GET HER PORTION.
PEOPLE CALL ABORTION FUNDS
BECAUSE WE REMAIN BE EXPERTS
WHEN IT COMES TO CONNECT THE
NUMBER COMPASSIONATE CARE.
ASSEMBLY NO OTHER NETWORK WITH
THE SHARED A TO GET AROUND
INTERGENERATIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE. WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE PATIENTS FOURTEEN
KAREN CALIFORNIA. AT ELEVEN
FORTY TWO WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA PORTION SUPPORT AND-
PROVIDE GRANTS TO ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE AT. THAT WILL PROVIDE
LOGISTICAL DIRECT SUPPORT TO
PEOPLE ACCESS TO ABORTION
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. BUT I
TELL YOU THAT ABORTION FUNDS
LIKE ACTORS ARE DEAR TO
CHALLENGING WORK. IT IS OUR
PASSION FOR CARING FOR OTHER
THAN PRIDE DOES. NOT AN
EXAGGERATION AND WE CAN.
THE FOURTEENTH ACTUALLY HONORED
BY THE DECADES OF WISDOM AND
HEARD IN ABORTION FUNDING WORK.
OPEN EXCEPT YOU GIVE ME TO SPEAK
TO FORTY TODAY I'M LOOKING FOR
THE TRUE LIBERATION WITH
ABORTION FUNDING FRIENDS CENTER
IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. I'M
CARE QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS LOPEZ I L. MISS LISA
MATSUBARA BEFORE YOU GO
RESPONSIBLE ARE LET ME- I SEE
CENTER SKINNER'S HERE CENTER
SKINNER DID. THE JOINT AUTHORS
OF THIS BILL. YES AND I WILL.
CLOSE I A SMALL TOMORROW. HIGHLY
SO MUCH OF OUR ON BEHALF OF THE
PARENTHOOD OF CALIFORNIA- I AND
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
BE AROUND FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRODUCE A MICROPHONE. I THANK MR
RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN THIS
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SAYING NO ONE- I'M SORRY THIS
MONTH SO FAR HI LISA MAZOWE ARE
AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND BOARD
MEMBER FOR ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE BOYS THOSE
OF- MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE
UP THOSE IN SUPPORT PROVIDE
THEIR NAME. THE FILIATION THEIR
POSITION ON S. B. ELEVEN FORTY
TWO. COMMENTS SUPPORT OF AT
ELEVEN FORTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. OF THE DEADLINE. FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN THE SCHOOL HAS.
THERE ARE QUITE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. FIFTY SHOULD SUPPORT
IN YOUR APPROACH WITH CALIFORNIA
ACROSS. IF YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIVE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIFTEEN CAN- WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE END
OF YOUR SUPPORT MY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND IT AT THE TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. ALRIGHT LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I BELIEVE
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ALEXANDER SNYDER
BRIDGEABLE. MYSTIFIED ARE YOU
ALL ONLINE. SO YOU'RE HERE ALL
RIGHT MISS CIDER IF YOU WOULD
ALL OF OKAY YOU MUST EITHER I'M
BRIDGET BLAIR ALL RIGHT MISS
BLAIR GO AHEAD THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BRIDGET BLAIR I AM THE FORMER
CEO OF HOLLISTER PREGNANCY
CENTER I HAVE HAD THREE FIRST
TRIMESTER ABORTIONS. AT FOURTEEN
I BECAME PREGNANT I WAS A NAIVE
CHILD PLANNED PARENTHOOD NEVER
ASKED ME ANY QUESTIONS THEY
SIGNED ME UP FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL AND I GOT MY FREE
ABORTION. DURING THE ABORTION I
SAW THE COLLECTION BOTTLE FILLED
WITH BLOOD AND BODY PARTS I WAS
TRAUMATIZED. AFTER THE ABORTION
I SPIRALED INTO DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ABUSE. PREGNANT AGAIN AT SIXTEEN
THE PAIN AND- COMPOUNDED ONE
CLICK A SECOND TIME I BECAME
DEPRESSED AND BEGAN STRUGGLING
IN SCHOOL THE THIRD TIME I WENT
TO THE CLINIC AND UNSTABLE
EMOTIONAL WRECK I DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY EMOTIONAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS OR ANY OPTIONS ON
THE MEDICAL TABLE I CRIED
VULNERABLE ON MY BACK WITH THE
FEET IN THE STIRRUPS. OVER ME
AND- DOT ONE TO DO THIS DO YOU I
SAID NO THE NURSE SAID IT WILL
BE OVER SOON I WAS A VISIBLE
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS YET THE
ABORTIONIST WENT TO WORK EVEN
THOUGH I SAID NO BEFORE THE
PROCEDURE BEGAN THEY DENIED MY
RIGHT TO CHOOSE THEY DENIED MY
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY MIND SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL ENTICE
WOMEN TO BOOK A FREE ABORTION
THROUGH A WEBSITE. THE NAY ERR
FAIR AND IT WILL COST SET UP
LODGING REIMBURSED LOST WAGES
INSURANCE EVEN RATE. WHAT'S TO
STOP SIMPLY IDENTIFIES IS
PREGNANT FROM BOOKING A FREE
ABORTION VACATION TO AUSTIN TO
LOS ANGELES AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE
WHO CONFIRMS THE PREGNANCY IN
ANOTHER STATE AND WHAT IF YOUNG
DESPERATE TEEN GIRS WHO COME
HERE CHANGE THEIR MINDS LIKE I
DID DO YOU THINK PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WILL SIMPLY ABSORB
THE COST NO THEY WILL NOT. S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL BECOME A
POWERFUL THREAT FORCING THESE
NAIVE GIRLS TO CLOSE THEIR EYES
AND GET THE PROCEDURE DONE
BECAUSE IT WILL BE OVER SOON SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL FIND A
HUGE NATIONAL ABORTION WILL FUND
A HUGE NATIONAL ABOARD. I THINK
. THE CROSS. I READ ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO ON SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU OF THE CIDER. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ALEXANDER SNYDER
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AND THE CEO
FOR THE LIFE LEGAL DEFENSE
FOUNDATION. SPF FORTY TWO IS NOT
A PRO. SOLE PURPOSE IS TO
PROMOTE AND ENCOURAGE ABORTION
THE STATED AIM OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO IS TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
A TRUE REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
STATE. THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
FOR ABSOLUTE FREEDOM WHEN IT
COMES TO REPRODUCTION TO
REPRODUCE MEANS TO COPY A BY
DEFINITION WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE CREATION OF NEW PEOPLE. WHEN
YOU ABOVE UP THEM BECAUSE YOU
WERE HAVE FREEDOM TO DO WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO THE ENTIRE PREMISE
OF THE BILL IS A LIE. SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO ESTABLISHES A
PROPAGANDA CAL. IN ABOUT HOW TO
GET A FREE ABORTION THE-
ALTERNATIVES TO ABORTION.
NOTHING ABOUT HOW TO ACCESS
PRENATAL CARE OR ANYTHING ELSE A
PREGNANT WOMAN MIGHT NEED OR
WANT. THE INFORMATION ON THE
WEBSITE WILL BE CONTROLLED BY SO
CALLED SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
WHICH ALL HAPPENED TO BE. IN
WHICH ALL HAPPENED TO BE
ENTITIES THAT A GREAT. PROMOTE
ABORTION. THE WEBSITE IS GOING
TO WOMEN ABOUT THE PHYSICAL LET
ALONE THE WELL DOCUMENTED MENTAL
AND EMOTIONAL COMPLICATIONS FROM
ABORTION OR THE REALITY OF THAT
IF THEY TAKE ABORTION PILLS THEY
COULD END UP DELIVERING IS SMALL
BUT FULLY FORMED PERSON. A
VICTIM OF REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
IN THE- PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND
OTHER SPONSORS OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO ALSO INCLUDED STATE
FUNDED OUTREACH PROGRAM TO TELL
THE PUBLIC HOW AND WHERE. TO
ACCESS ABORTION WHICH IS KIND OF
LIKE MCDONALD'S SPONSORING A
BILL. THERE'S TO PAY FOR
ADVERTISING. I HAMBURGERS I MEAN
WE BE A LITTLE SKEPTICAL RIGHT.
SB ELEVEN FORTY TWO AUTHORIZES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS TO
MANAGE GRANT PROGRAM TO ENTICE
OUT OF STATE WOMEN COME TO
CALIFORNIA FOR FREE ABORTIONS.
TO RELIVE THE LEAD. NOTED THAT
HAS NO EXPIRY OR BEING TO
ADMINISTER SAFER PROGRAMS BUT
THE MORE EGREGIOUS OVERSIGHT IS
APPOINTING A COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS TWO
MEN. GRAHAM SAID. OBLITERATING
TEXT DOESN'T CONTAIN A SINGLE
REFERENCE TO WOMEN. ONLY
ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE PROMOTE OR
PROVIDE ABORTIONS LIKE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR GRANT FUNDING NO
CONFLICTS THERE I'M SURE. HOW
THE **** IS GOOD LUCK THE BILL
EXPRESSLY EXAMS GRANT APPLICANT
THANK YOU KNOW SURE WINNER UNDER
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
ALREADY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OTHERS HUMAN ROOM TWELVE. BY OUR
- SB A LIVE FORTY TWO IF YOU
STEP FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR AND YOUR
- GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
NATASHA SERRANO FROM HACIENDA
HEIGHTS AND I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO ABORTION IS MURDER THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS NOT IN YOUR FROM
WEST COVINA CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSING THE STILL
THERE DUE TO THANK YOU. HELLO
PEOPLE MY NAME IS NATHAN NOT
FROM- ORANGE COUNTY IN FULLERTON
AND I. URGE YOU TO A- BLANK YOU
. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
HAMILTON ST REPRESENTING
ALTADENA CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MALAYSIAN
BUT THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THERESA BRENNAN PRESIDENT
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. JENNIFER'S
CLUB CO FROM RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA PART OF A STATE WIDE
PRO LIFE COALITION AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ELENA FROM SOAKING
COUNTY LIBERTY COALITION AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A TAXPAYER
THANK YOU. I AM GOING TO STEER A
MOM AND A GRANDMOTHER AND FROM
REDLANDS CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL YOU. CHANDOR STEER
FROM REDLANDS CALIFORNIA AND AS
A TAXPAYER I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GAIL MITCHELL FROM
HIGHLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'VE
ASKED YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. JOANNE IS A
DIRECT FROM THE CARPET
CALIFORNIA GRANDMOTHER AND
MOTHER. ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS THANK YOU. MARTINE SANTIAGO
FROM PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA
MASKING TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO GREG ABBOTT
OCEAN THE FOUNDER OF NOW NOT ON
OUR WATCH COME FROM FONTANA
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME'S MELISSA
SANTIAGO FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. I AM STRONGLY URGING ON
BEHALF OF OUR NATION THAT IS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ANASTASIA JOHNSON I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I MOSTLY
FUNERAL DIRECTOR AND I'M ASKING
YOU PLEASE VOTE NOON THIS BILL
YOU. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
MODERATE FROM ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA
THE MOTHER OF TWO AND SOON TO BE
THREE. NUMEROUS COMMUNITY PLEASE
NOTE ON THIS. THANK. HI MY
NAME'S ELIZABETH WROTE TO MY
MOTHER FOR GRANDMOTHER SEVEN I'M
FROM YUCAIPA CALIFORNIA AND I
ALSO POSES FILL THANK YOU. HELLO
I'M EDWARD IS A DARK FROM THE
KUIPER. FATHER OF TWO
GRANDFATHER OF SIX AND- I VOTE
NO ON THE BILL PLEASE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHICH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION THEY
SHOULD APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
NAME IS MICHELLE I SHINE CAL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SAYING NO
ONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED APPROACHING A FULL.
UNDER THE PHONE. MOTOR UP THOSE
THE PHARMACY IN TO S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY TWO IF THEY CAN PROVIDE
THEIR NAME THEIR FILIATION THE
POSITION. WHAT IS. YOU ARE IF
YOU WISH TO COME NOT POSITION
PRESS ONE ZERO- WE GO TO LINE
SIX TWENTY FOUR PEOPLE AT. AND
THE HEARING- COUNTY. THANK.
MEXICO TO LINE FOR TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PRESIDENT OF
COUNTING ON NOT PART OF ANY
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUP MY MOTHER
OF TWO CHILDREN NATIONALLY
OPPOSED THE MURDER OF INNOCENT
THEY HAVE CALLED A FEMALE.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE RESULT OF
THAT I AM A RESIDENT OF PERSONAL. THANK YOU. NIGHT OF THE TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE TO
LINE SIX TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD- IDENTITY ALL RIGHT- LIVE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY FROM THE
POLLS. THANK YOU. NOT TO GO TO
LINE SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TONY ROBOTIC WITH CAPITAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION
TO AT THE ELEVEN FORTY. THANK
YOU. THANK TO THE TIMELINE SIX
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
CLOTHESLINE FOR NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR NINE
NINE YOUR LINES OF. I WILL GO ON
TO NINETY SIX THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES AND PLASTER COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE MY NAME IS
KIM EMERSON. THANK YOU. THANKS
TO THE TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE COURT FROM
AT HOSPIRA CALIFORNIA AND I'D
START FEARING WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TO THIS KIND OF
KNOWLEDGE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
COMING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMENTS SING SING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. GONZALEZ LOS BILL.
THERE IS IT CAN CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
TRAGICALLY THE ACTION BY OTHER
STATES. HAS CAUSED A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE. IF PEOPLE DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO LEGAL
ABORTION. THEIR LIVES ARE IN
DANGER AND WHAT WE WITNESSED
WHEN BEFORE ROE VERSUS WADE
THERE WAS A MINIMUM AVERAGE FIVE
THOUSAND DEATHS ANNUALLY IN THE
U. S. FROM ATTEMPTED ABORTION
ILLEGAL ABOARD. NO DOUBT WHEN
YOU CAN MAP IT WAS FIFTY YEARS
AGO WHEN THE POPULATION OF OUR
COUNTRY. MUCH TODAY SO YOU CAN.
ACT HOW MANY DEATHS WE MAY FACE.
SO THIS IS NEEDED TO PREVENT.
THOSE ILLEGAL ABORTIONS BECAUSE
OF THE RESTRICTIONS BY OTHER
STATES NOW WITHIN OUR OWN STATE.
THE SOME MAY I ASK WHO'S IN THIS
JUST FOR PEOPLE FROM OUT OF- AS
WELL. YEAH NOT IMITATE. AT WE
HAVE NOT PUT ANY LA PAZ PLACE
WOULD LET WE STORE LOW G. AND IF
YOU LIVE IN A RURAL AREA WELL WE
HAVE A GOOD AMOUNT OF CLINICS
THAT. REPORTS YOU COULD QUITE.
AND I NEED. A DAY YOU MAY NEED
TO A DAY OF WORK OR AT NEED TO
STAY OVER SOMEWHERE IN ORDER TO
ACCESS TO THAT SERVICE. SO THE
WEBSITE. BOOK ALSO BE VERY AND
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND WITH THAT.
YES ZERO VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR SKINNER ALL RIGHT
THERE'S A BEEN A MOTION BY
CENTER GONZALEZ MAN TO COUNSEL
YOU PLEASE ROLE AS THE PASSES
ENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PURPOSE AND- BY FOR JUST. ZERO I
THREE I. THOUGHT GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES BAIRD- CLEARED
AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE
WIENER WIENER HI YOU HAVE EIGHT
ZERO SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PLACE ON CALL.
THE MALL. AND LIMÓN SB. ONE
THREE EIGHT SEVEN THIS IS FAIR.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS SB ONE
THREE EIGHT SEVEN ESTABLISHES A
WORKING GROUP TO DISCUSS AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON IS TO
ENSURE BOARD PROVIDE THE DATE
STATE. TO RECALL SPENT SUMMERS
TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND ANNUAL
AFTER. PORT GET INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA.
REFLECTS ITS GREATER POPULATION
THE COLLECTION OF GUBERNATORIAL
POINT KEY DEMOGRAPHIC IS
CRITICAL IS A CREDIT TO A CHEAP
AND MAINTAIN J. RACIAL. ETHNIC
EQUITY ON BOARDS COMMISSIONS.
ANNUAL SERVICE RIGHT AND IF I
GAPS IN REPRESENTATION INCREASE
JACK WHICH TO COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO SEE. THE OF
THIS IS HEATHER FIVE WE HAVE CAN
DO BETTER AND INSTITUTIONALIZED
PRACTICES AND THE GAMES MADE TO
DIVERSIFY THE STATE'S BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. WITH THE AT TODAY
WE HAVE TAURUS HALF OF THE
SPONSOR IS ORGANIZE FOR
POLITICAL EQUITY HOPE. THANK YOU
FOR. STORES IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE
ON THE PHONE FUNERAL'S YOURSELF
I. YEAH I AM AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HELEN TOWARDS CEO HELLO. HISPANA
PUBLICLY FOLLY HOPE IS A
NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
ENSURING POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
. LEADER IN EDUCATION TO BACK
OFF AND THAT THE PLAN PUBLIC
PROUDLY FONG SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AND ARE GRATEFUL TO BE
WORKING WITH AND ALONE ON THIS.
SB THIRTY EIGHTY. SIX PAGE TEN.
TARA I WOULD THE ANNUALBE
RELEASED SCHERING THE
DEMOGRAPHIC OF ALL STATEMENTS
THE PREVIOUS YEAR THIS REPORT
WOULD INCLUDE IMPORTANT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA SUCH REYES. HE
THAT SEXUAL VETERAN AND REGION
OF THIS AND REPORT HELP AND- THE
UP DEMOGRAPHIC COMP OF BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS ACROSS THE STATE
IF ENACTED THE DATA BE FULL
LIGHT THE THANK. THEY'RE
MISTAKEN FOR IN ADDITION THE
ANNUAL SB THIRTEEN SEVEN WILL
CREATE TIME WORKING. THAT HAVE
OF A DEFINED WHICH IS THE
APPOINTMENT PROCESS THE TRUTH IS
THAT FIVE THREE IN NATURE NOT
HOLD ANY OF FORTY. WELCOME THE
PERSON YOU ARE THE STATE BOTH
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ENSURE THAT
HEALTH THAT COOLEY REPRESENTED
WITH THE RICH DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE. THE FIRST GOVERNMENT
POLICY. THAT REFLECT INTERESTS
OF THE SENATE AS MOST POPULOUS
IN THE FIRST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY. WE BELIEVE IT'S TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO CREATE
MECHANISMS TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOVERNANCE IS TRULY REFLECTIVE
OF THE COMMUNITY. THERE M. THE
MARKET. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
TODAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED FEW
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
SIGNALING APPROACHING MICROPHONE
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. OF THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WE'D
BE GRATEFUL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE LINE IN Q. ZERO NINE SIX
HUNDRED WHAT WILL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY SIX HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT LET'S LET'S TURN
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
ROOM TWO I SEE NO BOB PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM WAS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THEY SHOULD
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SAYING
NO ONE APPROACH IN MY PHONE
LET'S TURN THE PHONE LINES. IF
YOU QUEUE UP ANY OF THOSE. THE
POSITION TO S. B. IS. WITH
GRATEFUL. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS BECOME OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S
COME BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NO
HANDS RAISED. OH I'M SORRY
CENTER GONZALEZ. CHECK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU TO THE TO THE SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AGAIN
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS WAS- IN THE
SLOPES STEEPER AND IT'S
FANTASTIC BUILT BY SOME OF OUR
CLOSE FRIENDS AT HOPE WE'VE DONE
INCREDIBLE WORK WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS TRUE EQUITY
ON THE BOARDS OF THE- BACK. S.
FIRST SUPPORTER THIS. BILL WILL
MOVE THE BILL TO PROVIDE. ALL
RIGHT I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
SECOND SALAS MOVES THE BILL- ALL
RIGHT. NO OTHER FOR THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CEREMONY
COULD CLOSE. FIVE MILLION TO
CANCER YOU CALL THE ROLL- YES
THIS SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LEE MON- WITH
THE MOTION BY CENTER GONZALEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. I ALL
RIGHT THE REST SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG JONES
LAYERED- LAYERED ICE STERN STERN
AYE WIECKOWSKI I CASK AYE WIENER
- SEVENTY ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU SO. NEXT WE'VE
CENTER SKINNER SO HE- JUST THE-
FOR PURPOSES OF ALERTING THOSE
SYSTEM WHAT THE PROGRESS IS IT
WILL BE- AFTER CENTER- THE BELT
TURN TO THAT TURN TO COMMITTEE
TO BILLS. FOR SENATE PASSED THE
SENATE AND SALAS IN CENTER
HERTZBERG INSTEAD OF WHAT KELCE.
THE CHAIR. ALL RIGHT SENATE BILL
FOR YOUR- SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND I THE FIRST THANK
THE AND- THE CHAIR FOR WORKING
WITH ME I TO GREAT AND
AMENDMENTS I MEAN SEPARATING
WHAT. DEBT THAT SUBJECT TO THIS
. TO FIT WITHOUT BELOW. AND MET
DEBT AT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. IT
ALSO WILL CHANGE THE INTEREST
RATE IN THE BILL TO FEDERAL
PRIME SET ANNUALLY BY THE COURT
FOR CAPPED AT 5% SO YOU SEE THE
BUILDING BEFORE IT WOULD HAVE
SET IT AT A- AND- THE MAN. IT
FEDERAL WHICH THE COURT WOULD
SAID ANNUALLY AND THEN UP AT
FIVE. 61% OF THE POPULATION THE
US IS NOW IS ESTIMATED THIS IS
AS OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THREE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
PERSONAL DEBT INCREASED BY SIX
LAST YEAR IN FAMILIES IN THAT
SITUATION WHO FACE AN UNEXPECTED
MEDICAL BILL IS PREPARE. IN THE
RISING SHOULD BE GOOD FOR BEHIND
CREDIT CARD PAYMENTS LOAN OR
OTHER PAYMENTS NOWIF A- THE
DATA COLLECTOR GOES TO COURT TO
GET A JUDGMENT ON THAT DEBT AND
THE REASON WHY THEY DO THAT
BECAUSE GET A COURT JUDGMENT IN
THAT. LEAPERS COLLECTION
THROUGH. MEANS ON WAGES-
PROPERTIES VARIOUS THINGS LIKE
THAT. YOU CAN ONLY DO THAT ONCE
YOU GET A COURT JUDGMENT BUT
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW IF
THE DEBT ENDS UP IN. THE END IT
. HIS PERCENT WHICH IS HIGHER
THAN THE FEDERAL PRIME RATE HAS
BEEN FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY EIGHT
STATES WITH THE HIGHEST
STATUTORILY REQUIRED COURT YOUR
DENTURES FOR. RECENT YEARS
ARIZONA FOR EXAMPLE USED TO
FEDERAL PRIME PLUS ONE DELAWARE
23% NEW YORK JUST REDUCED TO TWO
PERCENT. YES TWELVE IT AS I
MENTIONED WE DO SEE INTEREST
RATE ON ON MORE DEBT JUST. OUT
IN MEDICAL BUT IT WONDER K. DANS
THE BILL YOU CAN FULLY NEW JUDGE
. AND THE REASON THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS.
CHISS IF I RENEW THAT SO NOW
YOUR YOUR DENTIST ACCUMULATE SO
IT'S I WENT TO A FIFTY DOLLAR.
SCOTT TEN. TO TREAT EACH SO NOW
THE DEBTS THAT WHATEVER THAT
COMPOUNDED AMOUNT BUT I HAVEN'T
GONE TO COLLECT I HAVEN'T REALLY
COLLECTED I RENEW IT. START 10%
I CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WITHOUT TAKING COLLECTION ACTION
SO IT INCREASES THE DEBT AND- SO
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS GET
COLLECTORS TO ACT ON THEIR- YEAH
. IT JOB YOU NEED TO. LINO WAGES
PUT LIENS ON THE PROPERTY
WHATEVER WITHOUT HAVING TO
INCREASE THE INDIVIDUALS DEBT IN
THE JOURNAL IT AMOUNTS NOW BY.
IN RURAL ELIMINATE THE AT. IF AN
ACTION WAS TAKEN LIKE A LEAN OR
SUCH IT STILL ALLOWS YOU TO
CONTINUE IT DOESN'T JUST. THE
TEN YEARS WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE. WHEN I DESCRIBED SO. AND TO
MY- GIULIANA FRIEDMAN FROM BAY
AREA LEGAL AID IN ANDREW DELE
FROM COMMUNITY LEGAL AID OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT
MISS FRIEDMAN OR FRESHMAN
BILLABLE. OR MR DALY. R. LISTER
WITH HIS FRIEND. AFTER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S GILLIAN ARE
PREGNANT AND I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY IN THE CONSUMER UNIT
LEGALLY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE. I'M KIND A LITTLE AND
FELL CONSUMER LAW CLINIC SERVING
WITHOUT PEOPLE YEAR. BUT THE
PEOPLE WE HELP ARE FACING
ASSEMBLY LINE LOW DOLLAR LIMITED
CIVIL COLLECTION CASES WHICH
MAKE A LARGE. FOR THE STATE'S
CIVIL COURT DOCKET. EIGHT PEOPLE
OFTEN ASK IMPROPER SERVICES JEFF
. DEFENDANTS SEPARATELY. ARE THE
THIRD. WHEN CREDIT OR A JUDGE
THEY HAVE TEN YEARS. DAWN.
QUESTION ON WAGES YEAH. ALL MY-
THANK OF LONG THEY CAN PAY FOR
THAN A- ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLAR. WHEN JUDGES ARE HIGH IN
INFINITELY RENDON. PEOPLE. THEY
HOW COUPLE STORY THREE CHANGED I
CAN'T FIND POPULOUS THOUSAND
DOLLARS EACH OBJECT AGAINST MY
BASED ON A PROJECT PURPOSE IS HE
LEARNED OF A LOT IN ABOUT A YEAR
LATER WHEN A AFTER CONTACT HER
IN FRONT TO GARNISH. THREE HOURS. YOU CAN AFFORD. MONTHLY IN AB
NETWORK BECAUSE THE PAYMENT SHE
WOULD MAKE. DONALD TEN YEARS AGO
FARBER WHO THE JUDGE FROM THE
SENATE OF TIME WILL HELP TO
PREVENT THE RENEWAL DID THE
FRAGILE SERVER BUT HAD WE NOT
SHE COULD PAYING MORE ON THE
FLOOR. VERY AVAILABLE RELATIVE
INCOMES ARE OF THE CAR. BECAUSE
ALL THIS IS. WHICH THE PRIME. NO. FILE. PEOPLE JUST FIVE DOLLARS
CAN YOU LATER CREDIT OVER NEW
THE JOSHUA OPENS NOTICE THAT
WHICH I THINK WITH YEAR OLD
ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND BY THE
CLAIM FROM DUNGEON C<c.cyan>.</c>
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MR DALY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
NEED TO DANDER DEARLY AND I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY AT COMMUNITY
LEGAL AID SO. YOU'RE A LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES
CA. WALDRON ROAD IT IS EXPENSIVE
PEOPLE THE LEGAL AID ATTORNEY I
CAN ATTEST TO THAT WHICH IS WHY
COMMUNITY LEGAL AID SO CAL BACK
AS BECAUSE HUNDRED. BILLION
QUESTION AT THE RIGHT. THANK
THAT MAKE IT WORK STATE. THANK A
BILL ON A CHOIR AND SHE EVOLVE
JUDGMENT AND THEN CAPITALIZING
ON THE HIGH INTEREST THEY CAN
COLLECT POST JUDGMENT. THE
CURRENT LAW 10% INTEREST.
JUDGMENT DOUBLE EVERY. DOCTORS
ARE INCENTIVIZED NOT MERELY
COLLECT ON THE DEBT AT THE RATE
OF RETURN IS FAR SUPERIOR THAN
ANYTHING FOUND IN THE
MARKETPLACE. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ALONE ORANGE COUNTY RECORDED
MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND DEBT
COLLECTION CASES. OF WHICH 46%
IN DEFAULT JUDGMENT. THAT
LEGALLY WE HELP OUR CLIENTS
AVOID DEFAULT JUDGMENT BUT WE
DON'T THAT HAPPENS YOU NEED TO
ENFORCEMENT OF THE JUDGMENT AND
THE FINANCIALLY CATASTROPHIC.
OUR TWENTY FIVE NO OF PRIOR LOS
. ENTIRELY FIND THEM FACE
ABILITY JUDGMENT. FOR EXAMPLE
OUR OFFICE RECENTLY THE CLIENTS
WHO A LONG TIME LOS ANGELES
COUNTY LIFEGUARDS. CONNECTION
WITH A DEFAULT JUDGMENT FILED IN
TWENTY TWELVE FOR ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS. I'M NOT PROPER
. THE PREVIOUS WITHOUT HAVING.
CAN YOU AND ONE JUDGE LATER
COLLECTORS WERE CHECKING
COLLECTED YET DURING THE CAN AND
WHILE YOU'VE DONE PLOY WHICH HAD
BALLOONED. THREE LAKES OKAY
SPORTS AT THE ON ENERGY NOT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HELLO THIS IS A OF B. HUH WHO
PRESENT HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
. MISTER NUMBERS OF MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY- YOU JUST HEARD THE
STORIES OF OUR LAW OUR PARTNERS
LEGAL SERVICE ADVOCATES ON THE
GROUND. AND THE STORIES THAT WE
SEE EVERY DAY COMING INTO YOU'RE
- STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ISRAEL. ALL
RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT- YOUR
NAME YOUR- POLICE YOUR POSITION.
WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SAYING NO ONE IS HERE
TWELVE. WHAT DOES THIS. ALL THE
TIME. WELL. SO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB TWELVE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE HAVE FIVE
LINES INTO WILL GO AWAY SIX
HUNDRED AND TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HE WILL BE TAKING A LOT
FURTHER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SIX FIVE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIX HUNDRED FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RACHEL FREITAS AND THE NUMBER
SIX IS SUBJECTED FROM CHILD
SUPPORT COLLECTION. POLICE ARE
THANK YOU FOR AS HE HUNDRED YOU
THANK YOU. BUT HUNDRED SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS THE
THREE ONE FOURTH ALAMEDA COUNTY
CONSTRUCT REPORTED THANK. THANK
YOU. SIX HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS WILL BE AWAY FROM ALL
THREE THOUSAND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE TWELVE HUNDRED. BE ABLE TO
ADDITIONAL LINES IN QUEUE
SYSTEM. ALREADY LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION I SEE NO MAIN
WITNESSES LISTED IN OPPOSITION
BUT APPARENTLY THERE IS ONE HERE
AT THE MALL. SO WHICH NUMBERS I
AM HERE IN SUPPORT JUST THREE OH
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD I'M SO SORRY
TO GO ABOVE ORDER DID CAN PIES
ARE. CAL LOAN. WISH IN THE NOT
OKAY MY LAW CENTER PARK ARE A
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE ARE.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ALEX AND ANI'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGMENT PRESERVATION
ALLIANCE BUT THE ALLIANCE
COMPRISED OF JUDGMENT
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
ATTORNEYS INVESTORS PROCESS
SERVERS PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS IS
INVOLVED IN THE IMPORTANT
SERVICE OF RECOVERING MONEY OWED
ON JUDGMENTS. AND TO GIVE
DEBTORS OF CAN DEBT REPRIEVE.
HOWEVER THE BILL GOES BEYOND
JUST CONSUMER DEBT. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF COURT JUDGMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE OWED TO VICTIMS
OF CRIMES SUCH AS FRAUD AND
ELDER ABUSE. THESE VICTIMS LOSE
THEIR RIGHT OF THEM BEYOND. SB
TWELVE ACTED. REPORTER RIGHT TO
BE. ENTITLED TO AN THAT RIGHT
BEYOND TEN YEARS IF NECESSARY.
WE ARE DEVASTATED AND TO REMOVE
BUTTON RENEWALS ON PERSONAL DEBT
JUDGMENTS THE PROBLEM WITH THE
BILL HOWEVER THAT AFFECTS EVERY
JUDGE REGARDLESS WIND OBLIGATION
ABOUT JUDGMENT WITHOUT ANY
CONSIDERATION FOR THE TRUE
VICTIM. GEN DO NOT GO DOOR
BECAUSE THE CREDIT TRYING TO MAX
INTEREST FOR YEARS BEFORE
ENFORCING. DORMANT JUDGMENTS ARE
RESULT OF SEVERAL FACTORS
INCLUDE BUT VERY FEW ATTORNEYS
KNOW HOW TO ENFORCE JUDGMENT.
JOSH BUSSELL ICEFIELD. THE BILL
ALSO CREEK TOO MEN MUCH COME.
THAT INCLUDES THE WORD ALLEGED
TO BE DO ALL IN. A MONEY
JUDGMENT VOTED NO LONGER THE
ALLEGED. HAS ORDERED IT DO
SENATE TILL THE JUDGEMENT IS
VACATED OR MODIFIED A COURT HAS
DETERMINED THE DEBTOR THE MONEY
THE DEBT PORT IN THE DEBT BETTER
HAVE THE DAY IN COURT TO
CHALLENGE WHAT WAS ALLEGED TO BE
TO. I DIDN'T HEAR OKAY THE
CHILDREN AT THE TIME EVEN TEN
YEARS LATER. THERE ARE WAYS TO
ACHIEVE GOALS OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS HOWEVER IF HISTORY
IN THE RIGHT TO RENEW IN MY
JUDGMENT FORWARDED. NOT VERY.
THE JUDGE. ALLIANCE FOR. URGE
THAT YOU NO ON S. B. HUNDRED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU'RE HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED PLEASE
APPROACH MICROPHONE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ON PHONE. ANYONE UP
IN UP ON THE PHONE. THE
GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN A POSITION
TO PRESS THE TWELVE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE. IT CLINTON Q.
OKAY THANK YOU BERLIN SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY SORRY THE
DESTRUCT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FIRST BY MEMBER GLOBAL TELLING
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DALY SEVEN I'M CALLING
FROM THE CITY OF OAKLAND I'M
ACTUALLY I THINK OF THE LIBERAL
MISTAKE BUT I'M ACTUALLY CALLING
IN SUPPORT YOU STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AT THE TOP OF YOUR- GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS RAYMOND
GOLDSTINE I- THE CALL YESTERDAY
I UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE WASN'T-
IS SCHEDULED. GET BODY ALTHOUGH
I'VE BEEN CREATED FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS TO OUR ENFORCEMENT
OF MONEY JUDGMENTS CERTAIN THE
SIR WILL GIVE YOU ONE ONE MANY
CERTAINLY. BUT SIR WHAT. WHAT
THE MINUTE. ONE MINUTE ARE I'M
NOT FOR A COUPLE REASONS I THINK
THE GOLDER LAW- BUT. PROP
PROPERTY RIGHTS THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE- BY LIMITING INTEREST LESS
AFFAIRS RETURN. ALSO WE ARE.
RECOUNTS DEBTORS PEOPLE TO- WAIT
IT OUT WE'RE NOT ELIMINATING THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE AFTER TEN
YEARS BECAUSE. ONE FOUR THREE.
PREVIOUS THIRTY SEVEN MOST
IMPORTANT THIS IS POORLY I LOVE
IT SIX SECONDS LIKE TO EXPLAIN
HOW THE FAMILY LAW. ON WHAT IS
WHY WELL KAMALA HARRIS FOR SIXTY
SECONDS RURAL'S GO AHEAD OKAY-
THANK YOU- SO- S. THAT IS NOT
ASSIGNED IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT WHY
THAT IS TO BE TREATED AS ANY
OTHER CLUB. CAN BE ENTITLED. THE
RETURN IN THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM WE HAVE TO BE ADDED TO
THE PEOPLE AVOIDING SUPPORT
OBLIGATIONS INTO BOARD THAT
WOULD BE VERY UNFAIR REMEMBER.
WHAT I- WHOLESALE WE'RE NOT
FORGETTING WE'RE NOT REMEMBER
YOU CHANGES ACCORDING MADE SIX
NINETY FIVE POINT TWO ONE WHICH
YOU. OUR. PRINCIPALEMENT ARE
ENTERED NOW REDUCE INTEREST ON
THAT WOULD BE A SHORT UNFAIR
IT'S ALSO ONE HUNDRED THIS THING
YOU YOU. WHAT DO YOU SUBMIT
THROUGH IF YOU CHOOSE RIGHT
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE UP AS ON
THE LINE. VETERANS HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM LYNCH FROM
PLATINUM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE RECEIVABLE MANAGEMENT
SINGLES MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION
INTERNATIONAL AND WE ARE CLOSED.
THANK YOU. SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS BILL
I'M BACK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND- THANK
YOU. FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO AFTERNOON NUMBER
EIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CURRICULA TIMBER COMPANY AND
CALLED JUSTICE MATTERS WE
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF CREDITORS
THE OLD MAN HERE BUT YOUR
AFFILIATION OPPOSITION ARE YOU
OPPOSED. I AM FOCUSED ON WE ARE-
HOPEFUL. YOU FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE WITH A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE OPPOSED TO SB
TWELVE HUNDRED THANK YOU. SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS NOW HE CREATED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO AND- THANK YOU. FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON. WHAT. THE TURN IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANTHONY ONEAL
CORNERING DENTURES ON OUR
MULTIPLE CIVIL JUDGMENTS WHICH
THE LORD THE TAKING OF EXISTING
CREDITOR RIGHTS AND I'M THREE
HOURS THANK YOU. HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
EIGHTY I'M A JUDGMENT RECOVERY
ASSISTANCE I STRONGLY APPROACH
BELL IT'S GONNA HURT A LOT OF
ANY GIVEN MUCH ALL RIGHT.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. J. R. SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BIGELOW
ADDITIONAL LIKE COMPUTER SCIENCE
. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- LET'S
RESPECT COMMITTEE QUESTIONS YES
SIR WHAT CAL SKI I COULD NOT
SUFFICIENTLY I LIKE THIS BILL
PROBABLY SURPRISES MY COLLEAGUES
SITTING SITTING HERE- BUT WHAT I
THINK THE WAY THE ONE I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THE- IS THE- ON.
LIMON THE VALUE OF THE LANE
BECAUSE I SIMILAR OF PEOPLE.
TRANSPARENZ WE WERE BACK IN
MOSCOW IS THAT YOU KNOW THESE
SIR. MORE OR LESS PEOPLE NOT
EVERYBODY'S POOR PERSON I GET IT
BUT BY LIMITING THE PERSONAL
DEBT TO FIFTY THOUSAND WHEN THIS
PREDATOR POINTER TEXTILE IN.
PERSONAL AND THEY CAN DO THAT
THEY CAN BRING HIM INTO COURT
AND SAY OKAY YOU GOT A WINNEBAGO
THAT'S NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT OR
YOU GOT OF CLUBS YOU GOT
WHATEVER IT IS AND THAT LEAD
ATTACHED TO THAT WHEN TEN YEARS
. THAT'S IS THE VALUE WHICH DOES
IT WHICH SORT OF REFLECTS WHAT
THE WHAT WHAT THE DEBTOR HAS
SUBMITTED ONLY HAS SO MUCH STOP
RIGHT NEAR AND THEY HAVE ALSO
DON'T HAVE NOPE. HARPER IF THE-
LEAN ON IT. BUT IT IS AND THAT
OPENS FROM THE OTHERS OF YOU IS
A PRACTITIONER. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NEGOTIATIONS TO SETTLE THESE
THESE LANES BECAUSE IF THEY JUST
KEEP BUILDING UP IT WAS MY
EXPERIENCE AT DEBTORS WILL NEVER
TALK TO BUT IF THEY NOTED IT'S
LIMITED TO PAY WHAT THEY HAVE.
IT'S THE CLUB FOR. SPEAKS FOR
SOME PRACTICAL IN THIS ARENA-
JUST WANT TO BRING THAT UP AND I
WILL- MOVE THE BILLS ALL RIGHT-
ASSEMBLY SKILLS THE BILL
RECOVERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I'LL- SKINNER
SKINNER RIGHT I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE JUST IN TERMS
OF. TRYING TO. MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S A FAIR SYSTEM- AND THAT THE
INTEREST DOESN'T END UP
COMPOUNDING SO SIGNIFICANTLY
THAT ON THAT YOU NEVER PAY OFF
THE DEBT AND THERE'S A
IMPOSSIBLE I'M- STEAD AND THE
AND THIS AREA IS REALLY
COMPLICATED AND THE- DEATH AS AS
THE- FOR. BUT I THINK THE ARE SO
JUDGMENT THAT PROBABLY
RIGHTFULLY SHOULD BE EXCLUDED IT
PARTICULARLY IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT JUDGMENTS THAT ARE AWARDED
BASED ON CRIMINAL CON- AT SOME.
DID TO AN INDIVIDUAL AND I
WONDER IF YOU'D BE WILLING TO AT
LEAST HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THOSE KINDS OF JUDGMENTS- BUT TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
COLLECTOR AND- KIND OF THAT. S.
WIENER'S BILL ABOUT- GETTING OFF
OF PER BREAK PROBATION OR PAROLE
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
WONDER IF YOU ME AND- DOWNTURN
IN COMMON CERTAINLY AND I
APPRECIATE QUESTION I ALSO WILL
APOLOGIZE THAT IN EIGHT MONTHS.
DID NOT LEAVE A MOSCOW THE
AMENDMENT THAT REMOVES FRAUD AND
ELDER ABUSE FROM THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL SO THOSE. THOSE
SPECS FIVE THERE'S A JUDGMENT
RELATED TO FRAUD OR TO REVIEW.
THOSE TOM. CHOI WOULD NOT AT FOR
BILL THE WEATHER THERE'S A YET
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. BUT HE TRIED
WITH THE BILL MAKE SURE IT DID.
POSTED DEAD IN DIDN'T RELATE TO
ANY OTHER TYPE OF CRIMINAL JUDGE
ME TYPE OF A IT'S A CIVIL- BUT
SEARCH WANT TO LOOK PICTURE WE
HAVE A SCRIPTED OF THAT. MIGHT
TAKE A MINUTE THAT REMOVE STRADA
ABUSE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
QUESTIONS BEEN MOVED NO I CAN
SKI OF LETS GET A CLOSE. THANK
YOU IT UP SB TWELVE HUNDRED
HELPS ALONG US THIRSTY STREET
BURDEN ON THE FAMILY. ACTUALLY
YOU STILL PUT THE DEATH ACTUALLY
. WITHOUT A DOUBT. THE IS SENATE
BILL TWELVE BASE SKINNER WITH
THE MOTION SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
THE MOTION TO PASS ASTHMA BY FOR
AMEND THREE WERE TO THE SEA ON
CREATION NUMBER. FOR YEAH. REGIS
ZERO I DRESSEL THE DRESS SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES LAYERED STERN- STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER
. YOU HAVE SIX TO ONE SO FAR
WITHOUT MEMBERS MISSING CHAIR
WILL PUT BACK ON CALL. CHIEF
COUNSEL TO TURN OVER THE GAVEL
TO US FOR JUST FOR FEW MINUTES.
SURFBOARDS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR. THANK YOU I'M GONNA NEED TO
FIND OUT WHERE WE'RE LOCATED WE
ARE SCRIPT. FOR THE- A NUMBER
EIGHTEEN VICE CENTER THERE ALSO
SB ONE OR. THREE TO FOUR.
WELCOME VISITOR ALSO THANK YOU
LUCKY YOU. ROISIN ONE DAY THIS
OCULAR SO AS YOU WERE PREPARED
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR- DO YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS- YES IN FACT THAT'S HOW
I WAS GOING TO START MY REMARKS
TO MAKE SURE I AYES AYE. SO OF
THAT AS I KICK OFF IF THAT'S
OKAY BY ALL MEANS OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE COUNSEL
THE DIDN'T EXCELLENT ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL. AND FOR HELPING US TO
OUTLINED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
ELEVEN THE ANALYSIS OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT UNDER OR IS THAT THE
BILL SHALL NOT BE CA. TO REQUIRE
LORD. DEEPER IT TEN- NOTICES
DISCLOSURES OR VALIDATIONS OF
DEBTS THE FIRST ONE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT UNDERSCORES THAT
LANDLORDS ARE EXEMPT. RASCHE
THROWN CAR. IN THE FALL ACT AND
DINNER HAVE TO PROVIDE SPENT
NOTED ON THEIR CONTACT WITH THE
DEBTOR OR VALIDATE- DEBTS UPON
REQUEST. THIS IS A BILL IS
SIMPLE AND IT'S URGENT THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE COLLECTION OF
RENT DEBT IS COVERED BY THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS OTHER KINDS OF
CONSUMER DEBT. UNDER THE
ROSENTHAL FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES ACT SPECIFICALLY IT
DEFINES RENTAL DEBT AS ON PAY IT
. THE OTHER ONE. HELLO ABOUT
TENANT UNDER TENANCY IT EXTENDS
THE PROTECTIONS OF THE ROSENTHAL
ACT TO COVER RENTAL DEBT THAT
BECAME PAST DUE ON OR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST. NINETEEN THIRD IT
EXEMPTS ANYONE COLLECTING RENTAL
DEBT FROM THE REQUIREMENT TO
LIST A DEBT COLLECTOR LICENSE
NUMBER WHEN COLLECTING RENT. AND
THIS BILL FINALLY A CONSUMER
CREDIT TRANSACTION DOES NOT MEAN
A TRANSACTION THAT RESULTS AND
RENTAL DEBT THIS MEANS THAT THE
LANDLORDS DO NOT NEED TO OBTAIN
A DE COLLECTOR LIGHT WINDS IN.
BLACK THE- ALL WAS THAT WE HAD
SUCH GREAT COMMITTEE A STAFF
THAT US. GET TO THESE AMENDMENTS
AND THE BILL DURING THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM TENANTS HAVE
ACCUMULATED UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNTS OF DEBT AS MUCH AS TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER
FAMILY. IN MY DESK. JUST NOT.
TOOLS AND PROCESSES THREE BIG-
PANDEMIC DEBT AND RENT RELIEF
ARE COMPLEX AND THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY CHANGING MANY
LANDLORDS HAVE RECEIVED
ASSISTANCE FROM RENT RELIEF
PROGRAMS ON THE LAST DAY OF THE
STATE WIDE PROGRAM OVER THIRTY
MILES. IT IT. IF IT BILL THAT IS
ACTUALLY IT'S STREAMING
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE THE
STAGGERING NEED AMONG HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS NOW THAT
RENT RELIEF PROGRAM SOME ENDED
AND WE'RE BEGINNING TO NAVIGATE
THE LEGAL. ABOUT A SICK DECENCY
IN MY DISTRICT NEARLY 80% ARE
RENTERS- THEY WERE ALREADY
LIVING ON THE EDGE BEFORE THE
DEEP INSTABILITY OF THIS DAMAGE
. TOM COMPARED TO UPPER IN
RENTERS ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY
UCLA RECENTLY- ROUGHLY TEN TIMES
AS MANY LOW INCOME RENTERS
BEHIND ON THEIR RENT IS FAMILY
BACK ON FEET THE STRESS OVER
PAYING THEIR BILLS WE WANT TO
KEEP. CEMENT AND ABUSE. THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL SAYS THAT THESE
FAMILY SHOULD BE FREE OF
HARASSMENT AFTER ALL THEY DID
NOT EVER IMAGINE THEMSELVES IN A
SITUATION OF OWING THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO STATE. CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY COLOR BLOCK SHOULD
EXPLICITLY PROTECT TENANTS FROM
ABUSIVE. IN THE COLLECTION OF
THE RENTAL DEBT THIS BILL SAYS
THAT TENANTS COLLAPSE AND HAVE
THE SAME CHANCE FROM HER CLINTON
IS SET UP OTHER TYPES SUMMER DAY
LIKE JUST.
EIGHT THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRING ANYTHING MORE THAN
THAT ARE SIMPLY NOT REFLECTED IN
THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL OR
EXISTING LAW TODAY WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES AND THE POLL LIZ ONCE
. PUBLIC CANCEL IS HERE IN PER.
AND TED BERMAN FROM CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME COME LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IS ON THE
WITNESS LINE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO MR MERMAN ARE YOU OF LET'S
START WITH THE MISSING YOU'LL
KIND OF KAISER. I ACTUALLY I'M
ELIZABETH SALAS GOOD AFTERNOON-
MISTER PROVIDING STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH PUBLIC COUNCILS CONSUMER
RIGHTS AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
PROJECT PUBLIC COUNCIL IS A
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION IN LOS ANGELES HAS
A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY. READY THE LAST
THING ABUSIVE AND THREATENING
DEBT COLLECTION TACTICS AGAINST
TENANTS ALL OF WHICH WOULD BE
PROHIBITED UNDER THIS BILL WE
WANT A SINGLE MOTHER WHO IS
EXPERIENCING SOME RESTAURANTS
FROM HER HEAD HER LAND.
DEMOCRATS AND YOU CAN. IT WOULD
WHAT ENDING READ MULTIPLE TIMES
PER WEEK HOUNDING THE TEND TO
PAY BECAUSE SHE OWES BACK RENT
THE LANDLORD HAS REFUSED TO MAKE
ANY WERE TO HER PRETTY AND HAS
ROOF IT THE STATE THAT FOR TWO
BACK. THE CASE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. EXPERIENCE SHE
RECEIVED A FLOOD OF HARASSING
TEXT MESSAGES FROM HER LANDLORD
DEMANDING SHE PAY THIS BACK RENT
AS RETALIATION FOR HER IN A BILL
TO PASS A CODE NINETY ACTUALLY.
I TENNIS. THAT SHE WAS ENTITLED
TO ACCESS UNDER HER LEAST AND
UNLAWFULLY INCREASE THE RENT ON
HER UNIT HAVING ONLY RECENTLY
OBTAINED A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST KIRBY BASING HARASSED
FROM AND IN SCHOOL OR OVER HER
WAS ON L. I. I. DOUBLE TENANTS
ASKED ALLOW TOPPED HER
COMMUNICATION GET THE LANDLORD
CONTINUE THEIR ACTIONS IN
ADDITION TO THE STORIES WE HAVE
HEARD OF AND BOARD SIMULATING
UNLAWFUL DETAINERS DAILY BY
MISREPRESENT THEIR ABILITY FILE
THE- WHAT I'VE FOUGHT SOME TO AS
IF TO HAD WHEN IN FACT. CAN ALL
. TO ALLOW. THESE ARE THE WOULD
BE PROHIBITED ON. PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO AND PER HARASSING
THREATENING AND ABUSIVE DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BOB WAS BERMAN IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. SERRANO YOU ON
THE PHONE. IN CURRENTLY NOT ALL
RIGHT MR MERMAN SHOWS UP WILL
COME BACK TO HIM OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT. SITTINGBOURNE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE MATER
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE THREE TWO FOUR. LADIES APART
FOR SB ONE THREE TWO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE SIX LANE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT FIRST PHOTO LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY. OKAY GO AHEAD
. FINANCIAL MEMBERS PETER
LAWLESS WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY PORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINETY SIX AND
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LOCAL I. SIX HUNDRED IN
KENYA LANES OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. FINGERPRINT ON THE TOP OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. BUT ALIVE SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN MILLION IS OPEN
PLEASE. HEY MY NAME. IS
ELIZABETH AND I'M CALLING FROM
THE CITY OF OAKLAND ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. FIVE SEVEN ZERO TWO
YEAR LONG LOPING PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M A CALIPHATE BY THE
FISHERY WITH THE ORGANIZATION
THE PUBLIC BE CALIFORNIA'S.
PROBABLY AT THE ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN ELEVENS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS HOLLY. THE
MEMBER AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF INDIAN THIRTEEN FIFTY
OR- THIRTEEN TWENTY COURT RULING
. SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR.
BUT HI YES HELLO MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA WANDER FINE ON MEMBERS
INDIVISIBLE SAN FRANCISCO
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE YO OUTSIDE
CALIFORNIA FIX ON INDIVISIBLE-
OFFERING MY SUPPORT FOR THE FILM
THANK YOU. THIS IS WHY SMELL.
THE BUREAU BIGGER CONTINUE WITH
PUBLIC COMMENTS GO AHEAD- MISTER
BERMAN GO HEAD. ASSEMBLY GET.
BERMAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOUR
PHONE. THIS IS TED MARMON BY
APOLOGIES ACTING CHAIR. ALRIGHT
GO AHEAD MR BERMAN. AND THANK
YOU SENATORS FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOUR MARBLE STAMINA TODAY'S
HAD MOMENTUM CALIFORNIA LOWEST
FIGURE COLLECTIONS. WE HAVEN'T.
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT RENTAL
DESK THAT MILLIONS OF TENANTS
AND LANDLORDS NOW FACE THE
CALIFORNIA AND LEGISLATURE HAS
NEVER HAD CLEAR AND SENATE YOU
OUT BYE ENDING THE PROTECTION OF
THE ROSENTHAL ACT TO THE
COLLECTION THAT. HI THIS. THE
SAME PROTECTION AS OTHER DEBTORS
MEANWHILE THE BILL ALSO LANDLORD
WITH CLEAR RULES OF THE ROAD.
ABOUT ANY OTHER BUSINESS OF THE
CONSUMER OF MONEY TO IN THE
STATE CAN CONSULT THE RODENT IF
YOU CAN AND TO COLLECT THE DEBT. CLEAR WHY THEIR DEBT
COLLECTION FOR. WITH TODAY'S
COMMITTEE AS FEATHER MENTIONED
THIRTEEN FOUR NOW ANSWERS
QUESTION THAT WERE IN THE
BANKING COMMITTEE AND IN
OPPOSITE LETTER ONE WHAT WORDS
COLLECTING THEIR OWN DEATH ARE
NOW EXPLICITLY EXACTLY ANYTHING
ALL. HELLO WE ARE CARE ALL
CLAIMS PROCESS PLANNING YOU'RE
FREE TO PURSUE DIS CLAIMS FOR
CIVIL I. THE PROVISION FEDERAL
LAW IN COURT INTO. ARE THE LAW
GRAN THE ENGINE FIRST THOUSAND
ONE SO THEY WILL NOT CHANGE.
LANDLORDS ACTUALLY NOT REQUIRED
TO BE LICENSED UNDER THE GNU
THAT COLLECTOR LICENSING ACT. WE
RENTAL THAT DEFAULT AS RESULTING
FROM A CREDIT TRANSACTION. SO
IT'S DIRECTLY ADDRESSED THE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS IDENTIFIED BY-
THE OPPOSITION EMBRACED BY
MEMBERS OF THE BANKING COMMITTEE
. WITH ALL. DUE TO FEDERAL LAW
ALREADY MR BERMAN GO HEAD RIGHT
LEGISLATURE SHOULD PROBABLY HAVE
DONE WELL WHICH IS THANK YOU SIR
JAN TO TENTH- THANKS SO UCH FOR
BEARING WITH THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND- WELL. AND I IF
THE ERROR ALLOWS THE TO READ THE
BRIEF LIST OF SUPPORTERS RATHER
THAN IN THE MALL CALL. UP FINE
OKAY OKAY CALIFORNIANS FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING COMMUNITY
SERVICE IS. WHERE'S COMMITTEE
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. AREA THAT
LEGAL SERVICES CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MARK MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH ADVOCACY SERVICES
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER
CLAWSON- CENTRAL ELDER RAS ELDER
LAW AND ADVOCACY LEGAL AID OF MY.
THANK YOU OVER LINE FIVE HUNDRED
AND FOR YOUR LATEST ALBUM. THE
BLADE FIVE ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIMPLY
PORTLAND I'M SORRY THANK YOU
LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT I A LONG
DAY ALREADY YOU. RELATED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARK
LAST. I AM HOW HEARD AND I WITH
. LULA WELL THE PORT. THANK YOU
VERY. IN ADDITIONAL LINES THAT
THIS TIME ALREADY LET'S NOT TURN
TO THE UP. OF THOSE ARE IF YOU
WERE THE MICROPHONE. AMBER
MEDICINE FROM THE UP CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL WHICH IS TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE NOT
HARASSED WHEN THEY COLLECT ASKED
TO RATE. BUT WE ARE. THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT WILL BE
ACCEPTED TODAY. WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR. THAT WE STILL OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF THE FORM. OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR. AND DINNER
ASSIST AS AN EXCELLENT JOB OF
MAKING CLEAR THAT THIS BILL WILL
NOT CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES WE STILL
HAVE TWO REASONS POSES. FIRST OF
BY PLAINLY STATE. PURPOSES TO
GOVERN THE BANKING AND CREDIT
SYSTEM BRENT IS DISTINCT FROM
ANY OTHER DEBT THAT THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO LUMP IT WITH ANOTHER
CREDIT CARD RENT IN ADVANCE OF
THE SERVICES PROVIDED. IN OTHER
WORDS RENT. CREDIT UNLIKE
MORTGAGE THERE IS NO SECURITY
INTERESTS THAT SECURES OUR
RENTAL DEBT SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WOULD IGNORE IGNORE THIS
REALITY ANY QUITE RENT AS THE-
IT WILL BE. THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
STILL THE CONFLICT WITH EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LANDLORD TENANT LAW
FOR EXAMPLE THE ROSENTHAL ACT
WOULD PROHIBIT LANDLORDS. WE
REGARDING SOURCE OF RENTAL DEBT
ARE OFTEN FAMILY MEMBERS FOR
EXAMPLE A PARENTS BOARD ONS OR
SOMETHING ABOUT SORT THEY DON'T
HAVE. IT'S THE OTHER CONSEQUENCE
OF THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT A
LANDLORD FROM SPEAKING TO THAT
GUARANTOR PARENT IF THAT CHILD
IS PAST DUE ON THE RENT UNLESS
AND UNTIL. BUT TENS OF JUDGING.
AGAINST THAT THAT TENANTS. THIS
WOULD HARM THE GUARANTOR PARENTS
AND THE TENANTS ALIKE AND SIMPLY
DOES NOT ALIGN WITH THE PURPORT
. THE BILL. ANOTHER EXAMPLE
ROSENTHAL ACT IF A PERSON HAS
BEEN A VICTIM OF IDENTITY THEFT
DEBT COLLECTION MUST IMMEDIATELY
CEASE THIS IS A PROVISION
EXPRESSLY MEANT TO APPLY TO
TRADITIONAL CONSUMER DEBT NOT
RENTALS AT. BUT AS APPLIED TO
THE RENTAL CONTEXT ALANLAR WOULD
PREVENT IT WOULD BE PREVENTED
FROM COLLECTING RENTAL DEBT
BECAUSE OF THIS PROVISION
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NONSENSICAL
AND WAS NOT THE INTENT OF THE
ORIGINAL. PRICE OF CODE SEC.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE ISSUES AT
THE BILL CREATES WITH
CALIFORNIA'S LANDLORD TENANT LAW
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE BILL'S
ANALYSIS. I WHAT THIS BILL IS
WELL INTENTIONED IT REQUIRES FAR
MORE NUANCE THAN CURRENTLY
EXISTS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU. OTHERS
OPPOSITE. YES SIR HELLO A
MONSTER SERRANO FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU OTHERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION
SINGLE ONE ELSE PRO TO CONFIRM
THOSE ON THE TELEPHONE. TWO OF
THOSE ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. ONE THREE TWO FOUR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
A POSITION OF F. B. ONE THREE
TWO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
HERE AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE LINES IN Q. WILL GO
TO LIKE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHNSON. THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
RELATED TO OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YEAH AFTERNOON MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING OF THOSE
THANK. FIVE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
AWARENESS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS PARTNERING WITH THEIR
AND RITA SO SEATS REPRESENTING
SEVEN CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THIRTY ONE
ELEVEN OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY ONE YOUR
LIFE IS OPEN. I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF. SB. ONE THREE FOUR.
LIKE KERN SORRY THANK YOU. WE
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL LIKE BUT THIS
THE FIRST TIME OKAY THIS FREE
BACK TO COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
MACASKILL. THIS IS A GOOD BILL
THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU TOOK HE SAID
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THAT'S NOT
SUBJECT TO THE DEATH LICENSING
ACT AND ALSO THAT THE- FEDERAL
NOTICES THE PLIGHT OF. WORDS AND
THAT THE AND IT'S NOT A CREDIT
TRANSFER TRANSACTION. IT GOES
DOWN TO THE BASIC. THREE OF
POLICY THAT YOU'RE COURTEOUS
WITH PEOPLE YOU DON'T HASSLE
THEM YOU DON'T YOU DON'T- THE
INACTIVE USING WITH THEM CAN YOU
. TALK TO THE TECHNICAL CONCERNS
THAT OPPOSITION HAS ON LET THE
CONFLICT LANDLORD TENANT LAW IN
TALKING TO FAMILY MEMBERS-
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING THAT IF
YOU'RE NOT BEING ABUSIVE AND
YOU'RE NOT BEING. HARASSING THEM
AND WHICH IS SORT OF THIS SCOPE
OF UP CLOSE AND FALL THAT. I
DON'T I DON'T SEE THE TAXI HAS
WOULD BE ABLE TO BUT I WANT TO
SPEAK FOR YOU- MAYBE MAYBE MISS
GONZALEZ IF YOU COULD RESPOND TO
THAT QUESTION YES TO THE EXTENT
THAT I UNDERSTOOD IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE QUESTION IS IF THE PARENT IS
ON THE LEASE WITH THE CHILD BUT
THE CURRENT DOESN'T LIVE AT THE
APARTMENT DOES THE BILL STOP THE
LANDLORD FROM CONTACTING. THE
PAIR. DEBTOR AS WITH THE CHILD
IF THAT'S WHAT WAS INTENDED IF
THEY WERE ABUSIVE AND HARASSING
CONDUCT WHAT THE FALLEN RIGHT
BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIVE
THERE DOESN'T GIVE THEM- RIGHT
IF THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEATH BY VIRTUE OF THEM BEING ON
THE LEASE THE LAND THERE CAN
CONTACT FOR PAYMENT THEY JUST
THE LAND THERE CAN'T JUST BE
ABUSIVE TOWARDS EITHER LIVING OR
THE PARENT NOT LIVE. I'VE DONE
THAT. SURE PROCEDURAL MOVE THE
BILL ALREADY THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS SENATE WHITE HOUSE
GEARS MOVE THE BILL SYNDROS OF
DUE CARE CLOSE. WE EXPECT ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTING YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU- CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL THE SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR DO TO US SO WITH MUCH
BYE CENTER WEIGHT CAL GIVE
EMOTIONAL. AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REVERSE- TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI I'M BURGER AYE BURGESS
. SEVEN ZERO. DID. HI YES SO I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES LAYERED- LAYERED ICE STERN
STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI QUICK
HOUSEKI AYE WIENER WIENER AYE I
HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO RIGHT NOW
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALREADY
THANK YOU PUT THAT ON CALL
CENTER ALSO- YOUR NEXT BILLS S.
B. ONE THREE SIX FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I WANT
TO AGAIN THANK THE CONSULTANT-
FOR THE ANALYSIS AND THE BIKE
AND ACCEPT- FOR ACCEPTING THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND THESE ARE
DISCUSSED ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS AND INCLUDED. IN THE
MOCK UP AT THE END OF THE
ANALYSIS. UP PLACE A POLICY
CALLED EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
THAT REQUIRES VENDOR COMPANIES
THAT HAVE ONE OF AN ESTIMATED
FOUR HUNDRED SERVICE CONTRACTS
WITH YOU SEE TO PAY THEIR
COMPANIES EMPLOYEES WAGES AND
BENEFITS EQUAL. TO WHAT YOU SEE
PAYS ITS OWN SERVER WORKERS WHO
WORKED FOR YOU SEE. UC'S
RESPONSE TO POSSIBLE VENDOR
COMPANY VIOLATIONS OF THIS
POLICY HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL AND THE PAY
INFORMATION REQUIRED UNDER THE-
QUOTE THE UNIVERSITY IS NOT THE
EMPLOYER OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND DOES NOT HAVE THIS
INFORMATION. QUOTE FILE OF
IMPACT THIS WORK. FOR YOU. NOR
ARE CUT BY A CLUTCH BARGAIN. AND
SO NO LAW READ THE PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS TO TELL THESE WORKERS
THE UNIVERSITY OR ANY STATE
AGENCY HOW WAGES AND BENEFITS
BEING PAID COMPARED TO WHAT THE
UC EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
REQUIRES THERE'S NOT ACTIVE OR
LEGAL WAY FOR US TO AND FOR THE
USE POLICY. ORPATH. THERE LOOK
IS IT'S IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THE BILL NOT NAY IN. ANY
EFFORTS STRIDES PROGRESS THAT
YOU SEE IS MAKING TOWARDS- THIRD
PARTY VENDOR COMPLIANCE THE BILL
MERELY PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANY WORKER TO RESOLVE THE
SITUATION WITH THE WAS GIVEN.
SOME THE VET. FOR UNDER. AN
HONEST LIST EIGHT FOUR WHERE
THEY WERE LIKELY VIOLATION OF
USED IS IT PAY FOR IT WORK
POLICY SB THIRTY SIXTY CREE OF.
APPLY TO USE. AND ANY LABOR MAN
COME. THE BASIC PAYROLL
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO KNOW IF
A VENDOR IS ABIDING BY UC POLICY
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE VENDOR TO
SUPPLY A WRITTEN NOTICE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES. ABOUT THE RELEVANT
COMPENSATION RIGHT AND IT WOULD
ALLOW CONTRACTING. COMPANY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE ANY
DISCREPANCIES BEFORE FACING ANY
CONSEQUENCES HOWEVER REFUSAL TO
COMPLY WOULD RESUL IN EMPLOYEES
HAVING THE RIGHT TO PURSUE
RECOVERY OF LOST WEEK. FORT THIS
CALL CHEN OF A- I'M- VIOLATING
FROM DOING BUSINESS YOU SEE FOR
FIVE YEAR- THERE'S NO RIGHT TO
SUIT YOU SEE THE RIGHT TO SUE
ONLY IS ONLY AFTER THE
CONTRACTORS ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP. WE HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESSES SUPPORT THAT
IS MONICA THAT LEON FRAZIER OF
AMERICA FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY IN THIS BLIMP. CALLED TO
NOT. NINE THANK YOU MISTER.
STILL THERE ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
WELL LET'S COME BACK TO MISTER
LEON IF- IF WE IF SHE APPEARS
LATER WILL WILL TAKE HER
TESTIMONY BUT THE MEANTIME
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WHO IS IN SUPPORT SB.
ONE THREE SIX- SEE ONE OF. PHONE
AT THIS POINT IN TIME. LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. THOSE-MODERATOR IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE THREE SIX FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE THREE
SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO AT THIS TIME. STRUGGLING
NUMBERS SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MASCOT ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS AND UNITED
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OCTOBER LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN YEAR THAT IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRIS THE DALLAS LAURIE I AM THE
POLITICAL ORGANIZER FOR THE
SOUTH BAY LABOR COUNCIL AND
EXTENDED SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS SIX HUNDRED
NINETY SIX ELEMENTS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER MALLON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TENURE IT IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL BE A
GREAT THING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN AWARENESS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOONS
BROWN BOTH CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND MEMBERS ELIGIBLE.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX YEAR
OLD IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS PAT WHALEN
ELLIS WILL SNAP BECAUSE HERE ON
BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA- UNION
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS THAT
YOU ACCURATE CP IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR LETTERS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS LINDA SACRAMENTO POLICE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN DIEGO. MEDICAL PRACTITIONER
TWENTY YEARS AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF FIFTY ONE THREE SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JUAN MATA IN THE
MEDICAL CENTER. AND I'M SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LOW PROVIDE IN Q.
AND TO SIGNAL MONICA BIGELOW
INSTRUMENTALISTS ALL RIGHT I WAS
STILL YOUNG. ARE YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD.
YEAH SORRY FOR THE- THANK YOU
SENATOR- GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY
FOR THE L. M. EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBER AND TREASURER FOR ASK ME
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE IT
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SERVICE
WORKERS WE NEED. CUTTING GRASS
PICKING UP TRASH. INCLUDING
CLEANING HOSPITAL BED PANS ARE
HELPING TO MAKE YOU HAPPY ONE OF
OUR GREATEST EDUCATION AND
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS RUN IN SIX
FEET. HERE TO SPEAK FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE NO PROTECTIONS IF THEY
WERE TO SPEAK OUT IN FEAR OF
RETALIATION. THESE ARE OUR
COLLEAGUES SERVICE WORKERS WE
WORK ALONGSIDE IT YOU FEE- WORK
FOR THIRD PARTY VENDORS AND
COMPANIES DOING BUSINESS WITH
YOU SEE. IF YOU HAVE A POLICY
TITLED EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
THAT MEANS FOR WORK BEING
PERFORMED AT U. P. ALL RIGHT
BETTER. BOTH WORKERS THE SAME
PAY AND BENEFITS THAT KHLOE WHO
ARE HIRED DIRECTLY BY YOU THE
RECEIPT. AND YOU THREE HAVE MADE
STRIDES. IN IMPLEMENTING THAT.
UNDER TO BE TRUTHFUL ABOUT
ACTUAL WAGES AND BENEFITS BEING
PAID. THE BILL WILL ENSURE IF
YOU'RE A THIRD PARTY VENDOR AND
WANT TO DO BUSINESS WITH YOU
FEET. YOU MUST ADHERE TO THEIR
POLICY EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK.
IT DOES SO BY MAKING THE
APPROPRIATE INDIVIDUALS AND-
INFORMATION. AND ALLOW ANYONE
OUT OF COME. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CURE AND CORRECT WHICH THE BILL
ALLOWS HIM THE VENDOR REPUTED TO
CURE AND CORRECT AND THEY- CAN
BUY YOU FEET. WE'RE UNDERPAID WE
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
ALREADY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE THREE SIX
FOUR. THREE MAJOR FACTORS BEACON
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL ITEM.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEAR
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ISABEL FONG AND ON
BEHALF OF COFFEE DISTRICT
COUNCIL THIRTY SIX I WOULD
EXPRESS TRUMP REPORT AT. FOR
THANK. WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
LINE TO THE TIME ALREADY THANK
YOU LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION- I HAVE NO IDENTIFIED
UP PRIMARY WITH HIS OPPOSITION
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION S. B.
THREE SIX FOUR SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE
LISBURN TO THE FAULT LINES
BAADER IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
TO ONE THREE. BURKE WE- IN
THURMOND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB ONE THREE SIX FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE LIE PROVIDE FIRST
PLATE NUMBER. FIRST CONNECTICUT
PROVIDE OF SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR AND MEMBER PETER WATER
WITH A BIKE AT THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE OPPOSED SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. REVENUE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHTY- PLEASE
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE
SENATE WHITE HOUSE SKI I THINK I
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENTS. HI A
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE LAW BUT
YOU SEE SUPPOSED TO WORK FOR
WORK ON AND HE ENTERS GET THIS
OP SURE ISRAEL GOOD. THEN
EMPLOYEE. THAT THEY MAY DISCLOSE
THE AND- BUT IT'S ONLY FOR THE
PURPOSES THAT OF COMPLIANCE IT'S
NOT FOR. YOU SHERRY HORROR YOU
KNOW SELLING ALL YOUR
INFORMATION THAT THAT THERE IS
OTHER SENSITIVE PRIVACY
INFORMATION TO OUTLET REPORT.
THAT WE'RE GOING. OR DO YOU D.
MANAGEMENT GROUP OF LOOK AT THE
FOR COMPLIANCE PURPOSES- AND
THAT'S THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THIS IS ADDITIONAL THINGS OF
THAT TO IMPLORE DOESN'T FEEL.
THREATEN I GUESS WHAT THE WITH
THE SHARING OF THEIR DATA OR
INFORMATION IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE- OF THE-
THIS IS. AMENDMENTS YES T IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE
INFORMATION IS- THAT THEY WOULD-
THAT'S BEEN REQUESTED IS ALIGNED
WITH THE LABOR CODE. SO THAT
THERE'S NO ISSUE OF THE CITY-
AND THEREFORE THAT THE NOTICE
THE GOAL WAS GOES OUT TO THE
WORKERS- BE SURE. THOSE JOINT
MANAGEMENT LABOR COMMITTEE AND
WITH UC SO THE MAIN THING IS
THEY KNOW. THE STATION IS THEY
KNOW WHAT THOUGH HOURLY WAGES SO
THAT WAY THEY CAN SEE MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE GETTING THAT WHAT
DATE WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
GET ON THE POLICY THESE PA. SB
SINCE THE WILL BE CONTACT INFO.
ON ON THIS THAT THE UC AND THE
MANAGEMENT TEAM CAN LOOK AT IT
TO DOUBLE DOUBLE CHECK THAT I.
BY ANSWER. THE BILL OKAY EVERY
VENDOR NOW SHOULD KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW WE WANT YOU TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE AND YOU GOT A CHANCE
TO CARE SO THAT'S RIGHT. BILL
TWO ONE FIVE THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU- OTHERS
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT SIR WHAT
COUNTS THE MOST THE BILL SENATE
ALSO CARE CLOSE THANK YOU ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS FISHING THANK
YOU SHE CAN ALSO BE. THIS IS
BILL THIRTEEN FOUR BY SENATOR DO
SO WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KEEP THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION
NUMBER FIVE. I BUDGET- CABALLERO
. RUSSELL DATA SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG JONES
LAYERED- LAYERED ICE STERN STERN
AYE WIECKOWSKI BY CAL SKI I
WINNER WINNER AYE YOU HAVE SEVEN
TO ONE SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALREADY WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL. OKAY NEXT SUMMER GONZALEZ
. S. B. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BUT
BEFORE YOU BEGIN THANK YOU
SENATORS ALSO FOR YOUR- OF. YOUR
FLEXIBILITY WITH RESPECT TO S.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THERE'S
A MOCK UP THIRTY THINK IS BEING
PASSED OUT TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND TO SUMMARIZE THE- AMENDMENT.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT- REQUIRES THE
BOARD OF THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM OF THE STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM TO
LIQUIDATE INVESTMENTS IN FOSSIL
FUEL COMPANY HONOR BEFORE JULY
ONE TWENTY THIRTY INSTEAD OF
JULY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
THAT ACCURATELY STATED SEVERAL
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU CAN HEAR ME
OKAY. THAT IS CORRECT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENTS-
THAT  WOULD GLADLY ACCEPT AGAIN
TO PUSH THE REQUIRED DATE FOR
DIVESTMENT TO THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY WHICH WILL PROVIDE
PENSION BOARD TO THE SEVEN YEAR
CUSHION. TO MEET THE BILL'S
DIVESTMENT REQUIREMENTS MEMBERS
AGAIN I'M PRESENTING SP ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WILL WHICH WILL
PERHAPS THE CALIFORNIA. PLEASE
SYSTEM AND THE CAP. FROM
INVESTING IN THE TWO HUNDRED
LARGEST FOSSIL FUEL COMPANIES
KNOWN AS THE CARBON UNDERGROUND
TWO HUNDRED- AND REQUIRE THAT
THE DATE DIVEST ANY CURRENT
INVESTMENTS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY AS STATED AND REQUIRE
ANNUAL REPORTING ON THEIR
PROGRESS IN MEETING THAT TARGET.
THIS MEASURE IS THE RESULT OF
YEARS OF ADVOCACY BY TEACHERS
FACULTY MEMBERS AND IN IS WHO
DEMANDED THAT THE CALPERS THURS
CAN IT CONTINUE INVESTING OVER
TEN BILLION DOLLARS OF THEIR
HARD EARNED PENSIONS IN THE VERY
INDUSTRY THAT IS TRUE.
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE THIRTY YEARS WE
WILL SEE THE WORST IMPACTS ON
CLIMATE CHANGE IF IMMEDIATE CUTS
IN EMISSIONS IN ALL SECTORS ARE
NOT MADE AS A CONSTITUENCIES
RISING SEA LEVELS EXTREME HEAT
ETCETERA AND EVEN OUR BRAVE
FIREFIGHTERS RISKING THEIR LIVES
BATTLE YOU'RE RIGHT STROPHIC
FOR. BY ENTRY SIX WHY. DURING
CLASS. COME BACK CONTINUES TO A
CA POLICY OF FIGHTING CHANGE
WILL OF INVESTING IN ITS PRIMARY
DRIVER AS A SCOPE OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S OVERSIGHT IS
PRIMARILY THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF REQUIRING DIVESTMENT I REFER
MEMBERS TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS CORRECT THE STATE'S
CALIFORNIA. ALLOW JUSTLY TO
PROVIDE CERTAIN ESTIMATES
EVERHART RETIRED. IN THE CONTENT
WAS LANGUAGE EMPOWERS BOTH TO
REFRAIN FROM THE BILL SHOULD
THEY DETERMINE IN GOOD FAITH
THAT IT WOULD IN THEIR FIDUCIARY
DUTIES UNDER THE CONSTITUTION SB
SEVENTY THREE ALL SEASON THAT
THE WORLDWIDE MEANT MOVE THAT
HAS. TRILLION DOLLAR. BEST MAKE
. THAT SYSTEM AND THE UC'S HAVE
ALSO COMPETENTLY AND PRO
ACTIVELY COMMITTED MOVING FOSSIL
FUEL INVESTMENTS FROM THEIR
PORTFOLIOS IN FACT UC'S SHIFTING
ONE THE PLAYERS OF INVESTMENTS
INTO CLEANNEW ENERGY PROJECTS.
I'M OPPONENTS OF THIS MEASURE
ARE THE PENSION FUNDS WILL FACE
A NEGATIVE FINANCIAL IMPACT IF
WE DIVEST TO THE CONTRARY
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT.
ACTUALLY IMPROVES NOT WEAKENS
INVESTMENT RETURNS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR
CHARLES TOMBS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND THOMPSON DO DIRECTOR OF
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS FOR THE
INSTITUTE FOR ENERGY ECONOMICS
AND FINANCIAL ANALYSIS THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE- GO AHEAD SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR- BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR CHARLES
TUNES I'M PROFESSOR OF AFRICANA
STUDIES AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FACULTY INCLUDING TENURE LINE
FACULTY. BRING BACK COULD BE I'M
SLOW FACULTY AND COACHES FROM
ALL TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM I AM SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE CFA IS A PROPER CO
SPONSOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AS WE ARE ALL AWARE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN AND
CONTINUES TO SEE THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE SEVERE
DROUGHT DEVASTATING WILDFIRES A
MORE SEVERE WEATHER PATTERNS.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE SEE MORE
FEROCIOUS HURRICANES AND
HISTORIC FLOODING DUE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE THE SEVERE ACOLYTE OKAY
THIS CALL THE RATE. OF OUR USE
UP PRODUCTION FOSSIL FUELS BUT
NOT ONLY IS CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ECOLOGICAL YOU IT IS. BOB IN IN
MEN ALL. SO AND SO JUSTICE
DESPITE. IMPACTING INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES DUE
TO HISTORICAL OPPRESSION IN
EQUITY UP POWER AND LACK OF
ACCESS TO RESOURCES FOR
PREVENTION AND RELIEF ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A GREAT DEAL
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE THERE
IS STILL MUCH MORE TO DO. YOUR
CONTRADICTION IT ON CLIMATE
CHANGE IS THAT OUR PUBLIC
PENSION SYSTEMS COMBINED HAVE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY
INVESTED IN FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WELL SIGNIFICANTLY
FURTHER ARE WERE TWENTY CLEANER
AND MORE LIVEABLE FUTURE. FOR US
YOUR CHILDREN. FOR OUR PROGRAM
THE BILL HAS SUPPORT FOR ME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR TOMBS
RITCHETT SAID AGAIN AND I SAID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OKAY WELL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE-
YES WHEN THEY ARE IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- I BELIEVE
ALSO THE PHONE IS TOP SEVEN ZERO
IS THAT RIGHT YEAH AMY YES I CAN
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR- SENT ALL OF THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS FOR THE
INSTITUTE FOR ENERGY ECONOMICS
AND FINANCIAL ANALYSIS- THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVENTY THREE.
5% GONZALEZ THE BILL REQUIRES
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS TO DIVEST
FROM FOSSIL FUEL COMPANIES I
SERVE SENIOR MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS IN NEW YORK CITY IN
NEW YORK STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE SEVENTEEN YEARS EACH
OFFICE PLAYS A PIVOTAL ROLE
MANAGING THE RESPECTIVE PENSION
SYSTEMS. TEN YEAR POSITION
PLEASE- TO DIVEST FUNDS RELATED
TO SOUTH AFRICA TOBACCO. OUR IT
IS RAIL GUNS AND REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS BY FAR THE CASE FOR THE
INVESTMENT OF FOSSIL FUELS IS
THE MOST FINANCIALLY COMPELLING
. THE FOSSIL FUEL SECTOR CLAIM
228% OF THE STANDARD AND POOR'S
FIVE HUNDRED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TODAY IT IS JUST OVER FOUR
PERCENT. RETURNS OVER THE PAST
DECADE HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY
WEAK AND MSCI'S FOSSIL FREE
INDEXES OUTPACED INDEXES THAT
CONTAIN FOSSIL FUELS. DESPITE
RECENT HIGHER OIL PRICES AND A
SPIKE IN VALUES LONG TERM
OUTLOOK IS NOT POSITIVE EVEN OIL
AND GAS COMPANIES ARE USING
CURRENT CASTER. HEY DAVID AND
REDUCE DEBTS AS OF MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY SIX SOME. ELEVEN HUNDRED.
ASPEN FUNDS OF DIFFERING SIZES
AND RARE VARYING MISSIONS HAVE
DIVESTED IN SOME FORM. EIGHT
BLACK ROCK WHICH IS THE- WAS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
HOUSE- AND THEY'RE NOT AN
ADVOCATE OF- OF FOSSIL FUELS- OF
DIVESTMENT RATHER I'M SORRY-
THIS IS WAS ASKED BY THE CITY OF
NEW YORK IF THEY WOULD. I'M
UNDERTAKEN DEFENSEMAN STUDY AND
THEY FOUND THAT THE CITY OF NEW
YORK COULD DIVEST AND STILL MEET
ITS FINANCIAL TARGETS AND THAT
THOSE- FUNDS THAT HAVE DIVESTED
IN THE PAST- HAVE DONE EITHER
POSITIVE OR NEUTRAL IN TERMS OF
RETURN- IN THE END. THANK YOU
MISTER SENCILLA. ATTACHES AND
SORRY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF YOU'D WRAP UP. YEAH IN
THE END IT'S A DEFENSIVE
STRATEGY TO PROTECT THE FUND
AGAINST- CLIMATE CHANGE AND I OR
JUST SUPPORT AND THANKS FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT- OTHERS IN THE CHAMBER
EXCUSE ME AT THE CHAMBER IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
APPROACH MIKE FROM GIVE US YOUR-
NAME YOUR FILIATION YOUR
POSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S MEGAN O'DONNELL A FACULTY
MEMBER AT CAL STATE MONTEREY BAY
REPRESENTING CFA AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL IT IS CRITICAL THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN WE'RE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT THE SACRAMENTO
CAMPUS I HEARD DR VOTE THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY AT EIGHT
THAT BETTER THAT WE LET
PROFESSOR OF EDUCATION AT
SACRAMENTO STATE ALSO EVP OF
NORTHERN CHAPTER PRESENTS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION RICHER AYE VOTE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. YES THEY'RE A
FACULTY MEMBER AT FRESNO STATE
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNICATION AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES- AND I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING CFA. THANK YOU.
MORE MILLER CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE FULLERTON
CFA AVP LECTURES ON SOUTH ALSO
TRAITOR OF THE CAP WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SHERINIAN
THESE SOCIOLOGISTS CSU SAN
MARCOS A. V. P. FOR RACIAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE FOR CFA NEW
GRANDMOTHER URGE YOUR YES VOTE
FOR MY GRANDKIDS THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A BANG BANG
I'M A LIBRARIAN FROM FRESNO
STATE AND CFA TREASURE I URGE
YOU AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI I'M CHRIS **** AND
I TEACH IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIOLOGY IN INTERDISCIPLINARY
SOCIAL SCIENCES AT SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY I AM ALSO THE
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT FOR SEE
A FACE COUNCIL FOR RACIAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE NORTH AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DR GREGORY BROWN. I'M A SOCIAL
FRESNO KERN. CAL STATE
FULLERTON. AND ALSO THE SOCIAL
VICE PRESIDENT SOUTH. CALIFORNIA
POPPIES SOLICITATION I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE. HI WHEN
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CAN I GALLAGHER FOR
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MEGHAN
SHUMWAY RETIRED NURSE AND
PROFOUND PERSPECTIVE- IN STRONG
SUPPORT FROM SACRAMENTO THREE
FIFTY THANK YOU. LYNETTE LEHRER
REPRESENTING COOL DAVIS
PHILOSOPHY CALIFORNIA YELLOW
INTERFAITH ALLIANCE FOR CLIMATE
JUSTICE AND A RETIRED TEACHER
URGING YOU PLEASE VOTE FOR S. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RUSSELL HENLEY OF SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO MY FORMER BOSS SENATOR
LAYERED AND- I'M A RETIREE FROM
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF STATE
SERVICE MY CALPERS PENSION AS A
PRIMARY AND FROM A HOLD HOLD ARE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL Q.
THANK YOU. YEAH I'M LUKE WILSON
FROM SACRAMENTO IN A CALPERS-
PENSIONER AND ALSO AND- HEY
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT
PENSION- AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. KELSEY KREMER I'M A
CALPERS MEMBER ALSO SPEAKING FOR
JOLIE THAT ACCESS TO COULD NOT
BE HERE SHE'S A CAL STIRS MEMBER
WERE THREE- AND WE STRUCK.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AWESOME COOL CINEMA
BELOW ON BEHALF OF THESE KIND OF
STRUCK LOS ANGELES ALTHOUGH WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE AN UGENT VOICE YES
THANK YOU. I'M CJ CAP AND WITH
FOSSIL FREE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS MERRIAM I'D I
WAS ALSO FOR CALIFORNIA AND I
URGE YOUR VOTE YES ON SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. SERVICE
FEES CALPERS RETIREE AND FASA
FOR CALIFORNIA MEMBER PLEASE
VOTE YES ON ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME'S ARTICLE OIL SABA I- WITH
SACRAMENTO CLIMATE COALITION
EIGHT AND I STRONGLY. SUPPORT S.
B. ONE ONE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON RON
RAPP LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. R. THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WAS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE. THEONE ONE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE CURRENTLY HAVE SIXTY
SIX FLAGS IN Q. ALL RIGHTY YOUR
FIRST LINE. PURCELL COMES FROM
LINE SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I MEMBERS HE MOCKED AT
THE HEADACHES THE ATHLETE AND IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU IT'S
JUST. SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING DINNER
BONHOMIE HAPPENS CARE CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND PEOPLE ARE.
PLEASE LISTEN FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
FIVE ZERO FORTY ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE'S LEAD-
ISSUE THOUGH COLIN. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AGO GOOD EVENING MEMBERS THE
COURT FEDERAL ANTI POVERTY
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CALLING AND FONG PART OF THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR LANES
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN ZERO SIX RELATED OVER
THERE THANKS FOR. SANTIAGO
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTALIST AND
SUSPECT. FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT IS
DR J. CONSTITUENT. GONZALEZ AND-
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
. NINE SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO EIGHT- HELLO MY
NAME IS SANDY AND I'M CALLING
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT AT ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TRANSIT
YES AND I AM A CALPERS MEMBERS
BUT THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
HISTORIC PRESERVATION. STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
THANK YOU. BY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS MY NAME IS TODD
SNYDER AND I'M CALLING FOR
INDIVISIBLE SAN FRANCISCO URGE
YOUR FIVE VOTE ON SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. EMPTINESS HELLO THE NEW.
YES I FIND FIVE OH THREE WHICH
WILL OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE MY
NAME IS TERRY BRADY AND MOORPARK
AND I AM NOT A HOUSE CHURCH
MEMBER AND I SUPPORT. SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU FOR THAT YET
THANK YOU HE- NINE SEVEN EIGHTY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE WEARABILITY AND I'M
CALLING FROM OAKLAND AND
REPRESENTING EXTENSION THE
VALIANT BAY AREA HAS STRONGLY
FOR ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK
YOU. SO. ONE SIX SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
BILL TO MAKE IT BACK THOUGH
CALLING IN FROM THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA CURRENTLY SITTING IN A ROOM
WITH A BUNCH OF OUR YOUTH
ACTIVISTS STRONGLY STRONGLY
SUPPORTING. ONE SEVEN THREE. I
WONDER WHAT OKAY I HAVE ONE NINE
EIGHT ZERO FIVE B. LINE IS OPEN
PEOPLE AT. HI THIS IS PETER
KERR. NUMBER EIGHTY PARENT- IN
DAVIS CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE SEVEN
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE HUNDRED
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND
THREE FIFTY CONTRA COSTA ACTION
STRONGLY SUPPORTING ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DR
LEONARD SKLAR I'M A CALPERS
PENSIONERS AND RETIRED PROFESSOR
OF EARTH AND CLIMATE SCIENCES AT
SAN FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY
AND FATHER OF A YOUNG CALIFORNIA
. YEAH HE. I AM FORTY SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD CURRENT NUMBER THIS IS
CHRISTINE CAMPBELL AMERICA FROM
WOODLAND CALIFORNIA. A LONG TIME
MEMBER OF FORFAR CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. FINE
SEVEN FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PEOPLE HAD. HELLO MY NUMBER
CALPERS MEMBER AS WELL AS A
MEMBER OF THE FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS FIFTY LOCAL TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN. THANK. NINE SEVEN NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
THE O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR TO STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA WITH THE PRETTY HEARING
GUARDRAILTHE AUTHOR ADDED TO
THE BILL WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS THAT YOU FOR BRINGING. YOU. NINE SIX EIGHTY THREE PLANETS
ORBIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
SURE AND I AM A CALPERS MEMBERS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE AND I
REQUEST YOUR IBOOK THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN ZERO THREE
A LINE IS OPEN PEOPLE HAD. THIS
IS HEIDI HARMAN FIRST MEMBERS
FORMER SLOPES MAYOR WHO DIVESTED
MY CITY AND MOTHER OF TWO
FIGHTING FOR A LITTLE POLITICAL
FUTURE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NINE SIX SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE HEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RUTH AND
WHIPPED IN TOUSAND OAKS I'M
CALLING AS A WILL BE WILD FIRE
IN FACT YOU EAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CONNECT OAK HELLO AND I URGE YOU
TO REMEMBER ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE. AS YOU VOTE YES ON SB ONE
ONE THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIND FIFTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ALWAYS FORGET
THE WE WILL INDIVISIBLE BOTH
FEDERAL AND CALIFORNIA
INDIVISIBLE WITH STRONG HE KNOWS
STRONG FAVOR OFF AND BE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. FIND
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BETH FORTY I AM A MEMBER OF THE
THIRD ACT ORGANIZATION AND LYFT
STRONGLY BEFORE BELFAST THE
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE LINED SIX
FORTY NINE YOU LINES OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIVE SIX FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND. FIND SEVEN THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HERE IS WILL PREPARE AND
WITH THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO I'M
A FIRST RETIREE AND ON BEHALF OF
MY GRANDCHILDREN I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE THANK. YOU. WELL TO ALIGN.
SEVEN FORTY FIFTY EYELINERS OPEN
PEOPLE HAD. HI MY NAME I HELLO
I'M WITH YOU CLIMATE STRIKE LOS
ANGELES AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT%
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK
YOU. NINE SEVEN ZERO ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS GAIL AND I'M CALLING IN
FROM SAN JOSE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. BOTH THE LINE. SEVEN
FIFTEEN THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN ZERO FIVE
UNITED OPEN. MONOCLE FOR WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. FIND SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE ALIGN ITSELF PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GLOBAL HELLO. IS
PROFESSOR TEACHING WE CALLED IS
. PAUL FAW PAUL SHOULD STAND DO
YOU ARE YOU SHOULD BE COLLEGE
DISTRICT. ONE THOUSAND THREE.
FATHER CONTROL INTO HEALTHY
CHANGE SURE SURE. THANK YOU FOR
LAST ELEVEN SEVEN THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE'LL GO TO LINE. SEVEN EIGHTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
JANET NINE ELEVEN PARKS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I'M WITH
INDIVISIBLE YOU'LL AND WE- AS
WELL AS I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OQOQO LINE OF. SIX
EIGHTY TWO THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PAMELA OR KILL ACCOUNTS OF
THE FISHERY AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE UNITED EDUCATORS OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE AT
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND. SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL BE GOING
NOW TO LINE SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LYNN KELLY
AND I'M FROM SOUTH PASADENA
MEMBER OF CAL STIRS A PROUD
MEMBER OF EVEN PROUDER WHEN YOU
PASS SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO LINE EIGHT ZERO SIX TWO EYES
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
DAN JACOBSON WITH BERMAN
CALIFORNIA- STRONG SUPPORTER
URGING A YES VOTE ON SPL UP IN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. WHAT TO
LINE SEVEN TWENTY FIVE A LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BOB
GOOD GOVERNMENT HEALTHY FOR THE
FISHERY AND I LOOKED BY HOME TO
THE PRIVATE CALL FIVE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. FIVE WITH
THE ORGANIZATION FOR FREE
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR IPHONE FOUR S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK. WE'LL GO TO
LINE. SEVEN SIX ZERO THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
DEBORAH SYLVIA CAL THIRDS
BENEFICIARY AFTER THIRTY YEARS
OF TEACHING IN THE CONTRA COSTA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND A
MEMBER OF FACULTY CALIFORNIA IS
STRONG SUPPORT AT THE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU. TAKE A
LOOK BLIND SEVEN FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BANKRUPTED BY MISTER
MEMBER AND RETIRED CHEMISTRY
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. AT THE BOTTOM LINE
SIX NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS REBECCA ELLIOTT WITH
INDIVISIBLE SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA.
STRONG WE ARE IN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THAT THE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR YES VOTE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. WHEN I
GO TO LINE SEVEN NINETY TWO THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS LYNN DAVIDSON BURKE I
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF-SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
EXADATA LINE SEVEN EIGHTY ONE
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. BUT NOT ANYMORE I WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE GREEN LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU. BUT IT'S GOING
TO LINE FIVE EIGHTY NINE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS EUGENE LOW I'M WITH THE
CREATION CARE AT ST MARY'S
CHURCH PACIFIC GROVE AND THE
WITH OR OF THE CASTERS MEMBER
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WHEN I GO TO
LINE. SEVEN FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A LOT OF
GOLF BURKE IN A NUMBER OF
EXTINCTION REBELLION BAY AREA AS
WELL AS THE CONCERNED YOUNG
PERSON LIVING IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY URGE A
YESVOTE ON SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHEN I GO TO LINE SEVEN FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS KAY
MCCARTY CALPERS NUMBER AND
DIFFERENT BENEFIT COUNTY.
SEVENTY THREE. WITH MY STAFF
WITH. THE NEXT TO LINE FIFTY
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM DOCTOR
CAROL LEAD REPRESENTING THE
DEMOCRATS ABROAD MORE AND WALNUT
CREEK WE ARE INSTALLING PORT AT
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU. PINE CREEK EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND MANY THOUSANDS LAST YEAR AND
THE CHARACTERS NUMBER WITH THE
SAN LORENZO VALLEY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. YEAH THANK YOU. FINE
SEVEN NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
ACCOUNTS STIRS NUMBER. AND I'M
WITH SPONSORED FREE CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. FIND
SEVEN NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARY
WILLIAMS FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY CHAPTER OF PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. NINE
SIX SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
DR LEASES FOR ROCCO CALPERS
PENSIONERS THE GRANDMOTHER AND A
PROUD CFA MEMBERS STRONGLY
URGING SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THOMAS I AM A
MEMBER OF A RAPID RESPONSE
VOLUNTEERS AND I RETIRED COUNTY
EMPLOYEE I STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT I SHOULD. YOU'RE
RIGHT I THINK YOU HAVE A FINE
LINE NUMBER SEVEN FORTY THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'D
BEEN UP TO WAR KILEY I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OVER BOTH THE ACTUAL
FINANCIAL AND ALSO MY MOTHER
VIRGINIA WERE HIGH WITH THE HELP
AND SCULPTORS RETIREE WE ARE ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF
YOU. PINE SIX. FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BALTAR'S SACRAMENTO DSA LABOR
COMMITTEE SELTERS MEMBER CALPERS
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JONES
WITH THREE FIFTEEN MINUTE BERMAN
AND THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION
AND ALSO A HEALTH SERVICE
RETIREE. AND I AM IN SUPPORT
THOUGH I WOULD PREFER THAT THE
DATE THE KEPT THE TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. OKAY I LIKED
THE LINE EIGHT HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS RYAN MAY I AM WITH
CHANGE BEGINS WITH ME AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NEXT. BRIAN SEVEN FORTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH THANK YOU KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KATHY DURHAM AND I'M CALLING
FROM MONTEREY COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THERE WILL BE NO RETIREES
UNATTACHED. THANK YOU NEXT. NINE
FIVE FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ETHAN
CARTER AND I AM A CULTURE IF YOU
DO GET THE FREE FOR DAVID TO SEE
IF YOU QUALIFY I'M ALSO
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE MEMBER
POLITICAL NAY NUMBER AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR SIERRA CLUB
ENCOUNTER. ELEVEN THE THREE.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE DOCTOR
ALEXA FORSTER I'M A CHARACTERS
NUMBER AND A PARENT NEEDS TO
KNOW THE COUNTY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU MODERATE CAN YOU
PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE STILL WAITING IN LINE
TO TESTIFY. WE HAVE. WELL OVER
TEN THAT ARE GOING NEXT. BUT OUR
NEXT QUESTION COMMENTED LINE SIX
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS FELIX AND I'M CALLING IN
FROM A PEAK IN CANADA WHITE
HOUSE DISTRICT TO SAY THAT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK. X. EIGHT
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
YOU CAN MEMBERS VINCE WHAT
MOTHER WITH THE CLIMATE CENTRE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. LINE EIGHT
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CYNTHIA SALAD ON A CALPERS
MEMBER AND ALSO WITH.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
AND CAN BE A PROBLEM. MY SUPPORT
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE ENDED I
FOUND MEMBERS CALPERS YES. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. BACK
TO BE LINE EIGHT FIFTEEN THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS SOPHIA BARBARA
ON THE MOTHER'S FROM TURKEY AND
I'M ALSO WAS FORCED TO FLEE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY THIS
IS SANDY EMERSON I'M A RETIREE
AND MEMBER OF FOSSIL STREET
CALIFORNIA CALLING IS STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE. FINE. EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ESTELLA I'M A MEMBER OF FOSSIL
FREE CALIFORNIA CALLING FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHT THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WINE EIGHT
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
PARK GOT THREE I AM AT FIFTY
THREE TEACHER AND CAL STIRS
MEMBER FROM SONOMA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA WHERE MY STUDENTS
HAVE EXPERIENCED SIX TRAUMATIC
HI MAKE. PEACE BOB HOW MANY
UNION TEACHERS ASSOCIATION VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY UNANIMOUSLY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THAT'S PLACE LINE SIX EIGHTY
EIGHT NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SHE LOOKS
BORN I'M A RISK- CALPERS
BENEFICIARY AND A RETIRED MEMBER
OF CFA AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL. EXCLUSIVE WINE EIGHT TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TRINA
MYERS STOPPED COUNT AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE EARTH
GUARDIANS WITH YOU IF THE YOUTH
ORGANIZATION WITH YOUTH CHANGE
AS YOUNG AS TEN TO TWENTY FIVE.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR NOT OBTAINING THE VOTING
STRONG THANK YOU. FINE EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
JENNIFER TANNER ON BEHALF OF ALL
AGE GROUPS OF THE DOUBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO-
INDIVISIBLE ORCHARD CITY NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET ON AND I'M
SAYING IT DEPENDS WELL THANK YOU
. FINE TEXAS SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU. MY APOLOGIES.
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. ALL RIGHT
HELLO THANK YOU MA'AM WE GO HERE
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO HEAD STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION
POSITION. OKAY HE GOT OUT OF THE
QUEUE- ACCORDED LINE EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS. I AM AWARE INDIVIDUAL YELLED
OUT IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AS PEOPLE IN
SEVENTY THREE AS FOR THE
RECOMMENDED CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN SEVEN
TWO THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CAPTAIN RONAN I'M A
CALPERS RETIREE WITH THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL GAS A MEMBER OF THE
INTELLIGENCE CALL FOR ACTION.
AND PLUS WOULD BE CALIFORNIA AND
I VOTE I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. LINE. EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PEOPLE HAD. JACKPOT I HAVE A
CALPERS PENSION AND I AM THE
LEGISLATION POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THREE FIFTY FALCON VALLEY WHICH
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
IT'S LESLIE PURCELL CALLING FROM
VENTURE AND STRONG SUPPORT
PLEASE DO THIS FOR OUR PLANET.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOW WITH THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO A CALPERS
RETIREE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS STEVEN MARKS ON MY
CALPERS RETIREE- RETIRED AS A
PROFESSOR FROM CAL POLY
UNIVERSITY I STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. THANK IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BEING
WITHHELD AND THAT CALPERS
RETIREE AND POSSIBLY CALIFORNIA
MEMBER. GREETS YOU TO SUPPORT S.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE CONCORD
. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANYTHING CREATIVELY WITH
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT CALLING IN
SUPPORT FOR AT ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHT
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATHY CAN RECLINE AND CALLING
FROM ARCADIA CALIFORNIA I'M A
MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY HUMBOLDT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GO AHEAD YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA LONGER ON.
CALL THE CALLING AND- UNDER- I
AM A CALPERS. CONTRIBUTING
MEMBER I A MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY
.ORG SACRAMENTO. CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INDIVISIBLE CONTENT FAILS
SACRAMENTO YES HELLO AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRONG
INDIVISIBLE OUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF A LATIN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU.
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
GETTING ME IN THE QUEUE THIS IS
STEPHANIE BROWN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND ORCHARD
CITY INDIVISIBLE ONE OF THE
LARGEST INDIVISIBLE CHAPTERS IN
THE NATION AND STRONG. HELLO
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LAURIE WILSON I'M A
RETIRED CALPERS BENEFICIARIES
pFLOTATION THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING UP THE BILL AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK HI
MY NAME LEVEL I'M WHERE'S ORDERS
FOR JUSTICE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. I. LENS AND THE
GREEN. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANITA MENDOZA I AM ALWAYS THE
ORGANIZATION WORSE FOR JUSTICE
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AND BE
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
FINE EIGHT THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BRYAN PEREZ I'M MORE
WATER FOR JUSTICE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. NINE EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK HELLO MAN I'M A
THIRD GENERATION CALIFORNIA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY FOURTEEN
GREAT NIECES AND NEPHEWS CLIMATE
OF BENEFICIARY OF ITS HEALTHCARE
TENSION IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF SEVEN GENERATIONS. FOR
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. NINE EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND HELEN WROTE
. RETIREE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHT SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YEAH YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE- HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURA FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA MCALISTER'S MEMBER
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF-
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU. FINE EIGHT SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE FUNDED BY MY NAME IS
CAROLYN ARE MUCH HELP FOR HEALTH
CARE IF MEMBER APPARENT AND IT
I'M A TEACHER AND I FELL INTO
PORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE AND
HI I'M WELL I AM THE PERSON HE
SPOKE SHOT. STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR. FIND
EIGHT ELEVEN EIGHT ONE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MCALESTER'S NUMBER AND A MEMBER
OF THE OAKLAND EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KEVIN J. PATEL
AND I'M A STUDENT AT LOYOLA
MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY AND ALSO A
U. CON ACTIVISTS CALLING IN FROM
LOS ANGELES. STRONG SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN THIRTY. THANK YOU. FOR
ANYONE ELSE THAT IS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. NINE EIGHT SEVEN TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATARINA I
WORK WITH YOU RECIPROCAL FROM
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD I'M CALLING
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AT. ELEVEN THIRTY THREE.
FIND SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER FIVE
ZERO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE ZERO FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS LAURA ROSENBERGER HAIDAR
PLEASE VOTE YES SIR SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE A WORD OVER TWENTY
DISEASES LINKED TO CLIMATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM. ONE MOMENT
HERE.
HELLO IF YOU H. OPULENT. I NEVER
ROSENBERGER HAIDAR. THE LOWER
RIVER HI PLEASE VOTE YES SB ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. L.
ONE MOMENT HERE AS WE WAIT FOR
THE OTHERS Q. YOU ARE HERE. AND
LAURIE ME- YOU ON THE LINE YOU
ME- DROP.
NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ELEVEN OVER ROSENBERGER HEIGHT
AND- I VOTED FOR SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU- HELLO ARE
YOU CAN- I DROPPED OFF THE
QUEUE- PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN SORRY TO
GET OUT OF THE QUESTION QUEUE.
OVER TWENTY USE THE LINK TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. YEAH LINE EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY OUR I'M A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS LOCAL
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE IN SAN DIEGO
AND ALSO THE GFP LABOR AND
CLIMATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
TWO CHARACTERS AND BUYING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT. THREE EIGHT
TWELVE EIGHT ONE TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
HERE AND PROGRAMS I'M A
CHARACTER RETIREE AND A NUMBER
OF POSSIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA. ALSO
A LIFELONG THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND UNION
REPRESENTATIVE RETIRED FROM THE
UPMANSHIP EDUCATION. SOLUTION
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT- AND
VOTE YEAH FOR SB ELEVEN. THREE
FORTY. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NINE EIGHT FIFTY SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I. EIGHT
SIX SIX. GO AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIVE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLINDED
BY FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU COULD WALK. NINE
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH IS.
YEAH STONE. HI OKAY I EVEN MORE
REYES HOME WHO WILL GO TO LINE.
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BILL BLASBERG TEACHER
ALSO VP CALIFORNIA MEMBER
ANTHONY CAL STURGE RECIPIENTS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
HEARD YOUR SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. BY SEVEN NINE
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVENTY
NINE. THE LIONS SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR LINE OF
PEOPLE HAD.
NINE EIGHT SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT A LINE. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT ZERO THE LIGHT POLE AND
FEASIBLE I HAD. THE BILL CALLS
FOR I'M RETIRED TEACHER. HEALTH
SHOULD BE A I CAN ALWAYS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. I AM. EIGHT SEVEN NINE. BUT
HAD. SEVEN NINE EIGHT NINE. HEY. OKAY OUR LINE SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CALL ME WHEN I'M WITH
THE CLIMATE JUSTICE GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE ZERO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINER BIBLE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEP YOU QUITE A FEW
PEOPLE NOT REMEMBERING THEIR
LINE NUMBERS. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHT NINE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DIANA
WINE AND ON THE CHAIR OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
CHAPTER IN CALLING IN SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHT EIGHTY THREE. GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY EVERYBODY PAYING
DIFFERENT BILL- BILLS- MINUS
FOUR AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
ALL RIGHT MA'AM THANK YOU YOU'RE
IN THE WRONG HOUSE. HOW DO I.
WITHOUT A CONFLICT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHT NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS THE NINTH THEY ALL INTERACT.
WITH YOU FIRST MCCLAIN NINE
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU. AND
THE LAST LINE IN THE QUESTION
QUEUE AT THE MOMENT IS TO LINE
EIGHT NINETY FOUR HELLO WE'VE
HAD. MY NAME IS TWELVE YEAR FOUR
SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE AND URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION- JOSELYN MARTINEZ
WEIGHED IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE.
PLEASE ANNOUNCE YOURSELF. SURE
I'M HERE GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THREE FOR MARTINEZ WAITED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN OPPOSITION
TO US ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THE
BOARD'S POLICY IS COMPOSED WHAT
IF IT INFRINGES ON ITS FIDUCIARY
DUTY AND INVESTMENT AUTHORITY IN
ORDER TO SECURE THE FINANCIAL
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIANS EDUCATOR
AND THAT'S THE TRUST FUNDS FOR
THE EXCLUSIVE BENEFIT OF THE-
30% OF. URGENCY REGARDING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND IS FOCUSED ON
UNDERSTANDING AND RESPONDING TO
THE RISK IT PRESENTS. BOTH TO
THE CHARACTERS PORTFOLIO AND
STABLE ECONOMIC GROWTH. IN ORDER
TO MINIMIZE RISK TO THE
PORTFOLIO WE ARE NOT WAITING WE
ARE PROACTIVELY TAKING STEPS NOW
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM OUR
PORTFOLIO. AT FONG. ADDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOW CARB
SOLUTION WHERE PARTY IN SOLVE
FOR THE LACK OF ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE CARBON EMISSIONS
DATA IN DETERMINING APPROPRIATE
CARBON RELATED METRICS AND
INTERMIN MISSION REDUCTION GOALS
THAT ALIGN WITH BOTH THE A
DUTIES AND ACCEPTED CLIMATE
SCIENCE COULD BE ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE MOVED CALPERS AWAY FROM
THOSE FRONTLINE EFFORTS BY
CHANGING THE DIVESTMENT WHICH
AGAIN CALPERS EXPOSURE TO THE
ECONOMY AND UNDERMINES EFFORTS
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
WORLD. YOU SUCCEED WITH PRIMUS
TO SIMPLY BE THAT THE AWAY. I
KNOW FIRST REPORT FOR BETTER OR
WORSE WITH DIVEST OF CERTAIN
FACTS- DO KNOW IS A DIVESTMENT
REDUCES DIVERSIFICATION OF
ASSETS WHICH ADDRESS TO THE
PORTFOLIO THE PAST EXPERIENCE
HAS SHOWN DIVESTMENT IS NOT
EFFECTIVE IN CAN RESULT IN LONG
TERM LOSSES TO THE FUND. HOW TO
COST OF DIVESTMENT FORECASTERS
TODAY ARE ESTIMATED TO BE NEARLY
NINE BILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE HOPE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON HOLISTIC
SOLUTIONS THAT ACKNOWLEDGE BOTH
THE COMPLEXITY. AND URGENCY OF
THIS GLOBAL CHALLENGE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU AND I SEE MISTER
SUBER'S HERE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATOR STOCK SUPERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS HERE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE THE CPF
REPRESENTS MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL
ACROSS THE STATE. AND MANY OF
THOSE MEMBERS ARE WORK FOR
CALPERS CONTRACTING AGENCIES IN
THE US RELY ON CALPERS- FOR A
SECURE RETIREMENT- JUST AS
GENERAL CONTEXT CPF AS OPPOSED
TO VARIETY OF DIVESTMENT MATTERS
IN THE IN THE PAST- SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS IT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH THE FIDUCIARY
DUTY OF THE ROAD. SYSTEM
SIMILARLY SIMILAR REGARD ELEVEN
SEVEN. HE. WE ARE CAN- THAT
WOULD- THIS WILL DRIVE
DIVESTMENT CALPERS IN A MANNER
THAT IS INCONSISTENT WITH THE
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. AND THE
INTERESTS OF OUR MEMBERS WHO
RELY ON SUCCESSFUL CALPERS
INVESTMENTS FOR A SECURE
RETIREMENT. POSITIVE RETURNS BY
THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE SIGNIFICANT EMPLOYEE AN
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS THAT ARE
MADE. BY OUR MEMBERS AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS ARE STABLE
. AND IT CAN WORK THIS MEASURE
DIVERTS FROM THE CURRENT POLICY
. CALPERS TEMPLATE CONSIDER.
INITIATIVES THE WAY IN RESPONSE
TO THE INVESTMENT INITIATIVES IS
INCLUDED WITHIN THEIR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TOTAL FUND INVESTMENT
POLICY AND FOCUSES ON ENGAGEMENT
IN ADDITION TO OUTLINING CALPERS
ALSO ASSESSES THESE INITIATIVES-
ALSO RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THE ULTIMATE IMPACT OF THE
DIVESTITURE THE- DIVESTMENT
STRATEGIES. WILL OCCUR THE SCENE
NOTES THAT QUOTE IN ADDITION TO
FEDERAL AND STATE DIVESTING IN
IT IS AN INEFFECTIVE STRATEGY
SOCIAL OR POLITICAL GOALS USUAL
CONSEQUENCES OFF YOUR TRIP OF A
OF THAT ASSET. OTHER INVEST.
STANFORD THE COMPANY TO ACT
RESPONSIBLY FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
NOTE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
CALPERS IS DOING TO RESPOND TO
CLIMATE CHANGE- FIRST CALPERS
HAS INITIATED- CLIMATE RELATED
RESEARCH WIDGET IS INTEGRATED
INTO ITS INVESTMENT STRATEGIES
AND DECISION MAKING- UNDER.
TRANSITION RISKS AND RISKS FROM
AN- SECOND CALPERS HAS WORKED TO
ADVOCATE FOR EFFECTIVE POLICIES
TO RESPOND TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THIRD CALPERS IS WORKING WITH
OTHER INVESTORS TO ENGAGE
PORTFOLIO COMPANIES TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE RIGHT. FOR EXAMPLE
CALPERS IS A CO FOUNDER AND
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBER OF
CLIMATE ACTION ONE HUNDRED PLUS
GROUP OF SEVEN HUNDRED INVEST.
HE WOULD HAPPEN UP OVER SIXTY H.
ASSETS UNDER MANAGEMENT AND
ENGAGE COMPANIES ON IMPROVING
CLIMATE CHANGE GOVERNANCE
CUTTING INITIALS IS ALWAYS AN
ELEMENT. FINANCIAL YES
ARTISTICALLY ASTRONOVA THANK YOU
SIR ALL RIGHT. IF OTHERS WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION. BUT STRUCTURE
MEMBERS MIKE MONAHAN A PROUD
PERS MEMBER ON BEHALF OF THE
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WOMEN AND MEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. MR MURS PAUL DEAR-
pPETROLEUM ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE AROUND TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSITION SAYING KNOWN
APPROACH IN MY PHONE MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION SB ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE. WE WOULD BE GRATEFUL IF-
IF YOU OF OPPOSITION TO SQ ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AND YOUR LINE NUMBER WILL
BEGIVEN TO YOU. LINE. SIX TWO
ZERO SIX TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SIX
TWO ZERO SIX TWO ZERO. THANK
MISTER CARE NUMBER SORRY ABOUT
THAT MATT COMMITTEE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA THAT'D
COOPERATIVE OPPORTUNITY THERE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN IF I HAD. GOOD
EVENING REMEMBER SANDRA BARRERA
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CLASS I TOLD POLICE
ACROSS THE STATE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BRIAN
NUMBER SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO COMMITTEE THIS IS- JEFF ON
A ROCK WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS AND ALSO THE HUMBOLDT
DEL NORTE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE EIGHT NINETY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ON OUR NEXT CALLER
CALLED NINE FIVE FOURTEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD MEMBERS
PAT ROBERT NEWMAN IT'S
REPRESENTIG THE RETIRED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIND EIGHT FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE PROPOSAL BACK THE
LOBBY OUT THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
OF IRON ORDERS WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE SIX
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT PEOPLE
GROBLER ALONG WITH THE LITTLE
BIRDS IT FOR CALIFORNIANS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON IF YOU'RE
A MEMBER OF THE SADDAM UNTIL UP
UNTIL TONIGHT FROM SIX SIXTY
FOUR MEMBERS OF THE STUDENT PRO
SMOKE WILL STUDENTS LEADERS. AND
WE'RE SPENDING A STRONG WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THE LEVINSON REPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BRIAN THREE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PEOPLE HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RICK SWELLED
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DESERT
CAL BELIEVERS AND WE STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. LINE.
SIX ZERO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
BEFORE I HAD. HI GOOD EVENING
THIS IS ROD COUPLED WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FACTORY.
BILL IS DETRIMENTAL TO WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND ON THESE
INVESTMENTS EARN A PAYCHECK AND
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE THAT IS
WHY THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PIPE
TRADES STANDS WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES PROPOSES BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NINE SIX
pPLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
JOHN SPAULDING. CALLING FROM
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTED A CARD AND YOU'LL
FALL CALPERS BUILDING TRADE. I
WOULD STAND STRONG OPPOSITION.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT
ONE FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE EIGHT EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
MONNING IT'S AWFUL AND I WOULD.
LONG COMPLAIN OFTEN ALONG WITH
YOU FIRST APOCALYPSE. WE REPORT
OF THE ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR. ALL
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GREG CLUSTER WITH A
CHARACTER THEN CALPERS NUMBER
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT BUT WAS
NEVER GIVEN A NUMBER TO CALL IN
DURING SUPPORT IN STRONG SUPPORT
I'M SORRY THE BUILDING TRADE FOR
LIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
CALL PLEASE. NINE EIGHT NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS GRETCHEN
MAKING HER SAN FRANCISCO I WAS
NOT GIVEN A NUMBER ON THE PRO
SIDE THOUGH SORRY ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU PORTABILITY SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHT NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HE'S GO AHEAD OF IT SINCE
MADE FOR PEOPLE. OF CALIFORNIA
CALPERS MEMBER I WAS NOT GIVEN A
NUMBER IDENTITY. ALL RIGHT AND
IN SUPPORT. OF THE TREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE EIGHT NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARGARET LUCKY
I ALSO HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM OF
NOT GETTING A SUPPORT NUMBER I
REPRESENT SB VILLAGE LANCASTER'S
MEMBER AND I'M STRONG WOMEN
FAVOR OF SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU. AND THE LAST
PERSON IN THE QUEUE IF THE LINE
NINE ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS KHALID I'M WITH THE GROUP
YOUTH BRITAIN'S APOCALYPSE AND
ACTING IN STRONG SUPPORT
UNVEILED ONE ONE SEVEN THREE ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU
MODERATOR. BOB LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY CASKEY. THE
SEVEN MILLS THIS IS A GOOD JOB
ON- SAYING THAT THE STATUTE MAY
BE CREATED WITHIN THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE SAVING.
GRACE PROVISION WOULD BE THAT IF
THE CALPERS OR CAL STIRS-
FINANCING GOOD FAITH THAT THE
ACTIONS CONSISTENT WITH THEIR-
BOARD RESPONSIBILITY OVER THERE
FINALLY FORD. I DIDN'T HEAR THAT
IN THE OPPOSITION IS THERE IS
THERE A DISAGREEMENT ON THAT. OR
IS IT IS A DISAGREEMENT. ON THE
RISKS TO THE FUN AND THE
DIVERSIFICATION IS A- THROUGH
THE CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR WHAT
KOWSKI I THINK- THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW
WHAT THAT TRUE- REASON FOR
OPPOSING A BILL LIKE THIS. GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THIS IS ONE TOOL
IN ADDITION TO ENGAGEMENT THAT
COULD BE USED- TO PROVIDE MORE
RETURNS- FOR. PARTICIPANTS IN
FACT THE CALPERS HAS A
DIVESTMENT REVIEW PRESENTATION I
BELIEVE THAT WAS DONE NOT TOO
LONG AGO I THINK BETTER ABOUT A
YEAR AGO. ON PAGE SIX OF THAT
EVEN STATES BASED ON THE FIVE OR
SIX DIVESTMENT POLICIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE HAVE BEEN DONE BY
THE BOARD LED LED BY CALPERS
STIRS BOARDS AND THE OTHER HALF
BY THE LEGISLATURE- THE- I QUOTE
CAL. ST HOW DAVIS. MANAGES FUND
THE ANY FEASIBLE INVESTMENT
ALTERNATIVES WOULD YIELD A LOWER
RATE OF RETURN WITH COMMENSURATE
DEGREES OF RISK FOR CREATE A
HIGHER DEGREE. OF RISK WITH
COMMENSURATE. RATES OF RETURN.
AND THAT WOULD BE CONSISTENT
WITH THEM. WAS A GUY'S NAME
SEPARATELY THE FIRST THE FIRST
WITNESS CENTER AT SAM'S TO YOLO
WITH USED TO THE FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS HE AT LEAST IT
INDICATES THAT THAT NEW YORK
CITY COULD MEET ITS FINANCIAL
TARGETS BY DIVESTING- AND I JUST
I DON'T KNOW. IT APPEARS THE
PORTFOLIO THEY CALPERS HAS IS
ABOUT 1% OF FOSSIL FUELS GIVE OR
TAKE WHATEVER YOU KNOW WHATEVER
THEY DO ON A DIFFERENT DAY I'D I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PORTFOLIO OF
. THE NEW YORK CITY WAS- AND THE
REASON I ASK IS THAT IS THAT
THERE IS SOME RISK WHEN YOU DO
SOME OF THE BEST DIVESTITURE
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER
GOOGLE AND EVERYTHING ELSE IT'S
MAKING MONEY RIGHT- OKAY BUT.
I'D SAY THE GUY FIFTH WHETHER WE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY THE WISDOM OF
IT I GUESS IS THE THIS IS THE
QUESTION- I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT
HOW HOW WE GET THERE. ALL RIGHT
OTHER QUESTIONS SIR SIR WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND FOR
LEADING ON IT I KNOW IT HAS BEEN
EASY. IN A LOT OF- BLOWBACK- I'M
PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR OF
THIS OF THIS BILL- AND- YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND- THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF CALPERS- TO BE A- FIDUCIARY-
I JUST DON'T SEE FOSSIL FUEL
DIVESTMENT. ANYWAY HARMING- THE-
THE PENSION FUND I JUST DON'T I
JUST DON'T SEE IT IT'S A IT'S A
SMALL PERCENTAGE. IT'S ONE.
INDUSTRY AMONG SO MANY- IT IS
WE'RE NOT ASKING THIRD BEST FROM
LIKE FORTY PERCENT. OF THE FUNDS
THIS IS A SMALL PERCENTAGE- AND
THIS IS HONESTLY AN INDUSTRY
THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE INVESTING
AND WE SHOULD NOT BE A PARTY TO
PROVIDING CAPITAL. TO AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS LITERALLY
BURNING AND FLOODING THE PLANET
THAT'S MAKING PEOPLE SICK. THAT
IS DESTROYING PEOPLE'S HOMES.
THAT IS FLOODING ROADS AND
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS- AND IT
SAYS WE SHOULDN'T BE A PARTY- SO
THAT AND SO I THINK THIS MAKES
ALL THE SENSE IN THE WORLD WE
ALSO YOU KNOW THIS IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
WHEN CALIFORNIA TAXES AND A VERY
POWERFUL MESSAGE AROUND THE
WORLD AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAVE WE
SHOULD NOT BE INVESTING IN
FOSSIL FUELS- SO I. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU SIR WIENER- DID
YOU MAKE MOTION SIR WINNER MOST
BOOK ASSEMBLY CASKEY OF QUESTION
I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION FOR THE
OPPOSITION LOOK AT MY NOTES AND-
IT IS THEY HOURS LATE. I THOUGHT
I HEARD THE OPPOSITION SAY THAT
THE BY. HOLDING ON THE
PORTFOLIOS THEY HAD-
OPPORTUNITIES FROM INSIDE IS A
SHAREHOLDER TO AFFECT THE PUBLIC
POLICY OF SOME OF THESE
CORPORATIONS TO MOVE THEM. TO A
CLIMATE OR A CARBON FREE- THE
SITUATION OR REDUCTION. I WAS
GONNA ASK IS TO ADDRESS THE
PERSON WHO SPOKE HOW DO YOU DO
THAT. AND HAS THAT BEEN THAT HAS
THAT BEEN EFFECTIVE. THAT'S WHAT
I KNOW THAT THAT DOES SEEM LIKE
WE CAN DO IT ON OUR OWN AND I
DIDN'T. WANT TO GET SOME SENSE
OF. HOW THE SENATE CHIEF.
SERVICE CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES
. THANK YOU- DUCKS A RESUME OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS CENTER I DID NOTE-
THAT CALPERS- APPROACH HAS BEEN
ONE OF ENGAGEMENT THROUGH-
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES LIKE THEIR
THEIR PARTICIPATION CO FOUNDING
OF THE CLIMATE ACTION ONE
HUNDRED PLUS WHICH HAS REALLY
FOCUSED ON ENGAGEMENT WITH THESE
COMPANIES TO ESTABLISH CLIMATE
GOVERNANCE- TO DRIVE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN DR OTHER RESPONSES
TO CLIMATE CHANGE- CALPERS
ACTUALLY DOES. DO SOME REPORTING
THAT'S REQUIRED FROM US SENATE
BILL FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN S. B.
NINE SIX FOR THE TALKS ABOUT
HOW- CALPERS IS ADDRESSING
CLIMATE RISK ACROSS THE
PORTFOLIO THEY DO TALK ABOUT-
ENGAGEMENT IN- SHARE OWNER
PROPOSALS- BEFORE THE COMPANY-
PROXY DISCUSSIONS BOARD MEMBERS
AND THOSE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT. I BELIEVE THE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM- ALLEN'S ON YOU KNOW WHAT
THE IN THEIR PUBLIC MATERIALS
ABOUT HOW THEY ENGAGE- YOU KNOW
ENTITIES ON A VARIETY OF ISSUES
INCLUDING RELATED TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND THERE'S NO
DISAGREEMENT WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA GOALS OF BEING CARBON
FREE BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND
REDUCING OUR EMISSIONS BY 40% BY
TWENTY THIRTY GREAT QUESTION.
THIS IS SET THAT'S INCORPORATING
CALPERS MCALISTER'S. YEAH I MEAN
I GOVERNOR LEASE YEAH I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THE RETIREMENT PLAN
BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
REPORT THEY DO ASSESS THIS
REPORT FROM- DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THEY HAVE TO UPDATE
EVERY THREE YEARS THEY DO TALK
ABOUT THEIR ALIGNMENT WITH THE
PARIS ACCORD AND OTHER PROPOSALS
WITHIN- THEIR MENTAL PUT FORTH
BY THIS. THE STATE. INCENT YES
IN THE CENTER AYE KASKI AS THEY
HAVE NET ZERO BOTH CALPERS AND
STIRS NET ZERO BY TWENTY FIFTY
WHICH IS JUST A PLEDGE. AT THIS
TIME- KNOWING THAT IT DOESN'T
ALIGN WITH CALIFORNIA GOALS. AND
WHEN YOU GO TO K. CLIMATE ACTION
ONE HUNDRED WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
YOU CAN GO ON CLIMATE ACTION ONE
HUNDRED DOT ORG. AND SEE YOU CAN
TYPE IN ANY OF THE TWO HUNDRED
LISTS THAT WE- CHEVRON. CLEARLY
THEY'RE NOT MEETING THEIR- GOALS
BY EVEN TWENTY FIFTY. IN TERM
GOALS NOT EVEN HITTING THAT SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE- OUR OWN GOALS
AS A AS A PORTFOLIO OF NINE
BILLION DOLLARS BETWEEN THE TWO
BOARDS. IF THE FOLKS THAT WERE
INVESTING IN AREN'T EVEN DOING
THAT. SO IT JUST BEGS THE
QUESTION ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO-
INSURE THAT THE PORTFOLIO
DOESN'T UNDER PERFORMING THE
NEXT FIVE TO TEN YEARS. WHEN WE
GET OUT OF THIS UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION OF WAR WHEN PRICES GO
DOWN AND WHEN WE HAVE
POTENTIALLY STRANDED ASSETS
WHICH IS. NOT WHERE WE WANT TO
BE. CENTER STERN. THANK YOU- I
WOULDN'T JUST- THANK THE AUTHOR-
OR THE JOINT AUTHORS FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD AND FOR
ALL THE ADVOCATES SHOWING UP
HERE- THE HISTORY OF DIVESTMENT-
IN THE CLIMATE ARENA IS THIS IS
NOT NEW GROUND THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE WAITING INTO I DON'T
THINK THIS IS- UNTESTED WATERS
THE DATA I'VE GOT HERE MY STAFF
FOR. SHOWS THAT ABOUT THIRTY
NINE TRILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS
ACROSS FIFTEEN HUNDRED
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE WORLD
ARE CURRENTLY DIVESTING SO IT I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED SECONDS ALL
IS THE NINE BILLION. IN A JOINT
THE JOINT HOLDINGS OF. OF SOME
OF OUR RETIREMENT FUNDS BUT-
WHEN WE'RE WHEN WE'RE JOINING
THIRTY NINE TRILLION DOLLARS IN
OTHER ASSETS IT IT DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE A RISKY MOVE I WAS
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE SO MANY OF
MY FRIENDS AND- AND THE PEOPLE
WHO FRANKLY DEFENDER. FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE FROM WILDFIRES
BURN MY HOUSE DOWN AND SO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE'S. WITH THAT
TREPIDATION AND SORT OF BUYING
THE LINE FROM THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY THAT SOMEHOW IF YOU
START TO. ABANDON THIS ADDICTION
TO OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION THAT
WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO PUT
OURSELVES AT RISK. IN FACT I
THINK QUITE THE OPPOSITE I
THINK. THAT CLIMATE THAT CLIMATE
COMMITMENT IS GOING TO KEEP OUR
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN SAY FOR-
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PORTFOLIO'S PERFORMANCE- ANY
OF THOSE THIRTY NINE TRILLION
AYE AYE AYE YOU CAN YOU CAN
ANALYZE THE DIFFERENT PENSION
FUNDS GOVERNMENT MY OWN ALMA
MATER HARVARD FINALLY AFTER A
DECADE OF ADVOCACY IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE LARGEST PRIVATE
HOLDING IN THE ENTIRE WORLD BE
ON THE CATHOLIC CHURCH THE LOCKS
IN THE WHOLE WORLD. CAN DIE
DIVESTMENT AND- THE SERRANO
CONFLICT WITH THEIR FIDUCIARY
DUTIES OR WITH ANY COMMITMENT TO
RETURN SERIES SAVINGS TO THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS AND IN FACT I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT- THIS LEGISLATION
WILL DE RISK OUR PORTFOLIO AND
NOT LEAVE US EXPOSED TO THE NEXT
TIME A GLOBAL PETRO DICTATOR
WANTS TO. ELECT TO GO TO WAR
WITH THEIR NEIGHBOR- TO HAVE OUR
LIABILITIES THAT EXPOSED TO THE
GLOBAL VOLATILITIES OF OPEC IN
THE LARGER OF FOSSIL FUEL
DICTATORSHIPS THAT THEY
CURRENTLY HOLD ALL CONSUMERS AND
OUR WORKERS OVER A BARREL SEEMS
TO ME MISGUIDED. I APPRECIATE.
THE TREPIDATION BUT WHAT I'M
HOPING THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION
AND ESPECIALLY- YOU KNOW THROUGH
THE- INCREASE LIQUIDATION PERIOD
THAT YOU PUT FORTH ANY
AMENDMENTS HERE WHICH I THINK IS
SIGNIFICANT AND DOES GIVE US
SOME TIME AND- HOPEFULLY ALIGNS
WITH WHAT CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
ARE DOING OPERATIONALLY NOW- IS
TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS. AND CLIMATE COMMITMENTS OR
FIND. IN SIGNING PLEDGES FIND-
BUT MONEY TALKS AND I THINK IT'S
TIME WE- WE PUT THAT THAT MONEY
TO WORK FOR THE FOR THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA SO. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- I WOULD LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON. TO THE MEASURE
AND- WHO LOOK FOR JUST THAT.
THANK YOU CENTER CERTAIN OTHER
CENTERS ARE ALSO. YES I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY- I
HOPE. THAT THE WAY WE FEEL THE
URGENCY. TO MOVE AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND MOVE IT FORWARD
THE WILL FLOW HAVE THE SAME
URGENCY WHEN IT COMES TO. THE
JOBS THAT WE'RE LOSING BECAUSE
WE WILL BE LOSING JOBS- THAT WE
HAVE THE SAME URGENCY. AND THE
SAME BOLDNESS. TO CREATE THE NEW
JOBS IN A WAY THAT THEY ARE WELL
PAID WELL PAID WITH RETIREMENT
WITH THE KINDS OF BENEFITS THAT
WE ALL SAY AND WE'RE GOING TO
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS
LET'S PUT IT. YEAH LET'S PUT
LET'S THROW DOWN IN THE SAME WAY
. UP FOR THE JOB. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE REPLACING IT WITH
FROM THE GREEN ECONOMY LET'S
SHOW THE SAME BOLDNESS AND THE
SAME- A COMMITMENT. THAT WE ARE
TODAY ON THE ON THIS END OF IT
BECAUSE ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER
DOESN'T WORK ALSO- AND LET'S
MAKE SURE WE ALL HAVE THAT SAME
COMMITMENT AND HOLD OURSELVES TO
THE- MISTER MISTER CHAN THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT EARLIER THIS THE
IS NOT LIMITED TO JUST SAID
TOTALLY SUBSCRIBE TO THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS AND GONNA. BE
HAPPY TO PARTNER ON THAT. IS ONE
PERSON I THINK THAT WAS HERE
WHEN HE WON THIS WENT THROUGH
THE LABOR COMMITTEE FOR ACTUALLY
CENTERED RUSSELL WAS TOO. AND I
THINK I'D LIKE SO I JUST LIKE TO
STIPULATE MY ENTIRE LONG SPEECH
FROM THAT COMMITTEE. HERE AGAIN
WITH THOSE TWO YET YEAH BECAUSE
HE BRIEFLY IT WAS HARVARD AND UC
OF DONE IT WITHOUT NEGATIVE-
IMPACT THERE WAS CONCERN. ABOUT
INFANTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN LABOR
ABOUT AN ACT OF GOD AND AS
THINGS ABOUT- DIVESTMENT AND YET
THERE WERE FIVE YEARS AND NOW
OUT OF THIS THESE AMENDMENTS
THURSDAY EIGHT YEARS. ALL THE
SAME ARGUMENTS WERE MADE ABOUT
LOSS AT THE TIME OF DIVESTMENT
IN SOUTH AFRICA AND THEY WERE
NOT TRUE AND THERE'S JUST AS AN
URGENCY TO DO THIS SO I WILL BE
AGAINST SPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY. NUMBER THANK YOU. SIR
HERTZBERG YEAH I JUST WANT TO
FOCUS THIS DISCUSSION AS I THINK
ABOUT THIS- IF SOMEBODY'S GONNA
BOND LAWYER AND BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS A LOT LOOK THE IDEA ABOUT
THE RATE OF RETURN AND COSTS IS
INTERESTING. BUT WHEN WE MAKE
THE BEST DECISIONS THERE FOR
MAKING A STATEMENT ABOUT WHERE
WE WANT TO GO. THE ISSUE HERE IS
CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE DEAD IN
THIRTEEN SECONDS BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT TAKING AND URGENT ACTION.
THAT URGENCY HAS INFORMED LIKE
JUST SANRIKU WOULD YOU THEIR.
SO SAYS TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP
PEOPLE EMPLOYED HIGH WAGE JOBS
RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION AS FAST AS WE CAN.
WE'VE GOTTA BE MAKING DECISIONS
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS BILL
WITH INVESTMENT BILL THAT MAXINE
WATERS TWO YEARS AGO IN SOUTH
AFRICA THOSE WERE MORAL
STATEMENTS THIS IS A STATEMENT
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE. NOT
ABOUT FIDUCIARY OBLIGATIONS
BECAUSE ISIS IF YOU REVIEW THE
PORTFOLIO OF OUR VARIOUS
INVESTMENTS IS A LOT OF THAT WE
COULD ANALYZE WITH THE BEST
MINDS OUT THERE THAT PROBABLY
AREN'T PERFORMING AS WELL RIGHT
THAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY GET READ
OF. THIS IS A STATEMENT ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND SO IF YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE THE STATEMENT OUR
CLIENT THAT CHANGE TO ME THE IT
HAS TO. DO WITH A SET OF
POLICIES THAT IS INFORMED BY
URGENCY I HAVE OPPOSED A LOT OF
THE STUFF THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT HERE BECAUSE IT'S ALL
ABOUT CHANGING DATES AND TIMES
AND- DID MARK DEADLINES AND
STUFF VERSUS SAYING. LET'S GO DO
THAT PLAN IN THE PORT FOR THE
HYDROGEN FOR YOUR AREA IN LONG
BEACH LET'S GO DO THE PROJECT
DWN IN IN FOR BATTERIES SO
WE'RE NOT RELYING ON CHILLY IN
OTHER PARTSOF THE COUNTRY.
KADING THOSE JOBS HERE LET'S
TAKE YOU KNOW SOLAR CELLS THE
SOLAR FIELDS IN MY HOBBY AND
LET'S PUT ELECTROLYZER IS THEIR
TURN REAL JOBS BECAUSE A PROBLEM
SOLVER IF YOU JUST. HAVE TO GET
DIRECTOR SET UP IF. IT'S
PLAINEST REAL JOBS THE HE
BECOMES A BIG PICTURE THINK
ABOUT HOW CREATE WE JOBS. AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS SO LOOK.
MY FRIEND IN THE CAR SHE'S BEEN
A FRIEND OF MINE FOR YEARS ONE
OF THE PEOPLE THE ONE ON THE
BOARD OF CUTBACKS ON. HE
ORCHESTRATED A PRETTY BRILLIANT
MOVE. PRETTY BRILLIANT WITH THE
SUPPORT OF OUR PEOPLE ARE
INVESTMENTS TO DO THAT. SO THIS
I AM PERSUADED TO SOME EXTENT
ABOUT THE ARGUMENT THAT OKAY
WELL IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
THESE ENTITIES THAT ARE GOING TO
POLLUTE THE EARTH IT DOESN'T
MATTER. WE DRAW THESE RIDICULOUS
LINES IN THE AIR THAT WE CALL
STATES AND CITIES AND COUNTIES
WE ARE ONE GIGANTIC GLOBE. THE
STUFF IN YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS
IN THE HARBOR IS KILLING US THAT
POLLUTANTS IN THE HARBOR THAT
STUFF'S COMING FROM OTHER PARTS
OF THE WORLD. SO IT BECOMES AYE
AYE ALL OVER SAY IS THIS BECAUSE
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE LARGER
ISSUE. APOLOGIZE I'M TAKING MR
LAYERED SPEECH BECAUSE I WORK ON
LABOR. BUT BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONTEXTUALIZE THIS
THING UP BECAUSE THE FOLKS THAT
ARE IN THE LABOR COMMITTEE THE
PROJECT INTO THIS. ARE
PROJECTING BECAUSE TO THE POINT
THAT SENATOR ALSO MADE. I CAN
WITH A MAN. REPLACE IT WITH REAL
WORK HAPPENING GUEST STARS
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GO WHAT WHAT'S
THE TERM. THAT WE USE- THE-
INTERESTS. CHARM WHAT DO NOT TO.
ARE GIVEN REAL AND WE'RE FIGURE
OUT. HOW TO CREATE AND- APPROACH
TO THIS LOOK. I'M OF A LARGE
BIRD ON THIS BECAUSE- THE TEST
IS. ARE WE REDUCING GHGS
ENVIRONMENT I USED TO TELL THE
ENVIRONMENT WAS TO SIT BACK AND
TALK ABOUT THIS ALL DAY LONG.
ALL THE REGULATIONS HOW MANY
POUNDS OF CARBON YOU REDUCE THE
ENVIRONMENT I TOOK OFF TWELVE
YEARS OF MY LIFE. AND I TRAVEL
THE WORLD TO REDUCE CARBON IN
THE WORLD RIGHT. DOES THIS IN
FACT DO THAT OR DOES IT JUST
MAKE A STATEMENT THAT'S THE
QUESTION SO LOOK AT YOUR THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS A LOT I'M GONNA VOTE
FOR THIS TODAY BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT. TO GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO KEEP. GO IT'S GOT
SIGNIFICANT. DISCUSSION POINTS
THAT WE NEED TO ENGAGE IN. AND
THIS IS THE FIRST THE SECOND
COMMITTEE BUT THE FIRST HOUSE
THAT NEEDS SOME HOMEWORK ON THIS
STUFF. IS STILL NEEDS SOME
HOMEWORK I THINK IS I THINK THAT
THE CHAIR. AT THE DATES BUT- I
DO THINK WE CAN ANALYZE THIS
LITTLE BIT MORE. BUT I THINK
YOUR EARNEST. AND YOUR CARD. YOU
TRY TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM. AND I
GIVE YOU CREDIT FOR THAT. BUT
BUT I DO THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE A
DEEPER THINK. ABOUT OUR LARGE
ARCHITECTURE WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING. TO ACTUALLY REDUCE GHGS
LET ALONE ALL THE NEAR TERM
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
CLIMATE. OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE BUT MISFORTUNE- IT WITH THE
AT CABBIE OUT THAT I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO ENSURE THAT GOING
FORWARD BUT- I WHAT I REALLY
WANT TO THINK IT THROUGH.
REGULAR REGARD FOR YOUR APPROACH
THIS AGAIN I REGARD YOU THINK
AND- AND PEOPLE. ARE REALLY
UPSET BECAUSE THE WORLD'S COMING
TO AN END SO TO SPEAK. AND WE
HAVE TO BE SMART ABOUT IT AND
DILIGENT AND EARNEST AND FAST.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE DO IN THE
WAY. THAT WE PUT PEOPLE TO WORK
AND HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS SO. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THERE I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE SOME OF THE DEEP THINK
THAT I'VE ENGAGED FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HERTZBERG.
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS- ALL
RIGHT. YOU CAN CLOSE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE DEBATE
AND THAT THE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS I KNOW THIS ISN'T AN
EASY- TASK TO ASK BUT I THINK
THAT IT'S- YOU KNOW I AM
LITERALLY PUTTING MY MONEY WHERE
MY MOUTH IS ON THE CALPERS
MEMBER. MYSELF CITY OF LONG
BEACH. I'M ALSO- A FOUR OH ONE
K. A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE A FOUR
ONE K. FROM ONE OF THE LARGEST
ESG MOST SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
CORPORATIONS- WHEN I WAS THERE
FOR SIX YEARS I ACTUALLY. WAS
ACTIVELY LOOKING AT VETTING
COMPANIES NOT JUST FOR FOSSIL
FUEL. DIVESTMENT BUT ALSO FOR
ENSURING THAT THEY WERE SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE. THAT THEY ACTUALLY-
DIDN'T VIOLATE HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS THAT THEY ALSO HAD
GOOD GOVERNMENT SO. I'M
LITERALLY PUTTING MY MONEY WHERE
MY MOUTH IS HERE IN ADDITION TO
SO MANY MEMBERS THAT HAVE SAID
THAT THEY WANT THIS DIVESTMENT
TO HAPPEN- WHAT I WILL JUST END
WITH SAYING IS WE'VE BEEN HERE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME IS
DIVESTMENT AS HAPPENED IN FACT
HOLSTERS MADE A STATEMENT. I'M
NOT TOO LONG AGO WITH PRIVATE
PENSIONS I'M SORRY PRIVATE
PRISONS- THE BASICALLY DIVESTED
WITHIN SIX MONTHS. BECAUSE
ENGAGE THEY WENT ON SITE AND
VISITED PRIVATE PRISONS A NOTICE
AT THAT FAMILIES IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ARE BEING SEPARATED.
FROM EACH OTHER SO WITH THAT
THEY CAN MAKE STATEMENTS WERE
HERE TO MAKE A STATEMENT TO AND
THAT IS TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DIVESTING AND DOING. RIGHT BY-
SCHURING THAT THERE'S GOOD JOB
IN THAT WERE. IN THOSE CLEAN
JOBS. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK
YOU CENTER GONZALEZ WAS THERE
MOTION. IS CENTER WE ARE MOVING
THAT'S CORRECT ALL RIGHT.
MENDOCINE COUNTY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG. FIVE BORDERS SNOW
CABALLERO THE RUSSELL THE REST
SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JONES.
AIRED LEHRER DIE STERN STERN AYE
A WHITE CAL SKI. WIENER WIENER
AYE. YOU HAVE SEVEN TWO ONE WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT BACK ON CALL NEXT I
THINK WE'VE SENT A WHITE CAL SKI
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX. IT'S
ACTUALLY CENTER HERS WAS NOT
PAYING ATTENTION APPARENTLY. NO
NO NO GO AHEAD CENTERS FOR I
JUST SEEING IF YOU'RE WATCHING.
YEAH YEAH RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT WELL
IT'S JUST A FUNCTION OF WELL
LIKE MORE SO ANYWAY SO. SENATE
HERTZBERG S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET ME A BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE. COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING EACH YEAR AND HERE.
GREAT TEAM FOR THE WORKER THIS
MAY- IN LOS. MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL EMPLOY. THE BY THE
K. HEALTH TREATING SEVEN FIFTY
PATIENTS LIE YEAR THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS MEMBERS WERE TESTED TO
THE BAO THEIR OWN PERSONAL RISKS
WITH DUTY TO CARE FOR PATIENTS
THE PANDEMIC MEMBERS TO
CONSIDERABLE TOLL ON THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. IT WILL
NEVER THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR
THEIR EXTRAORDINARY SACRIFICE
AND YET. THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IS RETURNING THE
SACRIFICE IN KIND BY OFFERING
SUBPAR HEALTH BENEFITS TO
CERTAIN POSITIONS DEPENDING ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY PARTICIPATE
IN EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION THAT'S
RIGHT OF THE FOUR HEALTH CARE
PLANS AVAILABLE TO COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ELLIE CURRENTLY SHARE
SUBJECTS COUNTY PHYSICIANS.
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS TO
ORGANIZE WRITTEN FOR YOUR HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS THIS PRACTICE OF
DISCRIMINATION MEMBERS IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOT NEW- THIS
WOULDN'T HAPPEN TWO DECADES AGO
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO AGAIN
ASSEMBLY THEN SIMPLY MEMBER SO
THE- MY ROOMMATE AT THE TIME.
PASSED A. B. TWO OH SIX. TO PUT
AN END TO THE DISCRIMINATION
THAT WAS COURT OF APPEALS
DECISION THAT DEALT WITH THE
MICHIGAN US IN THAT REGARD THIS
MEASURE CLOSES THE LOOPHOLES AS
RESULT OF THAT LITIGATION. AND I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT DOCTORS TO
INCREASE THESE HERE- PRESS IS
THE UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND DENTISTS AND CHRISTOPHER
AGREEMENT. AMERICAN. PHYSICIANS
AND DENTISTS THAT BELIEVES ON.
DR BUSING. BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG FOR CARRYING
THIS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL- I AM
NOT A DOCTOR BUT SHE GOT CALLED
AWAY MY NAME IS GEORGE OSBORNE
ON THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
THE UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
IN DENISON S. B. TO RE PLEASE
INTO THE RECORD HIS STATEMENT-
ON HIS BEHALF. HIS NAME IS TO
BUT SHE IS A CITY BOARD
CERTIFIED FAMILY PHYSICIAN AND
ATTORNEY AND FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
INTERNISTS TEST ME LOCAL TWO OH
SIX STRONGLY SYSTEM THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN WHAT ARE PSYCHIATRISTS
DENTISTS ORGANIZED BARGAINING
UNITS AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. M. MEGA
FLEX HEALTH PLAN DID NOT A STE.
MEGAPLEX IS WORSE 14217% OF AN
EMPLOYEE'S SALARY. WHERE IS THE
CHOICES PLAN PROVIDES A FLAT
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MUCH LOWER BENEFIT FOR MOST OF
OUR DOCTORS. MY ORGANIZED EIGHT
HUNDRED PLUS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PHYSICIANS IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE MANY DID HAVE MEGA FLEX. TO
DISSUADE UNIONIZATION. THE
COUNTY CLAIMED IT HAD A POLICY
OF NOT ALLOWING UNIONIZED
EMPLOYEES INTO MEGA FLEX. IT
MADE NO SECRET WHITE WANTED TO
RESERVE THE BEST BENEFITS FOR
ITS NON UNIONIZED WORKERS. A
COUNTY SPOKESMAN SAID TO THE TO
THE MEDIA QUOTE. THE COUNTY HAS
TO GIVE AN INCENTIVE FOR WORKERS
NOT. TO UNIONIZE CLOSE QUOTE.
OUR DOCTORS JOIN YOU APD ANYWAY
AND DURING OUR FIRST CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS THE COUNTY WOULDN'T
AGREE TO OFFER MEGA FLEX TO OUR
MEMBERS INSTEAD THEY IMPOSED
ENABLE YOU WHICH TOOK AWAY MEGA
FLEX FROM OUR MEMBERS. THE
DOCTORS WERE UNDERSTANDABLY
UPSET DECERTIFIED FROM OUR UNION
AND THEN WERE REWARDED BY THE
COUNTY BUT RESTORING THEIR MEGA
FLEX. THIS WAS CLEARLY A CASE OF
UNION DISCRIMINATION. YOU APD
FILED UNLAWFUL LABOR PRACTICE
ACTIONS A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
COUNTY AND SOUGHT LEGISLATION TO
RECTIFY THIS. LOS ANGELES
CLIPPERS SENTIMENT HILLS STUDIO
CREATED AND GOVERNOR GRAY SIGNED
INTO LAW AB TWO THOUSAND SIX
WHICH MADE IT DISCRIMINATORY AND
ILLEGAL FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TO REMOVE OR DISQUALIFY. OUR
MEMBERS FROM HEALTH BENEFIT
PLAN. AFTER A PHYSICIAN UNIT
UNION RECERTIFIED WITH YOU APD
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TOOK COLD TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF A LOOPHOLE IN AB
TWO THOUSAND SIX DURING THE
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS THEY
REFUSED TO OFFER MEGA FLEX OUR
MEMBERS. THROUGH LA MANAGERS
ARE- BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR RIGHT MAJOR. ALL RIGHT-
ALSO CHRISTOPHER I. OKAY YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT IT'S CHRIS BURTON
YES MY NAME IS CHRIS FRIEDMAN-
ON STAFF WITH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
THE LOCAL TO A SIX AND WE ARE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THIS BILL
WOULD STOP THE PRACTICE OF
DISQUALIFYING UNIONIZED
EMPLOYEES FROM PARTICIPATING
HEALTH. BENEFITS PLANS THAT
PROVIDE INCREASED BENEFITS THAT
ARE ONLY AVAILABLE TO MANAGERIAL
EMPLOYEES OR NOT MEMBERS OF THE
RECOGNIZE EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION
CURRENTLY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
UNIONIZE DOCTOR'S AND DENTIST'S
HIRED ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN A BENEFITS
PACKAGE THAT IS 20% LESS THAN
MANAGEMENT IN MILAN UTILIZED
DOCTORS AND DENTISTS SO THERE
ARE VACANCY RATES OF ALMOST 25%
PER MEMBERS UNITS REQUEST
CHANGES TO THIS PRACTICE AND
HAVE NOT GOOD NIGHT. CITING PAST
COURT CASES DECISIONS PRACTICE
ARE BEING IN MANAGEMENT NON NON
UNION BENEFIT PACKAGE THAT IS UP
20% RICHER IS THE TO STABILIZING
FORCE FOR ORGANIZED LABOR IN NOT
THE INTENT. OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SIX. WE BELIEVE THAT AS PEOPLE
PER WILL IS WHEN PEOPLE WE ASKED
YOU ANDREA OF OUR- CERTIFIED.
PHARMACISTS THAT AND DENNIS FOR
SOME SB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. A
TOTAL EQUAL BENEFITS THANK.
THANK YOU. R. I. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
PRESENT HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SAYING NO WHEN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE ON
THE PHONE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN THIRTEEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AN OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU A LINE NUMBER. THE. NINE NINE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF KRISTOFF MEYER CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES. WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THE BACKSEAT
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE. WE HAVE
NOBODY ELSE THAT HAS A QUEUE UP
AT THE MOMENT ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LISTED FOR THIS BILL BUT IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS MIKE FROM FEW HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SEEING KNOWN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE MOTOR
IF YOU TWO OF THOSE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN. YOUR IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS MOMENT. BUT WE HAVE NOBODY
TO HAVE QUEUED UP PROPOSITIONS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK
CENTER WE ARE MOVES THE BILL ALL
RIGHT SIR OTHERS QUESTIONS THE
QUESTIONS ARE ALL PART OF
RESPECTFULLY HAS BEEN UNDER HIS
ORDERS ALL RIGHT MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL YES- THIS IS SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS D.
PATH AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE. HI I'M BURKE AYE BURGESS
. IS NO ZERO. ZERO I DID ALSO
STRESS SO I'D GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG- I JONES. CLEARED
CLEARED I STERN STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI WHY CASKEY I WINNER.
RIGHT AT NINE TO ONE SO FAR WITH
THE MEMBER MISSING RIGHT TO PUT
THAT ON CALL. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE
HAVE CENTER WHITE CAL SKI WITH
S. B. TWELVE FIFTY SIX. SEVEN
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SING AT
SEVEN O'CLOCK- IS A STAFF
REPORT- BRILLIANTLY POINTS OUT
IN THIS ONE AND A HALF PAGE BILL
THAT- THE JUDICIARY'S
JURISDICTION IS OVER THE CIVIL
PENALTIES THERE'S NOTHING NEW
ABOUT THE FIRST OFFENSE SECOND
OFFENSE AND THIRD OFFENSE BEING
THE FIVE HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND- LEVELS CITY
ATTORNEYS IN GAS CITY COUNCIL.
COUNTY COUNCILS WOULD DO THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE BAN AT OF THE
BILL THAT'S IN PRINT. AND THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY IMPOSED A CIVIL
PENALTY SINCE IT'S NEGATIVELY-
IF- IMPACTS VIOLATIONS AND FALSE
AND THAT THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTION SO THIS BILL SB
TWELVE. FIFTY SIX MOVES AWAY
FROM THE SINGLE. PRODUCTS THAT
HARM THE ENVIRONMENT POSES A
THREAT TO ITS THREAT TO SAFETY
IN. OUT WORKERS IN ENDS UP IN
LANDFILLS- THERE'VE BEEN SOME
QUESTIONS YOU KNOW HI I WANT TO-
NO TED I AM WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR I'D LIKE TO SEE. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES TO AN EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY WOULD
RATHER THAN THE PAN SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN RACES
THAT ARE WE JUST GONNA USE ONE
PATENT A PATENT IS GOING TO
AFFECT. ONE COMPANY AS WE SEE-
TRANSITIONS TO A REFILLABLE SEN
ACTUALLY THERE ARE MULTIPLE PAT
HOUSTON THIS INDUSTRY PATENT FOR
FLAME KING KING HOLDS ITS
LOCATION. OF THE SAFETY RELIEF
FELL ABOUT THEIR PATENT IS FOR
THE SAFETY RELIEFVALVE TO BE
LOCATED WITHIN THE STEM OR
SERVICE- CONNECTION VALVE OF THE
CYLINDER. WORTHINGTON HAS A
SAFETY RELIEF VALVE LOCATED ON
THE TOP OF THE CYLINDER OFF TO
THE SIDE OF THE STEM THIS IS THE
EXISTING DESIGNED ONE MORE THAN
TEN ACQUIRED THE PRODUCT-
PRODUCTION FACILITY IN KANSAS
FROM COLEMAN MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO. AGO TO REFILL ASIF A SINGLE
USE CYLINDER THE REFILL OUR MUST
USE THE SAFETY RELIEF VALVE TO
ALLOW AIR TO. GAS FLOWING IN
FLAME KING AT MANCHESTER REFILL
POOLS ARE DESIGNED WITH THE
BLEEDER VALVES TO THE CONSUMER
DOESN'T NEED TO TOUCH. THE
SAFETY RELIEF VALVE THEREBY. NOT
AFFECTING THE INTEGRITY OF THE
IMPORTANT SAFETY DESIGN FEATURE
IN IN THIS WAY ANY CYLINDER
MANUFACTURER CAN DESIGN WHERE
THAT SAFETY RELIEF FELLAS
LOCATED ON THEIR CYLINDERS.
SINCE THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN
WHICH THE DESIGN TO REFILLABLE
CYLINDERS TO ACCOMMODATE THE
SAFETY RELEASE VALVE THERE IS.
NO LIMIT ON HOW MANY CAN BE
DESIGNED AND THEREFORE PATENTED
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WORTHINGTON
ALREADY INSTALL SEEK TO RELEASE
VALVE CORES FROM DIFFERENT
SEVERAL DIFFERENT MANUFACTURERS
INTO THE WORTHINGTON CYLINDERS
DURING THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS. SO AGAIN IT IS POSSIBLE
HAVE MULTIPLE ENTITIES- WITH
PATENTS ON VALVES- THE SPONSORS
WHO. HAVE STATED THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT AND IT'S NOT INTENDED
TO BENEFIT ONE COMPANY. OR ONE
COMPANY CENTRIST AND WE WANT TO
TRANSITION TO MORE. REUSABLE
SHOULDERS TO GET OUT OF THE WAY
STRINGS AND WHEN CALIFORNIA
BENEFITS. WITH THAT SAID MY
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS HAVE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK-
AND HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH WHERE
THE BAND AND THE OPPOSITION TO
SEE IF WE CAN FIND AGREEMENT. ON
BOTH THE DETAILS AND THE
STANDARD WILL POP EXTENDED TO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THESE
MATERIALS IN CALIFORNIA AND WITH
THAT I HAVE- PRISCILLA A QUIZ OR
A WITH THE ODD CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP. COUNCIL
DOUG COBALT THE PRESS. SO HERE.
THANK YOU THE INTEREST IS THAT
EITHER YOU OR PERHAPS YOUR
WITNESSES CAN ADDRESS THAT THE
FOR ISSUE IT THE NEW ALLU TO IT
IS THAT THE OTHER SO THAT THE
THIS BILL WOULD DICTATE A
PRODUCT DESIGN THE BENEFITS ONE
COMPANY IN ONLY ONE COMPANY THAT
CURRENTLY HOLDS PATENT. ISSUE
ONE ISSUE TOO IS THAT- THAT- THE
OPPOSITION IS SAYING YOU ALLUDED
TO THIS AS WELL THAT THAT A MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY OF DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE IS A DATE PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAMS SELL EITHER%
IN YOUR CLOSER PERHAPS WITH THE
SKIN ADDRESS THOSE TWO ISSUES.
THANK YOU- SO MISSED. CURIS
GHETTO SEATTLE'S OKAY SO YOU'RE
A US WITH THAT SO YOUR INTEREST
MILL FAILING HOW BEHALF OF CPSE
SPONSORS THE BILL- I'LL JUST GO
STRAIGHT TO THE POINT THAT YOU
KNOW AT. WORTHINGTON IS- THE
ONLY THERE'S TWO COMPANIES RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE DOING THE
REFILLABLE PROPANE TANKS THAT
STUFF LINKING AND- I BELIEVE. IT
IS- START AT MANCHESTER SO IT AS
SENATOR MCCASKEY STATED YOU KNOW
OR THE TEN RIGHT NOW CAN GO
AHEAD AND YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
BASICALLY WHERE IT STATED ON
WHERE THEY CAN. FORM THAT SAFETY
RELIEF VALVES SO WE'RE INTO
RIGHT NOW CAN DESIGN THE
CYLINDER IN A WAY THAT COULD BE
REFILLABLE AND DO A SIMILAR KIND
OF DESIGN THAT FLAME KING AND
MANCHESTER. HAVE DONE IT BEFORE
IN THE PAST- AND DOUG COBLE CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT BILL MORE
THAT- Q. AND DID YOU. YEAH THANK
YOU FEATURE AND MEMBERS- OF THE
COMMITTEE I HAVE SOME PANELS I'D
LIKE TO HAND THE SERGEANT. AND
MADE I THINK WILL HELP
ABSOLUTELY THERE WE GO THANK
YOU- I THINK THAT THESE WILL
HELP. TO GUIDE YOU BECAUSE WHAT
CENTER LIKE HEALTHY EXPLAINED
YOU WITH THE SERVICE CONNECTED
VALVE THE SAFETY RELIEF VALVE
THE BLEEDER VALVE THERE ARE A
LOT OF VALVES. AND YOU'LL SEE
THESE AS ON ON THE- SHEETS THEM
HAND OUT BUT I THINK I'LL
CLARIFY FOR YOU THAT- AT CENTER
WHAT BECAUSE HE POINTED OUT. THE
PATENT THAT FLAME KING HOUSE IS
ONLY ON THE LOCATION OF THE
SAFETY RELIEF VALVE AS A SAFETY
MEASURE IN CASE THE PROPANE
CYLINDER WITH IT EITHER DURING
FILLING OR DURING
TRANSPORTATION- ANY TIME. STARTS
TO EXCEED THE SAFE. PRESSURE
WITHIN THE CONTAINER THAT BALBAN
UP AND RELEASES I NEVER GAS TO
BRING IT BACK DOWN TO THAT SAFE
PRESSURE. AND SO THAT IS THEIR
SAFETY MECHANISM IT WAS NEVER
MEANT TO BE A VALVE TO OPEN UP
SO THAT YOU COULD RELEASE ERROR
TO REFILL THESE. THE CYLINDERS
AND SO- FOLKS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
REFILL IN THE SINGLE USE
CYLINDERS ARE ONE VIOLATE
FEDERAL LAW. BECAUSE IF YOU'VE
READ POLICE AND THEN PUT THEM
OUT ON THE ROAD TO GET ON THE
ROAD YOU ARE ACTUALLY IN
VIOLATION OF THE DOT FEDERAL LAW
A COOK. CAL COULD AT THE RELATED
REGULATIONS- AND THEN TO YOU'RE
PUTTING YOURSELF AT RISK BECAUSE
NOW THAT. THE CYLINDER HAS DONE
SOMETHING ISSUED A NEVER BEEN
DONE IT WAS NEVER DESIGNED. TO
BE REFILLED AND- BY THE SO
CALLED. ALL THE- SAFETY RELIEF.
ISSUE N. THE CONNECTION VALVE IN
THE BILL VALVE UNTIL I WANTED TO
BE SURE THAT THAT. THAT WAS
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT A PATENT
ON THE STEM WHICH IS WHERE FLAME
KING. CHOSE TO IN BED THE
STATE'S RELIEF VALVE AND IN THE
STATE TO RELIEF EVENT WHAT YOU
ALSO SEE IN THOSE DIAGRAMS.
WHICH IS RIGHT BELOW THAT SEEKS
TO REPEAT VALVES UTTERED A LOUD
THAT ALLOW THE TO BE. RELEASED
AND SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT- AND HOPEFULLY THAT'LL
HELP. YOU UNDERSTAND BETTER THE
ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S A PATENT. WALK DOWN HERE
ARE NOT. ALREADY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ALSO OF MRS AMY HEIM SCAMS
IS IT IS SHE ON THE PHONE SHE
HAD TO HOP OFF AND DUE TO
ANOTHER CONFLICT UNFORTUNATELY
BUT SHE DIDN'T ANTICIPATE WOULD
BE GOING NINE HOURS NO. I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT ALL RIGHT- OKAY-
THOSE OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SIGNAL AN APPROACHING MICROPHONE
OH I'M SORRY. OKAY SIGNALED
APPROACHING MY PHONE NOW
ALLISTER THE PHONE LINES THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
SIX. MODERATOR. OKAY PRESS
PEOPLE IT IS SIX FIVE ONE IF YOU
PRESS ONE IN THE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AT THE MOMENT.
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE THAT HAVE
QUEUED UP WE JUST WAITING TO
THEIR LINE NUMBERS TO BE EVEN
TO- ONE MOMENT.
LEVINE NUMBER SEVEN FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHAEL BATH
WITH THE PREY AND MCKINLEY ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIRES BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE BY
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS ELAINE
ORTIZ ON THE HAPPENED RECENTLY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD
AND I WILL BE OUT WITHIN THE
PHONE QUEUE ALL RIGHT APOLOGIES
ACTUALLY DID HAVE SOMEBODY THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE- JASON
SMELTER HERE ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL ALAMEDA STOP WASTE AND
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY INSTRUCTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT OF NO ONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE NO ONE ELSE
HERE- OPPOSITION. MISTER ROBSON
COULD YOU COULD IN HERE AT TEN
O'CLOCK THIS MORNING IN THE
MICROPHONE WAS NOT KEY TO
ELECTROCUTE YOU. APPROACH THEM-
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
GO AHEAD MICROBES IN HERE ON
BEHALF OF WORTHINGTON INDUSTRIES
AND- I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
MR COBALT HANDED OUT ON THE
PATENT- I'M GONNA STAND BY ARE.
MY CLIENTS LETTER AND YOU KNOW
EVERY ALL CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD
ON THE ON THE PATENT ISSUE- IT'S
AN INTEGRATED VALVE AND SO AND
IT'S INTEGRATED VALVE FOR A
REFILLABLE CYLINDER AND FROM OUR
CLIENT DOESN'T MAKE A ONE POUND
REFILLABLE CYLINDERS SO THEY
DON'T. AND THEY DON'T BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE YOU KNOW. TO
HAVE A SAFETY VALVE- HE YOU'D
HAVE TO YOU'D HAVE T GET THIS
PATENT HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THIS PATENT AND YOU KNOW
AND- THE RIGHTS TO THAT AND DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES. TACTIC TO USE
SOMEBODY ELSE'S INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY SO WE STAND BY THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL. IS THAT AFFECT
THE NET EFFECT IS THAT. THE-
THAT WE WORK IN WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO MARKET. THE ONE POUND
CYLINDER THAT THEY DO NOW UNDER
YOU KNOW THE COLEMAN BRANDON
SOME OTHER BRANDS. AND THE
SENATE. BUT THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE PAST OLDER WHITES AND
IMPORTS WHO HAVE BRANDS FLAME
KEEN AND LITTLE CAMPER. AND SO
THAT'S WE WILL ALSO BY THAT IN
IN IN AND THAT'S IN FACT. TO GET
ARE SIXTEEN POINT POINTED CENTER
WHITE HOUSE YOU'VE DONE- MADE IN
THIS POINT THE CHAIRMAN. WHAT
FONTS IS PRODUCED WITH TO THAT
IN QUALITY CAN CENTERS YOU KNOW
I THINK I NOT WANT TO BE FOR HIM
HE SPEAK FROM BY THING HE THINKS
THAT'S THE APPROACH I'M A
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM WOULD
ACTUALLY CAPTURE ALL CYLINDERS
NOT JUST ONE POUND GAS CYLINDER
PROTEINS OWNERS BUT- YOU KNOW.
OTHER OTHER ISOBUTANE CYLINDERS
ARE USED IN TORCHES THAT ARE
USED IN OTHER APPLICATIONS IT
WOULD CAPTURE THE REFILLABLE
CYLINDERS BECAUSE AT SME POINT
THREE FILSON REFILLABLE
CYLINDERS WHETHER YOUR PHONE OR
NOT THEY HAVE AN END OF LIFE
TOO. AND THEY HAVE THE SAME
DISPOSAL PROBLEMS AT A
DISPOSABLE SOME GRASS AND IS TO
MAKE CLEAR WE UNDERSTAND THE
WORDS THAT WERE USING. AND WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT CENTER IT'S A
DISPOSABLE CYLINDERS KIND OF
SINGLE USE OWNER I MEAN I HAVE
MY SHOULDERS AND MY GARAGE I'VE
HAD FOR YOU KNOW THEY'RE IN MY
GARAGE A LONG TIME BECAUSE I
DON'T CAN'T THAT MUCH I MEAN I
TURNED FIFTY AND I DON'T LIKE.
CAMPING ANYMORE BUT BUT BUT YOU
GET A LOT OF USES OUT OF IT YOU
COULD PROBABLY GET ABOUT YOU
KNOW LEAST FIFTEEN THIS IS ADAM.
SO THEY THEY HAVE PRACTICAL
APPLICATIONS THAT I DON'T THINK
YOU WANT TO BAN I WANT I WANT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THERE THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING OUT
ON THE RIVER. THIRTY SECONDS WAS
KEEPING WARM AND JUST PUTTING
FOOD WITH. WITH DISPOSABLE
PROPANE CYLINDERS THE REFILLABLE
ONES BECAUSE ABOUT THIS AS MUCH
SO YOU KNOW YOU'LL- PLEASE
YOU'RE JUST GONNA CALL IT CAUSE
PEOPLE TO SPEND MORE MONEY. TO
STAY WARM AT NIGHT. WITH THEIR
SLEEPING BAGS AND OTHER OTHER
PRACTICAL USES- THIS DISASTER
RESPONSE- SITUATIONS. WHERE
WHERE THEY- PEOPLE COME OUT NAY
THANK YOU MISTER OF. I PRE YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY- OTHER WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SAYING NO ONE ON THE
PHONE. THOSE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE AT THIS MOMENT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. IT APPEARS
THAT WE HAVE TO OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK.
QUESTIONS FROM THOSE HERE
PRESENT THIRD RUSSELL YES- I
JUST I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT-
SENATE WHITE HOUSE Q. WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IN TERMS OF I
THINK I HEARD YOU SAY. YOU WANT
TO WORK ON THIS- ALTERNATIVE. TO
THE BAND SOME. YEAH YEAH AND I'M
REALLY GLAD TO HEAR THAT BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO SEE A BAND IF WE
COULD FIGURE OUT. OF THE
ALTERNATIVE TO IT AND IT'S
COINCIDENTALLY JUST TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER TODAY UNDER A
PREVIOUS A BILL ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IN THIS GREEN ECONOMY
RIGHT AND HERE WE HAVE. THE
THREAT OF TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
WORKERS RIGHT. MAKING GOOD MONEY
REPRESENTED BY A UNION DOING
GOOD WORK- ABIDING BY YOU KNOW
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS ON.
AIR AND WATER QUALITY- I MEAN
THE DOING ALL THE GOOD STUFF
THAT A COMPANY SHOULD BE DOING
SO I DON'T. I WANT THEM TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS IF THEY'RE DOING GOOD
STUFF IF WE COULDN'T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO REAP REDO IT OR REBOOT IT
SO THAT'S A COMMITMENT I'M I'M
HOPING TO GET FROM YOU. SURE GO
AHEAD IN A WAY BECAUSE HE- THE
THOSE GOOD PEOPLE IN WISCONSIN
THAT ARE MAKING THESE THESE
CONTAINERS COULD MAKE AID
RETURNABLE CONTAINER IF THEY HAD
TO OR PUT OR THEY COULD
CERTAINLY WORK ON THE LINE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET A- A
REPRIEVE- A VALVE ON IT TO THEY
HAVE TO RELEASE TO THERE'S NOT
THIS PATENT PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE. BUT THAT'S THAT'S WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IT EITHER IS WE
WHAT I'VE GOT TO LETTER I'VE
I'VE SEEN THE LETTER BUT THEY
CAN YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OF GOOD UNION JOBS FOR
PEOPLE ARE MAKING RETURNABLE-
BOTTLES OR CONTAINERS AND THAT
WAS THAT'S THE IDEA THAT WE
STARTED OFF YEARS THAT WE WANT
TO GET. THESE DISPOSABLE OR NON
RENEWABLE CONTAINERS OUT AND GET
PEOPLE INTO REUSABLE ONE SICK TO
GO CAMPING AND HAVE AND HAVE A
PROPANE TANKS I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IF I CAN GET
TO THE EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY NOBODY ELSE IS
DOING THIS MEAN CONNECTICUT HAS
A BILL THAT'S BEFORE THEIR
LEGISLATURE SO THERE'S NOT LIKE
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS. AREA
HOW DO YOU GET TO THE DETAILS OF
THE COLLECTION YOU KNOW PEOPLE
ARE CAMPING SO YOU'D HAVE TO
HAVE THE COLLECTED THAT
COLLECTIONS OUT OF THE PARKS IN
THE PAPER PLACES WHERE PEOPLE
CAN'T BE OF GOT THIS SPORTING
GOODS SOURCES TELL THAT SOME OF
THEM ONLY SELL. REUSABLE ONES SO
THEY ONLY WANT TO TAKE THOSE
REUSABLE WHAT'S BUT YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT YOU KNOW TO FIND
OUT MORE ABOUT THE CONNECTICUT
BILL LOOK AT THE LEAD WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOME AND WORK
AND WORK THROUGH IT AND YOU KNOW
GET SOME. YOU MIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATORS A LETTER ON. IT THIS IS
- AN ISSUE- ON BEACHES IN
CALIFORNIA IS IN I KNOW I
RECORDED PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OUR RECYCLING THE
CANISTERS BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
LEFT ALL OVER THE UNIVERSE AND
SO THIS IS AN IDENTIFIABLE
PROBLEM AND YES IT IS THE IDEAL
WORLD WE'D HAVE EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY BUT I
THINK THE THING THAT YOU WERE ON
TO. HIS DEBTS IT THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE TO CENTER DRAWS SO IS
HAVING THE SAME JOBS JUST HAVE A
MANUFACTURED RECYCLABLE OR MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL- THINGS WAS DOING
IT AND I THINK. THIS IS STILL
THERE SOME OPEN ISSUES WITH THIS
BILL SO I JUST HEARD YOUR
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON IT TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND WILL
VOTE TO MOVE ALONG I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT ALONG THE
COAST AND DISPOSAL OF THESE IS A
BIG ISSUE. YOU KNOW SO FAR IT
SAID EARLIER OTHERS OTHER
QUESTIONS NO QUESTIONS NO
COMMENTS- ALL RIGHT. IT CENTER
STERN MERGE THE BILL SAID A
WHITE HOUSE SKI BEFORE YOU CLOSE
THEIR ACCOUNTS UNITED SPENT THE
SOME. OTHER ON ISSUE. I KNOW YOU
PERSON OF YOUR WORD YOU HAVE
COMMITTED. TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
TO SEE IF- IN EPR IS WORKABLE IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOU- CONTAINER WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO GET THIS ALL
SQUARED AWAY. AND I'LL USE IT AS
MY CLOTHES MISTER TURNER'S AND I
VOTE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT BENCI
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS US IN ABOUT TWELVE
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
HE WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN THE MOTION IS TO PASS. ON
BURKE HI I'M BURKE I PURCHASE.
FOR JUST SNOW CABALLERO FERRIERO
I DID ASAL. DATA SO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. JONES. NO FLARED.
THERE I'D START FIVE STAR I WAKE
HEALTH. WHAT COUNTS I WIENER
WIENER AYE THAT'S NINE TWO WITH
EVERY VOTE. SENATOR NINETY TWO
EVERYONE VOTING YES THOSE ARE
BILLS L. WITH RESPECT TO SEVEN
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. NEXT NEXT
BILL ON THE AGENDA IS ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS S.
B. TEN FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG FLORIDA THANK YOU- CIRCLE
EURO IN MEMBERS RESULT THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING SO DILIGENT TODAY
WE STARTED TEN O'CLOCK THIS
MORNING AND YOU'RE ALL STILL
HERE SO KUDOS TO ALL OF YOU
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO YESTERDAY
EARLY JOHNSON- BOUND HIS
GIRLFRIEND AND THEN STABBED TO
DEATH AND STRANGLED HER ALL THE
WHILE IT WAS BEING POSTED. ON
LIVE STREAM. NOW OF THE VIOLENCE
IS BECOME PART OF THE SOCIAL
MEDIA MILIEU AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS SIMPLY GIVES THE TARGET.
OF A VIOLENT THREAT IN
OPPORTUNITY AWAY AN AVENUE TO
HAVE THAT THREAT REMOVED. WHAT
IT SAYS IS THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS THAT HAVE OVER A
MILLION- PARTICIPANTS OVER ONE
MILLION DISCRETE MONTHLY
VIEWERS. THAT THAT THEY- HAVE TO
PROVIDE A PORTAL SO THAT YOU CAN
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE THE TARGET
OF A THREAT. YOU CAN TELL THEM
YOU'RE A TARGET OF THE THREAT
AND GIVE THEM FORTY EIGHT HOURS
TO TAKE THAT THREAT DOWN
OTHERWISE YOU CAN GO TO COURT TO
SEEK AN INJUNCTION. SECONDLY IS
IF THEY DECIDE THAT YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO. BASICALLY POSTED
PORTAL THEN YOU GO TO COURT
IMMEDIATELY AND ENSYNC ENERGY
SEEK AN INJUNCTION. A COURT WILL
THEN DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THAT THREAT FALLS WITHIN THE
AMBIT OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT. IN
ISSUE AN INJUNCTION IF THE
COMPANY DECIDES NOT TO FILE AN
INJUNCTION THEY CAN BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT OF COURT WITH ALL THE
REMEDIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
COURT FOR CONTEMPT BOB I HAVE NO
WITNESSES OF IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME HOWEVER I COULD GO FOR
ANOTHER TEN THIS IF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD SO DESIRE- SO
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU KNOW PRETTY
PRETTY UNANIMOUS THAT I'D LIKE
TO GO TO. TO HAVE WITNESSES
APPEAR ALL RIGHT THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IT IS ABOUT. OF. BUT I
MEAN LET ME SEE IF. ANYBODY THE
ROOM YES YES YES ARE THERE ANY
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TEST IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NO ONE MOVING- MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
FIFTY SIX. IF YOU HAVE SUPPORT.
SB TEN FIFTY SIX. POINT ZERO I
GET HOLD OF THE FAT RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE ADVISE US HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT MORE. THERE IS NOBODY
THAT WOULD OF. COURSE VERY GOOD-
WE NOW LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE O TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUALS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IT HAS OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS WITHIN
ZERO AT THIS MOMENT. OUR MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE AND IT'S
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION. NOBODY
ISSUED UP IN OPPOSITION VERY
GOOD SO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY THE TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT AND WILL BACK THAT THE
BILL TO THE COMMITTEES OR
ANYBODY THAT HAS A BURNING
QUESTION OR THAT HAS A- COMEDY
LIKE TO MAKE. SEEING NO ONE I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WITH SENATOR
STERN MOVES THE BILL YOU MAKE
INCLUDE SENATOR THANK YOU. SIR
CABALLERO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ORIGINAL VOTE. VERY
GOOD. PLEASE CALL THEIR OFFICE
AT THE SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY SIX
BY SENATOR- BURKE WITH A MOTION
BY SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS
DEEP PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. BURKE I
BURGESS VIETTEL I HAVE A AT ALL
I DID I SO THE ADDRESS SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. LAYARD
FLARED ICE TURNED STERN AYE WHY
CASKEY Y. CASKEY I WINNER WINNER
I EARNED A NINE THAT'S NINE TWO
ZERO WITH EVERYONE VOTING WHO'S
GOING TO BE HERE BILLS OUT. ALL-RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE AND ALL THE BILLS- BEN
CHIEF COUNSEL IF WE WOULD START
AT THE TOP AND WORK OUR WAY
THROUGH SURE AB WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BY. GONZALEZ AND SALAS HI THAT'S
ELEVEN TWO ZERO EVERYBODY VOTING
CONSENT CALPERS APPROVED. THE
NEXT BILL IS FILE ITEM ONE BY
SENATOR ATKINS S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI FORGES. CABALLERO ZERO
HI JONES JONES NO LAYARD FLARED
I. NINE TWO ONE EVERYONE VOTING
ROLLS OUT. NEXT BILL IS- S. B.
ELEVEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR ARE TO
LET THAT. THE CHAIR VOTING HYPE
BURGESS. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES- JONES NOT VOTING I WANT
TO PAINFUL. HE OF NINE ZERO
EVERYONE HELPED IT'D- THE NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM THREE SB TEN
FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR BACKER.
WITH FED CHAIR VOTING I. BORGIAS
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI- FOR.
THAT'S NINE TWO ONE BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS S. B. FOURTEEN
NINETEEN BY SENATOR BAKER BUT
THE CHAIR VOTING I. GONZALEZ.
OKAY THIS IS YES SB FOURTEEN
NINETEEN BY SENATOR BAKER.
GONZALEZ I. THAT'S NINETY TWO.
FILLS UP. NEXT BILL FILE ITEM
SIX S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
THAT'S NINETY TWO. FILLS UP.
NEXT BILL FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B.
NINE EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR
EGGMAN WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
FORTUS HERTZBERG. JONES NO JONES
NO MEANER I WIENER AYE THAT'S
EIGHT TO ONE BILLS OUT. NEXT
BILL IS SENATOR ADMINS S. B. TEN
SEVENTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHT WITH
THE- CARE HASN'T VOTED- OKAY SB
TEN SEVENTEEN SENATOR EGGMAN.
UMBERG HI AMBERG FIVE BURGESS
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI JONES NO
JONES NO WIENER WIENER I. NINE
TWO ONE. BILLS OUT. NEXT BILL
SENATOR EGGMAN S. B. THIRTEEN
ELEVEN. FILE ITEM NINE CHAIR
VOTING HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I
JONES NUMBER JONES NOT VOTING
THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO. FILLS OUT
NEXT ITEM FOR ITEM TEN SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. SHARE VOTING AYE
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I JONES NO
JONES NO NINE TWO TWO BILLS OUT
. EXPO S. B. NINE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR LEYVA FILE ITEM ELEVEN
CHAIR VOTING AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES NO JON SNOW
NINE TWO TWO. BILLS OUT NEXT
FALL S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LIAM ON A FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE BORJAS. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I'D JONES HI JONES I
WIENER WIENER HI THAT'S TEN TO
ZERO BILLS OUT. NEXT BILL AS B.
TWELVE HUNDRED BY SENATOR
SKINNER WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE THAT'S FILE ITEM FIFTEEN S.
B. TWELVE HUNDRED BY SENATOR
SKINNER. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY
JONES NO JONES KNOWS LAYERED
CLEARED BY WIENER WIENER AYE
THAT'S NINETY TWO BILLS OUT.
NEXT BILL FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR KABBADI IT'LL S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY TWO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN BUT THE CHAIR VOTING
HI FORTUS HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
JONES. JONES NO. THAT'S NINE TWO
ONE FILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR DO DOCILE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI BORJAS.
AVEIRO. FIVE SEVEN ZERO I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI JONES NO
JONES NO. THAT'S NINE TWO ONE.
FILLS OUT. S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR. THE RUSSELL-
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETEEN. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI JONES JONES NO THAT'S NINE
TWO TWO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. SURE
VOTING I SO IN THE FUTURE
CABALLERO. HI CABALLERO I JONES
NO JONES NO BY CAL SKI. THAT'S.
EIGHTY TWO BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS BY SENATOR HERTZBERG SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I JONES. NO JONES NO
WIENER WIENER HI. FILLS OUT
THAT'S NINETY TWO YES. NEXT IN
LAS BILL. HELLO I THINK THAT'S
IT THAT'S IT HELLO THIS IS A FAR
RIGHT. WE'RE OUT COME BACK NEXT
WEEK THE TWENTY SIX THE READY.
FILLED DAY WE'RE JOURNAL.